john stockwell was a high cia official for 12
years he quit at that time and wrote the book in
search of enemies there was also a documentary
made about john and his experiences in the cia
and his life this documentary has been seen
over a lot of the world in film festivals
sweden united states and in germany but never on
any of the tv networks including public television
john yorenono well we'll find out why
and john will be able to speak free and
uninhibitedly tonight as everybody always
does on alternative views news magazine
hey
uh
good evening welcome to alternative views tonight
we have a very special program for you featuring
john stockwell john was a former c.i.a officer who
wrote a book exposing the cia operations in angola
called in search of enemies last year we had john
on for a two-hour special portrait discussion in
which we discussed how he got into the cia
what disillusioned him about cia operations
and had one of the first television discussions
of the activities of the cia their recruitment
their day-by-day operation and the problems that
they that the cia causes for american foreign
policy and the subversion of american values that
are their daily practice tonight we're going to
have a follow-up to this we will begin with a
documentary film on the life of john stockwell
it was made by sal landau and haskell wexler this
excellent documentary was shown in many foreign
film festivals that won a lot of prizes but
needless to say it has never been shown on
american television so we'll have the tv debut
tonight of the documentary by john stockwell
about john stockwell we will also have a
special news feature in which we will show
you how the network television news covered
the story about the russian troops that were
supposedly discovered in cuba and the manufactured
crisis and the political uproar that this caused
we will have john's reaction to the network
covering of this story and we'll have a
account that goes behind the scenes that tells
you how this story was actually manufactured
we will also have a special one-hour discussion
with john that will discuss his current views on
the cia particularly why he thinks the cia should
be abolished and why it is a counterproductive
agency that is really subversive of our democracy
and the primary american values that we believe in
we'll begin john with having a discussion
with you about the documentary that was made
could you tell us a little bit about how this
film was made and what your reaction to it is
before we actually look at it yes i think it's an
interesting story the way sol landau and haskell
wexler put it together they came down to to
austin to do the filming part of it done on
up on lake travis and part of it around town here
i think it covers various aspects of of sort of
how john stockwell got to be with my my childhood
in africa and marine corps experience and whatnot
it its statements about the cia are pretty good i
did have one reservation about it when it was all
over though that i think is i appreciate having
the opportunity to to say before you see the film
and that's that saul landau checked me out
so to speak look me over and decided that
as as he put it he's a political activist that
i would be more effective as he put it if i were
presented as an ex-marine officer who would have
been happy with the ci if it had been efficient
and that's that's not why i gave up my career
and and quit the cia and and committed the
career suicide economic suicide that i did i
think it's certainly an argument against the
cia that it's incredibly inefficient
and ineffective but that comes after
several other issues like the morality
of an organization that has committed
acts of terrorism around the world killing
hundreds of thousands of people and discrediting
the united states and making the world a much
less safe place for for us to live and do business
in john what about distribution and showing of the
film it's been shown overseas it's been shown in
film festivals but the networks including pbs
won't touch it what's the background on that
well that's pretty much says it right there it was
shown at the new york film festival and provoked
the biggest discussion of any film that was shown
there it was shown at a german film festival and
and likewise was uh not controversial it
provoked a great discussion about the cia
on swedish national television
german national television
throughout europe and various parts of the third
world the u.s networks of course the big east
won't show any film they haven't done themselves
and so they wouldn't consider it and pbs looked at
it various pbs stations looked at it and none of
them were willing to show it for their own reasons
i don't think it's that controversial it i've
gone much further in my lecturing and the comments
that we make on this panel it i do not in
that film call for a closure of the cia
which which in fact i do believe as a patriotic
american that the cia should be closed down
well we're going to see the movie now right yeah
let's see the movie first okay so this you should
yeah i was proud i mean my dad works for the cia
you know i don't uh pretend to think that we would
have had a very successful marriage even if we
had not been in the cia he could go along with
it so far and then personal benefits were out it
was strictly a matter of principle i learned he
was a cia officer this last year oh good spy good
i got i gotta find out something he did you know
i've been straight all my life in terms of working
my way through college and and the gates rubber
company was a conservative company a good one
and very conservative straight the marine corps
then 12 years in the cia a team man an
organization man i think with my own individuality
yes
foreign
i went up to the sawmill for one final load of
lumber of course he was alone and a friend of
his congolese fan was with us bob was driving
this uh boy was riding on the top of the truck
top of the lumber and in crossing a plane
we saw an equivalent of a wild turkey
so he raised his 22 and shot from the
cab and dropped the bird in its tracks
and then he called his friend up on top of
the load of lumber the first one to it gets it
and that was quite a race because it meant a lot
to both of them bob won by maybe a yard and so we
shared the bird with the other missionaries things
like that in their experience and background that
they couldn't get over here and then his
mother could tell you some stories about
some of his adventures first time he wanted to go
on an antelope hunt well it was a place where they
drove quite a ways in the car and then had to walk
and um uh never had any missionary children gone
and i said why bob of course you can't go
he says now mother you told me that i'd live
until god was ready for me to end this life and i
want to go and we let him go he killed an envelope
and in the night here came this great commotion
in the yard and he had sent some africans in
with this antelope he was 15 years old so you
went from a clean upbringing into a world of
dirty tricks in your mature life yeah but the key
thing is that as you get recruited into the cia
it never occurs to you that if you're if you're
as naive as i was uh and i think most of the young
men that come into the ciar it never occurs to
you that you're getting into world of dirty tricks
you the the come on that they have the the things
they used to sell is that you're finally getting
into the elite inner circles of the united
states government all your life you've been
going through the amateurs and the prelims and the
the prep schools in effect and finally this is it
this is where the people are real pros the front
line warriors saving the nation from communists
the phoenix program was created by the cia
and its purpose was to kill and terrorize
and vietnam was forced to do business
with a police chief who was a sadistic
mutilator of prisoners he liked to carve him up
and throw the remains in the river and he was
completely paid and propped up by the ci his whole
career depended on one controlling that operation
so the cia needed him and two uh the cia propping
him up and funding him and uh he did his uh knife
work in a ci safe house we call it the pink house
i reported this to the chief of station he said
well you know it's a rough world and sometimes
you have to do business with people that really
aren't your first choice of the kind of people
you want to associate with so don't make a way
and so i went back you know what i do resign my
post yeah you know that's obviously that's your
last vote though you resign and you're out uh
and i wasn't ready to give up my career yet i
terminated the safe house i told the case
officers that i don't want to hear about
it if this guy has a compulsion to do this sort
of thing anymore uh i don't want to hear about
it how does the cia go about recruiting
its future candidates for officers and
asians hmm have any of y'all been approached here
as recruiters come through here and talk to me
you know somebody in this room might be sweating
right now because he's been told you know if they
ask you don't say anything i hear that they do use
professors to keep eyes out in their classes for
particular students who might be interested
in that sort of work but i wonder how were
you approached here at the university or were you
approached sometime later in your career at the
university a ci recruiter came through i went and
talked to them he did not write my name down and
in 64 early 64 i got a letter in the mail saying
would i mind if the cia did a security check
and i wrote back saying i was restless and i
wrote back saying i'd be delighted if it was
for possible employment with my background
there were fields where i would be unique
from the congo i went to the university
of texas and enrolled in the rotc program
i graduated in 1959 and took a
commission in the marine corps
i didn't see my future as a career officer
so when my term was up i accepted an offer
as a junior executive at the gates rubber
company and went with my family to colorado
we were very young and idealistic with three
children when the cia first approached us we
were in the marine corps for three years and did
not want to go the military route although there
was a very promising career there when you think
about his job being a career or national security
i think that at the time the emphasis was career
i think that most of what he did was for the next
fitness report so to speak i think that people
generate activity that is unnecessary overseas
in order to have some activity on their fitness
report and they really don't get promoted
within the cia unless they have so many
recruitments let's say in a tour of duty
are so many operations or ops as they call
them the way the cia works you're promoted
on the basis of your fitness report which you get
every few months or at the end of every assignment
at least once a year usually more often and
this evaluates your performance both with a
letter grade and also a written narrative that
and the assignments you get will will develop
your career i said why don't you just go in
there and tell them that this is immoral and
this is something you can't do and he said well
they don't want you're not going to get anywhere
in your career if you say no to assignments
and by that time though he was hooked by the
cia and the assignments were sexy assignments
and interesting assignments in one post we put
seven bugs in a foreign embassy it was a quite
dramatic and very exciting and we had officers
and support officers and technicians flying all
over africa on this thing and we got them in
of the seven bugs that we installed clean we never
got caught five of them never came up on the air
they were totally defective the sixth one uh would
transmit but you the the switch the activator to
shut off the thing when no one was speaking uh
was defective so it burned out its batteries
in the course of about six weeks time and went
off the air and one of them functioned properly
and that one although it was in an ambassador's
office of a country that was very much a target
of intelligence uh activities that one
never produced a single disseminable report
i felt like i was really making time
professionally i was a very young officer
when i met my first president we had a mutual
interest there were things i could do for him and
there were things he could do for us at least
in terms of making me feel secure in his country
if i was meeting him and he appreciated what i
was doing for him it wasn't likely that he was
going to throw me out if i made a mistake or
got caught and it was pretty heady stuff for
a very young officer and uh it meant that i was
getting recognition back at headquarters obviously
you know there's young stockwell who's meeting
president x and we better keep our own stock well
he looks good my function at home when agents
would come to the home would be to turn on the
uh record player and be sure that the curtains
were closed and that there was enough security
in my own home that the person wouldn't you
know be compromised by having come to our home
i didn't really at that time i didn't realize
that we would be putting these people in danger
and that some would be put in jail and that some
would be dead a lot of other things happen in the
world it's sort of like somebody pushing a rock
off the cliff and the rock hit somebody and uh and
then you know they step back and say i didn't kill
them the the rock killed him and this is sort
of what happened in ghana the the agency to my
knowledge did not write a paper saying let's
overthrow him kuma the chief of station there
was a very aggressive man and he became aware of
the fact that there was the possibility of a coup
developing and he knew the players people who in
the army who were unhappy and he began to report
and to to ask for encouragement to encourage
these men and as i understand it he was not
given a formal permission to attempt to overthrow
kruma but he was given permission to monitor the
developments of any coup and this gave him an
excuse to to meet these officers often daily
several times a day and to give them money
and in effect to give them encouragement
a soft file is a file that doesn't have
an official name on it or kryptonium on it
and is not registered into the agency's
ibm system the system of 201 numbers
so that it can't be traced if if you come to the
agency demanding to see your file and if they have
a soft file on you instead of a 201 you'll never
get it they may have a manila folder in there with
with reams of documents about you and you'll
never get access to it there were times when i
said well let's just get out of the cia you know
bob really you're making a decision which is it's
it's getting to the point where it's going to
be the cia or it's going to be our marriage
and he chose the cia what an opportunity i was
being asked to watch the ball the angolan ball
game from the outset how we got into it what we uh
they're all the rationalization and justification
as well as the decision-making processes i was to
watch this game not from the 50-yard line but from
from the the field itself a player coach i mean
go into angola and get in the action where the
where the people are groveling in the dust
and losing their lives as well as the high
policy planning sessions in washington and
i was delighted to have the opportunity to
to sacrifice a year of my life to see just
how the u s government does this sort of thing
the ci went into angola in july of 1975.
we started out with six million dollars and
eventually the total budget was 31 million dollars
the first effort was arms that were sent from
america to kinshasa in u.s air force c-141 planes
then from kinshasa we hauled the arms into the
goal line smaller the total was about 1 500
tons of arms 30 000 rifles and small
rockets and mortars our funds and arms
were going to two of the three angola factions
one of them headed up by holden roberto who had
had a relationship with us for about 15 years and
to savimbi who had not been well known by the cia
he had the sole virtue of being in opposition
to the npla and we were determined to oppose
president mobutu zaire wanted this program
we bribed him we gave him two million seven
hundred fifty thousand 000 ci officers went
in as advisers and trainers they were called
intelligence gatherers but in fact they
were preparing our allies for combat
i fled to san salvador on january 16th
what did the enemy do in san salvador
you mean what i saw
with
these americans what did they look like were
they white were they black describe them no it
there were not enough cia advisors to make a great
deal of difference however and we hired european
mercenaries and we tried to hire white angolan
refugees to go back in as mercenaries fighting
on our side the cia collaborated with the south
africans and it was not officially ordered by the
national security council but there was liaison
at all levels the cia was nervous about the
role the senate might play in this war senator
clark on the foreign relations committee made
a trip to africa to review the situation a
fact-finding trip to report to the senate
the cia watched him with some apprehension to
see that he didn't get information we didn't
want him to have the senate led by senator clark
shut down the angola program in december of 75
while the senate was shutting us
down a cuban army eventually of
10 to 15 000 combat soldiers to make 21 aircraft
tanks just swept over the fnla in united
and we lost decisively
the victory of the heroic people of angola
nevertheless i think we could have uh won the
thing if we had gone in very quickly when i
went out there and came back i recommended that
i said the forces are about equal right now and
if we go in with immediate abundant support we can
win we can take luanda by that i met tactical heir
and american advisers put in a several hundred
troops very quickly and put in some of these
really monstrous weapons airplanes you know that
fly around shooting eight thousand rounds a minute
down and you'd have been in towanda just like that
it appears from what you said that you advocated
that the united states should go into angola with
large weapons lots of firepower a small detachment
of americans and that your plan was rejected
and that was the final straw that did it for you
no that's very definitely a misunderstanding
yesterday we got distracted we were into that
and then we didn't get a chance to pursue
it probably changing of cameras or something
i was sick at my stomach that we were going
into angola i was this i was depressed that
the agency would be letting itself get
dragged into another paramilitary adventure
that quickly after vietnam when it would obviously
not succeed we couldn't possibly stay with it the
senate the press the public wouldn't be about
to let us escalate something up to the level
that it would have a chance of winning and
uh it would be highly damaging to the nation
and to the the cia particularly to to let
ourselves get dragged into some such a thing
once and at the outset when they offered
me this job then i had a choice of uh you
know what do i do do i participate or
do i resign or do i quietly lobby for
some other job and let someone
else run the angola program
and my decision was that i was going to stay
with the program because it was too interesting
to see how does the united states get dragged
into these things and how does the ci conduct
them once it's in them i don't think anybody could
could turn down that kind of an opportunity just
to know that it's not what some newspapermen is
telling you what happens when he doesn't really
know himself it's what's really happening you
were there running it so i decided to participate
and in order to make sure that i remained on the
inside i remained a good good soldier throughout
the whole thing i did not balk or fight it until
we got into phases that i thought were just beyond
the pale such as alliances with the south africans
and mercenaries for example when i went to angola
i was sent out there to come back with a military
assessment and uh that's what i recommended when i
got back if you guys want to win we can do it a
dramatic weapon a horrendous weapon if you will
against the mpla at that time would have just
brushed them aside it would have decimated
him it would have wiped them out and uh the fnla
would have been into wanda in a few moments time
suppose they had taken your military
recommendation how would you felt
i would have uh stayed as task force chief
and participated i i if you're going to do
some you know if you're going to learn french
or a foreign language the least you can do with
your poor pronunciation is speak out and i think
it's uh there are certain things that are criminal
but you compound it by losing if you're going
to go into angola if you have some national
compulsion to go into angola at least the united
states position would be much stronger if you won
and if they had accepted my recommendation
at that point i would have been much happier
uh if if they had gone ahead and won than i was
with the contemptible middle ground that they
followed the overall life overseas is very
agreeable i think it's one of the things that
a lot of men in the cia want to they want to stay
out overseas it's kind of a colonialist existence
there are lots of servants and the life is very
easy the housing is very adequate if not plush
we had about six white kids in our class and
then um you know everybody just blended in
it was you know a little bit of um like
racism or whatever on the teacher's part
and that you know she thought that the black
kids were a little deprived and everything but
you know in the schools everybody got along
it was a pleasant place for kids to grow up
i mean that you're living with the elite
of that society in terms of education
basically and experiences the people
who've traveled people who who've been
involved in a lot of experiences in life you know
ambassadors and people who are running the country
and the diplomats in different embassies and so
they're sharp people they're intelligent people
and they're they're well bred generally so the
conduct is relatively high a sense of culture when
we were in africa i don't remember everything but
i didn't i don't remember so much about the school
i mean like when we were there we'd go on our
safaris and we climbed kenya and ran all over the
place and we're just ambitious doing everything
he was a little older and longer-legged so he
could go on hunting safaris mel was just a year
about a year too young he just couldn't quite
pull it off although he did
a lot of the jogging with us
that's cheating he's supposed to give
us a little bit to get to get pumped up
this is about 90 pounds
this
morning
um
it's a highly competitive business
and you're working under stress
you go to the same cocktail parties
that the state department officers go to
and then a dinner party after the cocktail
party but in between you go meet an agent
and you pay him off and you get a receipt and
you rush up to the embassy and stow the stuff
so it won't fall out of your pocket at the dinner
party or something and then you go to the dinner
party and then after the dinner party you go
run another errand and this goes on day in and
day out saturdays sundays holidays and when you
begin to see that the the organization as a whole
is very sloppy and poorly run and the standards
are very low you're it's hard to stay motivated
it's hard to keep thinking it's worthwhile and
you really get to a state where you just just
really don't want to have to lock everything
about your professional life in a safe and lie
to all the people you know about who you really
are and what you're really doing and what your
real dreams and aspirations and promotions are and
be able to complain to them about your failures or
our problems well i realize now that the business
of the cia is to go out and to corrupt individuals
in their in place in their own countries and that
this is something that corrupts oneself this was
going against his upbringing which was a strong
christian very moral background and he was coming
into conflict with himself hating himself
angry with himself you know i would like to
to present myself as a man of intense principle
who saw bad things and immediately resigned and
discussed but my career was obviously going quite
well i had the prestige of people coming to me
for jobs coming to me for advice inviting
me to lunch wanting to play tennis with me
this is you know obviously human satisfaction
i was not yet in top management i couldn't
really give away a lot of jobs but i
could speak on the behalf of someone
my income was about thirty three thousand
dollars a year and ten years i could retire
on a twenty one thousand dollar a year
pension for the rest of my life i had
total security was it the thought that
you would be continuing to do things
like the vietnam involvement mingle and the
angle and involvement that you thought was
immoral or counterproductive at least well what
i tried to do was to psych myself into going back
to africa as a chief of station in some place
like cartoon for example which would have been
a nice post for my grade and just not push covert
operations very much if something came along it
was just sort of irresistible some agent that
just had to be recruited will let an officer in
my station recruit him but basically just play
a lot of tennis and let the paychecks come in
this is uh traditionally what uh burned out senior
case officers do and i muddled and and waffled
and vacillated and rationalized for about eight
months before i could tear myself away i i don't
really look at it as uh taking that much uh guts
to quit i just sort of didn't have any choice by
november and december i had intense pains in my
abdomen which were obviously the precursors of
a stomach ulcer from the internal conflict
of wanting to hang on to this career but not
respecting it i had requested many times that
bob just dropped out of the cia just get out
and start life in you someplace he wasn't able to
do so when i asked him to but now he has he's seen
even more since our divorce and yes i do feel
vindicated when a man comes back and says you
were right all along everything you ever said was
right everything you ever said about everybody who
walked into our house was right what lessons
did you learn from your dad's experience well
of course it brings up values just all over the
place and that that i mean i could go you could
break up on that a whole lot but you know i'm
listening to him right now i'm learning this is
something else what's your reaction to cia now
well i think up high there's slobs and then you're
down in the lower when you get down into the um
people are actually out in the field then they
would do the working you know it makes me a very
inefficient crooked really sloppy organization
i was not a man at peace with himself and since i
resigned i do not feel in a position of conflict
i feel in a position of being
at peace with myself morally
um
for our news coverage tonight we're
going to show you some clippings
taken from the network television news of the
quote discovery of the russian troops in cuba
and we will show you the way that the television
network news handled covered and interpreted this
event and the political ramifications and how
they were covered then we will discuss with john
if indeed the full story was told on network
news of the cuban russian relationship
and we will also see what distortions there were
in the television coverage and we'll let john
comment and give another interpretation
of the political implications of this
so-called event cuba is obstructing the senate's
work on salt to budget and military planning
as a result the administration is negotiating
with both the ussr and the u.s senate according
to congressional sources both negotiations are
serious with soviet ambassador dobrinan and with
senate leaders serious and intricate politics
on cuba are more murky in the senate than in
the kremlin the administration must strike one
deal with the soviet union but many deals here
with sam nunn demanding a 5 increase in us
military spending before he will vote for salt too
but cuba has frozen salt too the administration
must negotiate with frank church who says no
assault until all the soviet combat troops
leave cuba carter can make no deal with the
soviet union about the troops without dealing
with powerful scoop jackson who wants troops and
jets and submarines out before he'll consider
salt and he won't even do that without a 5
military budget increase that brings carter into
entirely new negotiations with budget chairman
musky who opposes any major spending increase
and according to the white house press secretary
decisions were made about how to deal with the
problem posed by those soviet combat forces in
cuba there was no further public comment
on the nature of those decisions however
here is a report from our white
house correspondent sam donaldson
president carter may decide to counter
the soviet combat presence in cuba
by stepping up an american military presence
both in the caribbean and elsewhere in the
world unless of course the soviets take
steps on their own to change the status quo
as the president has demanded no one here will
confirm that such a decision is in the works but
the president's own words on this subject ten days
ago point to such an approach we do have the right
to insist that the soviet union respect our
interests and our concerns if the soviet union
expects us to respect their sensibilities and
their concerns otherwise relations between our two
countries will inevitably be adversely affected
what the president was clearly saying was that
if the russians don't change the status quo by
taking action themselves the united states will
change it through its own actions not by provoking
a warlike confrontation but perhaps by stepping
up u.s combat forces in the caribbean which would
serve to neutralize any possible threat from cuba
and perhaps by challenging soviet interest
elsewhere through a mix of military and
economic moves that while not directly threatening
moscow would adversely affect russian concerns the
president said one advisor is not going to paper
over those troops the status quo will be changed
sam donaldson abc news the white house this is
john scaling top administration officials have
now started to consider a wide range of military
and economic pressures against the soviets among
the most sensitive is the possibility of helping
armed china with modern weapons a step that would
be sure to alarm the kremlin any such move
would come later after other less dangerous
decisions such as sharply reducing american grain
shipments now at a record level it is estimated
that american wheat and feedstock exports to the
soviets will surpass two billion dollars this year
administration leaders would be most reluctant to
order such cutbacks because of the humanitarian
aspect involved in such sales but if necessary
such decisions would be made say informants
along with a sharp reduction in shipments of
american machinery and high technology items
military countermeasures would seek to avoid
any direct military threat to the soviets
the steps that would be considered are reinforcing
american ground and united states units overseas
plus helping anti-soviet forces near the russian
border was told today that unless those soviet
troops are removed from cuba there's virtually no
chance for senate approval of the new strategic
arms treaty with moscow the grim warning came at
a white house meeting with congressional leaders
president's got a tough problem i said before
the only thing he can't do with this russian
troop problem is nothing he's got to do something
this is jimmy carter's challenge i think we've
used too much time i think the matter should have
been dealt with by now well john you were telling
me about this situation uh you know whether it
was you were in cuba or a friend was in cuba
when the word came down to cover it yeah a friend
of a friend of mine an acquaintance of mine that
i've met since i got out of the ci was passing
through town and he had been there covering the
non-aligned nations conference he was a writer
or he is a writer yes working on a magazine in
in washington a controversial magazine but he was
there as a reporter with the reporters covering
the conference they got the the various reporters
got instructions from their offices in washington
and new york to find out about the soviets in cuba
and they sent back messages according to him uh
all of them saying you've got to be kidding this
has got to be some kind of a grand put on and they
got terse messages back from their headquarters
saying it's it's the big story of right now do
it find out about the soviets in cuba and they
couldn't believe it it was it was an international
joke literally now well let's back up a big
step and note what what nobody brought out and
they certainly could have and that's that the the
subject the issue of soviet troops in cuba was a
spin-off an evolution of a ci operation to disrupt
and manipulate the non-aligned nations conference
fidel castro was managing this conference is
hosting it on in cuba near america which which is
a difference and he's the old anathema to the
cia the cia tried to kill him so many times
unsuccessfully 20 years unable to rid itself or
rid the united states of this communist leader
on our shores and this year the the non-aligned
nations conferences meeting in havana hosted by
castro the ci went all out the thing they seized
on as an issue to discredit castro was to make
him appear to be not non-aligned he's aligned with
the soviet union which is probably true it's it's
probably his achilles heel as an online nation's
leader is that he is aligned with the soviet union
uh how better could the cia bring this out than
to make a big issue of soviet troops in cuba
and it's been leaked out if you read these various
articles in time magazine and the new york times
in the washington post and elsewhere you notice
that it is admitted that the ci was working
with the national security council the national
security adviser brzezinski on the the subject
of the conference the upcoming conference and they
did seize on the presence of soviet troops in cuba
as an issue and in exactly during the conference
they make this this dramatic announcement of
soviet troops in cuba now what is brought out in
bits and pieces but not very well by the media and
covering this by the statements that were quoted
is that there was no threatening soviet presence
in cuba no one at any point pretended that the
u.s was a national security was being jeopardized
by a soviet force that could invade florida or
puerto rico or anywhere else it was a trivial
2000 men approximately a lot of semantics were
played on whether or not they were combat troops
well i would react by saying that
they were in fact combat troops
but combat troops are also instructors so
the soviets may be telling the truth there
but they they're infantry troops but they are not
assault troops even president carter in one of his
speeches admitted this they didn't have they they
do not have the delivery capability the the ships
airplanes helicopters however to to move from
cuba to florida or puerto rico or somewhere else
they're not assault troops they don't
have an aggressive posture or capability
they don't have the weapons that
would go with an assault unit
the press dramatized this issue by talking and you
you notice these commentators the the drama that
they would get in their voices where they would
say soviet troops in cuba you know if you want to
sit up and get nervous if they had said this tiny
soviet force in cuba every time they brought it up
or something like that it would have put it into
its true perspective something else well john do
you think they manufactured the story then that
we've known that there have been soviet troops
in cuba since 1962. definitely there was something
like 40 000 troops at that time and most were
withdrawn but there's been two or three thousand
troops there continuing the whole time and
and vance is the secretary of state's first
the administration's first announcement of
this as being an issue objected to the status
quo he did not object to the introduction of
soviet troops into cuba he said the status quo
is unacceptable because he knew that the soviets
knew and the cubans knew that we knew that they
had been there the whole time there was nothing
new about this issue the only thing that was new
was the non-aligned nations conference happening
right but did the media adequately point out that
no new cute russian troops were actually recently
placed in cuba didn't they give the impression
from the news clippings that this was something
new something threatening something dangerous
as if russia had recently put a whole flock of
new troops there that suddenly posed a threat so
this is this is really distortion of the grossest
magnitude because it's exercising the american
people it's jeopardizing salt notice also that
every one of the the senators and and other
individuals that are quoted there has some
major vested interest in making an issue out of
this except perhaps senator byrd salt won't go
said church unless the troops are out and
presidential hopeful baker said he won't be
able to remain silent if the troops aren't out
soon now he either has the guts to do something
about it or he doesn't there's no need to look
at this as though it's a crisis i was here in
the 1962 crisis i've been hearing some pretty
tense moments but there's no crisis here scoop
jackson is the original hawk always clamoring for
more arms and a more dramatic u.s military posture
baker of course in goldwater traditionally
critics of the democratic administration baker
with his own presidential aspirations both of them
conservative both of them looking for issues that
they can stir it up to to egg the administration
on to challenge the soviets to sort of go to war
the hawks were able to play this issue into
a situation which which apparently is going
to lead has led and is going to lead to an
escalation of military activity in the caribbean
and greater defense spending we now have in in
the press today 2 000 more u.s marines being put
into guantanamo bay on cuban soil and other
marine military maneuvers in the caribbean
it's been a it was a field
day for the for the hawks
dunn is another hawk 5 military budget increase
frank church of course is a traditional liberal
but he's in jeopardy of losing his position
in the new elections his state i believe
it's idaho has turned conservative under him
and so he was back when this was launched he
he he was advised of it over a scrambled
telephone while he was back in idaho campaigning
and he his reaction is has been quoted abundantly
that he said i can't sit on this i can't keep this
secret soviets in cuba i've got to come out with
it and the answer from the administration was we
realized that meaning obviously they called
him while he was home while he was on this
ultra conservative kick to give him ammunition
so he would bring it out and make an issue of it
carter's objectives are fairly clear hit at the
point that crisis non-crisis broke he had never
been lower in the polls his political future
was and still is very much in doubt and he
needed some issue that he could uh some crisis
or preferably awful sounding non-crisis so that
he could thump his chest and show how macho he
is in handling this non-crisis and so he did but
didn't this backfire in some ways against carter
because because he wasn't able to effectively
do anything about it that is he couldn't get
the russians to remove the troops that it made
him look weak again all the the networks made
this is what surprised me by looking at the
coverage of it the networks constantly made carter
look like a fool the president sought counsel from
the congressional delegation to the distinguished
jacob javits mr carter said what would you do
reply you mean you called us here at 8 30 in the
morning to ask us what we would do what are you
going to do senators and congressmen were told
the u.s asked the soviet union if the troops were
combat troops answer from moscow no the u.s asked
if they would take the troops out anyway answer
no another answer to the same question is
expected within a few days inquiry how many
days president two or three days vance not
that fast javits can we have another meeting
yes within a week vance not that fast that is what
you call your basic linkage between cuba and salt
even though sources said the meeting
was told the united states still
does not know why the soviet troops are there
and we do not know exactly how serious it all is
another congressional leader president accused
the president of trying to have it both ways
of being hard on one hand and soft on the other
according to this source the meeting was not very
enlightening or satisfying senate democratic
majority leader robert byrd didn't even bother
to attend the meeting with the president byrd
claimed that he had received a briefing from
secretary vance last night the result of today's
meeting the president did win some more time
however he did not generate much confidence in
his leadership the president hopes this policy
will convince hardliners particularly those in
the senate who are holding the salt treaty hostage
that he has effectively neutralized the russian
troops while at the same time proving anew that
he does not panic in a crisis and risk general
war but already the president's plan has hit one
tiny snag mr carter wanted to go on television
sunday night and where did that leak so widely
in washington that one afternoon newspaper here
headlined the carter talk on cuba on sunday then
the white house discovered that sunday was the
high holy jewish holiday yom kippur and so in some
confusion it rescheduled the speech for monday
night sam donaldson abc news the white house
they gave a lot of tv network coverage to connelly
and baker and these right-wing republicans
attacking carter for being soft so i think carter
really lost politically on this one also after the
the speech that carter made where he outlined
his plan immediately the headlines and the 10
o'clock news were russian troops to stay in
cuba as if carter had not really done anything
and therefore failed to be a strong leader
well isn't there a certain justice in that
though because this this whole thing started
with an operation brzezinski and the cia
juned up to embarrass cuba and the soviets and
but president they worked for president carter
the the ci is part of the white house and and and
carter uh permitted it apparently encouraged it
to be brought brought out and made public and made
into an international issue and in that sense it's
backfiring on him as a certain amount of justice
he had secretary vance make the the statements
and say make an issue out of it throw the
gauntlet down say the status quo is unacceptable
and the amateurishness of this administration
was was shown right then and there in that
the status quo was unchangeable by
the united states except this this
very weak solution he came up in the end well
we can't do anything about the soviets in cuba
so we'll increase our own military activity around
you always wonder how much something like this was
planned ahead of time since it had so
much of an effect of encouraging the hawks
and leader leading to greater military activity
and spending how much of it was was determined
ahead of time let's let's make an issue of the
soviet troops there so we can get into this
defense spending particularly since they've known
about it for 17 years since they've known about
it for 17 years well i noticed frequently that
they would toss around the cia as well we have
good intelligence i got a briefing by stanfield
turner blah blah they would be bringing it in
as if that would automatically give the stamp
of expertise on it i was just in a briefing
with stanfield turner the head of the cia a few
moments ago and he believes that those troops
are not there just to train cubans however we
do not know the mission of those troops early
this morning national security council members
including cia director turner and secretary of
state vance arrived to continue talks with the
president which went on here until late last night
about senator baker's suggestion that
the president now release intelligence
photographs of the soviet troops in cuba abc news
diplomatic correspondent barry dunsmore reports
the state department will oppose doing that while
negotiations are still underway but if the talks
break down release of the evidence might be a good
idea it's amazing how they would dare to do that
when you have this history of incredible
endless intelligence failures by the cia
in crisis after crisis after crisis the cia
coming up with faulty or false information
and for them to cite stansfield turner in
a situation like this remember the last u.s
cuban confrontation where uh president
carter was calling president castro a liar
and vice versa was a year and a half ago
at the time katangi's invaded the shabbat
and president carter said that we had intelligence
that it was a cuban operation and castro said it
absolutely was not a cuban operation that it
was katangi's and cuba had nothing to do with it
and president carter did much as they had there he
had ci you know the cia had information proving it
eventually it was resolved by some senators
going down to havana and meeting with castro
at his invitation and he convinced them that
there was reasonable doubt and they went back
and demanded and were shown the ci's intelligence
and the 17 senators walked out of that meeting and
said it didn't prove the presence of cuba behind
that invasion at all in other words in yet another
situation president carter uh was not telling the
truth he was misinformed and he was distorting the
information lying if you will and fidel castro was
telling the truth what amazes me once again is the
absolute distortion of grameko speech and the
russians position the russians admitted they
had troops there and that they've been there
for a long time grumeko said you know this is
a foolish put up job and let's forget about it and
get on with the business of salt and yet then the
senators would come and say grimiko's lying he's
an absolute liar he called it like it was soviet
foreign minister andre gramico today dismissed
the american charge with a short blunt demand
forget it in his speech the united nations general
assembly mr gramiko said it was all part of a
campaign to spread lies about the policies
of cuba and the soviet union but the truth
is that this propaganda is totally
without foundation in reality
and our advice on this score is simple it
is high time that you honestly admit that
this whole matter is artificial and proclaim it
to be closed although mr grimiko did not even
mention the presence of soviet troops in cuba
it was clear this is what he was talking about
just two weeks ago the soviet union admitted it
does have troops in cuba but only to train the
cubans in soviet military hardware that their
duties and numbers have not changed in 17 years
and that any charges that organized soviet combat
units have arrived in cuba are totally groundless
and mr gromiko insisted that there's no reason for
concern the soviet union and other countries of
the socialist community have never threatened
anybody nor are they threatening anybody now
this is lucha offi abc news at the united
nations suzanne compton at the capitol where
senators who have seen american intelligence
photos say gramico is lying i'm astonished
there is simply no basis for doubting that
the soviet union that the russians have
a fully equipped fully manned combat brigade
in cuba i would hope that the president
now would consider releasing the very very
reliable intelligence data we have including
aerial and satellite photography to conclusively
show that there are russian combat troops in cuba
each senator pointed out that gromeko was involved
in another cuban dispute the 1962 missile crisis
i think the the president really has to be firm in
this and just remind the american people that this
is the same mr gromyko who lied about missiles
he was caught red-handed and i regret that mr
grumiko has seen fit to state a ball-faced lie
that's what it is grimiko's intervention has had
a chilling effect on the strategic arms treaty
with the soviets a growing number of senators
including the man in control of the treaty foreign
relations chairman frank church say that unless
the president can soon certify that the russian
combat forces have been dismantled the salt
treaty will be put on ice it was not a good day
today for the united states at the united nations
absolutely he called it like it was he said
that they were there he said they were not
assault troops but they were there for training
and certainly we have troops all over the world
that are there to help install our and train and
use our our military equipment the hardware we've
installed we had for many years this huge unit in
in addis ababa we have of course 5 000 troops on
the soviet border in turkey these troops have no
capability of invading russia for heaven's sake
but they are combat troops they've all been
trained in how to shoot rifles and whatnot and i
would say that the only two people i saw in there
who who seemed to be candidly caught three i guess
calling it like it was was senator byrd who said
it was a non-crisis gromeko who it appeared to
me called it like it was said you're making
something out of nothing for your own purposes
and then fidel castro also calling it like it
was and andrew young also and andrew young yes
which we call training center
estanco
has been in cuba for the past 17 years
now then that's military facility
in conformity with the spirit of the
agreement on october of that year
and within the status quo that was set
up as a result of the october crisis
why has he brought this problem to
the right now to create a situation
situation is in a crisis
to place peace into a crisis
receiving the world public opinion and the
u.s public opinion andrew young bowed out as a
diplomat speaking his mind as usual last night he
spoke to five thousand blacks and at a time when
the administration has been saying it's gravely
concerned over those soviet combat troops in cuba
young ridiculed the threat if the
russians made a move against us
our defenses are strong enough to ignore
and wipe out and obliterate some 3 000
cubans and i mean russians in cuba what the
hell can they do to the united states of america
that is a totally irrelevant political issue that
has nothing to do with the national security of
this nation more relevant young said is inflation
and unemployment more of a threat than troops in
cuba then young philosophized about what
he thinks is wrong with foreign policy
it's not some awful strategic concept decided
by some folk that ain't never fought no wars
don't know nothing about suffering never been
poor and essentially and isolate themselves in
some ivory tower writing papers and theorizing to
each other those are the folks those essentially
other folk that have created the mess that the
world is now in andrew young's beautiful comment
and the other people wow john don't you think
that the network news is irresponsible in
failing to give this broader context for the story
in leaving out the fact that this was a story
based on leaks that really gave no new information
and the way they played this up night after night
and gave all these hawks such a pervasive
coverage you know our our enemies overseas we
talk about communist censorship of the press and
the communists talk about our censorship of the
press or our press working for the government
and as we sit here we find this an incredible
charge from from the communists because we know
that we have freedom of the press uh you can go
out and start a newspaper with a mimeograph
machine and print more or less what you want
and you probably won't be eliminated the next day
by the fbi although that has been known to happen
but the fact is that while you can't
claim plausibly and i wouldn't that
the new york times or the washington post
our time magazine or newsweek the biggies
are actually controlled by the administration
not in the sense of the administration calling
them up and saying here's our line on this issue
everybody do it the press plays directly into the
hands of the administration it's the voice of a
given administration the press has gotten us into
incredible situations in the world devastating
situations in the world such as the vietnam war
if the if the vietnam war if the press had been
conscientious in nailing the administration on its
lies and distortions during the vietnam war during
the buildup of the vietnam war it never would have
happened if they had balked then if they had had
interviews with people and then had someone come
on afterwards saying unfortunately all of that's
untrue see the press tries it claims it presents
the facts and facts are are if president carter or
scoop jackson or goldwater someone makes a speech
that is a fact that he made that speech and said
those words now the fact that all of those words
were false is never clarified to the public so
the administration can use the press to to put
out whatever it wants to on a given situation and
the press will play along for the sense of drama
as they say to sell newspapers so you have
crises like this that could never have existed
if the press had nailed him at the outset and
said this is nonsense it's a non-crisis there's
another irony here in that during this very
period the russians went to east germany in
a very big flourish they said they were going to
take 20 000 russian troops out of east germany and
we were going to withdraw a lot of their forces
from central europe and this was hardly covered
there were only seconds of coverage whereas this
seemed to be a major change in soviet uh policy
and a potential thaw in europe which could be much
more important than this non-event in cuba and yet
this was barely mentioned this is how the press
can create some stories and how they don't even
cover you've got to you've got to remember and
this is why i titled my book in search of enemies
it's necessary to our system of government to have
people to oppose and people to hate if you'll look
for example i believe it was yesterday president
carter just finished a small political swing
he made repeated statements about cuba
cuba's aggressive posture cuba's military the
the cuba being the most militarized country in
the world etc surely we have things that are more
important than cuba to to this nation right now
the collapsing economy the galloping inflation
all of the various uh minority groups that are
still suffering persecution in this country
he he nevertheless he focuses on cuba and makes
them into an enemy which they have no desire to be
so that we've got somebody to hate to oppose
so that we've got an excuse to thump our chest
and build up our military machine and he's
doing this obviously as a a major element in
his presidential campaign searching for enemies
looking for people that don't want to fight us
that we we need to have somebody to oppose
i think there's also kind of a long range
thing that they're looking forward to here also
you read some books and see some statements by
the high muckety mucks and they complain that the
vietnam war has had such a devastating effect on
public opinion that they can't wheel and deal
around the world now like they used to because
public opinion would not allow it people would
hit the streets again so i think this is part of
an overall policy of trying to whip up the cold
war rhetoric and look for enemies like you say
so that people will become hawkish and accept a
more militant stance and activist stance around
the world as a matter of fact it resulted in
the poll which was mentioned by ap and nbc
associated press poll shows americans by
three to one want the salt treaty held up
by the senate until the russian troops are moved
out of cuba 66 percent said hold up the treaty
22 percent said don't the others didn't know john
how would you comment on carter's speech on this
incident where he claimed that cuba was a puppet
a satellite of the soviet union it was an economic
failure do you think that's an accurate
account well you notice fidel castro was on
60 minutes the night before president
carter's big speech on this subject
and he called president carter dishonest on
this this subject and then the next night
carter went on television and it was almost
as though he set out to prove castro right
his presentation of the facts was so distorted
and he left out these these glaring omissions that
would give some balance to the thing that would
have explained it and put it into its perspective
things like cuba's long-standing and repeated
offer overture to us to normal normalize relations
which we have consistently spurned
the presence he did not mention the presence
of of our marine corps base on cuban soil
now mind you if the soviets had troops
on u.s soil or cuban troops on u.s soil
it would be a different thing but we actually
maintain a marine corps base on cuban soil
he made a big thing out of the cuba's dependency
economic dependency on the soviet union and he
called it cuba the economic failure of communism
he didn't point out that we've had a 20-year
economic war against cuba that it's a long ways
from russia and it's very close to us this war has
included of course the the assassination attempts
on the leader and the propaganda efforts to to to
disrupt the morale of the country but aside from
all that projects to destroy their sugar crops
and and cuba is almost totally dependent on its
sugar for one thing a blockade of cuba for many
many years embargo on the sale of many things to
cuba we did everything we could to make them into
our enemy and to force them into the arms of the
soviet union to force them to be dependent on the
soviet union we could have taken the opposite
policy and tried to help them get established
economically so that they could be part of the
community of nations and not be aligned with the
soviet union we pushed them into the arms of the
soviet union he didn't bother to point that out
this it's the greatest irony i think the hardest
thing for americans to to understand and realize
and face and accept is that our presidents have
now a tradition of being the most duplicious
of any world leaders our presidents lie the most
as a matter of policy because of the secrecy
establishment now it was it was absolute proof of
the putting of the whole thing about the cia this
was another ci operation that got out of hand a
rogue elephant they like to call them that put
that it jeopardized salt to and put the united
states in the position of being ridiculed in
the eyes of the world and preoccupied our
government for three weeks until carter finally
did you notice how when he was on
television how he kept smirking
he would be talking very seriously about
all these heavy things and he would kind of
give his his little his little grin he couldn't
repress it because he knew what a joke this whole
thing was there was there was no crisis but at the
same time it had become a crisis in the sense that
salt too was at stake well al slavinski is
going to join us now and we'll proceed with
more in-depth discussion of this and other
other items which might be on your mind
it's clear to me this is a pseudo issue but i'm
not clear of how the cia is behind it okay you
have to read between the lines only a little bit
to understand the ci's role because it has been
stated in the last few weeks i would be more alert
to what these statements meant having been part of
these things before but every three years there's
the the non-aligned nations conference and every
three years nine months before the conference
the ci mounts a massive operation to discredit
disrupt and manipulate this conference in uh in
19 whenever it was 1970 the big issue was china
was trying to get into the united nations and we
were leaning in the direction of talking directly
to china but the the thrust of the non-aligned
nations conference operation was to get all of
the delegates possible to to oppose endorsing
the entry of china into the united nations
i was involved in that when i had an agent who
was an intellectual third world figure who was a
an official in his government who could go to this
conference and so i was leaned on by headquarters
every station ci station in the world gets
these cables saying not just do you have
anyone who would go but they go through your
files back at headquarters and find out what
agents you have and come in and say send in our
intellect to this place and tell him what to say
and i got out my agent and and leaned on him
and said uh this is the line you've got to take
vis-a-vis china and he said wait a minute he said
wait a minute he said my my country is very poor
we need china we need a relation with china you're
ordering me to sabotage my country's interests for
one of your political ploys when everybody can
see that the united states is in the process
of going to bed with china in her own economic
interest he said how can i do that and ours too
and so i i went back to headquarters and said
that he was not responsive and so they sort of
put an x on how well he stood as a disciplined
agent and wrote you know little things about
you know i didn't have complete control of all
my agents well we shouldn't really dismiss the
cuban thing as being a mickey mouse situation
well here's what happens there's going to be
an increase in defense spending because of it
there's going to be increased military presidents
it's it's it has turned out it's a tempest and
a teapot but it won it jeopardized salt i think
that'll blow over and people get over that but it
has it is wound up when we're we were moving in
the direction of support for salt and a reduction
of strategic weapons and military posturing
that's that's what these treaties should be about
it has wound up to be a victory for the hawks
in in the defense department and in the cia and
also this this is kind of reminiscent of the days
when hoover would create a threat and go out and
stomp it down and get more money from congress
in the process isn't the cia doing the same thing
exactly although i don't knowing them as as i feel
i i do i i did and i believe i still do i don't
think that they are they have enough mind about
there's enough of them an intellect driving what
they do they always have these non-align nations
conference this time it's a biggie because it's in
cuba and it's the old ci nemesis castro is running
it this is the man the ci tried eight times to
kill he's tried to destroy cuba's sugar crops
and whatnot we've forced the ci's forced him to be
totally dependent on the soviet union economically
and he has he has stuck his finger in the ci's
eye over the years time and time again and gotten
away with it and he's doing it again 90 miles
from our own shores so the ci was obviously
incensed and and by that when you say ci in that
context you mean the intelligence establishment
because there are people who don't work in the
language like the big new brzezinski for example
that don't work in the cia but they're part of the
same complex and it's now it's it's been admitted
by the white house that uh brzezinski met with the
cia 40 committee meetings uh are the operations
advisory group meetings with the ci director
and ordered the ci to focus on cuba and focus on
their vulnerabilities and focus on soviets in
cuba and this was this they admitted that this
began last march and so they focused on the
their operation to discredit castro tell me
how have you changed since the last time we saw
you you had written the book in search of enemies
and it was doing well and people were talking
perhaps about doing a movie and you were trying
to get on the lecture series have all these good
things come about or as the cia been after your
defective fanny what you know you know
i don't i i really don't feel that i've
changed one bit through this whole
experience except a bit of broadening
a bit more confidence in mankind on one side
and a bit more cynical perhaps on the other
yes i've lectured all over
the nation three dozen times
i guess on different universities i've appeared
on television in every corner of the nation
but i still feel like the same old country how
have you been received and reception that's where
the the experience has been so rewarding
you know inside the ci you're very much
have the feeling of belonging to a religious
order that's not how you would verbalize it
inside the ci but that's the effect you you live
with cia people you socialize with cia people
and you have quite a feeling that outsiders the
rest of the world are hostile and misguided and
that inside the ci you're safe and you're with
people you can trust in people who view the world
correctly and it was the most refreshing thing
about leaving the cia and getting outside and
meeting people in the press and the media and
universities around the nation was to find how
many really decent people they are there are who
who are working hard for things they believe in
and are quite responsive to someone who's
made a gesture as as i have to a moral gesture
and lecturing for example i've as i say i've
lectured i guess three dozen times i haven't
counted but many many times and i have yet to
have one lecture that did not go hours beyond
the prescribed time even when i had to catch
an airplane they would still keep me for hours
a lecture you know would be scheduled for an hour
an hour and a half and 15 minutes of questions and
it would go on in fact until midnight one o'clock
with people asking questions and the discussion
just flowing and then more often than not go
somewhere to drink beer and talk on until three
or four in the morning the interest is extremely
high in this subject of of the secret government
and governmental abuses the encroachment of the
government on individuals inside our society but
also on on the peoples of the world speaking of
which john have you been contacted or pressured by
the cia there was a threat that they were going to
sue they had sued frank schnepp for publishing his
book about the cia and you were worried last time
you were here that you might be sued also have you
heard anything from the cia recently when they
when they sued snap which was spring a year ago
his book came out a few months before mine did
which i regret because i i think my book was a
much better book in a moral sense not quality of
writing or anything but the government got to him
first just before my book came out and sued him
and made snep a test case then my book came out
and unofficially they were you know talking in
washington it was clear that the government was
frustrated that they moved against him instead of
me and i was frustrated because there was going
to be a snap precedent instead of a stockpile
precedent and i think i would have put up a
fight that would have been much more effective for
this reason snep believes in the cia he believes
in covert action against the third world countries
he believes in secrecy his only complaint was that
in vietnam there was a scandal at the end and
it was covered up in the evacuation of vietnam
i believe that the cia is is a moral uh tragedy
and that it's discredited the united states
and that it should be closed down that we should
revert to openness and telling telling it like it
is and telling the truth to people i think secrecy
doesn't work i think it masks and provides a cover
for people to do things which would definitely
be unacceptable to the society at large there's
nothing they do that is forthright positive that
you can stand up in church or wherever you go
and say i'm you know this is what i did last
week and i'm proud of it overseas it's all
you're a secret operative that means your
existence there is a lie you're pretending
to be a diplomat or a scholar or something which
you're not you're getting information covertly
and that means i mean we have diplomats in
these countries who talk to people endlessly
if the information is overtly available
they will get it you're there to bribe
and to induce people to be spies to commit treason
and you're also there to instigate activities
uh meaning subversion now these are heavy crimes
in every country in the world normally punishable
by death this is what the cia does i think
you also made the point before a well-taken
point again that if we just went into some of
these countries and and bought them with money
we'd be doing a lot more for our american
interests than if we tried to insidiously
you know overthrow their governments uh give lsd
to their leaders uh hire prostitutes to be filmed
in in compromising positions with other leaders
if we just went in and just pump some money into
them and we could probably buy more friends
that way than what the cia has been doing over
the last 20 years or so and and i even hedge
a little bit at the word buy friends you know
they have a in the ci we had a saying that uh you
you can you can rent an african but you can't buy
and uh because you know you make payments to
people and and uh as long as it's in their
interest to work with you they will and then when
you run out of uh the situation changes they're
going to work continue to work in their interests
which may not be parallel to yours any longer
but the point is that there are certain
techniques of interpersonal and international
relations which work on the long term and lying
cheating deceit and skullduggery don't work in
the long term you put yourself down yes if we
would go in with this 13 billion dollars alone
and deal overtly with people i i'm sure and work
for sincerely for human rights and for democratic
action so that those countries can try to have
governments like our own and systems like our own
surely we would be further ahead than we are
right now what about intelligence gathering
if they did that without the dirty tricks is
that possible you think well this question
always comes up and i've i've thought about
it a great deal for years now and i conclude
my own personal conclusion is quite firm that the
quality of our intelligence would be much greater
if we did not have the ci's covert collection
systems if you've read anything about the ci
and kept up with it you've noticed that the ci has
a long history of colossal intelligence failures
i don't mean covert operations that exploded
in our face and splattered us with with foul
propaganda and presence around the world
but i mean failure to to advise the united
states government on what is happening in a
given situation in the world one of the more
dramatic ones recently was iran a year ago
where the the week that iran fell apart that
it broke down completely leading directly to the
shah's ouster the ci head and its typewriters uh
a report a national intelligence estimate that
there was no serious opposition to the shah
in iran you have one side of the house the
operators of which i was one out there recruiting
spies and gathering intelligence you have the
other side of the house are phds and people with
master's degrees who are professional analysts
and theoretically the system should produce
good intelligence the argument they always throw
out is that the cia you have to have the human
agent to find out what people intend to do you
can get their capabilities from their missile
manuals and whatnot but what they intend
to do with those missiles you have to have
an agent penetration the fallacy of this is that
look at our own white house who would you have to
have as your spy in the white house to know what
the white house is going to do i mean obviously
the white house doesn't know what it's going to
do in a given situation until usually a day or two
after it's done it and particularly this one but
the next one one was wasn't much better and you
would have had to have had henry kissinger in your
pocket to have an estimate of what was being done
and what he was going to do spies are the most
unreliable source of information that can be had
a spy is by definition almost a person of
abnormal psychology normal people don't
betray their countries abnormal people do betray
their countries for various reasons a spy can be
an adventurer who's out to have fun making up
information a fabricator for various reasons
a double agent working for his own country and for
you or working for his own country against you or
working for the french against both you and russia
and you add this all up inside the cia we took
our own spy information with huge doses of salt i
could go on and on and on with with illustrations
i think the point that you made that's what was
well taken last time that you were on the show
is that a an agency that spends over 10 billion
dollars a year collects now less than oh less
than okay 13 billion collects a lot less than
10 percent of the actual hardcore intelligence
i think what was the exact percentage that you see
yeah we were told inside the ci on uh things like
mid-career course that the clandestine services
collect about four percent of the total gross
input and of that clearly a trivial amount was
important we all knew that but we always lived
for that one report that you get that would be
a big report that would tell everything but see
the problem with secrecy in an
intelligence business is that it it
look at the academic world and try to
picture it if you were able to write
your thesis to convince one person your your
monitor your your professor and no one else
uh you could go to the professor and find out what
his biases were and he didn't have to convince
anyone else but the dean and you could go to him
you could go the two of you and have dinner with
the dean and find out how he felt about that
subject and you go back and write it to make
sure he's pleased and that way you get your your
degree and you're happy and you succeed and the
quality of the information plummets obviously in
the ci you have to convince your boss and his boss
and it goes up the chain of command to what will
sell to the very secret very tight intelligence
establishment and you don't have to convince
anyone else and you can ask them first what
they want you to write and this is how you get
situations like in in iran where you're reporting
that the shah is very stable because the president
liked the shop before this president the others
like the shah there's a great interrelationship of
someone like the shah with his billions of dollars
and our own moneyed establishment well
there's also a big relationship between the
uh secret uh service of the sabbath and the
cia they feed each other information the ci
put the shah in power and helped him organize
the savak and there's no way that you could get
a report up through the chain of command in the
ci saying that the shah was bankrupt it would not
sell you'd get it it would be torn up it would
not get published i believe you mentioned last
time you're on the show that the um the cia has
helped directly or indirectly trained most of the
repressive police forces in the in the world
including um uganda including brazil where
they were torturing priests and what have
you in the philippines in korea the kci kci
mobutu and zaire the the emperor in
ethiopia his police force these were
all ci liaison developed organizations we
didn't train them all we're not the only
people in the world who indulge in unfortunate
police activities the kgb i don't think the cia
john doesn't the cia and its processes of
secrecy also undermine our own democracy at home
that if the policies are being made and carried
out information gathered that's only accessible to
a few people you have government by a corporate
elite that's not responsible to the democratic
process and again and again we paid for this
government by the people doesn't work if you
have a secret government just forget it stop
right there and it's a fallacy that this is
a more effective way of government because we've
seen again and again that this creates disasters
whether we're talking about iran and vietnam that
the corporate elite is not so all-powerful or so
efficient and maybe it's better to trust the
people and to debate some of the policies and
have ideas out in the open you know i watch on
things like this tom snyder show on nbc where the
the the turner is is on and given uh national
prime time to say that people who attack the
cia like stockwell and others bill shep and
others are unamerican they're traitors was
his word and as i asked glenn while he said that
and uh that's that's that who is america admiral
turner the director of the cia now who is american
turner insists on secrecy and he's lobbying for
laws to put people like me in jail for going to
the american people and telling what we've done
in america's name with america's tax dollars and
i ask you who is american who is the traitor to
the american system the john stockwell and frank
sneps and others who are exercising the american
principle of participating of working together
to discuss what our country is doing and try to
influence it lord knows i might be wrong in
my position towards angola or any position
in the world but it's the american process to
stand up and thrash it out and to debate it to
get both sides out in the open and to see which
side has the most merits and to let the people
decide in angola we would not have had that war
i warrant if there had been public debate you had
henry kissinger and bill colby of the cia wanted
this war and they got it because they were able to
do it in secrecy they lied to the senate in order
to get it done the american interests that were
in angola were significant you had gulf oil and
boeing doing business with the angolan government
they were not permitted to vote to discuss to
participate in the decision to go to war in angola
they were distressed when it happened when they
found out they were they were put out of business
temporarily by the secret war the american
churches had extensive missionary organizations
inside angola and they were not permitted to to
participate in the decision to go into angola
and and of course the american scholars who
were working and go traveling the exchanges
they were not permitted to participate you
had two individuals engineered this war who
had never been to angola and one of them
had never set foot in africa in his life
neither of them were africanists even and
they engineered a war and got it done because
of secrecy that's a very good point that you
raised a fact that not very many people know
is that the cia has been engaging or trying to
start these wars throughout the country at least
as far back as the days of alan dulles when alan
dulles tried to get nixon interested in starting
a war in laos back in 54 and 55 and when that
fell through he later repeatedly took marine
helicopters out of leias flew him into saigon
airport and created a threat where there had
been none before and hence their involvement in
southeast asia was alan dulles's attempt to start
a war over there which he later was successful
in doing although kennedy and johnson have taken
most of the blame for the escalation of the
war i'm glad you've said that because i say it
every time i lecture this this we're not playing
with little secret operations that affect no one
our our economic problems now are greatly tied
to this 165 billion dollar disaster in vietnam
that was a ci operation for at least seven
years before we began an overt military campaign
the the cia was deeply involved in a secret war in
southeast asia and trying to get the united states
government involved the first whistleblower was a
gentleman named paul sakwa who was not because of
the mood of the nation and the press and whatnot
was not given an audience he did not succeed in
speaking out he didn't have quite the whatever
it takes to write a book and get it published
but he resigned his job in the early
sixties in protest over the ci's efforts
to to lobby to [ __ ] the american public
about what was happening in vietnam and he
quit because the station in saigon was putting
out false information consciously discussing
their ploys to lobby to get the americans to
wake up to the threat and do quote the right
thing the c i remind remember has published
by then it published a couple of thousand
english language books that means for american
consumption that were secretly published by the
cia paying someone to write a book and and many of
those books at that time were about vietnam john
how have you succeeded in getting your message
across to the american people the mass media been
open and willing to discuss your more radical
ideas about abolishing the cia are they willing
to debate this last time i talked to you on the
phone you were talking about a letter that you'd
written to the new york times or a column for the
op-ed page about the abolition of the cia did they
ever publish that no the initial reaction of the
press and the mass media to me was was quite good
i would say there was 98 or 99 favorable the
one exception was the washington post which is
conspicuously washington establishment
newspaper and very close to the cia
but since the the initial impact of publicity of
who is john stockwell and what does he have to say
simultaneously as the months have tracked
there's been a change in the stance of our
of our government our establishment including our
press establishment uh responding to president
carter's line and vice president mondale's line
and admiral turner's lobbying to get off the ci's
back and permit it to get back to work and this
is very conspicuous if you read the editorial
sections of the washington post and the new
york times and time magazine and newsweek it
i mean it's not a covert subtle thing they're
coming out and saying it let's get off get off
the cia's back and let them get back to work
well of course work you know for the cia is is
highness crimes against humanity that's their
function that's what this shows something very
disturbing and that is how the mass media
and the political establishment go along
with these cia games that they're dupes or
are they willing accomplices how do you read
the role of the media you know i was complaining
about exactly this just a couple of days ago to
a friend of mine on the new york times and another
friend on the washington post on the long distance
telephone pointing out that our press has accepted
a stance which makes it sort of the the willing uh
participant in such government
misdeeds employees and and and blunders
what the press does essentially is they report
they try to report facts there are obvious biases
and whatnot but essentially they report facts
if president carter makes a speech the word
it's the fact that he made a speech and it's a
fact that he said this that or the other the fact
that everything he said is a lie the press doesn't
take it as their responsibility to point that out
so what they do is when a crisis like this
develops they quote they have you know there's the
the fact that the president said such and so and
somebody else and somebody else and senator church
and and uh senator jackson and who was a senator
from florida and their lies and misstates
statements and exaggerations are become the issue
even though they're false and even though everyone
involved in the press knows that they're false no
one in the press points this out to the readers
even the the editors who write their columns
rarely tackle the president or the secretary
of state or even an admiral turner they will take
him on some time but they how often do you read
an article did you after the the president's
speech the other night about this crisis was
there any editorial in a major newspaper that
said that he he lied on point after point after
point well you know i think john pointed out
before when he was on the show that the cia
is now i guess and admitted that they have bought
journalists in the past but you also pointed out
that a lot of events were staged for the benefit
of the press and stories are of course spoon fed
to the press by the cia and most of these go
unchallenged well there's a social relationship
and class relationship with the upper
people who control the newspapers
the old boy network this has been pointed out by
you know many months back when they were talking
about cia and press relationships the press
people of the top members of the press meet
in the bilderberg group along with members
of the cia they're in the same social clubs
they know each other on a personal basis so
naturally there's going to be a relationship and
what what evolves is the end result of all this
is that the ci's existence in the 50s and the 60s
when it galloped so it got so far out of line drug
sex experiments on unwitting american guinea pigs
uh uh assassination attempts of world leaders
very successful some successful and and
many many uh crimes that you can only describe
as depraved and vietnam war in the angular war
and coups and these things were permissible this
this evolution of this organization was possible
only with the indulgence of the press if the press
had been alert had been smoking this organization
out had been reporting that the ci is doing this
that and the other it could never have gotten by
with it this is my big disappointment now is to
see the nation the establishment turning and the
press establishment this is what i said over the
phone just yesterday i think the last conversation
was in this series of conversations was just
that that we're heading right back where we
were with the indulgence of the press the press is
cooperating with the government to put the ci back
in action just where it was mind you we've gone
through all of these exposures of 1975 and 76 and
and the ci's charter has actually been expanded
in the last three years since then well john you
were talking about the press and the fact that
they have not performed this watchdog function
even when they have the opportunity such
as your letter to the new york times
tell us about that well there have been there
have been a couple i don't i don't have the
time to spend a lot of time writing all the
letters that occur to me obviously i think we
all have that syndrome of reading something
and say boy i'd like to answer that myself
and occasionally i i read something and i really
do feel like i have something valid to say
but last year i got a call from an editor
of the new york times who said that
they had run an article from congressman stratton
a letter calling for a stronger expanded cia
and deploring the fact that the nation was weak
because the ci was in trouble it was broken down
they had run a letter from admiral turner
saying don't worry about it we need help we
need your support but but we're still out there
pitching so don't don't worry about it too much
but give us your help and this guy who's i believe
mind and heart are pretty honest and pretty much
in the right place called me and he said we gotta
have somebody come in and say wait a minute you
know the other side of that is is calling for a
closure of the cia and so why don't you write that
one stockpool and i spent three weeks i didn't do
anything else i wrote this thing and i rewrote it
i talked to him on the phone i rewrote it i
rewrote it i rewrote it i rewrote it and they
never ran it did i ever tell you why i talked
to him endlessly but essentially it boiled down
at the end he he quit returning my phone calls
because he was getting embarrassed because
essentially the the one editor comes up with an
article he likes and he shops it around the other
editors and if they all sort of agree it gets
momentum going until the boss says okay let's run
with it and he couldn't get the momentum the the
they just weren't going to run an article that was
anti-cia and they did not and my own experience
by the way in dealing with the new york times
that time and three other occasions and dealing
with washington post or i've also published
is that what the new york times is is at least
10 times as enlightened as the washington post
well this most recent letter which you wrote to
the new york times also reveals the same type
of thinking you wrote to them about the cuban
situation did you not yes i i wrote to him about
the cuban situation and uh i must admit this
time i was wiser and more experienced and also
the editor that i was talking to was quite
candid with me and quite straightforward
and he told me the reasons quite promptly why
they couldn't run it it was very frustrating to
me because i thought it should be run and he would
say he agreed and then he would say but it's not
going to run that's obviously it just you know and
that that small group of people that article was
not going to get priority over the others but the
same principle is that no one has pointed out on
in an international organ a western international
organ that this thing started with a ci operation
which got out of hand it was a little bit
more successful than the ci ever dreamed
and politics john you've been traveling a
lot in trying to help get established to
make arrangements for a documentary which will
be produced by bbc and be shown hopefully on pbs
and then hopefully by the affiliates
there's a lot of hope along the line there
you've made three trips to cuba what are your
impressions of cuba and the cuban people and
the system they have down there you know i when
i went to cuba the first time i felt a little
bit like one of these longhorn football players
might feel if during ou week he found himself
up in oklahoma and he's walking around with
people and he finds they're really nice people
you know the hysteria that you get and the bad
guys down there in cuba i'd been so brainwashed
even trying to be intelligent and see through
our ci propaganda i had been so brainwashed
against communism that i i just i couldn't believe
what i actually saw in cuba now mind you the
the nature and mentality of the cuban people
is i'm sure vastly different from the soviets
and the soviet union i've not been to moscow and
from everything i read about it and i'm not sure
how much of it cia written books and how much of
its legitimate books i'm not eager to go except
maybe as a tourist it strikes me as a fairly bleak
climate and a political atmosphere that i wouldn't
want to live in but that may not be the fault of
communism i got down in cuba and i found people
were incredibly open you know you have the
stereotype of the oppressive communist state
where people are afraid to talk and afraid to talk
to a foreigner and everything and they were urging
me to go out on the streets and talk to anyone i
wanted to and we would have these conversations
they wanted to tell me about their system they're
proud of it a lot of fun they wanted to tell me
about the operations they'd run they wanted to
brag about how they had clobbered us in angola
and whatnot and you know you're sitting there
at uh at a dinner you know hosted by the film
national film company and present at that
particular dinner of eight people or something
was a member of the central committee and you know
it's kind of a little bit heavy and and uh some
party commissar and then a couple of people make
films and then one interpreter and because i
don't speak spanish very well and this one
guy from the film institute everybody else
orders uh mojitos this national drink down there
except him he he orders a brandy alexander and
then he proceeds for 45 minutes to tell us all
how he's really an anarchist in the eye of this
communism and everything yeah okay it's better
than capitalism for cuba but basically i don't
believe in any government much less communism
or capitalism and he goes on and on with this
and the central committee member is arguing with
him and they're pouring their drinks and having
and you know this isn't the way you visualize
a communist country working they have they have
cuba was you know this is
abundantly documented it was the
brothel the whorehouse of of the west of the
united states it was where you went to play
playground for the month playground for
the mafia playground for the rich new
york bankers for the people in america
who had money they went to cuba to play
it wasn't a very good deal for the cuban people 80
percent of the country was owned by outside money
from from the sugar lands to the banks to what
factories there were it was owned by outside
castro got power organized it along communist
lines and now the country belongs to the people
and there is no way that ci propaganda can can
make a case that the people in cuba regret that
they have so much more of a stake in what's going
on in their country and they're so proud of it
now they're exceptions this is what they kept
telling me they said get out and talk to people
and you're going to find people who are unhappy
and they're going to tell you problems we haven't
solved all our problems lord knows every time
we solve a problem we create two more but we're
trying and we think the people are involved and
that's what it appeared to me they're certainly
more involved than they were 20 years ago when
they were owned by by the mafia john did you
see evidence of increased democratization going
on in cuba they had some local elections i think
last year for the first time and fidel seemed to
say that well before the people weren't ready for
elections but now they've had experience political
experience education and they're ready and we're
going to have more and more democracy did you get
a sense that democracy was on the rise there do
you have any well i very much did i i went i was i
visited schools and i visited apartment complexes
and i talked to people about how is you know how
is it working how do you elect your representative
and who does you know who who gets to vote and
we would go into schools now obviously uh my two
trips there where i'm very busy working on a film
project which does not have it has 20 or 30 to do
with cuba doesn't make me an authority on cuba i'm
not a cuban scholar i haven't been deep into the
place i've seen sort of you know whirlwind tours
through here and there when they would take me on
these tours they would sort of point to a side of
town where which was built up in the last 20 years
and then they'd make me say where to turn and make
me say where to stop and make me say what building
to go into and what floor to stop on and which
door to knock on to talk to people so they they
really were trying to make an effort to let me
find people to talk to and i came away with the
very definitely the strong impression that the
people are involved but they're also involved in
electing their own officials now again i hedge a
little bit because i'm not a cuban scholar or an
authority on cuba i understand your book is out of
paperback now yes how's the distribution of that
going you know it's gone extremely well but we
did not get a mass-market sale norton brought it
out in paperback and we got the best i could tell
bookstores around the nation began running it in
april and they still are and it
is selling it's selling quite well
it's an interesting thing you learn when you write
a book and of course you know you want to get
a paperback sale and you want to get a movie
if any author wants these things to happen
paperback sales are the paperback business
is perhaps one of the squirliest of
the nation's businesses the the rule
the reasons that they will give you
for choosing one book and not another one are
incomprehensible things like for example my book
frank snep's book my book about the ci sneps book
about the evacuation of the u.s from from vietnam
did not get a mass-market sale but phil caputo's
book rumors of war about a marine lieutenant's
experience in vietnam 10 years ago and how he
was disgusted with the war and whatnot was was a
million dollar paperback hyped and sold all over
the nation but they didn't pick up snaps book
which is what happened recently you know what it's
all about psy hirsch you know who broke me lie he
was in vietnam he got onto the story he refused to
drop it he resisted intimidation and he he cracked
me lie and a series of articles and he pounded
away until he got prosecution on it he kept
after it until he did milai and he wrote a book
and he's a talented writer and he wrote a book
about how i cracked me like the inside story of
what all happened trying to get this story out
and it didn't get a mass market sale
if you can believe that but it didn't
and so what they'll tell you in new york is
that they look for books that have a certain
little touch or flair that they can do one
book for a million dollars instead of 10 for
a hundred thousand dollars and so a lot of
very good books don't get paperback sales
mention the movie that might be made
of your book what's happening with
that project well i'm i'm learning as i go
along about books and about movies i've got
three parties two in new york and one in
california and one of the ones in new york
has california connections that are heavyweights
that are people that are capable of doing big
movies of books like this who are talking to
me very seriously i've had four written offers
proposals and i rejected them because there was
a flaw in each one that made them unacceptable
but pull for me a little bit of luck and and we
might get a really exciting movie about this this
book in search of enemies in closing i wonder if
you could tell your thoughts on how you feel about
your having taken a moral stand against the cia
criticized its crimes its dirty tricks whereas
william colby the former director who was in
charge of the phoenix program that was literally
a program of genocide has continued to defend the
cia and travels around the country in defense of
it and has gotten a lot of media play and is taken
as one of the pillars of the establishment whereas
you're looked up on a bit as an outsider how
do you feel about this plus the fact that colby
is now retired and rather opulent splendor in
his little sailboat and here you're struggling
to make ends meet well i don't have any great
sense of bitterness i think it's an unfortunate
statement about our society and the way things
are that someone can't like colby can have
blood up to his armpits the deaths and
programs that he personally ordered and managed
total at least 40 000 people dead and that's
just two programs there were a lot of others
and he retires with great
dignity as you say an honor
but i don't feel the slightest bit of lack
of dignity or dishonor in my own position
absolutely not i have not been i've not had a
single experience in which people made me feel
less worthwhile or less worthwhile than colby he
did run out his full career and get his pension
he did have his legal degree and because of
connections that he had through the cia he's
established a practice and comfortable business
was thrown his way i would say the only thing
that aside from the moral issue of a person
who has committed gross crimes against humanity
not nearly the scale and scope of
holocaust but the same principle
is admired and leads a dignified life aside
from that just practically the way he lives
the only thing that i regret is the trend in
the nation to give people like bi-universities
primarily to give people like colby and former
president ford and admiral turner and kissinger
abundant fully funded opportunities to lecture and
they stand up and lie and tell it like it was not
and people like myself who are willing to to go
before the same groups of people and tell it like
it is and tell the truth and tell what happened
and i lectured at uc san diego uh six weeks after
president ford had been there ex-president for
it and he had rece he had lectured for one hour
much of what he'd said was patent lies not true
statements he answered three questions and left in
a limousine and got ten thousand dollars i stayed
for about five hours talking to those people and
uh did my level best to tell the truth and provide
accurate insights and i got four hundred dollars
and this and this is unfortunate it's it's a
further statement of the trend of the times
the establishment is back in people like colby
are getting a wider audience turner is invited
to lecture and permitted to stand up and deliver
his lies and he's funded for it yes i regret that
i have i have to pay my rent and i'm succeeding
in paying my rent but i would be a little bit
happier with the situation if i had more
opportunities to lecture even than i do
and more economic freedom to to get about more
and lecture more to people that are interested but
that's a small detail and it certainly was not a
surprise when i let's face it when you're sitting
inside the ci at the level of a colonel a younger
man you're not a director you haven't had national
international prominence and you quit the cia and
you you attack them you write a book exposing them
you're you don't expect to have the ci and the
establishment pat you on the back and buy your
limousine and set you up for life you know that
you're going to be a little bit of an outsider at
best in fact you worry about things much more
profound than that are you going to survive
are you going to be hurt or your children going to
be hurt these are the things that you think about
and decide probably not you will survive and they
won't bother your family but certainly you're not
going to be offered a hundred thousand dollar
a year job with exxon or gulf oil or some such
well john we really thank you for dropping
by again these are really exciting programs
and from the response the people
and the various audiences we've had
also consider it that way so keep it up
i'm really proud to have been part of this
show it's a very worthwhile show well come
back again all right thanks john goodnight
you remember the movie on television a while
back with muhammad ali called freedom road
about a freed slave during reconstruction
well we saw it here in austin but the folks
in boston didn't get to see it station wbz tv
said well due to the current racial tension
that exists in the boston area and because it
wishes to avoid contributing either directly
or indirectly to these tensions wbz tv will not
air the nbc movie now one black person said well
they don't cancel any white shows because
it's going to stir up the white kids
well we i guess we stir up most everybody here
in alternative views news magazine least we try
hey
good evening welcome to alternative views as
you might guess the tv presentation of the
events in iran has been atrocious there's been
a complete failure to explain the events and
to raise the real questions confronting the
american government and the american people
there have also been some extremely irresponsible
examples of reporting by barbara walters of abc
and tom snyder and nbc which we'll discuss
tonight in order to present a more rational
discussion of the political moral and
legal issues concerning the events in iran
tonight on alternative views we will have visiting
with us john stockwell the former cia case officer
who will help explain some of the role of the cia
in the iranian situation we will have john duncan
of the texas civil liberties union that will talk
about the possible violation of the civil rights
of iranian students and we will have
christie birdfeather a representative of
a coalition against racism and intervention
in the middle east that we'll talk about a
local group that is trying to prevent a military
intervention in that area let's have some news
as usual we start off with a report on oil there's
the liberty lobby magazine spotlight reports that
a congressman says that exxon actually rigged the
oil crisis or one of the participants in rigging
the oil crisis which we've just gone through
we've been telling you that for a long time they
he points to a gao report along this line and also
the a cia report which is a rather curious thing
where our own cia is doing undercover intelligence
works against the so-called american multinational
corporations i guess that tells them for
what it is but now the militant newspaper
also has an analysis of what is happening in
relation to oil and they say as in the past opec
is falling following behind the price increases
of the major oil companies and it works this way
it looks like the same thing was
happening as several months back
that the spot price for oil in other words the
independent market is roughly forty dollars a
barrel which is considerably more than what the
oil companies pay opec under long-term contracts
so what the oil companies do they buy the oil from
opec go and sell it on the spark spot market make
huge profits out of it then the arabs they say
hey we want part of that gravy too so we're going
to raise our prices so that we can get more and
then back and forth it goes and the whole price
just gets out of hand it's very much controlled
it's not out of hand but we get it in the neck
but actually oil consumption
in the u.s is down right now
the industry deliveries of gasoline
dropped five percent in september
and for heating fuels a drop of 7.2 percent
uh does this go along with what you've been uh
reading also along the lines of what's happening
in the oil world well it's obvious that oil prices
are not a function of demand um in the face of
declining demand oil prices continue to skyrocket
and this really zeros in on the 18 major oil
firms that are in absolute total control of
the world oil situation uh it's completely
out of the hands of the government right
well and now there's more hoarding of oil going on
they're getting ready for another round of big of
shortages and boosts the key reason for the high
spot price right now is that the oil companies
are hoarding millions upon millions of barrels of
oil business week reports that stockpiling is uh
going on that the tanks are being
filled worldwide and also the economist
says that they're telling the tankers to slow
down steam slowly across the ocean because we
want to make sure that as little oil as possible
actually gets to the market because if too much
comes and there'll be perhaps a drop in price
and maybe even a shattering of the uh of opec
well a few weeks ago frank the wall street journal
actually came out and said that indeed a handful
of oil companies are jacking up the world price of
oil but they failed to name the companies involved
well the recent energy department report said
that oil refiners increased the retail price
of home heating oil twice as fast as the price of
crude oil between january 77 and 79 and there was
an unpublicized civil trial in nova scotia canada
back four years ago but nothing was reported until
1979 in september 30th in the new york times but
it showed a very vivid picture of the fraud and
profiteering by exxon which of course is the
world's largest oil company it showed that
the company disguised increases in its profit
margins by backdating them to blend in with the
price increases tied to the opec price increases
they use transactions among their subsidiaries to
justify the price increases to their customers and
they also used offshore corporations to launder
and artificially inflate the price increases these
corporations were organized to avoid millions of
dollars in taxes well the big banks do that also
for sure to underline the importance of this frank
most of us i think are well aware now that the
oil companies third quarter profits this year were
absolutely astronomical some firms reporting
profits up as much as two thousand percent
and of course the uh the retort to this uh by a
company spokesman was that these these profits
were made strictly from overseas operations
well let's let's outline how profits are made
in overseas operation exxon or buys from one of
its subsidiaries in saudi arabia at 18 it turns
around and sells it to a subsidiary in the bahamas
at 25 and we're looking at seven dollars profits
made from oversea operation now the subsidiary
in the bahamas does nothing more to the oil
then turn around and sell it to an exxon refinery
in the united states for thirty five dollars
there's another ten dollars that is called
profits made from overseas operations frank
well what else you got any goodies there well
along the of course we seem to be doing most of
our news on all companies lately but you know
that's where the action is you know it's like
they asked willie sutton why he kept robbing
banks and he said that's where the money is
this is under the category of hedge you win tails
i lose frank phillips petroleum and the government
reached a 200 million dollar accord phillips
along with city service along with gulf oil
car mcgee and most of the major oil
companies have been have been guilty
which is no surprise to most of us of
overcharging us billions of dollars on on
what they um what they're making and so phillips
has agreed that even though they didn't do this
that they would not only not do it again in the
future but they have agreed to quote pay back
unquote the money now this is how they
plan to pay the 200 million dollars back
it'll come in the form of 100 million dollars in
added spending on oil production 22 million to
add to the supplies of heating oil and 75 million
in price boost that they will forego so when when
we find somebody guilty of over um i won't say
criminal but overt unconscionable activities
um they don't really have to pay the money back
they simply agree not to charge us in the future
this is the second time in two years that they've
done that yeah there was a story exactly like that
uh about nine months ago yeah uh a related thing
you remember several uh several months ago al we
talked about the a solar the hydrogen development
company that developed a car which they said
they could mass produce it's an inexpensive
photovoltaic cell that would convert sunlight
into electricity the electricity is then used
in an electrolytic process to convert water
into liquid hydrogen which the company officials
say is non-explosive and is similar to propane
as fuel which means it can be burned naturally
and internally cheap and totally non-polluting
too yeah but now the bad news and that was a
great thing because a big breakthrough right
well u.s district court in los angeles is
seeking with the company sued in the court
seeking eight million dollars in damages against
the u.s department of energy in the uh general
services administration the company contends
that former secretary of energy james schlesinger
arbitrarily blocked the company proposal
for a five million dollar order to convert
government-owned automobiles to run on hydrogen
and one company officials said we've successfully
run a hydrogen car all the way across the united
states and if we're allowed to enter the market we
will wipe out a multi-trillion dollar industry the
oil industry of course will not just be competing
with them we'll wipe them out the company claims
that the u s energy cartels are responsible for
the company's failure to get this federal
endorsement which is no surprise but it also
points up to the many many times we've pointed
out on this program that there are many workable
alternatives not only to the internal combustion
engine but improvements on it and also many
workable alternative sources of energy which can
be tapped right now if it were possible to do so
well speaking of being tapped well no i guess
that'd be too cynical there we've had before
stories about right-wing cubans down in miami who
were just terrorized people particularly other
cubans who are wanting to show what life is like
down in cuba right now and maybe show films or
get together to discuss in the situation in cuba
and try to get people to go back just to visit
well you remember the cuban film memories of
underdevelopment it's been here in austin a couple
of times there was a meeting in which people
were viewing the film it was broken up by our
members of an anti-castro group called abdallah
they smashed the film projector beat up brigade
activists and stole several hundred dollars and
fled after firing shots in the air then the film
was rescheduled to show in temple israel in miami
but after several threats by these right-wing
thugs the temple administrators canceled the
showing this is a continuation of things that
have been happening down there what's next this is
related to a show that we're going to be showing
i guess this this show on iran
as a high school civics class in maine
took the bill of rights took the name
off it made a petition out of it and of course
i guess characteristic of the american public
65 percent of the people signed a
petition banning the bill of rights
because they were afraid it might cuddle
criminals we've seen similar studies done
in detroit um where 60 of the people
in detroit didn't even know what it was
and about 75 percent or 80 of the republic thought
it was communist plot and so we're talking about
violation of rights in this country it's it's
kind of interesting to put it into perspective
that the majority of american public simply don't
they don't know what their rights are and when you
show them what the bill of rights looks like they
think it's either communistic or um or something
that that is you know in favor of criminals as
opposed to the average american citizen also
in the news this is something i usually do before
thanksgiving since most of you by the time you see
this will have already consumed mass quantities of
your thanksgiving dinner i would like to reiterate
where your meal is more than likely to
come from here in the state of texas
if you had shrimp in texas it may have come from
coca-cola deviled eggs may have come from cargill
tomatoes may have come from the ogden corporation
your beef probably came from gulf and western
sugar from h.l hunt creamed by etna life and
casualty citrus fruits from international minerals
and chemicals almonds and walnuts from getty oil
company your macadamia nuts from iu international
duckling probably came from schlitz your
turkey came from eastmark your applesauce
came from american brands which is not too bad
because at least they are a food conglomerate
potatoes came from u.s steel carrots
from teneco chicken from greyhound
ham from ltv corn by boeing if you had if you
had wine it might have come from prudential if
you had mushrooms it might have come from clorox
and that's frightening because we usually think
of clorox in terms of bathroom bowl cleaners
oh that's better than wine coming white wine
and if you had salmon it might have come from
unilever so as you're thinking back on your
thanksgiving dinner keep keeping keep in mind
the corporations that are responsible for it
well let's see what is happening
in the rest of the world
to begin we'll talk to john stockwell and
we'll ask john why are the iranians hate the
shot so much and why are they so angry with the
american government what is the facts behind this
you know i see the situation in iran as being
symptomatic of a world scale problem that that i
and others have been signaling in books and
lectures and articles for several years now of
an extremely callous and abusive policy by our
government particularly the secret government
the cia towards people in the third world and by
this i mean this endless string of covert actions
that have been designed that have killed a lot of
people and been designed in many cases to install
shahs and samosas and support the batistas and
and put the pinochets in power and these dictators
that we've affiliated ourselves with supported
put in power propped them up trained their secret
police have in many cases proceeded to kill a
lot of the local citizens and in country after
country there is great bitterness mounting towards
the united states for the cia's actions in many
cases of course most american citizens are pretty
innocent but but our ci is not innocent and this
is the case in point the cia in 1953 pulled off a
coup kermit roosevelt the ci has been very proud
of this action and roosevelt used to lecture all
of the training classes including mine in 1965.
telling how he ousted mosudek and installed
the shah in power and then they would also
mention training formation and training of
the savak the police to keep him in power
the proceeded through the sabbath to kill to
liquidate large numbers of iranian citizens
60 000 killed perhaps although obviously you can
never get firm figures on something like that and
100 or two hundred thousand who's who physically
remained or at least their lives were ruined and
uh needless to say that that sort of thing upsets
people there's a lot of iranians alive today who
have loved ones who are dead at the hands of
the shop and they're painfully aware the ci has
boasted endlessly about putting a shot in power
and they're painfully aware of this association
even then we were the the coup that ousted the
shah romani getting getting power the religious
revolt there we were still doing okay until we
rubbed the final salt in the wound by bringing
the shah into this country now to the iranian
government and the iranian people he is he is
a monster he committed gross crimes against the
iranian people and specific iranian individuals
and they have called since the the coup and he
fled the country they've called for him to be
returned so he could be put on trial for crime
specific crimes murder and all kinds of mayhem
yeah john i think they have evidence john that he
sacked somewhere between one to 17 billion dollars
out of the iranian economy in addition to killing
people yes massive theft and we and various other
uh prominent nations have instead of cooperating
to extradite him to have him stand trial for these
bloody and venal crimes we've given him haven
and the reaction is that the iranian citizens
the students got overreacted of course i don't
condone they're taking over the embassy but that's
what you can expect when you treat people that
way but john i saw today in the spotlight magazine
they always seem to have an undercover person or
a spokesperson somewhere who's willing to talk
they were saying that their man in the hospital
where the shaw is so the shot really doesn't have
cancer at least nothing that's very threatening
to his life what he does have is a simple case
of gallstones and which could be corrected by
surgery but they're actually keeping him there
as part of the ploy that he's really well
enough he could go back and uh he wouldn't
be very well after he went back but i mean
he could travel well he would be tried and
what would happen to him would be up
to the the iranian system of justice
but uh i personally i've watched the news fairly
carefully and i've it seems to be absolutely
uh unacceptable intolerable that we would send
him back we would permit him to be extradited and
yet it seems to me that we've staked our honor on
the support and protection of a man who's somewhat
of a monster and it's going to be one of the
greatest tragedies of our modern history if our 60
government officials die to protect the shah i
don't know how other people feel about this but
i just can't i can't see why we couldn't have sent
him back to begin with well even before that john
isn't there a very serious question of why carter
let the shah in the country in the first place
it was known that this would enrage the iranian
people it would be a gross insult to them
and intelligence sources showed that there
would be a possible threat to the american
embassy there if the shah was led into
the country don't you think this was
a gross air of carters incomprehensible it's an
arrogance of course looking at it other ways it's
it's the kind of arrogance that we've been guilty
of for the last 30 years particularly towards the
third world and third world sensibility so
it's not surprising to see us do this but it
was it's obviously been proven to be a colossal
blunder well carter didn't do this on his own um
david rockefeller and henry kissinger lobbied
quite heavily to get the shaw into the country
well we uh discussed this last week this
kissinger connection and it's interesting
that george ball the former under secretary
of state was on meet the press this sunday
and made precisely this point that if it wasn't
the obnoxious in his words pestering of the state
department and carter by henry kissinger the shah
would have never been led into the country the
next day kissinger was harassed by a lot of news
people and he denied this he claims in april of
this year he did ask the state department to let
the shah in to meet our commitments to him but he
hadn't spoken for months to the state department
they refused to comment on this this was also
confirmed once again the spotlight they talked
i guess under the table or had under the table
spokesperson with the house speaker tip o'neill
who corroborated this that the combination not
only of kissinger but david rockefeller and john
j mcclure these are the top people at the american
and the apex american power structure they're
the ones who put such pressure against carter too
denials in the past haven't haven't held a
whole lot of water when you consider that john
stockwell here was working in angola at the time
kissinger was was telling the american congress
that yes we don't have any people in angle and
we don't have any money going in there either
an even more disturbing
story about henry kissinger
appeared yesterday in the new york times by
anthony lewis who claims that kissinger has told
the shot to hardline it not to leave the united
states unless the carter administration publicly
invites him to do so i think the government
particularly the rockefellers and kissingers
feel that at all costs we must support the
dictators which we put into power and through
whose good services in the country particularly
to their police and the secret police
they maintain law and order so that the
rockefeller multinationals and corporations
and banks can exploit the countries and without
this implied promise of taking care of these
dictators after they are deposed then they're
less likely to want to cooperate with the us
while they're in power that's kissinger's position
this is what he urged on carter that if we don't
take care of our friends our friends are going to
desert us and they're going to not have confidence
in it but but it's very important to understand
that you're talking about at that point that
david rockefeller and henry kissinger's friends
and not the friends of the american people it's
it's the the dictators who are doing business the
pinochet is doing business with itt and it's very
nice for itt but it doesn't make any it doesn't
make for a better deal for the american people
and this is something that we must distinguish
christie you have uh some information on just
how the shah enriched himself do you notice one
interesting point i've just found out is that the
shah has taken ten percent of the gross profit
of iranian oil since 1963 this is every year
10 and if you can imagine how much money that is
so when they talk about 12 billion dollars being
taken out of iran by the shah and his family you
can well believe it you know also you think okay
where is it going i mean isn't going to a sock
somewhere it's probably undoubtedly in one of the
david rockefeller's banks it's probably in europe
also the shaw has stated that he has between 1 in
10 million dollars and actually i believe that
he has that in his own personal bank account
but then you talk about his family and
all their bank accounts around the world
it adds up fast well john if i go back a second
to the cia and iran not only has iran itself
been a play toy in the cia for so many
years but also in that general area
the cia has ultimately supported and deserted
the kurds and their attempts to have uh
their own state there have they not and this
has kept the whole pot boiling yes that's
the second major crime against humanity that the
cia has perpetrated in iran was in 1975 the shah
had a confrontation going with the the government
of iraq and as a ploy to to bring them to terms he
asked kissinger to have the ci intervene on
behalf to support the kurds to incite them to
to rebel in iraq and the ci went in with a
major covert action program and armed them
and encouraged them to fight then it worked and
the iraqi government came to terms and the shah
then called off the ci told kissinger to stop
supporting the kurds as part of his conditions
of agreement with the iraqi government and so
the ci did the problem of course was that this
left the kurds dangling the the the iraqi army was
beginning to move and it withdrew the support from
them so the ci had incited them and encouraged
them to revolt and then uh uh dropped them cold
and and it's it's impo another area where it's
impossible to get figures but a hundred thousand
or so were killed and uh kissinger when he was
asked about this by the congress recalled he said
that you shouldn't confuse uh covert action or the
intelligence business with missionary work which
strikes me as a fairly cynical statement from a
very cynical man nobel prize winner incredible
blood blood to his armpits at least thousands
and thousands and thousands of people dead in
this world because of whimsical adventures
that henry kissinger has ordered and
he gets peace prizes he also gets a lot of money
there was an article recently on his income and
he receives regular incomes from the rockefellers
he got five million dollars for his book he got a
million dollars from nbc as a commentator so who
says crime does not pay there's another aspect of
well this would be the overt part of it and
that's the arming of the iranian army itself
i was reading somewhere where until south vietnam
collapsed at that time that the iranian army
actually became the third largest in the world in
terms of hardware expense but that's how much we
had armed the shah this raises a a very disturbing
question about iran and that is the specter of
military solutions just today president carter
said in the newspaper that carter made it clear
that the honor of the country comes before the
lives of the hostages and there's been quite a few
all of them are involving some risk and
i think our military is uh likely to be
called upon to take some risk and i think
it's important that the country be prepared
uh to do that in a situation like this where
the country is really being blackmailed
by a foreign leader uh who seems to be more of a
religious fanatic than a politician does that mean
that there comes a point in time when those 49
people that are in that embassy become expendable
you want to take a cut at that yeah i i think that
in the uh in the broad context of international
relations uh that time is uh fast approaching
and i i think that you will see very shortly
kamini takes some actions that might well
be even more severe than he's taken already
against the hostages there's some risk
that i think all of us are expected to take
the risk that none of us would want to take though
is to be put out on the point and then abandoned
by the nation i think it's important that uh
anytime our people are called upon to take risks
in the name of our nation that our nation be
willing to take those risks too and i think
that's the watershed where we are right now and
we've tried to find a sort of a no risk uh a way
out of this dilemma and there isn't any well john
i'd like to pose the question to you is military
intervention a viable option what would be the
consequences of a military intervention in iran
what would happen if we either blockaded iran
or bombed their oil or tried to quote liberate
the hostages through military intervention
well we would be throwing a great big dash of
kerosene into a very hot situation in the
world violence breeds violence and we have
an enormous islamic population in the world
today somewhat antagonized by our recent policies
if at the present time there are a number
of people outside of iran muslims who do
not support the khomeini and what he's doing
against our embassy our installation there but
i think it's certain that if we invaded iran
and killed iranians for revenge or whatever
we would turn a broad segment of those people
against us they would side with the dead
muslims and not with us and that would have to
be let's back up a minute and note that there
is no military action possible now while the
hostages are there it would be certain death
for the hostages it would only be punitive after
and uh which they're talking about which they're
definitely talking this is why it's so disturbing
carter just said that the honor of the country is
more important than the lies of the hostages we
have got to learn sooner or later and the sooner
the better it's a very dangerous world we live
in we've got to learn as soon as possible that
you can't bludgeon the world into submission it's
not possible there's too many people out there
it's too big a world we can't go out there
and hit them all over the head and make them
do what we want them to do we have to work
with people and live with them on this globe
and if we're going to do so peacefully as the
most powerful nation and the richest nation we
have to establish sincere diplomatic efforts and
leadership towards tolerance and peace instead of
violence and bloodshed i think there's another
situation would happen if there was military
intervention and i think we saw the previews
of that in pakistan where the word that the
mosque in mecca had been desecrated there was a
violent revolt to the pakistan people against the
american embassies and evidently in turkey in
bangladesh in several islam islamic countries
there have been these revolts against the american
embassies so if there was a war with iran if there
was military action against iran wouldn't there
be an explosion of the islamic world that would
constitute a tremendous danger to u.s personnel
and uh property as well as the specter of the
oil cut cut-offs of opec boycotting oil certainly
certainly catastrophic for the american economy
and and back to this point in pakistan
and the way they reacted you know it's
hard for americans to understand that kind
of passionate overreaction against us and we
weren't even at fault you know the innocent
americans what what american people have to
fix in their minds very firmly and remember in in
evaluating these situations is that we have been
guilty of bloody aggressions in every corner of
this globe in the last 30 years through the cia
country after country about 30 countries
that the cia has has instigated fomented uh
actions in which local citizens were were killed
the local people always knew that this was being
done by the ci they knew you know their loved ones
were dead and they knew who had done it secrecy
in each of these situations was to keep us
the american people from knowing what our
government was doing and and the result we have a
situation in the world where we feel misunderstood
i believe the great majority of the american
people feel like they're pretty nice people and
people in iran and pakistan and elsewhere are very
quick to believe that we would support something
against mecca because we've supported actions in
so many other places that killed so many people
they're very passionate about having their own
relatives killed by by the american organization
just as the americans are passionate
about their feelings of the hostages
just look at public reaction to what happened in
iran you know there were people in the streets
screaming things like nuke iran and
throwing rocks and they became very
passionate and no one had even died yet
and no one had died yeah they were just
hostile people here really don't have any
concept of what goes on around the world i think
that during the iranian revolution it was
something like close to a million people died
i think between in the last 10 years and up to the
revolution it was incredible amounts of people and
i don't think people here really understand the
full scope of that i'm certain i'm certain we
don't and and i only hope that americans will
focus on this and understand it and begin to
reverse these policies to suppress and inhibit
the the kissinger type reaction towards the world
and uh straighten our act out before it's too
late before we we have tehran type situations
in every corner of the of the globe isn't
this working actually to the benefit of not
only committee but carter itself and it's both to
their benefit to keep dragging it out carter we
know is that carter we know is in trouble at home
with all kinds of political and economic problems
and humanity is in definite uh well there's some
question just how much control he actually has
over the country when gerald ford was president
um he went to war we went to war temporarily
a country that barely was out of the stone
age and they wanted to make ford look decisive
which kind of brings up the specter of
the people in the administration causing
this particular incident you notice that
president carter has gotten off of cuba
now that he's got iran to focus on he was in his
campaign addresses he was always mentioning cuba
in hostile terms and now that tehran is heated
up he's off of cuba's back for the time being but
this is also resulting in the bottom line as well
bottom line many increased defense expenditures
they were saying in the paper yesterday that
this is being upped again so from 140 to 160
billion it makes makes you wonder if there's cia
involvement in the takeover of the embassy you
know it brings out your paranoid all apparently
all the way around well this is why it's such an
explosive issue because the interests of certain
politicians romania and iran and carter in the
united states are invested in this situation
and they have more to gain politically it seems
by hardlining it than by taking a rational
orientation to try to find a solution to it
john don't you think that the cold war policy is
really detrimental to the interests of the people
of the united states that we at home face the
dangers of war of economic deprivation because of
this foreign policy so that it's in our interest
to find a peaceful diplomatic solution to this
absolutely i've said it many many times in my
lectures and appearances that the cia is the
greatest enemy and threat to the united states
national security of any organization in the
world it's gotten us in more and more serious
trouble than the kgb ever has or could or or
any of our enemies by that i mean the vietnam
war was as as as we said before on the show
for seven years until their propaganda heated it
into an overt intervention and look what that cost
us in terms of the vision of the country in terms
of economic resources squandered and 165 billion
dollar debt that we're still coping with and
an enormous reaction on the part of the world
against us and we also have our our aggression
against cuba and against china and against chile
and against angola against the kurds and many
many others that the cia did that it's digging
a big deep hole for the united states and the sad
thing is that the cia is a an unconstitutional and
extra constitutional organization it functions
illegally our constitution is pretty clear that
this sort of thing the american people should be
able to participate in deciding if we want to have
wars and how our tax dollars are spent and by
functioning secretly the ci is able to get us in
get us into war without the
people getting to debate and vote
and now what's happened in a situation like
this is that the iranian situation is perfect
it brings hits the xenophobia button it hits
the racism button and our civil liberties are in
severe danger if for no other reason because the
iranians in this country their civil liberties are
in danger and that's where john duncan has been
fighting of probably an unpopular battle isn't it
let's um move to this issue again john there
has been we've seen a very ugly racist backlash
against iranians in the united states we've
seen a lot of violence against iranian people
in new jersey this one company fired
all their bus drivers that were iranian
greenville state college and i think north
carolina kicked out on moss the iranian students
a massage parlor in austin had a sign in their
window no iranians and the government has
fueled this in a sense in the deportation
order for iranian students whose papers
aren't in order that's in the aclu in the last
couple days questioned the legality of some of
this maybe you can discuss the legal issues our
national organization has filed two lawsuits
one has to do with the right to march
and demonstrate in washington d.c
we won everything on that one except the question
of whether or not you could march in petition
in front of the white house you get very
bad law sometime when you get a hysterical
political situation and this is a case i
think a very bad law in which we allow the
iranian government to take some action that is
repulsive to all of us and then our government
uses that action as a reason to suspend
the first amendment to the u.s constitution
it's something that the public should not
tolerate the second line our area that
we've had real difficulties with and i think
where the carter administration has really
fueled the flames of anti-iranian re uh resentment
in this country is the order to all iranian
students and all those iranian visas to appear
before december the 14th to prove that they are
in the country illegally our national organization
has filed a suit challenging this it was filed
on november 27th it is a suit that says in effect
that you cannot single out iranians and have a
special set of rules concerning their deportation
the fifth amendment and the fourteenth amendment
of the u.s constitution says equal protection of
the laws for all persons past court decisions have
said that aliens are entitled to equal protection
of the laws and what we're saying here is that you
cannot single out a particular nationality and
apply the immigration laws in an unequal fashion
john is there a parallel to the situation
of japanese people in world war ii where
they were swept up in a dragnet and put in
concentration camps and being discriminated
against purely because of their nationality what's
the similarities and differences okay our office
a week or so ago addressed this particular issue
in terms of a step moving in that direction
a fear that if the government did not back off
and quit make fueling these flames within the
uh this country and quit making statements that
in effect encourage people to take actions against
iranians such as a current up in dallas yesterday
where a iranian-owned business was fire bombed and
burned out that we would wind up with the
sort of thing that we had after world war
one with the germans in which there was a whole
lot of anti-german sentiment addressed not against
just aliens but u.s citizens of german background
or if you look at what happened in world war ii
there the government went much further it was not
just japanese aliens that got picked up and sent
to concentration camps in wyoming and arkansas
it was japanese-american citizens the people of
japanese ancestry who were just picked up their
businesses were taken and they were shipped
and placed in concentration camps in wyoming and
arkansas without reference to whether where their
political sentiments lay the mere fact of ancestry
resulted in our country doing this and yet they
did not do it in hawaii where the percentage
of japanese americans is considerably higher
john when this greenville state college
kicked out all of the students this was
declared illegal wasn't it i think any state
university that kicks out an iranian student
has violated that student's constitutional
protections as guaranteed under the 14th amendment
i don't think there's a bit of doubt about that
and that any official action of that variety would
be a violation of constitutional rights there's
a debate now going on here at the university of
texas where it's a question of whether
the college campuses should allow this
ins investigation of iranian students on campus
the university of southern california and the
university of california berkeley has said
that the government should not interrogate
and check up on iranians on campus
whereas at texas they have what is your
organization's or your own position on this
well our national spokesman on that just
made a statement i think that it was a matter
of discretion my personal viewpoint would
be that the university has no obligation to
provide ins with the facilities in which to
interrogate and photograph iranian students
that if ins wants to set up their own thing
they're they've got a legal right to do so though
we're challenging the whole procedure and that the
universities are not required to cooperate with
them there's another question just simply of the
attitudes of american people towards iranians and
it seems there's been some quite gross racism in
regard to iranian people in the united states
which has sort of fueled this intolerance
you were on television recently in a call-in
program and you covered some of this material
what were some of the responses of the people
calling in well there was a whole lot of just
pure anti-iranian uh uh questions i am you know
personal attacks in terms of if you're not far
you know if you're criticizing what we're doing to
the iranians in this country you must be with them
a failure to understand that there are
constitutional protections and the reason
that we have some degree of order and some degree
of freedom in this society is it because we have
a constitution and rules the government has to
abide by but there was a good deal of hostility
directed at i think anyone who speaks out for
iranians this is also completely irrational in
that a good many of the iranian students here
in the united states are not supporters of the
ayatollah or the actions that he has been taking
but they've just been blanketed by their race
as oh there's no doubt about that in fact
if you look at what happened when kamini
came to power there were a number
of iranian students over here who
livelihood depended upon a check coming through
the iranian embassy and as a result of tai's
family ties back to the shah and his regime there
were certain students who got their money cut off
suddenly they were left in this country with no
visible means of support and in some cases having
relatives shot by the revolutionary council and
such and a prospect for going to prison if they
went back in fact the immigration naturalization
service had been teletyping messages repeatedly
to their offices prior to this whole episode
saying no deportation of any iranian student
until the mid-1980s at which time we will review
this it was a conscious decision on the part of
the state department saying there are students
here who will have real political difficulties
and may wind up as political prisoners if we
send them back to khamenei into that regime
and if you look at those who are illegal i would
suspect that the major portion of the anti-kumani
group of students in this country are those who
are the illegal students who have had their money
cut off and it's totally counterproductive to
hand him those that he'd most likely to lock up
well we would offer them i'm sure the same
political asylum that we have the shaw
right well christy you know a lot of iranians
how do they feel about this are they really
confused and scared you get a lot of different uh
viewpoints they're all scared and confused in fact
a lot of my friends right after this whole thing
hit were scared to go out to the grocery store
to buy groceries because they knew that people
would be hanging out of cars you know throwing
rocks i know people you know who've had their
lives threatened gotten threatening phone calls
and in a way though you really can't blame
the american people for getting this stirred
up there's a vacuum of information in this
country and what's really going on in iran
and just one example that really upset me was
when some of the black hostages were coming home
zeroing in on their mothers crying as you know
they were getting the information about their
sons coming home it really whipped up a lot of
sentiment in this country whereas you know they
should didn't show at all how iranian mothers felt
when their sons were getting shot you know it was
incredible how they manipulated these people and
whipped up this xenophobia as someone said earlier
and you know what kind of reaction can you expect
most iranians here understand that you know but
a lot of them have different
positions most of them do support
the embassy takeover maybe not the means by which
they did it it means they use you know taking
hostages but they do support the motives you know
trying to let america know that they mean business
about getting the shah back in iran and that sort
of sums up how a lot of my friends feel at least
well i think we should talk about then we've
been talking a little bit here and there about
the mass media treatment of this but this is
certainly one of the big factors in keeping the
fanning the flames and just like john when we
were talking in one of our past programs about
the mass media and its handling of the situation
with cuba and the russian troops there the if the
media of television had handled it differently
it would have been an entirely different located
thing which people would have seen the absurdity
of those few russian troops down there was
training but they didn't they kept fanning it this
goes all the way the same here this goes all the
way back earlier frank to how the american media
failed to cover the events in iran they failed to
show the torture that was going on under the shah
they failed to show the popular resentment that
was building up in the people in iran we had to
show on alternative views about a month before the
homeani revolution in which we were had iranian
students talking about the opposition movement
towards against the shah that was reaching epic
proportions it wasn't even mentioned on network
television there was there wasn't a awareness
in the part of the american people that the
iranians were being tortured systematically by the
shah and they were beginning to resist moreover
there has been a glorification of the shah by the
american media sort of a moderate liberal reformer
a friend of the american people this brings us
to the despicable barbara walters and her fawning
over the shaw his majesty his greatness and last
week i was extremely upset by this interview
that barbara walters got with asha she
was the only reporter that was allowed
to talk to him in the last eight months and
she completely uh whitewashed this whole
issue of the shot trying to make it appear as if
he had to come to america for medical treatment
or he would have died she also said some
interesting things about his uh wealth
she claimed that the shah said that he
was only worth from 100 to 200 million
um dollars oh poor baby poor baby and abc and
barbara completely accepted this as if the stories
of his having taken millions billions
of dollars out of iran were a myth
well this can be documented how much money the
shah took out of iran because also you've got
to realize the fact that he didn't all take it out
on his own person he's got plenty of relatives who
were leaving at the same time he wasn't he just
planted it on all of them if you i don't know
if anyone knows this but his sister tried to take
something like two pounds of heroin out of iran to
sell it abroad on the black market and was caught
in switzerland i believe and of course they let
her go you know but this is just an example of how
they were trying to get money out of the country
well christy you're involved now in a movement or
an organization to try to bring people together
to fight this situation yeah the name of our
organization is the coalition against intervention
and racism in the middle east and it's sort of
an ad hoc type coalition that was just formed
this week in austin and it's in response number
one and number two to the war moves that we're
making in the middle east the you know the kitty
hawk in the in the indian ocean and the several
american ships in the persian gulf and also the
harassment of iranian students in this country
this is sort of a collection of several groups
just to name a few young socialist alliance
students for libertarian society the texas
libertarian party new new american movement uh
these are people who have endorsed the coalition
we have some possible endorsements rcyb desock
the texas mobilization for survival workers world
it's sort of like a conglomerate of
groups and we sort of set up a platform
the first two which are already mentioned and also
the extradition of the shah to iran because uh
as we say the nobel peace prize winning amnesty
international once described the shah as having
the worst human rights record of any ruler in the
world we do not believe in giving asylum to mass
murderers we therefore call for the extradition
of the deposed shah okay what can you do what
can you accomplish and how how do you go about
it you think what can we accomplish well we we
sort of like to look at the roots of situations
you know people in this country are saying well
let the hostages go well our solutions will send
back the sha and you solve you'd solve the problem
because by bringing him here in the first
place we created a lot of these problems
i mean are are you getting publicity are you
writing to people or well yesterday and today
we staged two demonstrations on the ut campus
yesterday at belmont hall where the immigration
and naturalization service is interviewing iranian
students and today we had one on the west mall
pretty good turnout today and yesterday we're
also planning on having a public debate on campus
maybe a forum or a public discussion on campus and
we'll be soon setting up a table on the ut campus
and encouraging people to get involved in the
coalition and do what they can and uh this
could this has possibilities for going national
you know this could become a national coalition in
every city if there's military intervention in the
mideast i think we'll have the same thing as the
anti-war movement evolving that the 70s have been
portrayed as a decade in which people are quiet
quiescent apathetic whereas the 60s was an epic of
demonstrations but as it seems to me in the last
year we've reported on alternative views massive
demonstrations of hundreds of thousands of people
for gay rights against anti-nuclear
energy and um against big oil etc
so that uh if there seems to me there's a
uh a intervention a military intervention
uh on behalf of the us government in the mideast
there will be this um these demonstrations against
it and it will be i think the uh resurgence of
the anti-war that is one of the purposes of this
coalition that's one of our platforms is we are
against any type of military intervention covert
or or otherwise you know in the middle east and we
would like to try to stop these war movies before
they become more serious than they are yeah maybe
john if you stayed in the cia reserves you might
get called up and might get your old job back
i don't think he's going to give me a job back
well perhaps for the final question we might raise
the issue of what is the solution to the iranian
crisis several people including christie's group
have been have called for the extradition of the
shah back to um iran and when barbara walters
asked the shah if he would go if the american
government sent him back he said well i've
been called many things but stupid i am not
so the shaw evidently that's not too eager to
going back do you think another option would just
simply be to send him out of the united states
and to begin a international tribunal into the uh
shah's crimes do you think this would be
sufficient for the iranian government that they
won't or the people in the government of iran
won't be satisfied until they get the shot back
john do you have any feelings about this
well they're not going to be satisfied
with an international tribunal that would
would clearly be protective of the shah
it's impossible in a situation such as we have
in america with the power given the power of
president carter who brought the shy in and
henry kissinger and david rockefeller to have
a fair trial of the shah the only place he
could get well i'm not sure you could say
you get a fair trial in iran but if he is guilty
of these crimes as he obviously is that would be
the closest you could get to fair trial but
certainly they would never trust anywhere in
the world western or eastern world to take care
of take this responsibility for them what about
something like the bertrand russell wart crimes
tribunal where you have an international body of
legal experts philosophers public citizens where
you have a so-called non-biased impartial inquiry
that sort of thing is satisfying to to british
intellectuals it wouldn't satisfy the iranians
and it wouldn't satisfy the american people at
this point just like the u.n that yeah it's uh to
you know they would conclude that he was a monster
well that's already been observed and people have
had their loved ones killed by him and they want
obviously they want blood i personally think that
the american government is afraid of putting the
shah on trial and finding out what he will say
about what did go on on iran absolutely i think
you could probably speak on that real well i think
american taxpayers would be quite shocked to find
out what really did go on in iran well we'd like
to thank all of our guests tonight for providing
very interesting discussion of the very complex
issues surrounding the crisis in iran we haven't
solved it this crisis hasn't solved itself yet so
we'll keep looking at it and give you discussion
of these issues on alternative views good night
hey
um
a lot of people have been involved with the
cia over the years both directly and indirectly
yes a lot of people have been involved
particularly this man john stockwell who is with
us tonight on alternative views news magazine
hey
foreign
you have with us tonight john stockwell the
former cia case officer who's back for an
encore performance we're going tonight to discuss
the on company business the documentary film that
has been made recently about the cia we'll be
seeing some sections of that film tonight right
i should have mentioned that earlier we have a few
clippings that we will discuss and comment on and
we're also going to discuss john stockwell's
court case where the government is suing him
because he allegedly broke his contract or oath
with the cia not to disclose any information
about their operations and according to a recent
supreme court decision former employees of the cia
no longer have the right to disclose secrets
about the agency john could you tell us a few
things about the government lawsuit against
you first of all what was the frank snap case
what was the supreme court decision that's the
basis of the government's harassment of you now
well frank snep wrote a book similar to mine about
the the collapse of south vietnam and the scandal
of the u.s evacuation of of south vietnam in 1975
and he like me did not submit the book for ci
review or censorship for the obvious reason they
would not have let him publish the entire story
as a result the ci sued him in a test case the
reason they picked him was because his book
came out before mine by a few months and then
when mine came out they said that they would
have preferred they wish they'd waited and
gotten me instead for technical reasons my
case would have been more interesting to them and
actually would have been more interesting to me i
think i could have made a better fight than frank
snap did of it but they took it to their favorite
court in alexandria virginia where the judges
are notoriously biased in favor of the agency
that's right next door to them right next
door the statements the judges made during
the trial like early on that the facts of
the case didn't interest him one damn bit
mispronouncing frank snap's name repeatedly
during the trial interrupting on behalf of
the the the district attorney the prosecution to
to protest testimony that that the judge didn't
like was going on he would say objection sustained
when there had been no objection and things like
this throughout the trial and then perhaps the
most incredible of all when snap tried to get
some waiting to get the transcript of some of
the incredible statements that were made in court
through the the transcript of the
proceedings found that they had been expunged
so they were not part of the court record even
though all of the attorneys and journalists
present were witnessed that they had been
said and the ci taking snapped to this court
the judge referred during the proceedings to
frank snap's ill-gotten gains from his book
and ruled heavily in favor of the government that
snaps should have to pay the government everything
he'd earned from the book even though snap never
did reveal any information that was classified
they never claimed that he had he had revealed a
single secret their point was that he had signed
a contract with the government not to attack the
government without the government's permission
and therefore he his book was illegal a breach of
contract and that he by signing that had waived
all of his first amendment rights he no longer had
freedom of speech the appeals court in richmond
virginia ruled in in ci's favor but they ruled
that the the uh that a judge a federal judge could
not affix the damages that a jury would have to
fix the damages that the judge could award for the
government one dollar from frank snap the supreme
court in a decision this last january which was
described in the dissenting opinion as unique
in the history of the supreme court it refused
to hear the case he refused to hear frank snap's
arguments or the government's arguments but it
ruled in favor of the government it ruled it gave
the government more power than it had asked for
beyond that it legislated new law it's supposed
to interpret existing law but it ruled in its
in its written statement that its objective was
to create a situation a law that would protect
the confidentiality it considered necessary to
the functioning of the cia now that clearly is
the congress's responsibility to legislate new
law but it did it did rule that and we are now
stuck with the the snap decision snap is having
to pay back a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
from proceeds of his book three weeks later the
government initiated its lawsuit against me to
to deprive me of my uh ill-gotten game you're
gonna stop having parties and give away back all
those roller coasters and stuff like that you've
been gone yeah right we we laughed actually uh
the government was not aware of the fact that
a book like that does not make that much money
and uh three years the money has long since spent
three years in my travel and research costs and
my taxes and the money is spent and i lived as
you well know quite modestly during the interim
john what are the implications of this supreme
court decision what does this mean vis-a-vis
first amendment rights and government secrecy
and suppression of information from the public
well it means very simply that in that decision
that the supreme court has upset the delicate
balance of power on which our government functions
it means that people according to the to their
law their ruling people who have worked for the
government whether or not you signed an agreement
even if you did not sign an agreement you have
a fiduciary responsibility not to attack the
government without its permission if you work for
the government if you do they cannot under that
ruling put you in jail but they can sue you for
whatever damages a judge without a jury decides
to stick you with now that means for example that
see the ci is an office of the white house and
that means that the president has in his power
to to do incredible things as the ci has truly
incredible things depraved things and people who
know what these secrets are are not allowed to
speak out about it much less do anything about
it is quite literally an official secrets ruling
it's not an act of congress but it's an act of
the supreme court the under this ruling they
cannot put you in jail but they can sue any former
government employee for damages if he attacks the
government now by attacking the government
mind you i didn't write a book calling for
a violent overthrow of the government i wrote a
book which exposed a war the ci had done in angola
an irresponsible war in which 10 000 people were
killed needlessly not even to protect our national
security and about henry kissinger and william
colby lying to the congress to cover up that war i
felt that i was in a position where my bosses had
consciously and flagrantly defied the constitution
and were functioning as a secret police separate
apart and above the constitution and i struggled
with my conscience at length but i decided
that if it comes down to loyalty to the cia
and loyalty to the constitution you must
choose in favor of the the constitution
i was wrong according to our supreme
court it is the heaviest blow to the
first amendment in the history of this
country it's also very interesting that the
people like the aclu civil liberties union and
the press have roundly criticized the supreme
court for this decision what was the vote by
the way in the court remember three dissenting
opinions three so this is sort of nixon's revenge
the supreme court on the american people well i
must say though that this is really not an unusual
attack we've seen from the trilateral commission
the book crisis of democracy indicating that they
want legislation to do just what the supreme court
has done and the senate bill one and the son of
senate bill one which has been pushed so hard by
senator kennedy and which has been fought so
much by and successfully so far by the aclu also
would legalize exactly what the supreme court has
already done so it isn't that the supreme court is
such a maverick in this sense wasn't there another
bizarre decision that came a week or two or
shortly after the snap decision and that is
didn't the supreme court give henry kissinger
the right to use secret government documents when
he was secretary of state to write a book that he
was writing and moreover not to let any other
scholars even look at them to sort of withhold
them from the freedom of information act could
you comment on this and some of the implications
yeah this was also uh verbalized by the judge in
the frank snap case who ruled who stated that that
it was his opinion that high-level government
employees should be free to write books and and
whatnot but middle and lower level employees
should not and uh read that that if you you
are a high level employee and you write something
that is patently false and full of lies it's okay
if it's an apology for the crimes you've committed
or those around you have committed it's okay
but if you're someone who is in the middle levels
deeply involved in what really happened and want
to tell the american public about what was done
with our tax dollars often to the american public
that is not permissible speaking of telling
about the cia and what is happening in it
this movie which of which we'll see parts this
evening is really one of the most effective
pieces of filmmaking i've ever seen it just
hits you emotionally time and time again
how did it uh how did it happen how
did it all start well you know i wasn't
uh involved in it in any way in its production i
was just interviewed on it for an hour or two but
we do have someone with us here by extraordinary
good luck with good fortune who was uh
very much involved molly dougherty of is
from austin and happens to be visiting in
town and she helped alan frankovic get this film
moving how long did it take alan to make this
movie or the whole film crew molly it's an
extraordinary collection of news reels of
interviews it must have taken a long time to make
how long was he working on this i think he was
working on it close to seven years and a lot of
the problem was it's not just an extraordinary
amount of research involved in such a film in
order that every detail be totally accurate and
corroborated by several sources but also that he
had to spend a lot of time fundraising because
he couldn't find anybody to financially back
up the movie nobody put up a million dollars
and exxon weren't interested no no people learned
about the cia no they weren't very supportive and
the movie cost altogether around three hundred
and fifty thousand dollars and that was mostly
raised in fifty dollar hundred dollar in
a few thousand dollar increments so that's
one reason the film took so long to make where
has it been shown i know it's been here on pbs
it's been around the country on pbs
and uh what about outside the country
uh well it's shown at uh khan film festival uh
last week i believe what was the reaction there
i haven't heard yet at the berlin festival it
won the award yeah it won the critics award
for the for the best movie it's it's it's
unbelievable some of the material they have
even the tape recording of the super mario
gorillas holding the cia butcher and talking
to him and you can see him denying that he's and
you hear him deny that he's a member of the cia
and talking about oh how how sorry he is that
people are going to be hurt and here he was
involved in torturing and training other people to
torture you know it's been it's been said in the
reviews of this movie that trying to document for
for a film uh ci past secret operations is like
trying to catch a vampire's image in the mirror
you know it's it's it seems to be impossible but
these filmmakers by interviewing people and taking
film clips of situations what really happened
and working very very hard for a long period of
time have come up with incredible documentation
not one reviewer that i've read has challenged the
accuracy or authenticity of any point they make
in this film there are some people who have said
that the film was biased against the cia because
colby and helms looked like such hard people and
that it was therefore the filmmaker was trying
to catch the pro ci people in order to make
them look harsh and hard and of course that's
that's nonsense these gentlemen were in
fact are in fact very hard individuals
who were running an organization
that was into some very heavy stuff
yeah he basically lets those people down
themselves with their own words i mean he has
films or has a film clip of george meaney denying
that they got any money from the cia and then in
the next segment he documents how they did get
money from the cia i say to you category now that
it is not true well under no circumstances have
have we ever received or solicited any money from
the cia it doesn't say that the afl-cio receives
it with 33 million doesn't go to the flcio
you mentioned have stated just as categorical
as i have that they do not receive and have not
received cia the kia's trade union operations
are affected through a vast bureaucracy
of people these are the officers of the
international trade unions and of the
national unions especially in the united states
through which the c i a is able to infiltrate and
manipulate the international unions of course
mr meanie is has been in the past one of the
principle if not the principal u.s trade unionist
through which these operations are affected
i am a andy mcclellan i'm the inter-american
representative of the afl-cio and have been
since 1964. prior to that time i was the
associate inter-american representative
and prior to that time i was inter-american
representative of the international union of
food and allied workers based in geneva
but working in latin america i'm the
executive director of the american
institute for free labor development
prior to that time as a matter of fact i've been
the executive director now for some 10 years and
i've been with the american institute free labor
development since its founding in 1962. for the
period immediately prior to 1962 i was
the inter-american representative of the
postal telegraph in television international
which has headquarters in switzerland but
i was their their representative in the western
hemisphere there have been some people who've
accused the flco collaborating with the cia
and what would be your uh response to that
accusation i think that is so ridiculous and so
infantile so juvenile to make such an accusation
you mr doherty well i agree i i don't know of
any labor leader that wouldn't uh out help deny
such an accusation it's just not true in latin
america one of the principle and most effective
of the trade unionists of the american trade
unions who worked with us was bill doherty he
had originally started in the post-telegraph
and telephone workers international coming
up through the communications workers of
america later on he was transferred into the
american institute for free labor development
this was set up during the kennedy period
and is a joint effort by american trade
unionists like george meaney and the heads of
american-based multinational corporations
which operate in latin america
order is restored but not before 11 persons
are killed and a crippling general strike
is called over the power struggle between
the president and the parliament of brazil
says mr doherty quote what happened in brazil
on april 1st did not just happen it was planned
and planned months in advance many of the
trade union leaders some of whom were actually
trained in our institute were involved in the
revolution and in the overthrow of the gular
regime immediately prior to the the the military
takeover in brazil there was a group of students
from brazilian unions in training in front royal
uh this wasn't the first of the brazilian groups
that have been here nor has it been the last we've
we've had them continuously they weren't uh in
any kind of a course training for revolutionary
activities or clandestine activities they were
in a regular collective bargaining course it so
happens that when many of those students went
back home from that course their unions were
involved in this struggle against the attempt
of the communists to take over some of the unions
and that's precisely what i meant by the statement
one aspect of the film is that it's i think very
important is it has no narration that it doesn't
tell you what to think about what you're seeing
what it does is it was an incredible research job
and all these interviews with people from various
points of view it lets those people tell the story
and get exposes what the public record is
and then let you draw your own conclusions
and it shows the cause and effect for instance
it will take a look at cia torture schools
held in the united states the police program
began on a large scale under dwight eisenhower
he felt there was a need to train the police
to help with the fighting of communism after
the second world war he recruited for
the purpose a man named byron engel
byron engel was by the time he came into this
program a member of the cia so the only way they
get their information is through torture whenever
one could get the information about a specific
high ranking official in in torture not one
of these men off the street but a man who had
based his career on his ability to extract
information from political prisoners
in the cases that i investigated i found
that they had been trained at a united states
base i told you electric sharks and beatings and
telephones and finally it's a few hours like that
many of the people i spoke with exiles political
exiles in europe had been tortured with u.s
army field telephones they were simple they were
easy to operate and we had sent them in large
numbers as part of our military assistance
plan you hook up wires to the telephone
and you put one wire perhaps on a man's
penis when women are tortured oftentimes the
higher ranking officials will find an
excuse to come by and watch the torture
i decided that i would confirm everything
they wanted it was in such a condition
they certainly wouldn't settle for less and i
didn't want to go through any more torture i was
ideologically i was weak enough to say if they
know why not what we brought to it what we
as the united states through our efficient
system brought was the sense that you used
only the amount of torture appropriate to get
information and the reason torture persists
is that although they can't among the police
officers is that torture is not an effective way
to get information it of course is torture is a
necessity of the system not not because some minds
sick mind think of it and then they would show
they had for instance aj talking about how they
would attempt to subvert the democratic process
of a particular country at any one time uh down
in latin in ecuador we had on our payroll or in a
intimate working relationship with our station um
one vice president a president of the chamber
of deputies a president of the senate a vice
president of the senate a number of senators a
number of deputies uh the secretary general of the
democratic socialist party we even created
a party down there which we called the
popular revolutionary liberal party which
would appeal to a lot of different people
we had extensive propaganda operations
during this period also they love to brag
about inside the agency about
situations the ci helped create that were so
favorable to the united states now what they
talk about the common denominator is strong men
they were able to put in power in key situations
and governments they were able to to reverse uh
one of these was the shah who was ousted in a coup
and the cia had a counter coup and brought him
back and the cia used to love to brag about this
and uh what a great man the shah was as they
proceeded to train savak and uh and its forces
they were of course very close to batista they
were very close to just about mag seisei the the
and the current president of the philippines pak
and south korea and country after country after
country of our uh allies or our client states
in the third world this you you've you find
that the ci helped put in power the dictator or
reinforced someone who had just gotten into power
train their police train them in oppression of
suppression of the people and it worked for a
decade a decade and a half sometimes for 20 years
but unfortunately the people of the world are
i say unfortunately from the cia point of view
the people of the world have become too restless
and they're kicking out the dictators one after
the other and turning on the united states in the
process it was a short-sighted policy and a policy
that's now i believe it's thoroughly bankrupt
um john something that struck me about the
movie on company business the documentary was
how it revealed the relationship between the
cia and other parts of what might be called the
american power structure in other words the unions
were very active in cia operations business the
multinationals were the media were on cia payrolls
or were used as cia mouthpieces federal government
agencies were working in cooperation with the cia
i think that there it proves that there has been a
desire a compulsion by the leaders of
this country and the leaders of industry
to to function with and through a secret
police organization i.e to bypass and subvert
the the the way the constitution maps
out the way our government should run
for example in angola the war that i wrote
about that i was so deeply involved in
uh that there were various elements in the society
the american community that that had no interest
whatsoever in having a war happen there it
was not in our national security interests
in any sense of the word but by having the cia
do it you did not have to have public debate
the multinationals that actually were opposed to
the war couldn't debate in congress nor could the
missionaries nor could the academics nor could the
smaller business people with interest in angola
you can do it secretly and you don't have
government by the people and he's very curious
this is a a turning upside down of what one of
the men in the documentary said he was one of the
xcia people who did a lot of talking but he said
i'm not one of those kiss and tell people like
stockwell but he said i think somewhere phillips
i believe phillips he said somewhere in that what
problem is the cia that we were sending in the cia
to do things that we should send our army in to do
right yeah you know and back to the subject of the
objectivity of this film i i would like to point
out that that alan frankovic and howard dredge
went so far in a couple of points that i they gave
the establishment figure the ci figures such an
opportunity to speak that i i think that they went
beyond fairness for example one element in the
film one point in the film that simply makes my
blood boil is where they let this atlee phillips
who is who who resigned from the ci to create the
ci x's organization to go about propagandizing and
and lobbying on behalf of the cia they they allow
him to say in the film that he is convinced that
phil agee is the agent of some foreign government
and that to me is outrageous that one that he
would say it but that doesn't surprise me but
it should not be included in an objective film
because of course that is the cheapest kind
of a shot just about on a par of the level of
dignity or non-dignity of the cia to say that
well he attacked us so he must be an agent of a
foreign government there was something interesting
though about aeg in the second part of that film
it was widely reported in the media in america and
i believe this myself that a cia case officer in
greece was killed because phil agee had revealed
his address his name his location and that he was
therefore responsible for this cia agent's death
well aj denied that and pointed out that it was
well known in athens that for the last 20 years
a cia case officer had lived in a certain
house and a certain yeah the station chief
had lived in the same house four successions
of station chiefs had lived in the same house
and they were public figures and i mean they
had cocktail parties that the the diplomatic
and police community went to that you know they
were all going to the cia station chief's house
everyone in town knew that was the ci's house
meanwhile the station in athens had supported
engineered if you will more than one coup of the
the government of of greece and also had dabbled
in every situation in the middle east so they
had a lot of bitter enemies with the station
chief living in the same house and as as the they
point out in this age points out in this film
the station chief had been ordered by headquarters
to get a a new house a clean house and he'd refuse
because he didn't want to drive the extra 20
minutes ag had not known this man while he was in
the cia and had not revealed his name and yet uh
very conveniently the ci has used that man's death
as the their their cudgel to go after aeg and try
to make him out as to a traitor and a killer of
american agents well they pounded him all over
the all over the western hemisphere and they
served in europe they've gotten him run out of
four countries in europe he was trying to live i
think one of the most interesting things about the
film aegea is such a controversial character made
so by our media and by our government and yet i've
met him i had the pleasure in uh in january when
i was traveling through europe he is an individual
who comes across as very calm extraordinarily warm
and human vibrations very intellectual he was
deeply troubled by what he saw the cia doing
in latin america and concluded the only way to
fight it was to to get out and write about it and
expose its operations he had a fascinating
exchange with the new york times recently
where someone wrote an article saying that a.g
had his right i believe it was to his passport
but that they they disagreed with him
otherwise because of his exposing names
so phil wrote a rebuttal which they did publish in
which he pointed out that he had not revealed a ci
officer's name in well over three years whereas
and he listed all of the cases and there must
have been a dozen where the new york times had
revealed ci officers names and just nailed them
to the wall with their hypocrisy well as you've
said on previous programs that we've had with you
that overseas it's common knowledge is who is cia
absolutely or at least the american maybe not the
contract agent but at least the case scientist and
where he lives and all 85 percent of the cia case
officers not only are well known but they play to
that because it's glamorous to be the cia guy the
spook plus the fact that the kgb the russian kgb
officials have social relationships with the cia
endlessly drinking vodka together endlessly i was
in germany once and i picked up this book who's
who and the cia and they had literally thousands
of people listed including three of the neighbors
that i grew up with in falls church virginia that
so in certain areas of the world it's no secret
to the cia offices this gets back to the crux
of the whole matter of government secrecy
in that it is the the purpose of government
secrecy in terms of the ci is to keep the american
public from knowing what the government is doing
the victims the people in the countries overseas
almost always know the full truth about the bloody
operations that that are killing them and messing
up their lives secrecy is designed to keep the
american people from knowing about it the point
of that is the ci's big push for greater secrecy
and protection of its secrets is not to keep enemy
agents from knowing what it's doing they know it's
to keep it's political it's to keep the american
public the electorate from knowing what it's doing
because the american public could rise up and vote
the ci out of existence therefore it's hammering
away to muzzle me and snap and aeg it cannot exist
with an educated public if it continued
its operations of killing people overseas
of experimenting on american citizens with drugs
and drug sex mind control experiments the american
people would rise up and put it out of business
the only way it can continue its operations is
to have secrecy to keep the american public from
knowing what it's doing with this particular 13
billion dollars a year that it's been i think
one of the distressing issues of this whole
complex of things that you just
raised is how the media has been
up until this movie on company business and a
couple other uh pbs discussions or documentary
the media has been glorifying the cia
the most striking example and i think the
on company business really reveals this is the
story of dan matroni a cia agent in uruguay
we were unsuccessful in our
efforts to weaken the left
in uruguay during the period
when i was in uruguay 1964-1966
our job in the face of the growth of the
strength of the left during that period
was to promote repression it
was the only alternative we had
in 1966 we brought in a cia officer who set up his
office in the police department under the cover of
the public safety mission of aid this officer was
to work exclusively with the police intelligence
trying to improve its capabilities this officer
was still there in 1970 at the time that the
american public safety mission chief dan matrioni
was kidnapped and executed by the tuper motors
mitrione was the small city cop in richmond
indiana he had advanced to the position of
chief of police and had heard about
byron engel's program in washington
applied and of course he was exactly the sort
of person they were looking for to send abroad
diligent hard-working dan exemplified the highest
principles of the police profession that of social
service he served in brazil for seven years at
the international police academy in washington
for two and in montevideo for one there are a
quarter of a billion people in latin america
many of these countries the communist terrorists
are trying to tear the fabric of democracy upon
some of these countries uruguay among them
realize that the best protection against this
is the development of a democratic police have
asked the united states to help and this is what
dan was doing in uruguay he went to uruguay to
get information this is part of the testimony of
manuel avia of uruguay he said regarding mitrione
this question of perfectionism he insisted on
an economy of effort he used to say precise
pain in the precise place at the precise time
one of the pieces of equipment that had been
found useful were was a wire so very thin that
it could be fitted into the mouth between
the teeth and by pressing against the gums
increased the electrical charge and it was
through the diplomatic pouches that mitrione
got some of the equipment he needed for the
interrogations including these fine wires
several street beggars were picked up whose
disappearance would attract no attention
this was a technique that mitrione had
developed or rather perfected in brazil
using these beggars experiments were conducted
with different forms of interrogation letting the
students see the effects of different voltages on
different parts of the human body male and female
all those unhappy people died without really
knowing why they were undergoing this pain
without even having the cowardly
solution of answering any questions
because they were not asked questions they
were simply guinea pigs dan exemplified the
highest principles of the police profession this
callous murder emphasizes the essential inhumanity
of the terrorists the american people joined the
president in condemning this cold-blooded cry
against a defenseless human being mr
mitrione's devoted service to the cause
of peaceful progress in an orderly world will
remain as an example for free men everywhere
you've seen this movie state of siege
that costas garvis made east montan plays
dan matroni and shows the story of
the two pereiro gorillas and the
cia operations in uruguay and why they kidnapped
him well the u.s media made metronia out a hero
they made him out of victim of irrational
and despicable violence whereas it appears
from this documentary that matroni had his hands
in some of the most savage butchery imaginable
and the the point is that we're not talking
about a gestapo officer in auschwitz or
somewhere experimenting on people or torturing
people we're talking about a fine upstanding ci
officer doing his commission thing by the cia
what have these apparatuses of torture paid for
by the american government and given to these
people produced in america and they're even
trained here how to use them what's the cia role
in that school yeah the cia set up several in the
in the 50s and throughout the 60s several what
they call police training schools and uh which
included all of these techniques uh they also
had a school or two in uh the location i never
i never was in them teaching people how to make
plastic bombs how to blow up things how to throw
molotov cocktails into crowds and and
whatnot how to destabilize the country
i don't know i cannot testify that the ci is still
doing that now the film on company business brings
this out very well i presume they are but i don't
i don't know that john this raises the question
of sort of the balance sheet on the cia what is it
accomplished has it produced useful intelligence i
mean this is what the cia is supposed to do in its
charter it's supposed to be a central intelligence
agency what sort of intelligence political
military and otherwise has it produced what's
his record in terms of producing information
for the american government to make intelligent
political decisions well the congressman pike
put together a committee and investigated
the ci's intelligence gathering capability and
he concluded in his own words that it was lousy
the list of cia failures to gather and together
accurate intelligence to analyze it digest
it and disseminate it to the leaders of the
country accurately what's going to happen is a
long list of incredible bungled failures numerous
ones of which have led this country to the brink
of world war three time after time after time
take a situation look at what the cia did during
it and you'll find if not the entire situation
at least major elements of it were inaccurately
reported by the cia in a way which screwed up our
government government's ability to react to the
situation john what about just the gathering of
information of intelligence as distinguished from
the dirty tricks business the going out the
overt to aggressive type of behavior the point
is that secrecy doesn't work very well spies
are the poorest source of intelligence that you
can get anywhere you're talking about it play
gossip at the next time you have a party over
with intelligent friends and just start something
verbally and let it come back around the room and
see how it resembles what happened what was said
originally the point is it rarely does when you
get an agent who is reporting to you in secret he
he is he is you can't go with him to his office
to see what was really said he may be working for
you he may be working for you and his government
to give you false information he may be working
for the soviets to give you false information
about his government he may be a nut he
may be exaggerating stay on your payroll
and if you take ten agents eight of them or
nine of them are going to be all of these
things and you'll be lucky to come up with one
agent who is who is sort of true and honest
and conscientious and this is not stockwell's
lone criticism or sour grapes every case officer
in the ci if they're speaking candidly will tell
you this the first thing you do if you're a case
officer and you get your notes from a good agent
is you take out your blue pencil and you x out
all of the things that you know to be false and
if you find some paragraph or thread in there that
looks interesting you put a big circle around it
and then you use that to type up an intelligence
report so you will screen out from your best
agents reporting eighty percent of the stuff
that he reports because you think it's false now
of course if your basis of information is false
then you're you're come you're feeding the
government what it wants to know or what you
think will sell or what you think your bosses will
publish secrecy makes for lousy intelligence so
the good intelligence agency that we provide
political intelligence on the soviet union
on different european or third world countries
what would it do as opposed to what the cia does
otherwise how would you reform the intelligence
agency well first let's say categorically and
emphatically in our national security interests we
close down the ci's dirty tricks office completely
and and i mean that in in the coldest most
amoral terms of evaluation if you don't
care about the three hundred thousand
people the ci killed in the third world
just in terms of u.s national security the ci
has gotten us into far far more trouble than
it's gotten us out of by that i mean vietnam was
a ci operations for seven years before it managed
to get the presidency and the army involved and
the bay of pigs and angola and iran and nicaragua
and cuba and chile and indonesia the list is
endless of situations where the ci has gotten us
in and not the kgb not our enemies but the ci has
led us into these the 18-year war against china
which made it almost impossible for well over 20
years for the united states to do business with
this huge country and we almost got the decision
made to drop atomic bombs in almost all these
cases in almost all these cases we were on the
brink of world war iii of the holocaust because
of ci activities not because of the kgb of these
300 000 victims of ci operations not any of them
of those countries were actively involved in
terrorism or war against the united states
china wasn't dropping parachutists into the united
states to blow up our our installations and kill
people nor was cuba nor was angola or any of
these places it was one-sided wars killing people
but in addition to that only perhaps six maybe
ten people out of those three hundred thousand
actually worked for the kgb the ci was not
fighting the kgb it was killing people in
the third world and perhaps five percent of
them at the most and i doubt that seriously
were communist party members or communists
we were talking about three hundred thousand
just just dead people caught on the
battlefield now aside from all that
which is to say close the dirty tricks division
down play to our strength be public tell the world
what we believe in and deal with them openly and
we would be far further ahead in our international
affairs now than than we are but aside from
that what do you do about gathering intelligence
so you close the operations division down and
but you so you argue that the nation does need
good intelligence in order to function i fully
agree but intelligence gathered through covert
sources it produces a long history of failures of
corruption you're in the chain of command from the
president right down to you and you're working for
these people and you're reporting on a situation
about which they have an important policy like
during the collapse of vietnam the the kissinger's
policy was vietnamization it would succeed
we would give them arms and they would defend
themselves that was his policy we were ordered
not to report that vietnamization was not working
until one day suddenly the south collapsed to
everybody's surprise except for the case officers
that were there looking around at things to the
right and the left and you were there at that
time you were i was there oh yes i was there up
country in vietnam uh if we had had public debate
the intelligence gathered in a more open way and
shared with the academic community and the world
we would have had the failure the collapse of iran
for example the famous case where they the ci had
in its typewriters the reports that concluded
that there was no serious opposition to the shah
in iran it was in the typewriters the same weekend
that tehran first fell apart in the country
and that was for the same reason you were not
permitted to report that the shah was a monster
and that our policy and our relationship with
with iran was fallacious and that that the
shah was bankrupt in his own country john do you
think that the cia is even capable in its present
organization and with its present members do you
think it's even capable of providing intelligence
if they're they have the sort of james
bond mentality or the covert operations
mentality are these types of people even
capable of getting intelligence that's not
bundled up in other words if
if you're into playing spy
chances are you're going to have a bizarre view
of the world and be incapable of getting rational
objective intelligence and secondly you're going
to have difficulty cultivating sources who are
going to be reliable i fully agree and that's that
gets down to the very core of my point my argument
that the ci should be closed down in our national
security interest the the the managers of the ci
are activists they're trained to do things to take
action they enjoy it it's exciting to mount a war
and to sit in washington and send people over
to fight it excites a certain kind of person
and that kind of person is the one that gravitates
to the top of organizations like that and those
individuals are going to seek information and
favor people who report information that creates
a hostile adversary situation in the world so they
will have excuses to continue doing their thing
john let me ask you this it ties in a lot
of the things which we were talking about
it seems that the rockefellers david rockefeller
in the chase manhattan bank the rothschilds who
are the rockefeller counterparts in france
and the crime syndicate as represented by
um resorts international and the let's see
who's the big man of the head of the uh mafia
oh his name escapes all right lansky they
invested in an organization all three of them
the underworld and the overworld right they
invested in an organization which provides
security service and intelligence service for
anybody who will hire it they hired xcia people
they hired people from interpol national security
agency from the fbi they hired an ex-air force
general whose main job was security they hired
an ex-district attorney whose main job it was to
investigate and ferret out and
to prosecute the crime syndicate
and they also have ties through the rothschilds
with mossad now to me this is the outline don't
know i haven't heard anything about it since
then but this seems to me the outlines of a
of a really a monstrous organization tie all
of these together isn't this one of the things
wrong with secret intelligence agencies is that it
feeds right-wing paramilitary groups there's a lot
of private intelligence operating companies that
do sort of dirty work for corporations industrial
spine and probably worse who are often former
cia or fbi agency so it just creates a climate
and operations and practices in society that are
anti-democratic and are dangerous there's another
article in penthouse talking about the epic which
is uh el paso information center by the it's run
by the drug enforcement agency and it has inputs
from all the police and intelligence organizations
from all over the country including an interface
into interpol this is a result of nixon's decision
several years ago that all the intelligence
agencies should funnel provide information
to the drug enforcement agency so they have
computers now that bring in all this information
from their information banks into this area so raw
data unsubstantiated unevaluated it goes into the
computer so anybody can be tabbed by them and this
is another area where the intelligence with the
cia is creeping into out of the cia and into the
rest of our lives a small thing perhaps but an ex
xci agent who was involved in these cop training
programs torture places just been made head of the
new mexico prison where they had the uprising
a while back but you see it more and more
well john thanks a lot for coming on our
program again let's move now from 1980 to 1987
and check out some news stories about
the subject we've been talking about
every month or so i get a publication from amnesty
international since i'm a member it's called
appropriately enough amnesty action i
guess it's just a newsletter of some sort
they give a run down on who's being tortured
in the world they have one particular section
i always look at gives a rundown on central
america and what's going on down there and
i'd like to read you a little bit of it i think
it's interesting for instance in brazil their
new civilian government is introducing measures to
protect human rights although amnesty continues to
receive reports of torture and killings in that
country and argentine government is proceeding
with trials against nine military commanders for
the disappearances that occur between 76 and 82
and efforts there continuing to find a
hundred children that are still missing that
disappeared during this reign they say
also arbitrary arrest torture and killings
by guatemalan el salvador and military and
paramilitary forces appear to be more selectively
directed against suspected government opponents
last year this is more so than in previous
years both governments are also targeting trade
unionists and human rights workers for oppression
in honduras opposition forces reportedly torture
and assassinate their citizens there amnesty cites
indication that the united states assistance to
these forces encourages or condones these abuses
in colombia there's increased disappearances
and political killings by government agencies
and there's a steep rise in abductions and
killings in chile and they go on to say that in
mexico there's also a number of documented cases
the thing that's interesting about this is that
they also mention nicaragua this is the amnesty
international remember and the only thing they
say about nicaragua is quote amnesty's concerns
in nicaragua focused on short-term detention
of prisoners of conscience so no matter what the
reagan administration tells you the people who are
really in the business of documenting torture tell
it completely different on september 8 of 1985
the white house asked congress for 54 million
dollars to counter the terrorist threats to
start this business all over again of training and
supervising the central american police and army
forces same thing that they were stopped from
doing a few years ago but the administration
says that likes this program so much they plan to
make it a global one so it will serve as a model
in the worldwide fight against terrorism speaking
of state sponsored terrorism and torture there
was a report just released today by the americas
watch group which is a new york based civil rights
organization that indicated that the contras have
one of the worst records in the world for civil
liberties violations according to this hundred and
seventy page report that was just released the con
uh the conduct of the military conflict
particularly by the insurgent forces which are the
countries continue to have a severe impact on the
rural civilization rural civilians in nicaragua
violations of the law of armed conflicts by the
countries caused great suffering to the nicaraguan
people at a news conference releasing the report
their chairman ira nair said that the country is
still engaged in selective but systematic killing
of persons they perceive as representing the
government in indiscriminate attacks against
civilians or in disregard for their safety
and in outrages against the personal dignity
of prisoners one of the worst things that the
countries have been doing is setting lion
mines and i just saw in c-span an interview
with elliott abrams who's the assistant secretary
of state in charge of central america and he
was claiming that the contra landmines are only
set off by remote control and only are targeted
against military targets but they've made a few
mistakes whereas i've read report after report
that was confirmed in this america watch report
that indiscriminately they put land mines all over
different rural areas of nicaragua whoever goes
over them civilian military innocent tourists is
going to get blown up and that that's part of a
policy of systematic terrorism by the countries
that have been denounced in this america watch
and craig just like amnesty international they
said that the nicaraguan government had not
engaged in any systematic uh violation of civil
liberties that they'd been somewhat rough in their
interrogation activities of people suspected of
aiding the countries but there was no evidence of
torture or murder of any political prisoners and
they say that the nicaraguans in this report the
nicaraguan sandinista government has improved in
recent years and their civil rights liberty civil
rights record particularly as they've treated the
mosquito indians who at one time were subject to
government repression but now have been treated
better in recent years by the san diese the
government whereas the americas watch report
concluded that the countries were becoming
worse in their violation of civil liberties
and that was alternative use for this
evening alternative views is a production
of the alternative information network
p o box 7279 austin texas 78713
hey
hmm
this program was recorded in 1982. what were these
men doing they were making millions of dollars
selling ci terrorist equipment expertise and
actually training uh libyan selling this equipment
to libya and actually training terrorists
in the libyan china lake terrorist training
camp now as the story is is being squeezed
out in bits and pieces it's coming out it's
now been documented that there were active duty
special forces officers uh helping them to train
terrorists inside libya now we're talking about
up until 79 and they were also cia active duty
personnel at china lake training terrorists and
uh this even boggles my mind having been inside
and and from what i've seen but all of the all of
the to do we're making about terrorism and here we
are deliver here our cia is delivering technology
and actually training libyan terrorists another
fascinating evening with former cia official
john stockwell tonight on alternative views
back in 1981 we did a program with john stockwell
called cia update well it's no longer all that
current but well maybe it is there are a lot of
things we talked about in that program that you
still would be fascinated by so we're going to see
that again and present a new cia story from 1986.
john stockwell is one of our good
friends and a firm fixture on
alternative views i'm sure you know john by now
he was a former cia high official for 12 years
quit the cia and wrote very famous informative
book in search of enemies well he's a full-time
writer now and he is on his novel writing
experience and one is just coming out john
what's the name of it and what's it about well my
second book is red sunset it's a story about some
american oil company people in a small african
capital about the woman principally and the the
adventures she gets into which includes a chess
match a love story a terrorist kidnap attempt
which is the vehicle but really the purpose of
writing the book was to try to discuss what it's
like our enemies our detractors accuse us of being
imperialists and being involved in neocolonialism
and it's always fascinated me because i've lived
the life that they call neocolonialist of uh
in the in the big villa in a newly independent
country with several servants and shiny new cars
and jet planes here and there while most of the
people in the country have very little to survive
to live off of and so this is the story i wanted
to write a story about ordinary americans who live
that kind of a life and what what the life is
all about and how it affects the people around
them as well as themselves and where does it take
place what are the actual scenes and characters
and actions i said it in burundi and i chose
burundi because it's very in africa burundi is in
i chose it because it's exactly in the center
of africa it's it's as close to nowhere so so to
speak as you can get it's also very pretty place
it's right on the western rift valley right at
the northern tip of lake tanganyika and you have
the mitumba mountains and the virunga volcanoes
and the lake tanganyika and the city is actually
up overlooking the lake so it's a gorgeous little
place and and as i say quite remote well you
grew up in africa well i grew up in zaire which
is right across the on the other side of the
lake and then i served in zaire with the cia
these mutumba mountains that i write about in
this book were haven of rebels when i was in
zaire but i also served in burundi at one time so
we had problems with uh we the the mountains were
sort of an intelligence target so we were covering
them i was sending people into the mountains and i
became fascinated with them in fact there were no
viable rebels there there was a great exaggeration
of the rebel threat because that's a good way to
keep the united states and its aid interested in
in supporting your country and i try to bring
this out there was a kidnapped uh threat that was
brought to us from people across the lake who came
into burundi and said that they had information of
a plot to kidnap the american ambassador and this
of course stirred us up no end as you can imagine
flash cables to washington and on a full-time
alert and every security measure we could take
it turned out it was just a con there was just
some guys who wanted to squeeze a little money
a couple hundred dollars out of us but then i
was there in in 1771 about when i left but in 75
these same people did kidnap four european
scholars working with a caltech grant who were
studying fish or something on the lake and they
did kidnap them and take them into the mountains
and so naturally writing a novel about that area
i wanted to incorporate how you know how a kidnap
plot could work and what kind of people would
do it and how it would affect the people in the
city itself do you mostly focus on the african
political situation or the sort of machinations
between america and the soviet union
behind the scenes or do both of these
themes come out those those themes are in
the background i wanted to focus on the life
of an american woman who finds herself in such
a place and there is a soviet diplomat involved
there is she plays a big chess match against the
local chess master who's a south african banker
and some of their friends are british and the
africans are in the background their subplot
sort of uh in the background which some of the
reviewers have said is in a way an ironic way the
strongest part of the book is the africans
in the background but i really wanted the
story to be about this young woman not about
politics or diplomacy so much as just her life
so there's an element of the love story in that
as well as a political novel you're trying to
combine these themes it started out to be more
of a political intrigue novel adventure intrigue
in real life politics and what happened
was the love story took over the book
it was a subplot originally and then the
by the time i got the the manuscript to
new york and sold it the editors wanted me
to focus on the woman and the love story
and essentially they they persuaded me and so it
is primarily a love story yes well john you've
been prohibited by the courts now to say anything
or write anything about the cia and its operations
no no that's not exactly correct no i can say all
kinds of things about the ci but i have to submit
it to them for censorship first so i assure you i
could write a hundred thousand page book about the
cia and as long as it was favorable they wouldn't
censor a word but you can speak though well
impromptu speaking is covered particularly if it's
about the subject of my previous book or what i've
lectured before they they admitted that it would
be very difficult to try to enforce an injunction
against interviews and and speeches but if i had
written notes for say this interview i would have
to submit those notes for censorship well as long
as it's impromptu though i'm supposed to be okay
we have a lot of things here loaded up about the
cia the stories and information that we've been
gathering waiting for your next trip over to
alternative views fortunately i haven't seen their
notes that they're going to be working from so and
they're not under injunctions they don't have to
be censored okay doug you have probably the most
important one there well john to start off let's
look at the cia under the reagan administration
what are some of the most significant occurrences
vis-a-vis the cia under reagan what has he done in
terms of his policies that have affected the cia
well the the reagan election when he came into
office there was great joy in dancing in the
halls of the cia they recognized that they would
be set back into full uh full-fledged activities
much like they were at the height
of their powers in the 50s and 60s
and and that euphoria has pretty much
continued i have not been inside the
building obviously but i have had a
couple of conversations with people
uh who were and uh without telling me anything
of any substance they did their voices were
were crowing and and gloating about how the world
was being righted in their mind and they were out
there defending uh national security and freedom
in all kinds of places as the ci has done in
chile and angola and nicaragua and elsewhere
for so many years they announced on october
the 1st that they're going to literally double
the size of their new headquarters the cia which
would indicate that they're obviously planning
many more activities and an expansion of their
entire operations what are some of the evidence
of an expanded cia under reagan well of course
you know i i was kidding i was up in washington
recently and i was getting so many invitations
to go and lecture that i was i was kidding and
saying that i had something that would go on
forever because i'm the last whistleblower because
they've got the court orders and injunctions and
the supreme court rulings and now the names of
agents bill going through and there won't be
all of which is to say that we probably will never
know for sure what they're doing now under reagan
because they are succeeding in getting in a de
facto official secrets acts so the american public
and the victims will never know the true stories
of the current activities like the war in angola
the pre-vietnam ci covert action the chile
coup the assassinations they will be muzzled
probably forever so we won't know for sure what
you hear about are the occasional it you know
it's an organization that will always
go around shooting itself in the foot
because it deals with activists who are trained
to to break the law who have activist instincts
and they will always be getting themselves in
trouble and what we're really seeing now are gross
blunders and gross missteps and one case where
two agents went so far a foul of propriety in the
law that it did erupt into the public view that's
turple and wilson 60 minutes and a pbs documentary
those are the ones who helped were helping
libya right incredible if if you can believe it
look at the way our president is dealing with
the libyan problem and qaddafi our country so
concerned with the terrorism the hitman team that
was supposed to be tracking our president down to
kill him and now we find that two fairly senior
cia officers were out actually training they
had they had resigned from the cia but they were
being supported by people who were at the very top
of the cia who who it's not clear and of course
it may never come clear exactly to what degree
they were being supported but they were being met
debriefed and assisted in some ways by people like
ted shackley who who was a top ci he was chief of
the latin america division chief of the far east
division and then assistant deputy director of
operations now what were these men doing they were
making millions of dollars selling ci terrorist
equipment expertise and actually training
libyan selling this equipment to libya and
actually training terrorists in the libyan
china lake terrorist training camp now as the
story is is being squeezed out in bits and pieces
it's coming out it's now been documented
that there were active duty special forces
officers uh helping them to train terrorists
inside libya now we're talking about up until
78-79 and there were also ci active duty personnel
at china lake training terrorists and uh this even
boggles my mind having been inside and from
what i've seen but all of the all of the to
do we're making about terrorism and here we are
deliver here our cia is delivering technology and
actually training libyan terrorists this sort
of illustrates your thesis in uh of search for
enemies that the function of the cia is to cause
problems that makes it possible for military
intervention so that would fit into this sort of
scenario that you've drawn indeed and there's no
other real explanation for it now one one of the
ci officers who was still in the cia he denied at
first association with him they were claiming that
he had supported him he denied it and uh then when
it when it was when he had to admit or perjure
himself he had to admit that there was association
he he claimed that it was only to keep contact
so they could tell him what the terror who
the terrorists were and what they were doing
therefore it was a legit legitimate ci enterprise
but then when when the senate tried to squeeze
out and the justice department documentation
from the cia there was none and he said that
was because it was something that he was
keeping in his vest pocket so either we have a
full-fledged ci operation or we have an illegal
venal corrupt operation but either way there was
complicity with these people who were training
and and making the libyan terrorists a great
deal more more effective now mind you we're
talking about millions of dollars we're talking
about the the latest and terrorist uh you know
explosive devices and and the way you can make an
ashtray into an explosive device so when a bad guy
puts out his or a good guy for that matter puts
out his cigar it blows up and kills everyone in
the room you know this sort of thing well isn't
there that this seems even more incredible from
a couple points of view one is the fact that maybe
it's a super machiavellian thing that the cia and
the fbi need to have terrorists in the world to
justify their increased money for appropriations
for instance when the cia made their latest report
they indicated that there were 3336 terrorist
attacks during the previous year now alexander
haig didn't think that was enough so he sent the
report back to the cia said give me more terrorist
attacks so they they upped it to almost 6 000.
this then the other aspect of this is that the
cia has historically had a close relationship
with the israeli secret police the mossad and yet
the mossad and the libyan government and their
secret police or mortal enemies supposedly
so what's going on here well on the one
hand the cia purist would argue that we have an
intelligence requirement to provide information
to our government about terrorists and terrorist
organizations about the world and therefore the
only way you can get this information
is to penetrate terrorist organizations
get your people inside so they can tell you what's
being done the other side of that is is very much
in the direct and and on the first argument you
would you would try to have contact with mossad
and with the libyans and with the plo and with
the red brigade anyone you could and the kgb and
the kgb uh to gather information about them that's
the purest purest argument but how can you explain
this provision of of of shiploads of terrorist
equipment to the libyans and training by active
duty special forces and active duty ci officers
now that's that's where it gets the machiavellian
it blows your mind and there's no way you can
justify delivering the equipment to them in order
to gather information about who they are that's
not necessary to gather intelligence and the only
answer is that a little bit of both that you have
an organization that functions in a troubled world
it gets more money and more opportunity
as like you say hague wants six thousand
terrorist bombings last year not three thousand
because it's more dramatic and he can get more
mileage out of it the cia by the same token would
like to have a more troubled world because they're
they have more to do the president the congress
and the press and everybody are are relying on
them and giving them their carte blanche more
in a troubled world than in a peaceful world
uh but then the other thing that has raised its
head not the first time but but so ominously in
this wilson turple thing is is individuals doing
it for gain for millions of bucks let's face it
someone in the ci who's commanded wars around
the world uh it sent people off to die which
you know which is the ultimate ego trip for a
pentagon type of person is the ultimate power
that a human being can have is to send other
humans off to die not sentence one individual
to the gas chamber but send 5000 off to die well
take someone who's been at the top of the ci and
he's been doing this secretly and and commanding
forces in the world manipulating governments
and then he hits a certain age of maybe 50
or possibly 60 if he goes the whole route
and then he retires on 20 000 a year and it just
you know it just isn't comfortable it doesn't work
now some of these people have managed to to retire
comfortably like bill colby the former director
and uh dick helms former director by becoming
agents of foreign governments and so declaring
themselves to our our justice department and
getting a salary from the iranian government or
the japanese government or elsewhere and people
down the line have done the same sort of thing
and walters is now very getting hundreds
of thousands of dollars consulting for
guatemala argentina chile et cetera and vernon
walters was who the deputy director of the cia
when i was in he was the deputy director
over me and was nixon's white house man too
so selling themselves as agents of foreign
governments to sell their expertise and contacts
that they gathered in their cia careers and then
you have these guys it's now surfaced and it's
it's an obvious it's a documented fact have been
selling uh technology terrorist technology to the
libyan government meanwhile our government is
not moving against the vernon walters or the
dick helmses or the bill colbys who have become
agents of foreign governments but they're suing
john stockwell for writing a book to the american
people to tell the truth about what's going on and
they're trying to pass a bill that would make
it illegal for any publication to publish the
names of any cia agents how does this constitute a
threat to freedom of the press mind you this bill
is it's justified on the basis of the revelation
of names but the bill goes far far beyond names
it says names of secret agents or the activities
of secret agents that could draw attention to them
now this means for example let's take some
things that the ci has done a secret agent
kicks in your door and rapes your wife now if
you went out and wrote an article about that
and published it in the paper both you and the
editors of the paper even if you didn't name him
you just said mr x working for the cia kicked in
my door last night and raped my wife that would be
a felony under this law and the debate in congress
on this law some of the critics and there are some
fortunately but not enough said wait a minute the
way this thing the way i read this proposed bill
if the london times published an article about a
ci escapade somewhere the new york times could not
reprint the london times article without
committing a felony and the sponsors of
the bill stood up and roared that is right we
want to stop all of this talk about the cia
so what we have here by the sponsor's own
admission is an official secrets act and a
very strict one one that will cover anything they
want to cover up they classify it and claim it has
to do with secret agents activities my book can
never be published the the cbs and pbs stories
that you mentioned on on turple and wilson
could not be published it would be a felony
many of the 60 minute shows would be felonies
so this provides a cover of secrecy for the
cia of the broadest possible sort for the first
time in our history freedom of speech has been
is being now it hasn't passed yet although
the knows count is that it will go sliding
right through congress right now but for the
first time in our history the secret police of
the government are being given legal precedent
over freedom of speech and freedom of the press
now mind you they've bludgeoned people before
and punished people before such as myself and
frank snap and and philadelphi for for attacking
for criticizing the the cia but they've done that
in civil court but now it will be a felony to
criticize the ci to complain about its activities
to expose its corruption and and the record
is clear we're talking about an organization
that has been responsible for three hundred
thousand deaths by their own records by the
senate's own records three hundred thousand
deaths in the in the third world and that's that's
a modest figure i gave that figure myself and
senate testimony and the next morning sai hersh
i was playing tennis with him and he he he said
stock well you're all wet he said the figures
over 500 000 you forgot indonesia now that's what
they've been doing out in the world of course
in the mood of these times there are a lot of
americans who who would just assume melt africa or
asia or wherever they really could care less but
they have been doing things in the united states
that you would you know strange levy kind of
things that you would only a credit to the gestapo
or the kgb at their worst drug control the mk
ultra extensive over years experimenting with
unwitting americans by by dropping them lsd and
then filming their activities under the influence
of drugs they didn't know they had received as
well as infiltrating political groups and spying
on americans which were against the cia charter
it was not supposed to be domestically involved
and carter put some guidelines regulating
domestic activity of the cia and reagan has
signed an executive order putting these aside
putting these aside in effect unleashing the cia
domestically so that any political group can be
or any individual could be the target of a cia
operation so this is a another threat to our civil
liberties here in the country for sure and they're
defining who the targets are they don't have to
even go to a judge and say we think this person's
a target they decide who a target is and secrecy
as i've said before and and many other people have
said including some some leading senators secrecy
is primarily designed to cover up their misdeeds
only in in the very rare most internal sensitive
cases is secrecy a matter of national security yes
diplomacy at a certain point you need some secrecy
to negotiate some things at a certain point some
military operations have to be secret to work but
you know we're talking about a tenth of a percent
as compared to everything that is in fact uh being
declared secret what they're trying to cover up
is the wars the killings the drug experimentation
and the corruption there's another bizarre
development that seems to be taking place
with the cia under the reagan administration
that i think involves a tremendous expansion
of cia operations and a sort of new field for
the cia to get involved in and that's the use
of businessmen and the department of commerce
as potential agents when the max hugel affair
took place early in the reagan administration
where this corrupt politician businessman friend
of reagan's was put in a position of high power
in the cia and it turns out that he had all kinds
of corrupt business backgrounds and connections it
came out on abc's nightline the ted capo show
in an interview with bobby inman who's deputy
director of the cia that the reason max hugo was
brought into the white house was that he had a lot
of businessmen connections that they would be able
to use for operations abroad what do you make of
this is this a significantly new field for the
cia to be involved in we know that they've used
politicians and diplomats abroad they've used
military abroad they've even used journalists
that's been revealed well it's by no means new but
but we're talking about a degree they've done it
many many times and they've done favors for people
all over the world gathering information for them
you know a little favor yes we'll find out this
for you what not but it's a question of degree and
in in the last few years including before i got
out there was the government the us government was
crying for more economic information and during
a lot of the years that i was in we were not you
know we would get an economic information and
pass it on to the ambassador to stop him in the
hall and say hey i heard such and so a deal is
going down or something but what's happening now
is your microphone yes my microphone
is falling off the cia agreement
i'm sure what's happening now is this corruption
that i'm talking about where a political
uh party a white house administration is
salting people into top positions in the
agency because of their business connections
with the intent of using the organization
and its resources to gather intelligence to
help the people who are sponsoring that party
this is of course the heaviest form of corruption
that position that hugo was in was deputy director
of operations now this is the focal point the
commanding officer of worldwide clandestine
operations now you think of the sensitivity
and the complexity of covert operations in 150
countries and this is a job that has to be a pro
and a brilliant pro and one with driving energy
in any sense of the word and mind you i i think
that we would probably be better off if the job
didn't exist but but there's no way it can
function with a political appointee in there
and as a matter of fact there was the uh part of
the reason he was withdrawn was because uh he was
shooting himself in the foot repeatedly several
times there was an incident about libya and he was
you know in this effort to get the cia moving
again he was approving some some exceedingly
dangerous assassinating gaddafi according to a
newsweek he was proposing to assassinate qaddafi
and there to my relief now the senate supervisory
the oversight committee which has never succeeded
in overseeing the ci room had never tried very
much mostly they're encouraging them to go out
and do they did scream at that one and stop
him and it was shortly thereafter that hugo was
was removed from office now we have the other one
at the top william casey is another businessman
with all kinds of conflicts of interest he's still
holding the portfolio on his own business interest
plus all of his contacts and he's running
the whole intelligence organization right now
and he again like the other one he's shooting
himself in the foot about once a week and late
lately two days ago he testified to the senate
and about the freedom of information operation
and he was claiming that the ci couldn't
function because they had they had so
many agents wouldn't work with us but also so
many people resigned because of this uh foia
and when the committee of course didn't just take
his word for it they said give us documentation
and he couldn't produce any documentation and
finally he had to admit that not one person had
been fired because of or resigned because of the
foia so once again john you were talking about
complexity and the byzantine nature of some of
the operations that go on in the in the cia here
is one really mind-blowing thing which was in
the august 81 inquiry the libertarian magazine
it talks about an incredible thing it talks
about first of all a florida-based worldwide
finance corporation that's that's its name it's a
financial conglomerate and after there were some
complaints that led to the doorstep of this thing
a local district attorney started investigating it
there were congressional investigations and
the justice department started getting into it
and they found that cia was involved cuban
exiles were involved which isn't really
all that unusual because they've been involved
for decades down there in the miami area
in their operations against fidelity assassination
of a president right but this also gets involved
with drug trafficking and even further than that
they've found that there are relationships with
the russian kgb and the cia operating together
exchanging information they found that there is
there have been relationships with castro's
intelligence and the cia in which the cia
and castro decided that they would permit
the drug trafficking and helping it along
and then share the the help and
sharing and the profits so they could
so they could finance each other's
operations and it the investigations
well they kind of it became so complex that
the investigations not only kind of collapsed
because they couldn't figure out what the
heck was happening they couldn't unravel it
but also the cia stepped in and put the kibosh on
it and even the fbi was frustrated because they
were involved in it too this seems like something
which you couldn't even dream up if you had a wild
imagination we're on some kind of drug trip does
this sound unreasonable no you know like real
life is often stranger than fiction and uh i've
i've already run into this in the three books
that i've written with trying to write scenes as
exactly as they happened and then your editors
scream at you and you say but but i was there and
that's exactly the way it happened and they they
finally say well nobody would believe it in france
but yes i'm quite sure that's that could happen
i don't know anything about that organization i
haven't followed it but all of that could easily
happen well the one part of it really sounds
true and that's the permission and expediting
of the narcotic traffic for the cuban exile so
that they can help finance their operations this
sounds very much like what was going on in vietnam
southeast asia sounds like a dream business to get
into because you would be able to do favors
for the cia the fbi the kgb the anti-castro
groups in florida and the ann castro himself
and the drug runners so you would have all of
these organizations paying you off and giving
you protection and that sounds like if you were
if you were into corruption in crime it
would be a dream organization well there
was drug trafficking by the cia and during
the vietnam war yes that's been documented uh
and the book has been written politics of heroin
in southeast asia with with uh documents i mean
documented with government documents they got that
uh conclusively proved and stated that the cia
was the way it started is they were working with
mountain yards who had up in thailand mostly
but also in laos cambodia and vietnam who had
made their living traditionally by growing heroin
and shipping it out and so they had
the ci had its air forces flying
planes back and forth and the mountain yard
allies would be flying down to the capitol
and they would want to get on the planes of these
suitcases full of heroin and the ci you know some
ci officers were trying to kick them off but you
know these were your allies you needed them so
the ci was making decisions to let them ride
and then it got to the point where uh and by
that i'm making making decisions up the chain of
command then it got to the point where they were
actually flying special flights dc3 flights
to carry the the heroin down to the capital
as favors for the allies and also to sort of
help finance the whole operation and then it
got to the point where of course some of the ci
officers involved were finding ways to use ci
vehicles to fly stuff back to the states and
market it that's documented the last leg of that
was not to my knowledge approved by washington
that was that was the maverick but the rest of
it was approved by washington there's another
surprising story that came out in the latest
covert action information bulletin and that is
that shortly before his death anwar sadat admitted
that egypt was the conduit for cia funds to create
problems in afghanistan to aid the rebels so that
the united states was involved early on in the
reagan administration with actually fostering
the afghan rebellion have you heard any stories
of this nature only what i've read in the press
and you know this gets this to me gets into some
of the ultimate cynicism at the same time one of
the more complex decisions of people in the
intelligence world is you have the soviets in
afghanistan and it's our national politic policy
to regret their presence there you have rebels who
are fighting them and obviously if they had more
arms they would fight better but there isn't any
chance of our giving them enough support that
they could win or even get some momentum going
against the soviets so we trickle some arms into
them so they can escalate the flight the fighting
with the result that a lot more people are killed
and their hopes are raised and they think they're
in some cases they're flat told of course the
worst case in history of this being done was
where the cia had a huge program to encourage
the hungarian uprising and they succeeded the
country erupted in a massive uprising and then
when the soviets put their tanks in the united
states jumped you know back across the ocean and
got our hands off the place and the hungarians
twenty thousand hungarians died what
happened with the kurds you see what happened
in iran yes many thousands of kurds died identical
when we had satisfied the shah's little pressure
policy initiative against iraq and the shah
said okay i've got my agreement with iraq we
jumped back and withdrew our aid from the kurds
and the iraqis retaliated and wiped them out
there's also a report here about biological
warfare in cuba that certain mosquitoes
were introduced to cubans claim by the cia
that resulted in fever malaria of all sorts
have you heard anything about that story yes
the dinghy fever i've certainly heard about it
i've seen written stories about it i've
talked to people about it the the us
health the us medical authority's line is that
it's not technically possible to introduce fever
or fever-ridden mosquitoes into cuba which is
of course nonsense the difficult thing about
that is that there's an epidemic of fever in
cuba the cubans claim the cia was behind it
the cubans could be making it up they could
believe it and be saying it or it could be
completely true the point though is that our
government rci has been guilty of so many things
just as nasty as that over the past 30 years
that it's absolutely impossible to to deny it
plus the fact that they carried out experiments
just on this type of thing they released
millions of mosquitoes over at charleston south
carolina to just to observe what would happen
and then apparently it's possible when they
put this into effect in cuba although it then i
understand their main their main target would have
been for the soviet union well they're preparing
for the biological warfare wherever you know in
our concern with nuclear warfare and i am very
concerned all these atom bombs that we have and
they have and the macho people some of them not
very bright uh beating themselves on the you know
the chest and and talking but the chemical and
biological bombs that are being amassed may
be a hundred times as lethal and dangerous
and threatening to life on the on on earth than
than the nuclear bombs well the nazis foresaw this
rather than put their technology into a
nuclear atomic bomb program they had these
chemical warfare you remember the ci had uh
had been it had been revealed that they had
some poison they were and and the president nixon
had ordered them to get rid of it right and then
they didn't get rid of it and pres and director
colby was called up to explain why they hadn't
obeyed a specific presidential order and with
his incredible talent for disarming the senate
he said after all gentlemen we're not talking
about a big warehouse he said we're talking about
something this size and he held up a little vial
it was enough poison to kill everyone in a city
of fifty thousand he held up a little vial this
big he said it was sitting in the back of a safe
and you know when you think about that and when
you think that there are warehouses of that poison
alone not to mention the disease and germs and
things that can blow this way and that uh the and
there isn't the publicity of the public attention
on the the abc arsenals that are being stockpiled
john another event we wanted you to comment on
since this is part of your past experience in
south africa or angola has to do with the invasion
by south african troops in angola on the pretext
that angola is supporting nanibian rebels and that
south africa has to clean up the operations there
and there's soviet and cuban troops there they're
a threat to south africa would you comment on that
what's the current status has south africa been
continuing to harass and go several months back
we reported in detail it's my understanding
that south africa has sort of a permanent
uh military force inside angola i don't mean
they've built camps but they are there bombing
raiding dropping people in are on a permanent
basis regularly several hundred miles up inside
angola what you have in terms of the validity of
their claims you know africa was was when it was
broken into colonies that became countries they
were done without any reference whatsoever to the
the the existing tribes or ethnic groupings so
that in angola for example you have on the north
you have the bakongo as a large original
tribe that now overlaps in three countries
and uh in the north uh east you have the balunda
who who overlap angola and into zaire and in the
south you have the people who are the namibians
are are the the people who are of the ethnic
grouping with the people in southwest africa but
half of the people live inside angola now it goes
without saying that these people with their ethnic
link to those people are going to be sympathetic
and there's going to be support and it's going
to be traveling back and forth across the border
but what you get into is of course modern law
what is south africa's right to go up and and
bomb and strafe south africa's position of course
is is uh it's an outlaw position on south west
africa they're simply refusing to to give it its
own freedom its own elections which was mandated
by the united nations a long years ago and they
just absolutely refused to cooperate with this
and and to date no no pressure has been brought
on them that would really encourage them to
to set namibia free to give it its free election
is there any evidence of cia complicity in this
frank wanted to ask about the seychelles
island some of these might be connected
well the there was a coup
attempt of the seychelles islands
in which a rugby team supposedly rugby
team uh came into the seshel islands into
the airport and there are also some people
that were that came in earlier in hotels
and they tried to overthrow the government they
had weapons with them and later it was determined
that they their base of operations was
south africa matter of fact they took
over an airplane and returned to south africa
from what you're reading of this is is there
was there cia complicity and money involved in
that or are the south africans just becoming
like a new cia and doing their own mischief
well it also connected and in all in all
fairness and to state the obvious the cia is
not the only agent of mischief in the world
and there are many other agents of mischief the
ci is working with many of the others as they do
as they commit their crimes i have as far as
is there any documentation i wouldn't have the
faintest idea all i know is what i've read in the
papers so you have to speculate they obviously had
at least an atmosphere of encouragement in south
africa including in the south african government
when they they skyjacked the plane and
flew back to south africa five of them
were arrested and the rest were just
turned free immediately and these five
were flown off in a helicopter to someone's
estate after posting a minimal bond then
because of international pressure south
africa did go back and arrest 30 more
it's not clear yet what they're going to succeed
in and what they're going to try them for or or
if they will in fact convict them but i i could
easily see something like that as more likely
developing from uh south africans with their
very aggressive attitude towards the seychelles
possibly with ci4 knowledge but quite possibly
without the cia knowing about it ahead of time
had the ci known about it ahead of time i'm i'm
reasonably sure they would not have complained or
protested that wouldn't be in their nature but i
see no reason to to to suggest that they set it up
on the other hand it's quite possible it's the
sort of thing that the cia station chief might
very well do having dinner going to the office of
the boss chief i think they call it something else
now the south african security force and saying
you know what you know you big talk what are you
going to do about the seychelles why don't you
fly some people up there and take the place and
turn it in the right direction and then the the
south african calling in a couple of uh rugby
players or former mercenaries and saying you know
it would be easy here's what you would have to do
and uh giving them some advice and guiding
and setting it in motion maybe some money
right i might note to our audience it is quite
remarkable that john stockwell in the last few
years has begun his second career as a novelist as
you might know it's very difficult to get a book
published much less a novel these days and john's
first novel was immediately picked up by william
moore which is one of the best new york publishers
and has just come out so we congratulate you john
on your new career and wish you all the best but
we still want you to come back and talk to us
about the cia and many other things on alternative
views remember i'm the last whistleblower
i'll never be i'll never be dated thank
you john thank you thank you very much
since we videotaped our interview with john
stockwell on recent cia activities a conference
has taken place in the boston area on reviving
the cia over a 10-day period more than a thousand
people attended and quite a few scholars and
anti-cia activists provided an update on cia
activity there were two reports in that conference
that we didn't touch on in our discussion with
john first of all saul landau of the institute for
policy studies in washington dc reported that he
had information that the reagan administration had
notified congress in mid-december that the c.i.a
was coordinating border raids from honduras into
nicaragua and was also using a clandestine radio
station to send false rumors to the mosquito
indians in eastern nicaragua the sandinistas
intended to exterminate them in an attempt to
get these indians to have an uprising against the
nicaraguan government there was also a report in
the conference by a vietnamese scholar novin long
that during the cia operations in vietnam they
recruited agents who are still active in vietnam
carrying on cia operations against the vietnamese
people and also indicated that certain right-wing
vietnamese are now being paid by the cia to
spy on the vietnamese who have come to settle
in this country and that in some cases certain of
these right-wing vietnamese have taken retaliatory
actions against left-wing members of the
vietnamese community living in america indicating
that there are still vietnamese intelligence
agents and politics going on in this country
now we jump from 1981 to 1986. well well well
guess what it looks like old danny love might
have been doing some business with the cia after
all of course not admitted until he got back into
the united states and then not even publicized
much in by the regular media but it seems that
two days after donnie loft left the soviet union
the u.s officials changed their story about his
contacts with the c.i.a back in 1985 so it raises
some questions about how innocent the man was
maybe he was was innocent but maybe
he was just used well we'll see
donaloff confirmed some of these
allegations himself at an october 13th
issue of news u.s news and world report where he
said he was approached by a father roman who is a
who was supposedly a priest and he was sought out
by him and was given some information well long
island newspaper newsday correspondent roy goodman
made an investigation into this and he reported
that this father roman promised to give
danilov some material on religious subjects
and he asked danny loft to take the material
to the u.s embassy which deniloff did
but there were some other envelopes including
one addressed to cia director william casey
and that was given to the cia station chief
all from this one package from father roman
now in one letter was a reference to rockets
and other military subjects according to
the uh newsday washington reporter and one embassy
asked danilov how to get in touch with roman
and he provided information on how to do it so
in a very unusual move and one administration
officials was very amateurish a cia man
actually called this father rahman on the phone
and said yeah we got the packet and then
he later said remind a note saying that
he had received the package from the journalist
friend just re just confirming his telephone
conversation so as a result of all these
events the u.s was eager to have dunedov
freed because of the c.i.a
mishandling of this whole business so
it's a question whether danilov was
really involved himself or whether he
was just inadvertently used but nonetheless well
what's the final analysis helen ellen ray who
contributes a lot to the covert action information
bolton and is the co-director of the institute for
media analysis said in answer the question
was then he loved spying he said well he
admits to delivering documents to the embassy
discussing them with cia agents and giving
them information about the man who gave them to
him which the cia then used to contact the man
and she said you don't have to be on
the cia's payroll to commit espionage
and it might at least have led the soviet union to
believe that danilov was a spy and who knows maybe
the guy was a set up by the kgb right and indeed
a faction of the kgb that was opposed to gorbachev
summit with the u.s this is all lost in murky u.s
soviet relations but what's most striking to me
about the danilov zakarov affair is that the u.s
media almost unanimously assumed that danilov was
an innocent journalist who is either set up by the
c.i.a or a victim of ci of rather kgb repression
whereas zakarov was supposedly a soviet spy who
was caught red-handed and was guilty without any
question at all well an article in october first
in these times raises some question about this
and indicates that the zakarov case has all the
earmarks of an fbi sting parallel to the abscam
case where the fbi stung certain congressmen by
tempting them with certain lucrative payoffs from
different supposed arabs who are really fbi
agents in disguise well to put the zacharov
case in perspective in these times argues you
have to go back to the early days of the reagan
administration when gene kirkpatrick was the
head of the u.s delegation to the united nations
and was claiming that the u.n was a hotbed
of third world radicalism and that the u.n
was a nest of soviet spies the problem was that
gene kirkpatrick didn't have any evidence that
any soviet u.n officials were actually engaged in
espionage for the soviet union and were therefore
looking very closely at the soviet un employees
to see if they could find some evidence of any
kind of spine for the soviet union whatsoever the
story then jumps to 1983 when a computer major
at queen's college got a call from a u.n official
asking him if he would do some work accessing some
data networks for him to get some information on
technology and military affairs the computer major
john had put up an advertisement saying that he
was willing to do database searches for people and
zacharov had seen the advertisement and contacted
him and then supposedly john went to the fbi
and said that he was approached by a soviet agent
or a soviet u.n official who was going to ask him
to do some computer searches and from there after
the fbi was monitoring this situation very closely
what zacharov was doing at this time from 1983
to 1985 was perfectly legal he was at that time
in the un center for science and technology where
he was responsible for collecting and appraising
information on scientific developments to give
to third world countries so it was logical that
he would look for some database searches in 18 in
1985 however john was given a job with a queen's
firm that was engaged in manufacture of
unclassified precision parts for military
equipment it was suggested in this in these
times article that john might have been given
this job to try to set up zakarov to tempt him
with some military information and thus be able
to arrest him as a spy and now it's not clear who
to believe zakarov admitted that he'd worked with
john for a couple years and said that he continued
to get information from john from this military
a company that he worked for in queens but claimed
that this was all unclassified data john however
and the fbi confirms this claims that zacharov
offered to do a 10-year contract with john
to pay him for unclassified military information
and it was at this point that he was arrested and
was accused of being a spy and then of course
a week later shortly thereafter the soviets
pinched danella in any case the question is
why would the u.s arrest the zakarov in any
case since he there was no information that
he had anything that was of value any military
secrets and this became a major media blitz
against the soviet union and imperiled the summit
the hypothesis of the in these times reporter is
that there might have been people in the reagan
administration who are trying to sabotage the
summit between ray and gorbachev and this was
one way to do it it might have been even more
complex than that i think it was in the nation
i forgot to bring that article with me but there
was a a reporter analysis of it speculating on
perhaps it might have been the danilov affair
set up by the kgb or the military-industrial
complex of the the soviet union itself because
we know the soviet union is not a monolith
and there are hawks in the within the
pulley bureau and etc who would not like to
see all these great reductions and armaments
that that they secretary is wanting to
to offer so it could be that they set up
danilov knowing that the united states
would take the bait and create a lot of hate and
discontent and then they wouldn't be able to get
this agreement and so the hawks in the soviet
union won as well as in the united states right
and what's striking is the way that the media
in the united states just presumed that the
know-off was innocent and zakarov was guilty and
didn't do any in-depth investigation of either
of these fellows or they didn't release any of
the information that quest that cast shadows on
the official report in the left-wing newspapers
you didn't see any of this in time newsweek the
networks or any of the major newspapers that's
why you got to read the alternative press in
order to find out what's happening that's
alternative views for this evening we'd like
to thank austin community television ac tv for
the use of their equipment alternative views is
a production of the alternative information
network po box 7279 austin texas 78713
um
although this program is made in 1982 the
information contained in it has not been
presented in the establishment media the cia's
greatest operation without any qualifications it's
better than in terms of their interest than when
they install the shah in power it's uh better than
the coup in guatemala and of course their many
failures from their own point of view better than
putting pinochet in power in terms of ci values
what it is is nothing less than an official
secrets act this is the the legislation that the
cia has been trying for 30 years to get to give it
legal protection and legal exemption from freedom
of speech and freedom of the press we'll begin to
learn what it's like to live in a third world
country which is being targeted by the c i a
many americans have lost sight of the fact that
many citizens of other countries particularly
in the third world uh have been the victims
of massive cia operations covert operations
everything from recruitment to bribery to buying
of an election on up the line to paramilitary
activities and terrorism training and torture and
even assassination and overthrowing of governments
and i think that americans fail to
realize this until it starts sometimes to hit them
at home and that's apparently what's going to be
happening now and legally john
stockwell former high cia official and
lewis wolfe co-editor of covert action
information bulletin tonight on alternative views
hey
although glasnost is occurring in the soviet
union we still have not had glasnost in the
united states concerning the subjects which we'll
discuss on alternative views good evening glad
you're with us tonight on alternative views
this is a very special treat because we have
two very very prominent people in the world of
covert activity experts in their field and nice
people too that's a strange combination but we've
got them we have john stockwell back with us john
was a key official in the cia for several
years before quitting and writing about his
experiences in the book on company business his
most recent book is a novel entitled red sunset
also going to do something special tonight a
few weeks ago we did an interview with lewis
wolf who's one of the editors of covert action
information bulletin now this is one of the
boltons which really has been freaking out the
cia for many years because it does name names of
agents but that's just one of the things it does
it has a lot of stories about covert activity and
some overt activity of intelligence organizations
and semi-intelligence organizations around
the world so you'll find out what happens with
coups and various types of activities like this
around the world by reading covert action
information bulletin well we were going to
have john with us where to do the interview with
lewis wolfe but john is out of town so what we're
going to do is the next best thing we're going
to show segments of the interview we did with
lewis wolfe and then we'll have john comment
on them lewis and his colleagues since 1978
have been publishing articles exposing the various
operations of the cia all over the world and some
of the threats to civil liberties and democracy
that this organization has contained lewis welcome
to alternative use thank you i'm glad to be here
first of all how did you get into the cia watch
business and what led you and your colleagues
to found the covert action information bulletin
well i have been a journalist since the 1960s and
actually 1966 i spent nine years in southeast asia
and it was really there that i first came
to grips with what the cia does in the
world that its main function as i learned
at that time in laos in the philippines is
intervening covertly in the affairs of other
countries and in fact covert action by the cia's
own definition is activity secret activity which
can be carried out without the knowledge of the
targets of that activity being able to learn that
it was carried out by the cia or in fact by the us
government and what led you and your colleagues
to found the covert action information bulletin
when did you begin to do this well it was after a
long succession of efforts largely growing out of
the watergate revelations of the church committee
and pike committee reports even the rockefeller
commission reports which documented gross and
ongoing and very large scale cia covert activities
that had been carried out up till that time the
american people didn't know very much about this
and that was really what the cia is about is
keeping it secret from the american people
in in some the cia's activities of course are
known to the people who against whom they're
carried out but it's the american people who are
the last to know about it and we as a result of a
lot of those revelations and a lot of other people
who were concerned about it decided to try and
put together a journalistic effort to look into
these areas there was a another magazine counter
spy which started earlier and after several years
it it bit the dust and we decided after two years
in 1978 to start covert action information
bulletin well it looks like there's going to be
some real problems coming up not only just for
you and covert action information bulletin but
also for civil liberties in general in
the united states and finding out what's
happening what our government is doing
in our name covertly around the world
with the intelligence identities protection
act just about to be passed in congress and
with reagan's executive order 12 33 things are
going to be quite different shortly aren't they
there is clearly a a very marked escalation
towards secrecy in this government these two
pieces of one legislation and one executive
order the executive order does not have to be
propounded by congress congress doesn't have
a single word to say about it basically these
two working in tandem with each other along
with other efforts by this administration to
embed the cia and the other intelligence
agencies of which there are some 18
federal agencies in secrecy this bill is the cia's
greatest operation without any qualifications it's
better than in terms of their interest than when
they install the shah in power it's uh better than
the coup in guatemala and of course there are many
failures from their own point of view better than
putting pinochet in power in terms of ci values
what it is is nothing less than an official
secrets act this is the the legislation that the
cia has been trying for 30 years to get to give it
legal protection and legal exemption from freedom
of speech and freedom of the press now what makes
it such a beautiful operation is that it is in
the process of being passed it's going through
the congress more or less like a dose of the salts
with the senate voted on it a couple of months ago
the vote was something like 90 to 2 and the
house it's expected to pass by a similar majority
and yet the american people by and large including
media people including television interviewers
across the nation and journalists are oblivious
that it's even passing much less what it really
means now what it really means see it's couched
and what makes it such a typical and beautiful ci
operation is that it's couched in the terms
of protecting our agents were out in the cold
risking their lives to defend the country this is
senator benson was the original sponsor of this
bill by the way and this was what he said about it
in many speeches here in texas now it's passed to
senator john chafee and jake garn sponsoring the
bill in washington now who can argue with that
legal protection from our agents whose names
are being exposed by irresponsible people who
don't agree with the government's policies now if
the facts were that simple if those were the true
facts who could argue with it but the truth
is that these agents lives are not in danger
because of their names being exposed the truth is
that these agents are functioning from embassies
with diplomatic passports under circumstances in
which if the worst possibly happens and they're
absolutely caught buying secrets from some local
spy agent a minister in the government or what
not the worst that will be will happen to them
even in the soviet union is that they will be
asked to leave the country under no circumstances
will they ever be attacked or jailed or executed
or what not by the government another government
by the host government where they're living and
breaking all the local laws by being a secret
agent and and recruiting spies and inducing people
to commit treason now in in the four or five posts
that i served in overseas full time we had full
liaison with the president of the country the
chief of the police and all the police officers
and all the military officers this means
that we met with them weekly in the name
of the ci no secrets to have lunch or dinner and
exchange information and do favors for each other
if there were ever a terrorist attack or threat
against one of us the first thing we would do
would be to pick up the telephone and call the
local police chief and say hey there's a threat
against us and i might note that this would this
would also apply in the soviet union if there were
terrorist threat in moscow against the u.s embassy
or a u.s case officer ci man they would call the
local police and say you know somebody's about
to blow us up there is a brotherhood of secret
quote secret police agents that functions like a
brotherhood even when they're supposedly on the
other side they're competing but it's sort of like
professional football players they're on different
different teams but they're still professional
football players well you had buddies who were kgb
played tennis with them played chess with them
socialized with them went drinking with them
and that was the sop for all case officers
everywhere two thousand plus well over two
thousand names have been revealed printed
published in the last few years and not one
agent has been killed because of his name being
revealed now there were two cases where it looked
like they were put up jobs one and one which
the congressman and the cia always mentioned is
the reason why richard welch and athens the 18th
of december in 1975 was killed he was shot up by
terrorists in front of his home and at that moment
the church committee which was in full session
was out of business washington every door in
washington closed on the church committee because
as though the church investigation had anything
whatsoever to do with it they flew him back and
gave him a full state ceremony which of course
was admission that he was cia to the world
i mean the headlines were ci chief kill they
didn't say the third secretary of embassy
killed the united states government made as much
politics as they could out of the fact that this
man was a career diplomat agent now the fact
was they caught the terrorists that killed him
and they they ascertained they verified that those
were the individuals who had published his name
in an athens newspaper three days before they
killed him because they wanted world attention to
what they were doing and it had nothing to do with
the investigations or publications in washington
and they already planned to kill him now this man
had been ordered by ci security to change houses
because he was living in the same house that eight
other ci station chiefs had lived in before him
generation after generation after generation after
generation of ci station chiefs had lived in that
same mansion it was a big villa and a very posh
part of athens as governments had changed coups
the colonel's coups the monarchy in and out of
power much earlier and dealing with all of the
terrorist activities and anti-terrorist activities
and coups in the middle east from athens
with the ci heavily involved with each government
and change of government and the ins and outs
in these governments and yet the cia station chief
was living in the same house throughout eventually
he was killed he refused to move because he said
it was a good house now there is no way that that
can be blamed on u s journalists publishing names
in washington moreover as i pointed out the cia
the cia director bill colby exploited that man's
death to make a big issue and to effectively close
down the church committee that was investigating
the cia which was investigating the ci's extensive
malpractices they put the church committee on the
defensive and out of business now there was one
other incident in el salvador where two agents
who were under a labor cover uh were killed
by right wing by the government uh police the
secret plea they're treasury agents is it in
el salvador that do the the killing down there now
these uh these two guys were in contact with the
government they were killed by government agents
set up in a hotel in shot and the united states
announced to the world that they were secret
agents their names had been published much
previously but the united states identified them
thereby admitting they were agents and admitting
that they were using this labor organization
as cover where did they make this announcement
they did it the the prosecuting attorney the
state the state department's representative
in the passport case in which they took philadel's
passport away from him revealed the identities of
these agents and claimed that that proved that
people publishing the names led to their death
they were already dead when the government chose
to use a totally fictitious a totally false ploy
to discredit phil agee he had not revealed their
names and so it's now in the supreme court records
it's cited by the supreme court justices in
their decision against phil agee and his passport
him keeping his passport these agents
being killed i.e the supreme court and
the state department reveal their identities to
accomplish their objective against philadelphia
there was another situation in jamaica where
it looked like it was a planned put-up job
in that case indeed the chief of station's house
was shot up with machine gun bullets and so they
made uh considerable propaganda publicity uh out
of that with photographs of the bullets but what
it's true his name had been published but what
happened is uh the back wall of his garage well
away from the house received five machine gun
bullets at a time when his family was out of the
country and he was not in the house and yet they
tried to use that to make publicity to show that
it made it dangerous to have the names revealed it
was also during an election where the opposition
to the social democratic government wanted
to make it appear that terrorism was rampant
in jamaica and so wasn't there some political
exploitation oh indeed there was considerable
political exploitation of it and and all evidence
points that it was it was the the government seek
uh secret police that fired the bullets right but
again the the press in washington played this as
played cooperated with the ci to give publicity
for the bill against the exposing of names
there's no real need for the bill it's not
protected in any way or national security
that's not required by the history of the cia
precisely on the one hand that's the problem and i
i go a bit further to point out that these agents
80 percent of them were identified from overt
information in the library of congress the people
publishing the covert action information bulletin
go to the library of congress and go through the
state department's overt records of its personnel
and come up with the ci officers names infallibly
because there are little indicators in there which
you or you or you anyone can go in
and read through and say that ci
and that's ci and that ci plus isn't it just
generally known in most cia stations who is cia
don't they find themselves to be known we used to
call it contacts and information we used to call
it wearing an invisible badge you you acted as
though you had a badge ci up here you you you drew
people to you imci talked to me you were taught
to do this allen dulles and the original ci great
in his book the craft of intelligence makes this
point that you have to be known to be an effective
intelligence officer but see that's on
the one hand the bill is is not necessary
and it's dishonest in that sense it's based on
false premises on the other hand the bill is so
written that it goes far beyond the protection
of agents names for example the bill is so
written that it will be a felony for agents
names to be published even if they're already
to republish the names even if they've
already been published as in the library
of congress or anywhere else it also includes
activities of agents so that you can if an agent
kicks in the door of your house and rapes your
wife or whatever and you publish a story about
it without citing the name it would still be a
felony under the executive order so we have to
see both the executive order and the intelligence
identities bill as almost part of a package
under the executive order the cia now will be
allowed and is allowed since it was signed in
december by the president it is now law the cia
will be allowed to carry out covert activities
in the united states as well as the all the other
agencies too so that if you were to discover for
example that a member of an intelligence agency
had infiltrated say your church organization
your student organization trade union or whatever
organization or any group of more than two people
was infiltrated and you discovered this and you
so much as mentioned it to a friend without even
writing a news article or without even talking
about it on the media uh on television for
example you could be held criminally liable under
this bill and we're talking about a bill which
authorizes or which penalizes persons and for 15
years in prison i'm sorry five years in prison
fifteen thousand dollar fine or both for
persons who've never worked in the government
and that that's a pretty heavy price to have to
pay to try and hold up your rights uh to stand
up for your rights against the onslaught of the
intelligence agencies now the new york times to
give you uh the the proof of the the the argument
that this is an official secrets act the new york
times in questioning the sponsors of the bill on
the floor of the senate pointed out that as it
was written if the london times published a story
about ci activities and station chief some scandal
of some kind the new york times couldn't republish
the london times story without committing a felony
and the sponsor of the bill slapped his hand on
the table and said that's right we want to knock
off all this criticism of the cia so the situation
has already come up with the revelation of cia
activity in iran recently which was not published
in the united states for very long but eventually
it got either washington post or the new york
times did it and there was a big uproar because
they were publishing it and the in the last
hearings the new york times uh questioning
again senator chafee about this bill said that
as they read it they would not be able to publish
their very legitimate and valuable stories about
the activities of cia agents ed wilson and frank
turple who were selling terrorist technology to
libya after they left the cia without committing
a felony and senator chafee said yes in the future
the washington post and the new york times will
have to be careful what they publish about the
cia i should say if this bill had been law then
we would have never known about watergate it
was it wouldn't be to expose it absolutely
but now it will be clear to many more americans
that there is a sort of a split foreign policy as
there is a split-level policy at home there is
the rhetoric and then there is the reality and
with secrecy in their best pocket they can now
carry out a lot of these activities and do it
as they say legally and what's once more we're
going back to the the age of almost the cowboy
politics that the cia carried out in the 50s
and 60s they claim as a result of the church
committee and other revelations that they don't do
that anymore well this administration is not only
not saying that but they're saying that it's
now legal and now they're being very upfront
about covert activity in many cases the covert
activities are now being overt activities it's
been talking about the cia being the main focus of
this bill but it isn't just the cia it's the fbi
where they're involved in quote anti-terrorist
activities and of course reagan has said anybody
who dissents is a terrorist and involved in
disinformation that's no exaggeration that's great
and also any of the other government or military
intelligence organizations i think many americans
as a result of these two matters and others
also will begin to learn what it's like to
live in a third world country which is being
targeted by the cia many americans have lost
sight of the fact that many citizens of other
countries particularly in the third world
have been the victims of massive
cia operations covert operations
everything from recruitment to bribery to buying
of an election on up the line to paramilitary
activities and terrorism training and torture and
even assassination and overthrowing of governments
and i think that americans fail to realize
this until it starts sometimes to hit them
at home and that's apparently what's going to
be happening now and legally this administration
makes no bones that it wishes to that it sees
its own people uh many of us uh as the enemy
and in fact there are many people i think in in
the country who consider themselves very middle
of the road who would be opposed to this it
it is absolutely incompatible with our system
of government as we have known it in the past
moreover it's written to include obviously more
than the cia that was all government agencies that
have a right to secrecy will be included in this
thing john isn't this literally unconstitutional
though this is absolutely unconstitutional it
seems to us that there are people in congress
who are prepared to relegate the first amendment
to a lower priority and they are more
interested in what they call national security
one member of congress as well as
one deputy director of of the cia
once stated that uh the first
amendment that's only an amendment
seems to me that's a rather shocking description
of one of the hallmarks of of our constitution
this is why i call it their greatest operation
is they're doing it without a constitutional
amendment which is beautiful in itself it is
if they propose to have all the states ratify
a bill saying throw out freedom of speech
and freedom of the press and give the ci
it would never pass but on the one hand they're
doing it without constitutional amendments and
and two they're doing it without the nation
even being aware of it which says something
about the vigilance of americans and and their own
feelings about their freedom of speech and press
they could care less they would rather watch a
football game why is this the case or why have
they gotten so far with it without media scrutiny
without public uproar etc it's not just the apathy
of the people listen it also the media just hasn't
reported on what's involved in this well the media
in this country is is and is the most apathetic
that i've ever seen in the world in terms of
playing a ball with the administration eighty
percent of our news is reporting quotations of
political leaders president reagan giving a speech
in which everything he says is either distortions
of historical fact or our propaganda
statements in effect or both face lies
all mixed together and yet the press will report
his speech as a fact it is a fact he made a speech
he said those words but they they don't say at
the end and everybody in the room that it was all
balderdash now there's a little bit more of that
with reagan than there was with other presidents
because he makes these misstatements so constantly
he gets the facts screwed up so much but the press
doesn't have any sense of defending its own
rights we have had an occasional editorial
including in the austin american statesman saying
that the names of agents bill is unfortunate and
that's about the size the new york times ran an
editorial saying this is unfortunate they said it
was kind of it was kind of wistful i read it when
i was on my way to lecture at yale and wesleyan a
couple of months ago and i read it the new york
times they were saying golly gee whiz they mean
this thing to apply to us too yeah there was
another in which they mentioned lewis wolfe and
they said well it's a bad bill but on the other
hand we've got to take care of people like lewis
wolf and maybe john stockwell they cannot believe
that the this that such a thing will actually
apply to them but uh unfortunately the cia has
many allies in congress and some even in the media
and so sometimes you can pick up a newspaper
and read some of the cia's own propaganda
coming from from some of those people what is
the source of the cia's power in washington
well i think it's the whole idea that the cia
has built up even in the halls of congress that
it is somehow a sacred entity and that while
there was a lot of criticism of j edgar hoover
and the fbi uh not a whole lot of it while he
was alive it's all happened since he died um
it's interesting because it is known for
example that hoover had a lot of information and
a lot of very damaging information against
members of congress it is also clear that
the cia maintains relations with a number of
congress people who have some of whom have
said so on the floor of congress that they are
in close contact with the cia and uh this bill
for example which was written by the cia and they
said so deputy director frank carlucci said it on
national television back in 1978 and said we are
now about to deliver this bill up to to congress
that's a little bit of a strange way for laws to
be written if they're going to be written by the
cia now what this bill is it's part of a number
of bills and legal precedents that the government
is obtaining to keep now they're not going to
go out and arrest the editor of the new york
times and put him in jail for 10 years the week
after this bill is passed they're not that stupid
but they're getting they may arrest lou
wolf if he violates it i think they probably
would because they could make propaganda
out of such an arrest but what they're
they're doing is they're getting that bill they're
getting the passport ruling for example they're
getting the other legal precedent such as the
lawsuit against frank snep marketing myself
and travel restrictions they're getting authority
for the secretary of state to throw people out of
the country who should have political exile
here such as the el salvadorian refugees and
they're getting these things ready so that the
next war that they get us into as in vietnam
they will have the legal power muscle to handle
it differently than they did during the vietnam
war they handled the centered home to make it
impossible to speak out the descent that choked
off kissingers and nixon's and before that rusk's
efforts in vietnam the dis the popular uprising at
home that forced the united states government
to abandon its policies and plans in vietnam
will not be nearly the government will have
weapons to crush such a thing in the future
it'll have an official secrets act to make it
illegal to publish stories like milai and whatnot
because they were obviously secret agents involved
so the publication of the mili stories would be a
felony jane fonda and cora weiss's travels to try
to make communication and establish some basis for
working out a peaceful solution to the thing they
would snap their passports up in the future and
and then the other restrictions on travel the
other restrictions on government agents so that
an officer has been in the service can't stop
and say we were bombing villages and bombing
churches and schools that would be a felony
he would go to jail it's a british official
secrets act with a different name you know
you were mentioning a while ago it's not
only just the cia but it's others too we had
a program recently which you may remember
about the greensboro massacres in which the clan
and the nazis in broad daylight and in front of
of tv cameras shot down five labor organizers
and killed them in greensboro north carolina
it came out by the investigations that bureau of
alcohol tobacco firearms agents was working with
the nazis indeed he was the one who gave them
the names of the people to be shot also there
was fbi and local police complicity with the klan
members as a matter of fact it's come out that the
fbi itself established over 40 chapters of
the klan over the years in north carolina
alone these revelations would be a felony now yeah
exactly this passes it would be a felony to reveal
such information to the american public or
government off by and for the people is is soon to
be a thing of the past in the united states what
this will do is to put the cia the fbi and these
other government agencies outside of the realm of
public criticism and even discussion or law yeah
outside of the law because they've broken every
law of man and god in in the activities they have
conducted the the experimentation on american
citizens for example with chemicals and disease
the propaganda of the united states breaking and
entering colonel white's famous words about where
else can a red-blooded boy lie kill cheat steal
rape and pillage in the name of the all-highest
now they will be able to that was who was this
this was colonel george m white one of the
founders of the cia who eventually directed the
mk ultra program and he was retiring uh he and
i overlapped by about four years he he came out
of retirement to address my mid-career seminar
and telling about how we put the cia together
and we did this and the other in his letters
memoirs he wrote and then allowed it to be
published that statement where else could a
red-blooded american boy lie kill cheat steal rape
and pillage with the blessings of the old highest
and that was before they had an official
secrets act to protect their activity john
there's been very few people in this country that
have actually told us what the cia has been up
to and exposed some of their misdeeds etc you of
course and a few other former agents have written
some books and given lectures criticizing
agents activities this would be impossible
in the future would it not be we will never know
uh the truth and the details the blood and gore
the extent of of responsibility and culpability
for the ci's program in nicaragua right now
unless someone like reagan or in his administ
a top official chooses to stand up and denounce
what's happening because top officials are exempt
from these laws but we will never know the truth
about for example the shah and the evacuation
of iran and which was a debacle i was told by a
friend of mine who who who was close to a third
friend of mine who was part of the cia security
establishment and iran who said it was a debacle
that far exceeded the evacuation of vietnam
the evacuation of the united states from uh from
iran and uh this this story will never come out
and the many other stories the assassinations that
probably are being planned today uh such such as
the coup in in uh in chile or the assassination of
patrice lumumba these sort of things are going on
but the public won't know about them in the
future why is the government been so outraged
by this publication and putting so much heat on
them i don't think there's any other publication
in america that's had so much government pressure
put on them then well you have two forces in the
government functioning here you have one is
an a defensive outrage against being attacked
secret police organizations don't like to be
exposed and attacked that's the same anger
that they focused at me people who are performing
activities that the the full range of the society
the 90 of the society would describe as depraved
people who are doing this while for functioning
under the cover of being legitimate state
department diplomats prestigious cover
positions don't like to have their activities
and names published for what they really are
this is traditional anywhere in the world the goon
squads in chile don't like to be attacked nor does
the kgb in in russia to be attacked and exposed
but nowhere else in the world do they become
as self-righteous and as vindictive as they do
in washington where they they the united states
ambivalence the duplicity the the the jekyll and
hyde aspect of the united states character where
we profess such high ideals and yet traditionally
we have ex exploited we have engaged in activities
that included uh dropping atom bombs on
women and children in japan eliminating
large elements of the indian population of this
country and in the past 30 years killing well
over 800 thousand people in the third world under
circumstances that can only be called terrorism
but doing it pretending all the while to be
idealistic high-minded human rights oriented
freedom-loving people now these values are brought
together in the cia where people are diplomats
by cover and cia agents by trade and when they
have themselves exposed and have their children
their family their friends find out that hey
you weren't really a nice diplomat all these
years you were in fact running the phoenix
program in vietnam that killed 40 000 people
including many innocent people this isn't this
isn't something that makes these people feel
good and they get very angry moreover the nation
in in the mid 70s was clearly close to closing
down the ci to rejecting this kind of activity so
they were fighting for their existence and there
you get into the other driving force of their
reaction against lou wolf and bill shap and
myself and others is just simply exploitation
working the the thing against the the people
there is a theory which is of course nonsense
that phil agee was was sent by the ci to reveal
names to create an atmosphere which would lead
eventually to an official secrets act now that is
certainly nonsense and uh in the extent to which
it discredits uh very honorable men you know i but
the fact is that they are exploiting this
revelation of names extensively to affect
the passage of an official secrets act
they were tr they've tried every other
way over the past 30 years every other way you
could conceive of they didn't succeed until
modern times and the curious vacillation of
the american public and washington and the
senators and and congressmen in terms of
just pure conservativism and callousness
and i think that american people really have
to understand that it is their rights uh who
which are being threatened here now we are among
many people ones who reject the idea that it's
more important to protect our rights
than than people in other countries
clearly that is not the case the minute we are
involved in the torture or in the death of a
single person in another country our rights are
being abridged in our tax money to say the least
is being used and our humanity is being violated
because we're being asked to accept inhuman acts
perpetuated in our name as americans plus the
fact that it eventually will come home they use
it successfully overseas they'll use it on the
united states citizens as well one of the most
interesting aspects of this bill and the
current environment in washington is to project
what it does to the legal system of a free society
like ours in terms of the individual when you
begin to give a special police a secret police
a legal priority legal freedoms and rights over
the citizens we have some examples we don't have
to speculate the bill isn't passed yet and yet
some of the things that have been happening
in the last few years illustrate what we can
look forward to for example one to begin with
a personal experience i testified to the senate
um a little over a year over a year ago
against this bill i demanded the right to
testify because they had aclu testifying against
it and journalists but no one who had been inside
who knew about cover and could say this is [
__ ] i was there we didn't do it that way they
they acquiesced and let me testify now you have to
write out a written statement before you testify
and submit it and then you verbally introduce
yourself on the floor of the senate i am so and
so and what and uh then proceed to make a verbal
statement which parallels the written statement
the senate oversight intelligence oversight
committee submitted my written statement to
the cia for censorship the day before my
testimony the cia struck out two parts
which were in the public record published
in my book and republished in many magazines
overt information which both of you have read and
many other people in this nation forty thousand
people or so that bought my book have read
which was not national security information
but there were two things that i cited that
showed the cia's disregard for agents cover
it just illustrated the fact that there was no
that they weren't secret agents the ci struck
them out and returned the report deleting these
points now i was meeting with the representatives
of the senate committee just before i went on to
testify and the senate legal counsel the young
attorney threatened me right outside their office
i didn't have a badge to get inside the officer
was standing in a little foyer outside and i mean
finger in the chest you know and i'm warning you
john stock well do not use the floor of the senate
to challenge ci review like this and i'm backing
up like that then we walk into the he didn't
know you're an international karate champion
and so then i went in to testify and i began
to introduce myself and jake garns from utah
uh i was saying you know stock will 19 years
the marine corps and marine corps reserves
13 years in the cia the wars and medals
and whatnot to establish the fact that i
you know i have certain credentials for having
served my country and he interrupted me to say i
know who you are you're a traitor and everything
about you fills me with loathing and disgust
and i said senator no one is going to
say something like that to me anywhere
and he said i just did i have my freedom of speech
too and grinned at the cameras and i said yeah but
the difference is that i give you your freedom of
speech and you're trying to take mine away from me
okay in frank snap's case where the government
sued him to take a civil suit to take take away
the prophets from his book so-called they took
away all the gross proceeds not just the prophets
they took him into the fourth oh yes
he couldn't deduct his typing costs
or whatever they took away the gross
of everything the book had made
now in the first day of hearing in the fourth
district court under judge orrin lewis with
all kinds of attorneys and journalists attending
this thing uh orrin lewis made statements which uh
the washington post three major newspapers in the
nation were virtually calling for his impeachment
the next day for the bias of his statements he
said that it would not be necessary to have a jury
that he could handle it himself he said that the
facts in the case didn't interest him one damn bit
he said that it was his objective to take away
from mr snap his quote ill-gotten gains that
was before the trial even this was the first day
this was in the first days of the thing highest
open mind he did this in front of like i say 50
attorneys who were there because of the the the
unconstitutional new law aspect of the case
and journalists prominent journalists from
all over the world now the mo that's horrifying
but what's much more horrifying is what follows
frank snep and his attorney were relaxed after
that figuring that whatever happened they had it
won in the appeals because of his incredibly
prejudiced statements then and throughout
the case he kept interrupting uh the the the
state's council uh to to disallow to protest
snep's positions and vice versa i mean he was
conducting the the hearings now snap and mark
lynch the aclu attorney working with him felt
that they had absolutely won in the appeals when
they got the court record to go to the fourth
district appeals court in richmond virginia
those statements had been expunged from the record
and the appeals court refused to address itself to
the fact that orrin lewis's prejudicial statements
had been written out the judge had gotten to the
court recorder and told him to type the thing
up without those statements is that legal what
what's the status that's a pure raw felony or in
lewis and the the court recorder whoever did it
should you know should get about 15 years for that
but the courts refused to consider the fact that
the court record had been modified there were
50 witnesses three newspapers calling for the
men's uh virtually for the man's impeachment for
his statements and then when they get there the
court record it doesn't say the same thing that
all of these witnesses said it did afterwards
that's just one example this also shows very
graphically how if you have these police agencies
like the cia or the fbi getting out of control
how they corrupt the entire legal system and
then the case of uh of phil agee that we mentioned
previously in his passport hearing where the state
is revealing names falsely claiming these men were
killed in order to prove a point to get broader
legislation for the cia and then just a little
case that has no implications in terms of names
of agents bills or whatnot freedom of speech but
it illustrates the point phil lichke quit the cia
he was writing a book about koreagate which i hope
he gets published it's truly a horrifying account
of its own about the inside story he submitted
it for review as the law requires him to do
they challenged it and deleted a lot of things
so then he would write footnotes saying the
information blanked out in the above paragraphs
discusses a high-ranking ci official who was
taken out by korean police and gotten drunk and
coerced and without you know trying to come up
with a footnote and then submit the footnotes for
review and he was truly a thorn in their side and
then they were having to address themselves to
what of the footnotes could they because you know
they eventually have to defend these things in
court but anyway he was working on his book very
seriously with them through the review process his
wife was unstable treated for mental problems in
psychiatric treatment she they were in the process
of getting a divorce the ci had its councils work
with her and work with her counsels now they claim
this was necessary to prevent her or the divorce
proceedings from revealing national security
information but she wasn't an employee of the cia
they had prominent ci i mean gs17 cia officers
go to the hear the divorce hearings and testify
against philitsky character assassination saying
things that his friends would absolutely deny in
terms of his character and his stability and when
he and his attorney tried to cross-examine them
the court said no because of national security
they couldn't be questioned on the statements
they had made about him and they were permitted
to walk out of the room without cross-examination
so they could stand up and destroy his character
lying while he did so and walk away without being
cross-examined now see the the the precedent in
that case means that if the government begins to
come after people like they have to rewrite the
whole legal system if they begin to prosecute
people under the names of agents bill they
can't you know the citizens defense of this
was the truth this horrible thing was happening
which might make some points with the jury
cannot be brought out they claim national security
so they will allow government witnesses to come in
and testify for the prosecution but they will
not allow them to be cross-examined to pull out
the whole truth to defend the individual this is
what we're getting into with the new law legal
libel legal libel legal slander legal libel legal
slander legal biased information and depriving the
citizen the defendant of the right to defend
himself to act to get the full information out
it's a new law it's a new era we're getting into
it's 180 degrees new from what this country is all
about and again i repeat the irony that the the
beauty of it from the cia's point of view is that
the great mass of the american people including
the press and the movers of the society are
oblivious of what's happening john we wanted to
thank you for coming on our show to revealing to
our audience here exactly what's at stake in this
name of agent's bill and we also want to tell you
that next week we have some more revelations
some startling revelations about recent cia
activity with lewis wolff of the covert action
information bulletin who will be back and john
stockwell will again comment on some of lewis's
revelations we'll have some more updated stories
about the cia so the cia watch continues on
alternative views and now for some news stories
how many of you have heard of sonoma state college
well it's in california and each year they select
the 10 most censored stories of the year and
those who don't quite make the top 10 are
considered the old 15 or 20 under reported
stories of the year how do they select this
well they have a panel mainly a combination
of press muckrakers and people from the press
itself people from cbs or new york times
and so since 1976 they've been doing this
and very interestingly every one of these top
10 stories has been covered by alternative views
mainly because the stories originate or appear
in the alternative press for instance the basic
code this was in 1981 the top story was the basic
cause of our economic crisis monopoly militarism
and multinationalization have destroyed america's
free enterprise the next story was in justice of
greensboro members of the clan and the nazis
shooting down those labor leaders there we've
covered these the third one is buying america and
radioactive burying america and radioactive waste
one hungry one child dies
of hunger every two seconds
and on and on and on anyway these are all stories
that we've covered but nobody nobody else the one
we missed was one which well it came across in
the chicago tribune i don't like the chicago
tribune i guess you do either but this is an
incredible thing i've never heard of this before
so this will close the gap and now we've reported
on all stories since 1976 did you know that there
is a bank in the united states government which
will fund projects which congress does not approve
of or if congress does approve they only give
them a pittance rather than as much as they want
and they give a sample or if the federal or
the executive branch wants to do something
quietly they have this special little bank which
does it for instance nasa wanted a new satellite
to track other other satellites but it was
afraid that congress wouldn't approve the money
they wanted western union to do it and they would
finance it just hey buddy here's the money and uh
and the government would it was a
straight loan from the government to them
this bank is in the office of the
federal treasury building in washington
and was reported back in 1979 the bank
operates with just a handful of staff members
but it has extended some five billion dollars in
loans since it started in nineteen seventy four
and this is more than the total outstanding
loans of the bank of america the world's largest
private bank that's big bucks that's incredible i
have an astonishing story here that i think will
be on possibly simona college's 10 biggest stories
that's been neglected for this year this is a
story that i haven't seen reported on television
or any of the media and it is the trial that's
going on now of the top chemical testing company
in america called the industrial bio testing
laboratories that is now going on in a case that
in these times in a story on this alleges is
the most massive scientific fraud in u.s history
since 1953 the industrial biotesting laboratories
is the largest corporation in america that tests
all of the chemicals that are used in herbicides
pesticides that are used on many different
products that we use daily what these corporations
do is they pay this corporation industrial bio
testing laboratories money to carry out tests to
see if the products that these corporations want
to sell are safe or not and then the government
takes a look at the tests and certifies on
the basis of these chemical tests whether a
product is or is not safe well after seven years
of government investigation it appears that there
has been massive scientific fraud in the testing
that the bio test laboratories have been carrying
out in other words they've been doing shoddy
scientific research and testing they've been
covering over dangers in some of the products
that we use falsifying evidence doing shoddy
examination making claims in tests that they
didn't really carry out failing to experiment
for certain dangerous chemicals and substances so
it could be that many many products that are now
on the market that went through this company are
dangerous to give you a sense of the magnitude of
what's at stake here the indies times stories
indicates that over ten thousand ibt studies
have been carried out to register products for
the american market and at least two thousand of
them are primary research that no other testing
company or no other government test was carried
through to test the safety of these current
these products moreover independent canadian and
american scientists have called the majority of
the studies that this corporation has carried out
to be scientifically invalid and they claim that
almost all of the insecticides and herbicides
that are on the market today over 325 of them that
were certified by this company and their test may
not be safe at all so this is a massive scientific
scandal that may have a lot of importance for us
because this may mean we've been using products
that have really not been safe and this hadn't
been covered at all in the media that i've seen
about even though it seems to be a major story
the wall street journal reports the doctors
defrauding medicare may face fines in excess of
a hundred thousand dollars the health department's
inspector general is readying civil penalties for
doctors who double bill patients are charged for
operations that they never perform officials also
are investigating kickback payments by medical
equipment suppliers to hospitals and therapists
there are several good books out on this subject
but one i thought was particularly good was called
tender loving greed by mary mendelsohn and it
chronicled abuses in the nursing home industry
and one of the things she says is a big scam in
nursing homes nowadays that actually has the mob
involved in it is the milking of the medicare
profits by rewriting loans it seems that the
mobs will buy up a whole chain of nursing homes
and then funnel the medicare and medicaid money
into rewritten loans that with interest rates
of like 40 percent so that most of the money
instead of going to the patients themselves in
the form of food and health care is actually
going to the coffers of the mobsters that's tender
loving greed by mary mendelsohn excellent book
this concludes the first of our three-part
series on covert action featuring john stockwell
former high cia official and lewis wolff editor
of covert action information bulletin alternative
views is a production of the alternative
information network po box 7279 austin texas 78712
good night
foreign
oh
although this program was made in 1982
the information contained in it was never
presented on the regular media it was
in fact the new york times in a story
in january who disclosed the first part of
the story which was that the green berets
eight of them were present during a
torture session and the member of the
salvadoran army who talked about this who
is now deserted and was living in mexico
he was somewhat intimidated i guess by talking to
the new york times and he's later revealed to the
to mexican media and that's the transcript in this
store in this article that the special forces and
i should say the u.s special forces was created
originally by the cia the special forces were
actually involved in the torture as opposed to
standing by observing it the training facilities
for torture for interrogation techniques were in
san antonio texas at one time it troubles me not
obviously because i was once part of all this
but also just as an american citizen to realize
that this country is indulging in activities
that are just as cruel and just as as depraved
in some cases and almost as extensive as what for
example the the gestapo indulged in in germany
we haven't liquidated uh 5 million jews but 800
000 minimum figure people killed in terrorist
circumstances in the third world is a lot of
people dead former cia official john stockwell
and co-editor of covert action information
bulletin lewis wolf tonight on alternative views
uh
tonight on part two of covert action part two of
a three-part series we again feature lewis wolff
editor of covert action information bulletin
and john stockwell former cia official and
author of in search of enemies and red sunset
we'll take you on a tour of covert intelligence
activity around the world some by the cia some
by other countries and even an attempted coup
by the ku klux klan now some news we have
something on the fbi it seems like they're
trying to climb back in our bedrooms and
telephones and everywhere else all of our
organizations that we have back in april
28th there was the upi story which quoted the
fbi director william webster is saying folks we
have some new fbi guidelines and that means we're
going to be able to go into the political spying
business again but he says don't worry about it
our agents only will be doing it if we
think that a crime is going to be committed
there were some pretty uh stringent uh guidelines
laid down on the fbi back during the ford
administration as a result of the revelations of
the cointelpro program from 1957 to 1951 into 71
amazingly enough i gave a presentation at a
college class these are college graduate students
they didn't know what the cointelpro program
was i thought my god is our memory that short
so to let you know what cointelpro was through
j edgar hoover's program to infiltrate dislocate
disrupt any lawful political organizations which
j edgar hoover didn't like they had wiretaps
bugs surreptitious mail openings break-ins
they sent anonymous letters and all to break
up marriages they disrupted meetings ostracized
people from their professions got people fired
from their jobs they provoked target groups
into rivalries that could result in death
they dynamited the publishing places of
the dissident press organizations and our
from our program on the clan we found out that the
clan had organized over 40 chapters of the klan in
north carolina alone back in the 60s anyway it was
a terrible terrible thing and but they're wanting
to do it again but supposedly more gently but in
the june 83 edition of the inquiry magazine the
libertarian magazine matt hentoff says watch out
folks the interpretation which william webster
gives on what they can do is much more broad than
even tail gunner joe mccarthy had in his heyday
and the new guidelines give to the agents to
let them go on their feelings as to what may
advocate only advocate what they consider to be
criminal activity and that could be most anything
and as the as the article ends it says if keeping
tabs on mere public advocacy is an authorized law
informant activity law enforcement activity in
the domestic security field then between what
the fbi hears from soap boxes and informants
and learns from collectively signs assigned
ads and letters to newspaper editors folks
get ready for another cointelpro program
as an example of the sort of thing that the fbi
has been doing over the last several decades
in the subversive groups that they've been
infiltrating and harassing one case is the
national lawyers guild they've recently put a
multi-million dollar lawsuit through the courts
claiming that the fbi has been illegally harassing
them surveilling them infiltrating their group
since the 1940s and during this lawsuit a document
came out that revealed that an fbi informer within
the national lawyers guild bar association has
every year been leaking to the fbi a list of
all of the names of the members of the national
lawyers guild that the fbi has put into its files
to keep information on and to surveil and they've
also the national lawyers guild has uncovered
over four hundred thousand pages of documents
that the fbi had amassed on them that are in
fbi files showing the depth of the surveillance
of the fbi on the national lawyers guild
and they claim that another three million pages of
documents have also been amassed by the fbi that
the fbi has refused so far to release but that
freedom of information suits are trying to get
opened up and disclosed so here's an example of
the kinds of groups that the fbi claim you have
to have to keep their eye on the national lawyers
guild this very subversive organization of liberal
lawyers there's in this article in inquiry
it says that not only will the new guidelines
allow the fbi to continue investigations into
organizations but it can do it even when an
organization is inactive like if the international
workers of the world the old iww wobblies if they
wanted to get organized again the fbi would be
there be one of the first ones to join up to to
continue their surveillance of them even if there
is no immediate harm there's a guideline even if
there is no immediate harm from the organization
and there's another thing that is continuing to
that we still have which their media don't talk
about and that is the concentration camps in
the united states we have concentration camps i
think what there are six or eight of them around
the country that are caretaker status and anytime
the president says there is a national emergency
the fbi trots out its files and says okay we'll
put these people in these concentration camps
that's on the law and they're just ready and
waiting i have one final piece of data on
this national lawyer's guild suit and that is
the fbi itself has confirmed that at least 13
guild members were undercover fbi agents and 102
more were paid informants this shows the extent
to which the fbi has infiltrated even liberal
groups like the f the national lawyers guild
and has also subverted or corrupted their members
by making them paid informants of the fbi so this
just shows you that any group can be infiltrated
and surveilled by the fbi and on these lists of
people to be put in concentration camps in the
event of so-called national emergency are people
like a good friend john duncan i imagine from the
civil liberties union civil liberties union folks
are on the fbi's list people like oh jane fonda
dr spock dear dr spock is on the list so we might
have pretty good time that concentration camp
don't you expect that we'll be there yeah i was
a member of sds back in the 60s and i'll tell you
what there never was a more boring organization
i went to about two meetings and they sat around
argued about semantics and this and that and
finally this one radical guy had real frizzy hair
and just kind of a crazy dude he was advocating
taking over mcdonald's taking over this taking
over that one of the meetings he finally talked
us in we went down and occupied the mcdonald's
and after after a while i got to thinking boy
this is pretty stupid and i'd always been an
advocate of freedom of milkshake so i ended up
buying a strawberry milkshake and going home and
that was the extent of my involvement with sds
but i'm sure it's in a file somewhere and
that guy who that who provoked everybody
doing it more than likely was an fbi agent it
was obvious because he was so blatant about it
they found that in previous programs we've
had on civil liberties they found that the
fellow who triggered the chicago riot by skinny
enough climbing up the uh um oh not a ladder what
do you call those things in the parks where
the pigeons flying maple or statues that's it
anyway this guy climbed up on the statue and
and fluttered a vietcong flag up there and that
triggered the police then another another person
went up and slapped a policeman in the face
both of these guys even though they
had beards and long hair were both
police undercover people i mean they were
provocative agents and other people i've talked to
said their organizations had these provocateurs
in them who turned out to be fbi agents
what else you got craig well let me see i clipped
a little thing out of the paper i think it was the
awesome paper i neglected to market careless me
this is a direct quote i wonder if you could guess
who said this i quote every gun that is made every
warship launched every rocket fired signifies in
the final sense a theft from those who hunger
and are not fed those who are cold and are not
clothed this world in arms is not spending money
alone it is spending the sweat of its laborers the
genius of its scientists the hopes of its children
this is not a way of life at all in any true sense
under the cloud of war it is
humanity hanging on a cross of iron
you guys have any idea who said
that he also said as part of that
every warship launched every gun that is fired
every bomb that is dropped represents a theft
a theft from those people who are hungry and
don't have enough clothes and don't have work you
obviously know who it is what do you think stokely
carmichael no that was dwight david eisenhower
that's the versive president we had yes indeed and
he was a republican i may note and the commander
of allied forces in europe during the war so you
might think he would know something about that
and now the second in a three-part series
on covert action with john stockwell
and lewis wolff john there has been over
the last few years also a small handful of
journalists who have been sort of cia watchdogs
most prominent of which has been lewis wolff
we have an interview with him maybe
you can to introduce this interview
tell us a little bit about louis wolfe and his
journalistic publications who is lewis and what
has he been doing over the years and why is the
government so outraged by him well his background
is is it's thoroughly a legitimate standard if
you will journalism he was assigned for a couple
of years in manchester writing for a couple of
prominent news organizations manchester england
yes manchester england and eventually made his way
through london back to the united states where he
gravitated to a scrutiny of the cia and the
intelligence community watching the revelations
of the church committee information that he had
come across in his research some of which he had
published as part of news stories previously
other parts of which he was not permitted to
publish by the nature of the press establishment
and so he uh put together with bill schapp and
ellen ray the covert action information bulletin
whose function was to focus on the intelligence
organizations of the united states and discuss
and expose in a perfectly legitimate way the
covert action activities of the cia principally
as well as the other uh intelligence organizations
i believe they formed that in about 1976
and have been in washington since publishing
stories of true stories their quality their
standards of journalism are exceedingly high
that bulletin is distributed in the
state department and it's sold out
the first morning that it's put on the
stands in the state department news stands
they also publish in that bulletin the names of ci
agents and where they are now as they're assigned
and reassigned about the world i believe that in
very recent months they have ceased the policy
of publishing uh names because the controversy
is so hot and they would just assume and and
also it's never been their intention to break the
law they've made that clear from the outset bill
schapp is the brother he is a a highly competent
attorney and is the brother of a top sportscaster
in new york city he is a very articulate man
himself and has testified to the senate many times
against the names of agents bill for example and
and defending what he and lou will for doing and
after his testimony many times senators have
come up and shaken his hand and said i disagree
with you but you certainly make your case for
the legitimacy of what you're doing very well
let's let's yeah let's take a look at some of
the things which lewis wolf had to say and we'll
let you comment every so often on greatest okay
what in the years that you've been publishing
it you think are some of your most significant
revelations are there some stories that
even shocked you well i think one of the
big stories that we were able to document in some
detail was the the whole scope of cia activities
similar to what the cia did in chile and which
was documented by the senate select committee
was the whole covert action program in jamaica
in between 1976 and 1980 and we were we did a
great deal of research into that and we discovered
many in many ways a very similar program almost a
classic model that was followed along the lines
of what they did in chile including three major
categories military paramilitary activity
the use of propaganda in the in the media
and the third one which was economic warfare using
the multilateral organizations the international
monetary fund and others to withhold loans which
had been promised to the jamaican government
this is one example what are a couple more
of the details of that you particularly
mentioned those first two examples of actual
paramilitary activity well cia was involved in
in jamaica there was a fire for example that
took place in jamaica of an old people's home
i think 150 old and infirmed
women many of them blind
were living in this home and as it turned out
the place burned down in the space of about
eight minutes seven or eight minutes it was
discovered that the foam wires had been cut
and that the exits had all been blocked even those
who could see their way out could not get out
and that the means by which the fire was set was
the use of a petroleum jelly which was unavailable
in jamaica this was one indication among others
that there was outside help why would the cia
you might ask why would the cia want to murder
150 old women it was because it was an effort
part of a very large scale effort to discredit
the government in jamaica which was at the time
headed by michael manley the prime minister
there were images produced of michael manley
in the media in the daily gleaner which was
the newspaper which the united states through
the cia helped to support and there is a
good deal of evidence of that there were
images of michael manley showing a death
mask i mean it was his face which had been
somehow made to look like a death mask although
it was pretending to be a photograph of him
and there were many ways to try and discredit him
this is very very similar in fact to what the cia
did to try and discredit salvador allende in chile
if you remember richard nixon instructed the cia
in a meeting which was in 1970 in the white house
and there was a document in the senate report
which is reprinted and he said make the economy
scream those were his words and that's of course
what the cia proceeded to do in chile and that's
what they also did in jamaica they also furnished
a lot of munitions and assistance to the terrorist
squads that were going around killing people in
the in the cities and also in the countryside in
jamaica as well that's correct well john you had a
trip down to jamaica and you saw a lot of these
things about jamaica with your own eyes right
yes indeed a very moving a very interesting trip
to me to see a target country at a time in the
height of a ci operation when i was completely
outside so there's no way that i could see
to see the problem that journalists have always
had when the us government was targeting on a
country in a situation trying to destabilize it
overthrow or manipulate the elections or whatever
of trying to figure out what's going on when you
don't have access to all of the flow of cables and
the discussions and national security council
meetings and whatnot for the planning i observed
that from published information the cia station
there was quite large for that size of a country
it was huge in fact it was bigger than any
station i knew of in africa although jamaica
was a fairly small island with two million
people that's typical of when the cis has
got a big operation going into place they beef up
the station and beef up the offices back stateside
the tone and flow of articles in the
gleaner what it was of course as lou says
definitely a chapter out of chile or
a chapter out of the angolan operation
every indication of a massive ci operation going
to destabilize the government to make the economy
scream and in that case i would say that probably
someone got promoted for that one probably several
people because manly was run out of what does
it work by illegitimate yeah without without a
scandal without an assassination without uh the
things that have caused the cia so much grief
uh manly a champion of of social democracy
of of giving the people a piece of the pie
was thrown out of office and an arch capitalist
was put in office and and again there was uh
minimal adverse publicity lou wolf and the others
were studying the situation and did publish about
what was going on but it was not published in the
new york times in the washington post and the big
the big television networks didn't do studies
on it primarily because even if the journalists
of the big organs knew what was
happening and might have wanted to
they really just because of the secrecy
couldn't get the truth about what the united
you know the st when we formed the cia we
committed our leaders to having two policies
as loose as the rhetoric the public statements
and the truth about what united states policy is
so an interesting measure of of
presidents is how effectively they lie
interesting discussions that occur inside the
cia is about lying would would you lie you know
you're the ddo and you're going to testify to the
senate in serious discussions are you going to lie
because if you do it's perjury and there's a
chance you could go to jail and yet you know the
organization expects you to lie president carter
was one of the most effective liars i have ever
watched on television and through the
media as a poker player men i would
never go up against that man he could look at
that camera and stay say things that obviously
he knew were completely and totally false and
i would study his expression and i could detect
nothing except occasionally a little wisp of
a smile that wasn't consistent with what he
was saying like he thought it was funny but one
of his more classic tech actually yeah well the
the smile that i was referring to wasn't that it
was just a kind of like he was repressing a grin
like he thought it was funny how he rationalized
these things i don't know but one of his most
uh of conspicuous lies was when he sat down
with manly just a few weeks before the elections
in washington and told him face to face that
the ci don't have the cia doing anything to
destabilize you or your government we have no
such program going when obviously he did and
he pulled it off to the point where even manly
was troubled very effective lie another major
story that we we uncovered was the whole range
of cia media operations throughout the world
we did an analysis of these operations and the use
of money very large scale money is thought between
one third and and forty percent of the cia's
budget and i should say that that budget figure
is the biggest secret that there is in washington
today at that time it was estimated that the 1978
budget was in the range of one and a half billion
dollars uh a more recent estimate by a military
journal not a liberal journal by any means
estimated that the cia's budget today is in
the range of 10 billion dollars at any rate
this analysis that we made of the cia's media
operations disclosed among other things that
they deliver through cia couriers ready to
print or ready to broadcast news and i put that
in inverted commas which is used by the media
and this is created by the cia how often
does the cia manipulate the media in this way
plant stories get their views in the media is this
fairly common as a modus operandi for the cia it
goes beyond your in the in the course
of the past 30 years it goes beyond your
wildest imagination the extent to which the
ci has gone to manipulate public opinion
if you include the mh chaos program which was a
billion dollar program of setting up proprietary
companies setting up student organizations
so they could draw radical students in and
do every kind of of duplicious manipulation of of
national student movements press propaganda labor
extensive formation of labor unions funding of
major labor unions with the objective essentially
of manipulating the mind and attitudes of workers
throughout the nation and the world this was the
essential tool that they used to destabilize chile
and overthrow allende was of course making the
economy scream getting to the military officers
but it was essentially the truckers union that
finally brought the country down and justified
quote justified pinochet j's takeover of power
five thousand university professors they've
co-opted this is church committee revelations
i'm not making this up it's in print church
committee's revelations five thousand university
professors co-opted to help the cia manipulate
people's minds 400 journalists in the u.s
including big-name journalists now that's a big
chunk of the prominent journalist co-opted to
function routinely to put help the ci put out the
stories and biases to the world there are a whole
range of of areas wherein the cia provides
briefings to selected journalists and there
are numerous cases where the cia has for example
published books and several thousand books were
published in english by by the cia and this is
documented in the church committee report they
set up 250 new services and wire services some of
which not all but some of which are still in the
pocket of the cia and i think it's only fair to to
say that even some journalists who don't realize
there are some who are winning but there are
also some who do not realize that they're being
targeted by the cia when they come home from a
trip overseas they might talk to somebody and they
don't realize at least right away who they're
talking to and then it turns out that they've
been the source of information which was
used by the cia and then specific operations
around the world from corner to corner to
discredit this individual create an impression
about that situation such as el salvador the
famous white papers in the angolan operation
which i i note were you know back in the back
in the good old days we did a better job our our
white papers in the angolan operation were based
on very specific photographs and heart information
of soviet ships putting into portugal and
angola the white paper that the cia produced for
alexander haig to justify the intervention in el
salvador was a piece of trash it was discredited
by the right and the left and the center it didn't
hold together i should point for example to the
the stories that came out during the angola
operation where it was discovered that the cia
was involved in a massive covert operation which
the congress cut off when they learned about it
there were certainly a small handful really a tiny
handful you could count them on the fingers of one
hand of the members of congress who knew about
that operation and the scale of it beforehand and
then they cut it off well one of the revelations
at the time that came out was that the cia had
created a story that was
planted in the media that the
cubans who were in angola at the time were raping
angolan women and that they were really doing very
very gross things to these women and killing them
uh well it was disclosed in fact by john stockwell
among other people who was the former cia station
chief or in charge of the cia's task force in
angola that that whole story was created by the
cia station in in zambia uh and in in in zaire
where they sat around a table and wrote this
story and then it was fed to a a stringer who
then fed it to a new service who then got it
to the ap associated press who then picked it
up and was sent around the world and was
printed in hundreds of newspapers as fact
but you can rest assured that it it is at
least very difficult for the american people
including us to know what is true about the
sandinista government in nicaragua for example
or about el salvador or about argentina and the
falklands right now our former ally of a month ago
is now our enemy in this confrontation in jamaica
for example and then this this very uh specific
uh the libyan hit squad the not the mythical
libyan hit squad we had a situation where reagan
and president reagan and president gadhafi
were confronting each other internationally
reagan ordered our ship into what libya
claims as its waters with the specific
intention of either standing qaddafi down
or provoking an incident and it worked
he shot down two libyan jet fighter planes
and then gaddafi was incensed and there was
a credibility problem there was the president
of the giant united states confronting this
relatively small arab country i guess this leads
us to your covert action information bulletin
because there's a story in here about the hit
squads and it actually originated apparently
with the israeli secret police the mossad
it's a very interesting case study of of how
these propaganda operations can come about
apparently since the israelis working as
they have for many years very closely the the
israeli secret intelligence service or mossad
has worked very very closely with the cia and
in fact the cia helped to set it up back in
the in the mid 50s originally part of the story
came from mossad that there were two people who
apparently were either employed or were agents
contract agents for mossad who fed some of this
information to the us government i see and the
u.s government was fully prepared to believe it
they said that one of their witnesses or one
of their sources had been polygraphed and had
checked out his information had checked out there
was a story suggesting that it was reported by one
of the networks that somebody had been offered a
quarter of a million dollars for his information
to the effect that there were hit squads
and some of it originated as i said from
mossad and some of it originated from cia
fabrications jack anderson for example
reported that some of the information that
he had been given and reported in his column
had turned out to have been cia fabrications
it's important to remember that
the israelis as much i guess as
the u.s considers it a priority to discredit
and to possibly destabilize or overthrow the
libyan government and one method that they saw
thought of i guess was to create a story that said
that libya had sent death squads to assassinate
president reagan and other high officials
go ahead well only recently some of the same high
officials who before were saying that there were
that they had evidence that some of these hit
squads had entered the country through canada
are now on record and quoted in newsweek and other
media saying that they never located a single
person and a single single evidence that there was
a hit squad and yet they say
there is still a threat well
i think it's fair to assume though there is not
enough information yet to say but it's fair to
assume that the cia was hoping through this to
create a justification for further intervention
in libya possible military activity or economic
boycott as or blockade as they've now proposed as
has been proposed by the white house let's take
a look at some of the articles in the latest
issue of the covert action information bulletin
not only will it give you an idea of what the
magazine is about it's sir oh my goodness over
50 pages but also it gives just this one issue
gives a good example of the widespread
operations not only of the cia it's not
just restricted to the cia but mercenary
activities around the world as well
we've been following the sichelle island
attempted coup for ever since it started and
we did a program with john stockwell just recently
where we mentioned that i noticed on page four you
have an article that says shell beat back the
mercenaries this is quite a complex operation
which involves south africa and mercenaries
and the french was the cia involved in that
there's still a lot of information that will come
out but it is known that the some of the activity
i should say primarily the main source of
the coup or attempted coup was south africa
that south african intelligence
including one admitted former
so-called former member of the
south african intelligence corps
who says that he quote unquote retired in order to
go for a visit to the seychelles for his vacation
and largely the the program was initiated by the
by the south africans it does appear however that
the united states which has had an ongoing
interest in creating a base of operations in
the indian ocean and the seychelles is is a
very strategic area not just because of its
it has no large natural resources as such but
that it is a critical importance to to the us
as a jumping point in in the indian ocean it looks
like there are other aspects too that they're also
trying to keep the government of mauritius from
becoming a more progressive government there were
some significant elections coming up plus there
was something i didn't know at all and that was
the fact that there is an island chain commodores
which actually were taken over in a coup
which was carried out by mercenaries yes that in
that case it was largely french intelligence which
was the source of that one there is some
indication that the cia was involved though
somewhat peripherally in that one so i can see
where that could stimulate people like in the
the group down in new orleans of
missionary of missionaries boy
they are in a way aren't they mercenaries
that were going to take over dominica
yes since they apparently the plot fell through
for grenada and they've seen that it can happen
in comoros that they actually can take over an
island government and run it the the case of the
attempted coup in dominica is a very interesting
one and here the u.s involvement is rather rather
strong there was an attempt to build a force
mainly made up of members of the ku klux klan
together with some other former and active
mercenaries who had long involvement in u.s
special forces and army background and they at
first their first idea was to invade grenada
but then they realized that the grenadine
government probably would be able to to offset
their activities and and probably defeat them
and uh since their security forces are quite well
organized there and so they changed their plan
and and decided to go into dominica the former
prime minister patrick john who was very very
closely identified with south africa in fact he
had helped to set up a monitoring station and also
a base for the manufacture of long-range torpedoes
which could be built with the help of south africa
on in which he helped to set up and basically
they had hoped he had hoped that if they if the
coup succeeded and he agreed with the clan people
that uh if it succeeded that he would
give them rights to casinos to gambling
operations to he would even give them several
posts in his cabinet if he came back to power
well of course needless to say it
failed but see was there some dopes
some narcotics business exactly this is as
there often is things this is on page 44 by
the way we're getting a little bit ahead
of you this is also covered in the same
in the same yes this highlights a point
though that we've made several times on this
show how the cia will use anyone to carry
through their objectives the ku klux klan
mercenaries the mafia drug operations it's reasons
like this that john stockwell thinks that the cia
is completely corrupt in immoral operation not
to mention the 800 000 people that have been
killed through cia operations i think 800 000 is
a very very conservative figure but yes that's
that's uh correct uh there is clearly a trend
today in the cia to to move more in the direction
of contracting out some of the operations
that it does not really want to get itself
not that it doesn't want to get involved but
doesn't want to get caught with his pants down
doing it and so some of the more sensitive
activities they're branching out and letting other
either other intelligence services or other quote
unquote private freelance types it looks like
that they are developing a very significant
alliance with the south africans and the
argentinas once again these are both covered in
this edition of the covert action information
bulletin angola the pretoria's continuing war
talks about the south african involvement there
mozambique rebels exposed once again we find south
africa involved in that and the cia in that case
yeah and the cia and then we get to an article
here about argentina activates international
death squads and this article shows that
these god wretched horrible people in
involved in a tremendous amount of torture and
maiming and killing of people in argentina are now
like say their subcontractees and not only that
but the u.s is trying to make a regional type of
kind of a nato it's called saito which is a good
saint over saido say to him but anyway with south
africa taking care of the area in the indian ocean
and africa and argentina taking care of central
america and south america in fact argentina
said they would be glad to come up and help
with the el salvadorian folks right that's correct
argentina if there's a country in the world that
has perfected the art of torture and the art
of making people disappear it is argentina
and thousands upon thousands of
argentinians have have disappeared and
i think that this article demonstrates
and this was an article which
we did a lot of research on and which was the
result of a lot of press reports which came out in
some of them in south africa itself of the fact
that the cia that the argentinians had sent some
of their more renowned and best known torturers
to south africa because they could no longer
be active in argentina they were so well
known so they sent them to south africa as
part of the diplomatic corps in the argentine
embassy they were special in torture yes
go ahead it is unclear at this point whether
they were advising the south africans who also
know a good deal about how to torture people and
how them uh how to make people die in prison as
they have the highest rate of death of people in
in their prisons whether in fact they're training
each other is unclear but certainly they have
a good deal of of sharing and common interests
involved we showed the movie on company business
which you or sections of the movie on company
business which you might remember this movie
showed the complicity of the cia with torture
all around the world as a matter of fact
there are cia torture schools in the united
states they bring people over here from various
countries abroad police military teach them the
very sophisticated ways of torture then they go
back and operate on their own folks back home
and just to make sure that everything goes right
the cia then has their agents which go down and
supervise they hold clinics they bring people off
the streets and torture them i mean it sounds like
something which you couldn't even think up out
of a sick imagination but this is what goes on
and the next article in your bulletin for
march talks about the salvadorian deserter
who disclosed the green beret torture role this
was in the news just recently and it has actually
the transcript and the considerable summary of
what actually went on when it showed the americans
supervising and helping out and they tortured the
first person to show that house be done this is a
14 year old boy and the next person brought in
was a 13 year old girl of course after raping
her then they let the el salvadorians
try it and make sure they did it right
it's a gruesome story and i
think this is an example of
something that the american people are
being asked to overlook or to turn the
blind eye to that is the brutality of the
salvadoran government it is not a case of
salvadoran of president duarte as quote-unquote
a moderate person who's trying to stand up to the
forces both from left and right which the new york
times always says exactly it was in fact the new
york times in a story in january who disclosed
the first part of the story which was that the
green berets eight of them were present during
a torture session and it was a major story uh
strangely it was such a major story but it
was on page two of the new york times rather
than on page one but it was a very big and
important story i would say however that uh
one of the reasons i guessed was that
the the salvadoran the member of the
salvadoran army who talked about this who is
now deserted and who's living in mexico uh
he was somewhat intimidated i guess by
talking to the new york times and he's
later revealed to the to mexican media and that's
the transcript in this store in this article
that the special forces and i should say the u.s
special forces was created originally by the cia
the special forces were actually involved in the
torture as opposed to standing by observing it
they said they didn't rape the little
girl though i mean there is some morality
right louis how does this torture and
all of these cia covert operations
fit into american foreign policy as a whole you
have a couple articles in your current journal
about the role of the cia and these
sorts of operations we're talking about
within american foreign policy
could you focus on that for a minute
well i i guess it comes down to the the whole
doctrine that the united states feels it has to
keep its role in its sphere of
influence or spheres of influence
and part of this is putting governments in
power and part of it is keeping them in power
now there are many governments with whom the
united states has been closely identified around
the country who cannot stay in power without
massive repression and uh of course el salvador
is one there are many others around the world
and all the three continents uh argentina and
south africa for two absolutely obviously uh south
korea is another example uh and the philippines
i think we have to understand though that
what why would the united states do this
is it simply to keep somebody who is a friend of
the united states in power successive presidents
and it's not just reagan and it's not carter
before him it's successful president since
basically since the 50s since eisenhower
have been working hand in glove and even
have been on camera embracing successive
dictators with whom we've been identified
the most recent example if you remember
was the case of of jimmy carter embracing
the shah of iran a few months before he was
overthrown on the steps of the white house
i think it's because of the cia's involvement
and in fact direction of much of these
activities it's not that the cia is working on
its own as some people suggest as a rogue elephant
the cia works directly under the under the
guidance and direction of the chief of state
of the president and of course this president
not only doesn't know but doesn't want to know
every day what the cia is doing but the fact of
the matter is that they that they're doing what
the president asked them to do and the other thing
i should just mention quickly is that the cia
carries out these activities to keep the interests
of the corporations u.s corporations who have
great interests at stake for example in south
africa and in all the other countries we've
mentioned that's right the multinationals value
stability above everything else plus the ability
to operate there keep the economy low as far as
wages and be able to take the riches out of the
country and these right-wing dictatorships let
them do that of course there's a point which is
reached that like in el salvador once it gets too
far and the people really start not a revolution
then the multinationals suffer there and there
is a certain level beyond which the u.s when it
becomes publicly known as opposed to known in the
country itself publicly known in the united states
that the u.s is so closely identified with such a
repressive regime as today in el salvador that it
finally realizes it has to fish or cut bait it
has to decide whether we continue to support this
openly or whether we have to find other ways to
support as for example argentina has now offered
we understand directly to the united states to
be a surrogate for the us in in el salvador also
honduras is playing that role this is what's so
chilling about this agent's identities information
act that it will cover over the possibility of the
media exposing the worst abuses of the cia which
will mean the american people won't know what it's
doing we'll have a secret government and we will
therefore increase the power and the scope
of operations of the cia whereas in the past
when there has been media and public focus on cia
operations and excesses there has been pressure to
cut back on the cia i think however the most
threatening part of this is the is the whole
move towards greater and greater secrecy and so
that the media will not even have the opportunity
to report on this whole area it will be illegal
almost for a journalist for one of the major media
to write or to report about intelligence in
many ways that will just be beyond the pale
now this also ties in with the progress of senate
bill one in the senate or the great grand center
senate bill one which is designed to take away
a lot of our civil liberties we're gradually
becoming a police state really looks like doesn't
it well what can be done about it well i don't
feel it's fair to be rhetorical about this i
agree that there is a move and towards greater
and greater secrecy and greater and greater or
less and less accountability of the government
to the people and there are of course a lot of
people who are opposed to this including quite
a few members of congress for example 29 members
of congress signed a resolution challenging the
right of the president to intervene in el salvador
under the war powers act he has no right to to do
this and they're challenging his right and that's
29 members out of hundreds but it is a significant
i think indication that there
is even in the halls of congress
opposition to his policies as well as in the
country at large i mean the overwhelming majority
are against reagan's policy in el salvador and
i think the uh recent polls have shown that
the foreign policy in general is not entirely
accepted or is there is great doubt and great
wonderment as to whether there's any continuity
whether the policy is thought out whether
it's based on realities or only the uh very
anti-communist rhetoric of this administration
uh there are also quite a few people high in the
administration who have intelligence backgrounds
and this is another indication that the that
the intelligence is on the on the rise in in
this administration lewis is the final question
and to conclude what can the american people do
against these worst excesses of the cia and
indeed against the threats to all of our
civil liberties involved in some of these bills
that are being passed that will unleash the cia
i think the biggest thing is that people can
educate themselves as to what is going on
to read their press and to demand to know
what is going on from from the media to
try and exercise their rights that is to let
their congress their member of congress know
that they don't accept whatever the policy may be
even to demonstrate publicly if they're opposed
to these activities i think most of all is to
be to keep themselves informed and to speak
out against it well thank you very much for and
good luck and watch watch your way home there may
be somebody following you well i i believe it's
best to uh to speak out openly and uh and not
be paranoid i'm just i'm not willing to resign
myself to fear okay thank you and that is the
second of our three-part series on covert action
the cia and now we have a final word from doug
here's some of the antics that the moral
majority has been up to recently the head
of their maryland chapter jim wright recently
went to the amer the maryland state legislature
and complained about some bakery that was selling
gingerbread cookies of little boys and little
girls whose anatomy was displayed in these cookies
and predictably the cookie source sales soared
after the moral majority attack on these cookies
and evidently the legislators are still laughing
in maryland about that not quite as funny is the
head of the moral majority in new york a reverend
dan four was recently caught with his foot in
the mouth in an interview with the new york
times first of all he told the times that the jews
have god given ability to make money they control
the media they control the city when the jewish
reporter who was interviewing him mentioned that
jews had been subject to inquisitions throughout
the centuries and that the anti-semitism the moral
majority was feeding into this he said that
the head of the moral majority said that well
there was never any christian persecution of jews
and the moral the reporter joe klein in the new
york times reminded him of the spanish inquisition
and his persecution of jews here's what the moral
majority said well those weren't christians
they were roman catholics strange distinction
and then last but not least the head of the
santa clara county chapter of the moral majority
opined to reporters that capital punishment
would be in line with bible dictates and
appropriate treatment for homosexuality now it's
true that the moral majority has been criticized
recently in the media and it's also argued that
the kiss of death in a political election is moral
majority support we've seen two elections recently
in austin on housing discrimination for in the
school board when the moral majority got heavily
involved in this and the opponents were able to
mobilize opposition to this moral majority attempt
to legislate its morality and was able to defeat
moral majority initiatives moreover the moral
majority television programs are getting more
and more in debt and i read in broadcasting
that their viewing audience has gone down
about 16 now you would think that the moral
majority would be on the defensive and in a
retreat but in fact jerry falwell is exploiting
these attacks on the moral majority to try to
raise more money every month he sends out a new
fundraising letter saying that they're about to
go bankrupt and that they will be destroyed by
their enemies unless you dig into your pockets
and send the moral majority some more money
so there was a result of this whereas last
year they were only able to raise two million
dollars they've already in the last 12 months
been able to raise 5.7 million dollars and i've
been increasingly successful with these crisis
campaigns to raise money and to play on the
sympathies of their supporters that the moral
majority is a beleaguered oppositional group
that's been attacked by all these liberals and
humanist etc so we're far from having heard
the last of the moral majority unfortunately
this concludes the second in our three-part
series on covert action featuring john stockwell
former cia official and louis wolf co-editor
of covert action information bulletin
alternative views is a production of
the alternative information network
po box 7279 austin texas 78712 if you'd
like to write to us give us some of your
feedback we'd really like to hear from you
please contact us at this address good nine
hey
foreign
oh
part of the campaign by the cia against nicaragua
isn't is through paramilitary units and squads
of somas former soma sista soldiers who are
being trained in honduras and their campaign
is against these mosquito indians and a lot
of hundreds of mosquitoes have been killed
by those squads and cross-border raids now
the circumstances of this killing are pure
terrorism recruiting terrorists to go across
the border and blow up and assassinate and kill
we have to remember that the next
time president reagan or alexander
the hague are making their pious statements
about the threat of international terrorism
and the horrors of international terrorism the
united states is without any serious competition
leading the world in international terrorism
today and for the past 30 years the last in
our three-part series on what the intelligence
services are doing with john stockwell former cia
official and editor of covert action information
bulletin lewis wolfe tonight on alternative views
this is our last program in the series on
what the government and private intelligence
organizations are doing around the world this is
lewis wolfe co-editor of covert action information
bulletin which specializes in revealing what these
organizations are doing our other guest is john
stockwell who was with the cia for many years had
a high position in the organization actually ran
their angolan operation and quit wrote the book
in search of enemies subsequently a new novel
red sunset tonight we'll discuss particularly the
cia in latin america and the total ramification
on how this fits in to the united states
foreign policy and the ramifications overseas
now let's have some news everybody knows there's
unemployment but the cost to the american people
to individuals as well as the economy and
the social fabric of the nation is staggering
for instance each one percent increment of
unemployment diminishes the gross national product
by about 68 billion these are 1980 estimates a lot
of studies now are being made by sociologists and
economists so the impact of of unemployment
and this is just one of the statistics
the direct cost to the federal government in
lost tax revenue and increased expenditures
for each 1 percent rise in
unemployment is over 25 billion
and of course when the deficit goes up so the
interest rates and that puts an additional
burden on the economy but these statistics on
unemployment actually underestimate the problem
because you have to add to the unemployment
which we have right now to almost 10 percent
the 5.8 million involuntary part-time workers
or they're at a record high to 1.2 million
and also add the record number of discouraged
workers 10.8 million so you actually get a
grand total of unemployed or partly employed 17.8
million or 16.2 percent now if you also compare
this with a great depression and to count in the
factor of the millions of people who are in the
armed forces are working for the government in
relationship to defense take them out of it and
put them on unemployed roles like they were back
in 1929 we actually would have an unemployment
great a rate much more severe than of the great
depression it even gets worse when you talk about
individuals they've found now that each percentage
point of increase of unemployment sustained over
five years provides a 4.1 increase in suicides
4.3 percent increase among men 2.3 among women
in first-time admissions to state mental hospitals
1.9 percent increase in deaths from disease
an increase of 4 in prison admissions 5.7
increase in homicides and of course kids who
don't get jobs during the summer are more likely
to turn to crime to make ends meet so everything
isn't just the cold heart well today friends the
unemployment rate rose up almost to 10 percent
people are hurting some people are not though
some people are not in fact while a lot of people
are hurting for the unemployment and the poor
are getting poorer under reaganomics the rich
are getting richer forbes magazine advertises
itself on television as a capitalist tool that
will help young executives get the skills and the
information they need to help them in their climb
up the corporate ladder and every year they they
publish the salaries of the highest 20 corporate
executives and the winner this year folks was
the president of warner's communication who
came in for a cool 27 and a half million dollars
a year they also listed the next person who was
7.5 million a year also a corporate executive of
a communications empire and then listed the next
20 corporate executives all of whom made over
a million dollars a year missing for the first
time from the top 20 were corporation executives
from the automobile the steel or the manufacturing
industries which evidently aren't doing so well
under today's economy in fact craig you have some
information that small business like the poor
and the unemployed are suffering the age of
reaganomics right and not so small necessarily i
like to call this little bit of commentary still
we got fun yes folks it's time once again to ask
how's business not so good to put it in a nutshell
but if you've been following the annex of the
reagan team you know it's not their fault when
inflation dips below the double-digit level
it's because reaganomics is taking hold but
when leading economic indicators continue to
shrivel and die on the vine then of course
it's the business blight brought on by that
old peanut farmer jimmy carter lingering on
you might say that politicians in general can
display an amazing flexibility in some matters
particularly when relating to interim elections
well the lingering effects of peanut policy this
time has led to a virtual epidemic of bankruptcies
the wall street journal reports a post-depression
high in the percentage of failing firms
for the first three months of this year an
average of 36 businesses per hour have gone
belly up an increase from last year of 29
at that pace nearly 75 000 companies will
go bankrupt this year a new american record
now these aren't just your family-run
shoestring organizations either
braniff airlines for one went down in flames
recently and indications are that international
harvester may soon join the scrap heap with
revenues last year of over seven billion dollars
international harvester would be the largest u.s
company ever to file bankruptcy at least for the
time being that is edward altman the chairman
of the mba program at new york university
estimates that 200 of the biggest 2 000 industrial
concerns now teeter on the brink of collapse
well inevitably the big losers when a company
folds are the workers four out of five bankruptcy
filings are for straight liquidation as in that's
all she wrote in the trucking industry for example
144 companies have gone under since
mid-1980 at the cost of over 28 000 jobs
but that's not the worst of it consider the
plight of hundreds of west virginia coal miners
who were stuck with unpaid medical bills
when their employers went bankrupt without
having paid the insurance premiums what a nice
surprise the big winners in bankruptcy naturally
are lawyers accountants and bankers that's when
the loots all divvied up particularly since the
1979 revision of the bankruptcy code eliminated
the requirement that quote a spirit of economy
prevail when bankruptcy lawyers set their fees as
might be expected the hogs are hunkering down to
the old trough in miami for instance a lawyer in
a bankruptcy proceeding for the gac corporation
sought court approval for a fee you're going to
love this for 210 dollars an hour for 7 000 hours
of work or a cool 1.5 million dollars for a half a
year's job the judge settled the paltry 650 000 on
them you know friends maybe we're all in the wrong
line of work and with all this talk of bankruptcy
and depression i thought i was making the shrewd
move socking my money into apples and pencils
well i have a story here on the tragedy of
dolphins around the world particularly in
japan this was provided by the greenpeace people
well in the spring of 1980 japanese fishermen
began slaughtering dolphins off of
iki island they thought then that the
dolphins were stealing their catch refusing
to acknowledge the fact that overfishing and
heavy coastal pollution by man really
bore much of the blame the real blame
dolphins just by the hundreds lie dead along the
beaches of iki island and by japan is waiting to
be processed into fertilizer the japanese
fishermen plan to continue this slaughter
and they will unless worldwide pressure is put on
them and this is the what the greenpeace people
are trying to do worldwide thousands of dolphins
are being killed every year by americans japanese
turks peruvians man's war against the dolphins
doesn't have any boundaries at all the united
states alone the government allows the killing
of 31 000 dolphins a year by american tuna boats
so how do these wonderful amazing
fun-loving gentle animals end
ground into fertilizer the consequence of man's
unthinking and unfeeling relation to
the earth and his fellow creatures
let's focus on one of the current and most
spectacular revelations that the cia has made in
recent years and that is their expose of nicaragua
that was just yesterday the day before we're
taping this where a department of fence personnel
and a cia director bobby inman i think it was
claimed to have photographs that showed that
nicaragua was greatly increasing their military
forces that it was on the same model as cuba's
that this was all being funded by the soviet union
that nicaragua was systematically carrying
out genocidal operations against indian tribes
living in nicaragua where they had pictures
of villages that had been destroyed what would
your attitude towards this be i think the first
time that i can remember since the bay of pigs
that a single uh there may have been one other
case but it's almost the only case since then
that the cia or u.s intelligence has disclosed
satellite data with from which they say this came
now satellite data by its very nature and
depending on how far they enlarge it can be made
to prove anything these pictures i'm not saying
i do not know i have not seen the pictures but
we are asked to believe that these picture
pictures were taken within the last several months
in nicaragua or over nicaragua by u.s
satellites we are further asked to believe that
the the activity which is portrayed in
these pictures is taking place as of now
recently secretary hague said and he held it up
as as the smoking gun in a press conference that
his information was that the nicaraguan government
was engaged in massive repression against the
mosquito indians right that was the big point they
made again yesterday with these pictures of burned
out villages well one of those the picture to
which secretary haig referred to in his press
conference ten days ago was a picture which was
published in the figaro magazine in in paris and
it later turned out that that picture had been
published with a caption saying that this was
the nicaragua the present nicaraguan government
showing them burning houses and burning people
alive i believe uh it turned out that that
picture and la figaro has admitted it since then
was a picture that was taken during the samosa
rule and that those pictures were five four five
years old and of course mr hague has had to
or general hague has had to pull back on that
one but they are now still saying that there's
massive repression against the mosquito indians
i would simply point out that it's a dichotomy
and a contradiction for this government to
give a great deal of attention to the human
rights of mosquitoes if in fact these abuses
are taking place when in fact native americans are
not accorded the same attention by our government
nor are the el salvadorian people
who are systematically being
killed by these death squads and the guatemalan
indians are being almost annihilated it's
almost a genocidal campaign by the guatemalan
government against the indians in guatemala
i do hope that some of this well first of all
there is a a lot of evidence coming out that the
part of the campaign by the cia against nicaragua
isn't is through paramilitary units and squads
of somas former soma sista soldiers who are being
trained in honduras and their campaign is against
these mosquito indians and a lot of hundreds of
mosquitoes have been killed by those squads and
cross-border raids one of the reasons why that the
nicaraguan government has been forced i believe
by these campaigns to to move a lot of these
people away from the areas where they're in
danger is because of those activities not because
of a policy of the nicaraguan government it's as
a result what would their reason to have
genocide against these tribes the current
government nicaragua the state department
hasn't given any hypotheses about why they
would be engaging in this i can't see any motive
for it yeah it seems strange well they pretend and
would have us believe that the nicaraguan
government is is a totalitarian one-party
top-down dictatorial rule and that they have
no wish to integrate the mosquito indians into
into their into a society into their
society and that furthermore they
have us believe that the mosquitoes want
to secede or want to have an independent
country or state or at least an area
which they can call a separate country
i don't think there's any evidence to show
that that's what the mosquito indians wish john
since the time we did that interview with lewis
wolf there's been quite a few revelations about
cia covert operations in nicaragua can you comment
on those i think there was some stories in these
times about some of the things that the cia
was up to there i can comment in a speculative
way since i i don't you know i'm analyzing the
news now based on my past experience of course
but uh let's see what's the inflation rate
since uh 1975 to 1982 in america yeah what
would that amount to five years it's been about
10 a year almost even more the point is that the
ci's budget it's been announced that the the cia
the president signed an order on the first of
december ordering the ci into full paramilitary
covert action against nicaragua from honduras
organizing mercenaries to destabilize the
countryside to counter the cuban aggression
in that country is what what they announced was
the justification and the budget they were given
was 19 million i compare that with the 14 million
that i was given in 1975. and i'm then for the
angolan operation the parallels are quite striking
you know there were parallels with the angular
operation in the bay of pigs uh for example
and other covert actions but then guatemala
was different and iran was different so you know
each one each situation is different but here
we have so it's so close they're working from
honduras we were working from zaire in kinshasa
they're working with ex samosas we were working
with the portuguese exiles the portuguese who
had fled for example creating an army out of
these people also they have quote mercenaries
but actually soldiers who were sent from argentina
for example and venezuela and chile and colombia
to to join this force we had people
coming from various places from france
for example and of course the south
african force they're functioning
i could i could map out the
the office for you the program
the international program some things that i
would observe if you've read my book is that
such an operation is global the commander would
not be sitting in honduras running the thing
the commander of the nicaraguan task force
will be in washington he will be sending agents
all around the world coordinating different
aspects of this thing they'll be sending cables
to every station in the world advising the chief
of station what his activities should be these
are the local police and the local president the
local press to create an atmosphere supporting to
the greatest extent possible what they're doing
seeking arms that aren't attributable seeking
sources of news comments and releases that can
be put together in white papers to to persuade
and then the bottom line that the justification
reagan has given and the ci have given for
doing this intervention is to counter the cuban
activities in nicaragua but see the point is that
they're not going to be any cubans die in this
thing there i believe there it said that there are
2 000 cubans in nicaragua now they're functioning
to help build an airport and no doubt military
advising although i've i've not seen that
confirmed anywhere a lot of doctors medical
personnel doctors and medical personnel and
teachers and whatnot and from italy and several
other countries as well it's not just cubans oh
indeed nicaragua but a variety of countries the
nicaraguan arms it's been shown are not coming
from the soviet union they're buying them from
france and italy and all kinds of other places or
are they coming from from uh from cuba this has
been proven but but the point is that this program
of the ci is not going to be killing cubans
it's going to be killing nicaraguans it's
not going to be killing nicaraguan officials
not that many nicaraguan soldiers it's going to be
destabilizing the countryside blowing up bridges
ambushing bush buses if they follow the pattern
that they have in other places there'll be
some schools bombed and marketplaces bombed to
destabilize the economy so it can't function so
the network and fabric of society will break down
they kill village leaders i've read about that the
phoenix program being duplicated killing village
leaders hauling people out and executing them to
terrorize them from from cooperating with the
government and their families and their families
in fact the last three weeks in these times
has had some very good articles on nicaragua
that indicates that from honduras some hit squads
were sent into nicaragua that have killed at least
30 leaders and just innocent people in that region
and have terrorized peasants and people living
in nicaragua near the honduras border because of
these hit raids although on the other hand they've
led these people to organize and become even
more firm and resolute in their will to protect
their country so sometimes these destabilization
programs backfire and end up stabilizing the
country unifying it certainly did in the bay of
pigs the ci invasion there unified cuba under a
fidel castro he came out of that thing 10 times
100 times stronger than he was going into it
and uh and that probably will be in effect
in nicaragua these nicaraguans dying will
be added to the 800 000 i mentioned
earlier the the victims people who died
as a direct as direct victims of ci covert
actions in the last 30 years the minimum figure
given by all responsible parties in
press and government studies and what not
hundred thousand the figures range from eight
hundred thousand to a couple of million victims
of ci operations indirect type of indirect now
that does not include for example the people who
died in the vietnam war which was a direct result
of a cia covert action more than what million and
a half in indonesia the million and a half in
indonesia now that's that's a lot of dead people
now the circumstances of this killing are pure
terrorism recruiting terrorists to go across the
border and blow up and assassinate and kill we
have to remember that the next time president
reagan or alexander the hague are making
their pious statements about the threat of
international terrorism and the horrors of
international terrorism the united states
is without any serious competition leading the
world in international terrorism today and for
the past 30 years john isn't there something
unique about this nicaraguan situation is that
the administration is openly admitting that they
are carrying it on that's truly a difference
and this gets back to the rogue elephant is the
ci a rogue elephant or is it has it all these
years been doing what the president wants and of
course the truth is both in some cases it's done
what it wanted contrary to presidential orders in
other cases it's done what the president probably
wanted but didn't say in this case because of the
nature of the secretary of state and the president
the the cia is clearly doing exactly what the
president wanted now the president didn't hold
a press conference to say i'm sending
in the cia to kill people in nicaragua
but it has been admitted by
the white house that they did
it's been leaked and the president smiled at the
leaks that he did order the ci into this action
so he's clearly you know he's he sees himself as
a you know marshall reagan uh uh sort of you know
showing off how he can shoot you know let those
people know he's got got something he can do louis
while we're on central america we might also note
that your group has published a book called white
paper white wash in which you analyze the infamous
white paper that was published by the american
government to justify american intervention in
el salvador can you just briefly indicate some of
the obvious whitewash in the white paper and
some of the things published in your book and
then maybe we can tell our audience where they can
get this the white paper was published in 1979 by
by well i should say i'm sorry there were
prior indications of of propaganda about
u.s intervention in el salvador but the the
original white paper that we're talking about
here came out in 1981 february february 1981 and
it was uh said to have been captured the series of
documents that were captured by the salvadoran
armed forces now we should remember first of
all that there were three accounts offered as to
how the information was captured one said it was
found by a state department intelligence man who
went to to el salvador and saw it on a table in
the headquarters of the salvadoran armed forces
a second account said that it was found in what
was called a safe house of the guerrillas in san
salvador and the third and most unlikely account
was that it was uh captured from a gorilla who
was found walking through the streets of el
salvador with a whole packet of documents under
his arm each of those accounts were offered as
the source of of these documents we have
analyzed the documents that's in in this book
co-edited by uh warner paltrow edited by warner
protell with interviews with philip agee and
it's very interesting to analyze as has been
done in the book line by line word by word the
the so-called white paper there are parts of
the paper for example that refer to in english
uh sections of the so-called spanish original
spanish language documents that don't exist
uh there are creative translation exactly there
are there's one document for example that's partly
in spanish in handwritten spanish and then on
the same document it's typewritten in english
so we're asked to believe that whomever
was sitting down at the table writing these
shopping lists for arms from cuba from
vietnam from ethiopia where and libya
was going to move from a pen in spanish
to a typewriter and type in english
and very i might say very literal very literary
english there are a lot of contradictions in the
white paper basically we should understand this
because it was and is the the first and and the
most important justification that has been
used by the government for its intervention
in el salvador of course now they pretend that
because the white paper was so widely discredited
even by one of its authors who gave an interview
to the wall street journal and disclosed that he
even had a lot of questions about it so i think
there's a lot of reason that this document or this
exercise in propaganda is a classic in cia
propaganda if the audience wants to order
this book how can they get it well i can write
to the publisher which is deep cover publications
should i give the address in post office box
677 new york new york 10013 and it's uh well 650
plus a dollar fifty handling and can people also
get the mailing list for your other publications
you've published a book called dirty work
the cia in western europe and another one
called dirty work the cia in africa as well
as putting out this covert action information
bulletin will you give information on how they can
order that uh those other things they can write
to us to covert action information bullets in in
washington i'll give the address post office box
50272-50272 washington dc 2 000 4 and
we'll be happy to send you the information
i find this very sad by the
way i find i it troubles me
not obviously because i was once part of all this
but also just as an american citizen to realize
that this country is indulging in activities
that are just as cruel and just as as depraved
in some cases and almost as extensive as what for
example the the gestapo indulged in in germany
we haven't liquidated uh five million jews but
eight hundred thousand minimum figure people
killed in terrorist circumstances in the
third world is a lot of people dead and
the responsibility ultimately yes you know it's
done by the cia and it's a secret organization
and therefore we have plausible denial to our
own consciences because there's nothing we can
do about it we don't know about it they didn't
consult us but the other side of that coin is that
the ci is the united states police organ and what
it does we the american people are responsible
for so that in addition to the personal losses
of freedom of speech and freedom of the press
we are responsible for the genocide of terrorism
that's taking place against the world today
in our name and with our tax dollars and with the
changes of the laws and executive orders the whole
apparatus of the intelligence services including
the fbi and their right-wing hit squad buddies
like the nazis and the klan are now being
able to be turned on the american people
earned on the american impunity remember that
lou wolf mentioning the executive order which
we've all followed with great interest that too
is president reagan going public bragging about
what he's doing with the cia but don't forget
that the ci has always functioned extensively
inside the united states mhks you know a billion
dollar program was all domestic and experiment mk
ultra experimentation on american citizens with
drugs and lsd and whatnot that went on for 20
years and that was inside the united states
on american guinea pigs the opening of mail
for 20 years was american citizens mail they've
always done this thing the operation mongoose
war against cuba was run from from florida and
they had over a thousand safe houses and boat
docks and whatnot that they were operating from
the united states the training facilities for
uh torture for interrogation techniques were in
san antonio texas at one time a few years back
and you know that's something that's easy to move
somewhere else i don't know where it is today
john recently one of the individuals in
the cia that was in charge of these covert
operations has recently resigned and that
is admiral bobby inman who was allegedly
second in command at the cia it's been widely
reported that inman himself believed that
william casey who is the director of the cia was
overly fond of quote adventurous but ill-advised
cia operations aboard abroad and senator
joseph biden of delaware has recently noted
without inman the intelligent agencies may be
given license to try all kinds of questionable
things here and abroad in the light of what
they've been doing even under inman already
what would your comments on the inman resignation
in the future of the cia well i would have to
regret the fact that he left not that he was a
paragon of liberal virtue but he seemed to be
when compared with william casey and and some of
the others jesse helms over on the senate side
carlucci his predecessor he seemed to have some
pretty strong instincts for protecting american
institutions he protested the names of agents
bill at one time or at least one version of it
as being unessential to american national security
and of course he got a lot of criticism for that
it would seem that he was in in effect a
moderating influence on some of the crueler
instincts of men like casey who of course
is a a very inept and corrupt individual
the corruption being that he's maintained his own
business portfolio he's a millionaire while he's
ci director he's running the cia he's running his
own businesses and of course from the cia he can
have some influence on world economic matters he
has also been appearing at republican fundraisers
and of course that's one of the biggest no no's
in uh in in the united states governmental system
to have the head of a police organization with
the influence of the cia to openly advocate one
political party's position and help it raise
money in that kind of a corrupt adventuresome
atmosphere one would have to regret inman's
resignation the whole milieu the environment
is favorable to reagan and the cia and what they
want to accomplish what they are accomplishing
if you go one step further and consider
uh reagan's policies his first year in
office he's muted this a little bit faced
with a clear indication by the american
people populous about war he and and
attila the hague were speaking constantly
about the viability of nuclear war war was an
effective tool we shouldn't be afraid of war
going to war in el salvador discussing
sending troops into nicaragua
talking frequently about going to the source quote
in cuba and talking about you know demonstration
wars or limited wars nuclear wars in europe and
what not these people gave every indication that
they were looking for war now they have toned
this down a little bit in the last two months
first you saw the turn we all saw the turn
everybody reads the newspapers when the
polls responded 89 percent of the american
people said they were did not favor american
military intervention in nicaragua and this was a
pretty clear indication to the the president that
the american people were not going to support
him he would not be a successful president
if he got us into a war it would be something that
he would have trouble selling trouble maintaining
at the same time there was a move in congress
that if the government of el salvador didn't
modify its human rights positions they wouldn't
get more money for aid and then the second thing
of course has been this massive groundswell
reaction to his attitudes towards the bomb and
that's national every corner of the
nation little bitty towns across the
nation organizing effectively and having big
demonstrations as well as the big the big cities
the nation and the world so deeply concerned
about the threat of nuclear war and just
absolutely horrified that you could possibly have
a president in office whose mental capacities were
so limited that he would actually talk publicly
of demonstration atom bombs in europe popping off
a bomb to show our will and resolve limiting
nuclear war to europe and the possibility of
surviving nuclear war in the united states this
has horrified people to the point where he's
got a big political problem on his hand from
the famous ground zero and the freeze and the
result is that it's it's forcing a change in their
stated policies and attitudes they're toning down
quite a bit from what they were saying a year ago
at this time for example responding to the mood of
the nation and some frustration i think clearly
well thank you john that's fine we've exhausted
you again but we appreciate it now news stories
from three different years first may of 1982
we started our three-part investigation of cia
covert action with a program with john stockwell
and lewis wolff that talked about the intelligence
identities protection act and they did a criticism
of it of how it would subvert american civil
liberties freedom of speech and our democracy
well since then we found out in an article in the
progressive that uncle walter walter cronkite has
joined john stockwell and others in criticizing
the intelligence identities protection act the
progressive reports that walder was talking
in dallas to the national associations of
broadcasters convention and he attacked the reagan
administration's pattern of restriction on press
freedom he deplored administration support
for supreme court rulings that permit police
to raid newsrooms in search of sources and the
compelled journalists to disclose sources in court
he also lamented the administration decision
to limit the freedom of information act
and the reagan policy of no longer declassifying
government documents automatically after 30 years
walter scorned a plan to protect business
information that would keep investigative
stories and commentary on topics ranging
from pollution threats to dangerous drugs
at a serious disadvantage and he called the
free press's democracy the only fail-safe system
against both the dangers of its own excesses and
the approach of tyranny while i'm citing story
from the progressive i might also note that in the
page after the story on walter cronkite there's a
story dateline austin texas with a headline and
that's the way it really is the article begins
the ever shriveling scope the triumph of technique
over content and the cheerful rush to incipity
among anchors on network news are familiar
aspects of television news from the happy
talk and video gimmicks of local newscasts
to the corporate paranoia of the networks
television's current events reporting has
become almost dysfunctional viewers know this
hence the deep-seated distrust of the broadcast
media but the oligarchic nature of the television
industry has blocked alternatives up until now
leaving most americans reliant on the lighted box
as their primary source of information at last the
stranglehold may be broken the article reads and
by whom and by where we cried for the past three
years we learned a weekly news documentary program
alternative use produced in austin and broadcast
over the public access channel provided by the
local cable franchise has been doing what others
do not it has been presenting very unslick intense
hour-long documentaries and interviews with the
likes of clark russell means stokely carmichael
madeline murray o'hare john henry faulk george
wald john henry falk helen caldecott william
kunsler daniel ellsberg and john stockwell and
then the article goes on to describe our program
the format and what we're trying to accomplish so
we thank the progressive for publishing this and
we'll pat ourselves in the back well i mean i'm
slick hey i thought we were pretty slick trust us
well i'm i would assume by now that you've
heard about that famous remark by thomas k
jones deputy under secretary
of defense for nuclear theater
uh forces or strategic theater nuclear forces
that's part of our own slickness there he says
hey don't worry about nuclear war everybody's
going to make it if you got enough dirt
if there are enough shovels to go around you
need those two things dig a hole covered up
with a couple of doors throw three feet of dirt on
top and you're safe from a nuclear holocaust folks
well even to top that in that
was just plain stupid but in
insensibility the department of energy study
recommended that after a nuclear attack
people over 40 years of age should be the first
to leave their bomb shelters hail with that
these post-tac pioneers would search for food and
clean up a bit you know for the younger survivors
because they say older people have
a shorter life expectancy anyway
and uh the study reasoned that near
lethal doses of radiation would make
much difference anyway by the time they caught
anything they'd already be dead and also they
wouldn't pass on any radiation-induced genetic
defects to future general well i don't know
anyway they asked grey panther president maggie [
__ ] what she thought about that she told them i'm
right behind you frank yeah 39. but something is
being done about it the city council in cambridge
massachusetts determined that they instead of
having a cooperation day for evacuation with the
civil defense folks they would have a preventive
evacuation day by urging their citizens to join
the mass rally for disarmament in new york city
on june the 12th a lot of people are going to that
do y'all like fairy tales well there's a dandy
one every week in sunday's parade magazine
if you're into real fantasy i'm talking of course
about your basic free enterprise message from
the ever loving people of mobile oil part of
their multi-million dollar a year pr package
i'm sure you've all seen this it's called
observations and they've always got this
little cartoon in here that's never
funny in case you've all noticed before
well this whole thing is designed
to show america once and for all
who are the good guys and who are the bad
a biggest beautiful campaign you might say
we're seeing a lot of this kind of thing on tv
now too the white water canoeist experiencing
the thrill of victory while simultaneously
clearing the good name of getty oil
those cute little oil wells to swarm with 59
different endangered species of birds and bugs the
industrious cartoon pie maker who has the world
beating a path to his door to bid on his pies
they all strained to make that one meaningful
statement hell we just plain old folk like you
well is anybody listening personally i'm
underwhelmed at their sincerity and a tad
put off by the political motif of stuff like
this you think reagan's a supply cider this
column makes them sound like karl marx or freddy
ingles this particular one was exemplary it made a
monumental leap of reasoning across two centuries
to assert that george washington's troops almost
starved to death at valley forge because of
price controls we'll all be i didn't know that
after a quick razzle dazzle with oil
production figures and constant 1980 dollars
the text then leads you to the inescapable
conclusion that it would be silly to put price
controls on natural gas i mean we wouldn't
want the troops to starve all those poor old
oil barons down gutting it out in the trenches
with the dirt the vermin the spilled perrier
i may just be paranoid but whenever corporations
start billing their programs and ideas as a boon
to all mankind i think it's time to hide the
silverware and i still can't help but feel a
little bit guilty when we fund the torture
of peasants so that united fruit can bring
the world to us packed in a light syrup from
may of 1982 we now switch to may of 1983.
according to the wall street journal mr reagan's
energy department has been busily doling out more
of that welfare for the rich rich oil companies
in this case the general accounting office which
is a congressional watchdog agency says that
the department is making settlements with oil
moguls that are unduly favorable to the industry
so what's new the gao charges that the reagan team
is letting some of the major oil companies off the
hook to the tune of tens of millions of dollars
shell oil u.s steel's marathon oil mobile
oil company and several others were nailed
for overcharging customers prior to the decontrol
of oil in 1981. you may have seen the 60 minutes
segment that dealt with how new oil miraculously
became old oil with its higher price tag and
all that rot well now comes payback time and
suddenly the reagan gang is getting generous
again with our money the administration's top
official in the department rayburn hanslick
says the new settlements are based on quote more
accurate and more realistic cost figures than they
ever had before i guess somebody boogered up a
neater set of books for the department this time
shell oil for one will save a pretty penny because
of this company officials had originally bargained
with the carter administration to settle an
alleged 151 million dollars in overcharges
the carter people said annie up 75 million will
call it square well now mr reagan's department
says that 50 million is quite enough thank
you marathon oil overcharged customers some
41 million dollars according to government
investigators mr hanslick and the boys in the
back room will settle for 11 million the topper
is a deal they cut with mobile overall mobile may
have ripped off buyers for more than 900 million
dollars 900 million dollars in various cost
violations our benevolent energy department says
29 million will cover it or cover it up might be
a better way to put it because of the hubbubs
surrounding these sweet deals the department
has delayed signing some of the agreements and
others pending with gulf oil and city service
which was just recently swallowed up by accidental
petroleum the wall street noted also that the
reagan team has not shown any great enthusiasm
at all for pursuing this type of enforcement
in fact the administration budget for 1984
proposed cutting their allotment from 21
million down to 7 million they don't want them
nosing around too much but why would they want to
bite the hand that feeds them for my own part i'm
not particularly surprised by this whole affair
once a week it seems the business press carries
something or other like this it's blatant stuff
and it's pretty old hat what really amazes me is
that so much energy is devoted to railing against
piss ant things such as unreported busboy and
waitress tips social security overpayments
where gramps has gotten a part-time job selling
candles and food stamp abuse these damn people are
eating and all the while it's business as usual
in the county house you know i've just about
decided to become a finance baron so i can live
outside of the law too say craig i found an old
statistic which used about a few years ago but it
bears on what you were saying a while ago when the
price of gasoline at the pump is raised one penny
around the country do you know how
much wealth goes from us to them
yeah that is got to be astounding more than five
dollars it's 2.9 million dollars a day a day a
day in pennies so you can imagine how much is
going back to the oil companies after the oil
brought the price down and then they government
uh put on that what five cents again five cents
but they raised it much higher about 17 anywhere
between 10 and 17 cents they raise it above that
so you can figure out that additional above
the tax and figure out from 2.9 million a day
take that over a year i'm no good
at math but that's a lot of money
in may of 1983 the congress went along with
reagan's crazed plan to produce the mx missile
and it looks like money is being freed to continue
the mx missile program even though it appeared
that it was going to be defeated however there's
an article in these times that indicate that it's
going to be a little bit difficult to base these
mx missiles anywhere in the country because of the
public opposition to the missile the grass roots
opposition that's arising when carter was talking
about his race track concept to have the mx
missiles on this race track that would be put
in nevada or utah the citizens of that state
organized and put tremendous pressure on the
governor the state legislature to try to make
it not be the case that these missiles be put in
in nevada and utah so that suddenly this
program was abandoned by the federal government
then they started talking about montana
and wyoming as a good place to put
the dense pack mx missiles well there was a lot
of opposition that has already arisen in montana
the governor came out against it and eight of
the nine congressional representatives as well
as grassroots groups throughout montana however
wyoming the governor and some of the congress
people there seems to be a little friendlier
to the mx and they have invited the air force
to come and check out the state and said they
would cooperate with them as an mx missile site
however a grassroots opposition group in wyoming
is now starting to form called western solidarity
some of the same people that organized opposition
to the mx and these other states are going to
wyoming to help them organize they're planning a
big rally in cheyenne wyoming and more and more
groups and individuals are becoming aware of
the dangers to their ecology and of course to
their very survival if there was ever a nuclear
war so grassroots opposition to the mx missile
program is growing significantly in wyoming itself
therefore if the reagan administration attempts to
try to base these mx missiles anywhere in the
southwest to the northwest they're going to get
grassroots opposition from a new group called
western solidarity that's organized throughout
this region consisting of ranchers of church
groups of environmentalists of public citizens all
of whom are opposed to the mx missile including
now a group in wyoming we've had stories from 1982
and 83 and now may 1985. probably ronald reagan's
greatest political and public relations blunder
was his visit to bitburg germany to the cemetery
where ss troopers were buried along with other
german and american soldiers you also might wonder
why reagan originally didn't agree to go to a
concentration camp and to a commemoration service
for the dead jews who were killed in the holocaust
well the new york times reported that nancy reagan
put a zap on that that she thought that holocaust
and concentration camps were sort of a downer and
too depressing and she thought that reagan should
project a more positive happy cheerful image so
she vetoed a trip to a concentration camp however
there was such an outcry when it was revealed that
there were all these ss stormtroopers buried at
bitburg that reagan did finally agree to go to a
concentration camp well the village voice the week
before reagan's visit to germany had an article
about anti-semitism in the reagan administration
and some very dubious attitudes of some of his
officials in an article called bitburg tip of
the iceberg reagan's communications director is
pat buchanan who you may have seen on the cable
news network on the firing line show and buchanan
i think was also a spiro agnew speechwriter and
very active in the nixon administration craig
you've read about buchanan's attitude towards
anti-semitism and the jews that's right there is
an office in the congress had a hand in setting up
under the aegis of the justice departments
called the office of special investigations
and which supposedly was set up to prosecute
and deport alleged nazi war criminal
criminals and collaborators who fraudulently
entered the united states well mr mc buchanan
since he became involved with it it has not been
uh too gung-ho about uh prosecuting these people
in fact he said in in a speech he said he saw
nothing singular about the holocaust he said and
it quote just seems to me that allocating funds
into running down aggressively these people is
just not a proper use of resources like you say he
was involved with the the nixon campaign he was a
speechwriter for mr nixon and uh if you recall
if you read the the watergate tapes the book
that was made from the tapes there were several
anti-semitic slurs on the tape from mr buchanan
and it said that mr buchanan was the one important
white house staffer who convinced mr reagan to go
ahead and visit bitburg the reagan administration
in fact ronald reagan himself this time is also
in trouble for writing a friendly letter to one
of the most notorious anti-semitics in the whole
united states a doctor roger pearson who's the
president of a council for social and economic
studies reagan wrote him a letter congratulating
him on his journal and saying that you are
performing a valuable service and bringing to a
wide audience the work of leading scholars who
are supportive of a free enterprise economy of
firm and consistent foreign policy and a strong
national defense however mr pearson has also been
active in anti-semitic circles for many decades
in britain in 1956 he started publishing a racist
journal called northern world whose purpose was
to make whites aware of their forgotten racial
heritage and to cut through the judaic fog of
lies about our origin and the accomplishment of
our race and western culture in 1958 mr pearson
founded a northern league in britain whose
purpose was to bring together the strands
of post-war neo-nazism and whose members included
racial theorists were active in the nazi regime in
germany then he came to the united states in 1964
and began publishing a journal called western dent
destiny who had on its editorial board what the
village voice described as a rogues gallery of
racist and anti-semites clan leaders holocaust
debunkers former waffen ss officers british
and american neo-nazis and fascists members
of the white citizens council etc they then
started publishing a journal called mankind
quarterly that specialized in racist articles
including one that reported on a 1962 trip
to south africa that was sponsored by the
apartheid government to study quote bantu racial
characteristics that was illustrated by a photo of
a zulu man in profile intended to illustrate his
jewish nose since then mr pearson has published
a whole stream of racist and anti-semitic
books eugenics and race blood groups and race
he received 36 thousand dollars from the pioneer
fund that was dedicated to scientific racism and
run by political associates of senator jesse
helms and more recently has been involved with
the liberty lobby anti-semitic and racist in
publishing several anti-semitic things so this
is a gentleman that ronald reagan sent a personal
letter to congratulating him on the valuable
service that his public publishing enterprises are
carrying forth and even after the criticism was
leveled against mr pearson for being one of the
most grotesque racists in his country the reagan
administration refused to retract the praise in
this letter and refused to criticize mr pearson
publicly showing an incredible moral blindness on
the part of the reagan administration towards the
issue of anti-semitism it's nothing new though and
that's alternative views for this evening we hope
you enjoyed our three-part series on covert action
around the world if you have any comments to make
here's our address alternative information
network po box 7279 austin texas 78712
good night
alternative views program was recorded in june of
1983 the people now have the truth enough of it
over the 35-year history that they know about
washington's compulsive lying the politics of
lying the schizophrenia president after president
goes up there and says the lies and cover stories
for the ci for example the people know of the
government after government that washington
has overthrown constitutional democracies
democratically elected presidents that we
overthrew with violence and installed dictators to
replace them this is what the american people know
about increasingly today and that's why reagan's
policies in nicaragua are running into such
such gap he is running policies in nicaragua to
support sweetheart deals with his cronies in the
multinational world in california in the financial
world and that is the only reason they're doing
we've done this in angola vietnam we've done
it over 20 000 times in the last 35 years
the church committee report showed us that
over a hundred several hundred corporate
actions per year for 35 years that's
got to be 15 to 20 000 covert operations
the toll of dead now first line victims has got
to be over a million people killed former high
cia official john stockwell has recently returned
from trips to nicaragua and grenada he tells us
about that and compares it to the operation
he ran in angola tonight on alternative view
hey
although the world has changed since 1983 when
this program was recorded the u s policies have
not we're very happy to have with us tonight
john stockwell to talk about the cia and
reagan's foreign policy in latin america john
is a former cia case officer who wrote the book
exposing the angola operations that he was
in charge of in search for enemies and has
also published a novel about africa where he
was also active in the cia called red sunsets
the last year john has been lecturing
throughout america going to some of the major
university campuses to give public lectures
on the cia and has also been traveling widely
in central america and the caribbean so john
welcome to alternative views we're glad to see
you back in austin it's good to be back yeah
and two of the trips that you took let's begin
talking about and that is trips to grenada and
nicaragua you went to grenada in february and
grenada in january and then again in march okay
what were some of the things that you experienced
down there grenada came into the news during
that period and you've been to grenada about
uh two years ago also two years ago i went to
grenada to lecture and this in january it was
purely a business trip i had some attorneys
in houston some maritime stuff they wanted me
to intercede for them and so i went and observed
and of course talked to as many people as i could
in march when i was back there
again follow up on the same business
but uh i was in grenada when president
reagan announced on television up here
that grenada was a threat to the united states
national security interests and showed the
pictures of grenada with the cuban yeah a russian
airfield airfield and the new cuban housing and
and now i was at a party that night their
ambassador telephoned and said you know
what had happened uh i was at a party that night
and jacqueline kreff the minister of education
uh she said she said darn she said they found
us out we were planning to invade washington
next week and then our armies were going to go and
take philadelphia in new york city then we would
move across the midwest and capture california
by the end of may was our timetable she said
and the point being of course that grenada is
one-third the size of austin texas demographically
and geographically it's it's 80 000 people it's
about 16 miles by 8 miles it's national government
budget total uh is closer to st edwards university
than to the university of texas and uh its three
main sources of income are all dealing with the
west western tourism which is why they need this
this airport uh yeah they don't have an airport
they can bring in the tourists yeah they have a
tiny little thing that they you have to land in
trinidad or barbados and overnight and then fly
on a little puddle hopper into grenada and then go
across the mountain to get to the capitol so they
need the imf has recommended this this airfield
be built this airport be built since uh 76 77 78
and uh they didn't find a way to do it
until the new government came into power
and put together international financing
but their second source of income is
spices cocoa and nutmeg sold to the west and
their third source of income is the largest u.s
medical school outside of the united states
continental limit so what you see there
is love boat coming into town once every other day
regularly western tourists all over the place and
u.s medical students you know with michigan state
and stanford t-shirts and cutaways and sandals
walking around everywhere with their
noses in books this is a good school
they took top honors on the on the
medical boards last year in up here but
this air base that reagan keeps talking about
and the new cuban housing it's an airport it's
internationally financed the cubans have only
put up 30 percent of the financing a florida
company has put up 15 of the financing and the
equipment you know and it's there's there's no
barbed wire there's no machine guns there's no
guard post the medical students from the saint
george's university go up there to ride these
little hondas and things they rent to race them on
the strip that's being built you you walk
you have the tourist complexes grand ants
right out of st george's a couple of miles where
you have about 15 hotels western tourists and uh
you walk up the hill from the last of these hotels
they kind of sprawl around 100 yards to get to
this open field which is got a few houses on it
and that exactly is what reagan showed on the map
is the new cuban housing but there's no fence i
had my wife with me and we went walking one sunday
sunday morning and we stopped at a bridge just
here on the left the communities get out every
sunday and clean up and paint and fix up the
neighborhoods and whatnot of community projects
we helped them paint on this bridge abutment for
a while and then we went and stepped across the
ditch where the cubans were playing baseball
now i don't speak spanish they didn't speak
english they didn't know who i was it couldn't
have been anything political in any sense of
the word i just walked up smiling and they
gave me the bat and so i promptly struck out
and we went back across the ditch and walked
away now this is the threat to our national
security that reagan's talking about i think
he's overplayed his hand the mouse that roared
he is so bloody desperate for enemies to make
it to be a a big plot in the caribbean it's not
just nicaragua or just nicaragua in el salvador
and cuba it's also you've got draw lines and
axes and grenada down here and an airport that
would support submarine operations and whatnot
he's pretty desperate though if this is how far he
has to go to justify these policies i told jackie
though when she was making her joke and everybody
around us was laughing i said jackie you know the
sorry thing is that if he says that on national
television it means grenadans are going to die
and she you know immediately got sober and she
said you don't have to tell us that we know about
the world they've already uh yeah bond and tried
to assassinate their leadership yeah they have six
hard cases that they've documented
and investigated thoroughly
of violent acts of destabilization that
originated from the cia one was the effort
to bomb to kill all the leaders of the government
where we're at a national day thing up on a podium
they got a bomb underneath it but the concrete
deflected the blast out to the crowd so the
leaders weren't touched but a hundred people
were blown apart the woman killed that many no
three of them died and a hundred people were
injured or injured torn apart uh the woman
that brought the bomb up in a basket of fruit and
placed it under there of course they caught her uh
her brother had been to barbados
in the u.s embassy four days before
one of his cousins uh who had also been to
barbados in the u.s embassy was driving around
the northern end of the island and hit a bump
or something his car went off a bomb and his
car went off and they went and investigated
his home it was an arsenal of of plastic and
detonators and whatnot that's just one another one
a large ship load 650 000 of spices was poisoned
and one of their four or five generator
plants was sabotaged with stuff in the fuel to
kill the diesels this is the type of thing
they've been doing to the cubans for years
burning the crops and sabotage the cubans and many
other corners of the world yes john what is the
relationship between grenada and the soviet union
reagan has created the specter of grenada being
used as a soviet base and he's even elicited the
possibility there may be missile soviet missiles
there that's why we got to be tough with them is
there any basis for this and the right western
tourists all over the island they're not russians
or russian tourists there's hundreds of you know
love boat puts into town you rent these little
cars you know that don't have sides just a roof on
and you drive all over the place around the
the southern and uh eastern side of the island
i i've flown in these plans planes landing it's
it's a very rugged coastline these little inlets
and little fingers of land all gorgeous all with
nice houses on them where canadians and americans
have retired there's no bases of any kind on this
place they have their own militia and their own
very tiny armed force which of course anybody in
this world has but it doesn't threaten anyone and
they lean over backwards to be very very polite to
westerners they like westerners they talk to you
moreover you've got to remember that beyond
all of this trying to name these people as
communists uh flora lewis herself from
the new york times not exactly a liberal
came back and wrote in the new york times that
it had a moderate free enterprise system of
economics they haven't nationalized anything
and yet nevertheless because the
leadership has dared to stand up and say
that in principle we represent the people our
objective is to give them a piece of the pie
and then they did this thing which is the most
threatening of all to washington to the reagan
class of the world the leadership all took cuts in
pay one third of what their predecessors have been
taking and of course see that is the ultimate
challenge to the capitalists to the reagans and
the reaganomics and the david rockefellers and
xm bank people is a leadership that really would
take less money and really would try to give it
to the people and i remember last time you were
talking about grenada or either that i read
it subsequently that when they had the the
government got together to determine what the
budget would be for the following year for the
government everybody on the island sat in on it
and had their input and they voted on it and yeah
this is true there has to be there has to be a
message in the fact that angola has its revolution
uh the literacy overall was less than 15 among
the people in the interior it was one percent
and immediately they began building schools in
every corner of this big land nicaragua in the
first three years since independence built over
a thousand schools plus clinics for people but
teaching them the literacy campaign it's the same
thing cuba did 25 years ago the literacy campaign
teaching the people how to read and how to write
and then talking to them the long addresses
that fidel has given to the people endlessly
telling them about their economic problems and
what they're trying to do and the significant
difference is not lying to them as washington
does don't well speaking of nicaragua can you
tell us about that since you were there just
a couple of weeks ago nicaragua makes me
alternately want to cry and want to scream
it's kind of brought me back out of retirement
on the lecturing and speaking out because i've
very much been working to get into writing
novels and building a fiction writing career
once again the united states government
has designated a small country with the
people's oriented government as threatening
to our national security interests and uh
as the nicaraguan ambassador said in the united
nations security council yesterday the united
states is waging war against nicaragua undeclared
war but it's war and kirkpatrick got up and
raged and waved her arms and stomped out because
her position is simply totally untenable she could
not sit there and face the world because
we are waging war today against nicaragua
we're killing nicaraguans by the dozens by the
droves we're arming contras which is one of the
fact that somosis who were thrown out were arming
them we're we're we're equipping them with with uh
mercenaries from other countries training them
working through through and with the honduran
army and sending them in waves now the second wave
of over over 1300 people went in just last week
attacking and killing we're not killing
communists the communist party does
not support the sandinistas they don't
believe in what the sandinistas believe in
they're not killing russians they're not killing
kgb they're not killing cubans god forbid i hope
they never do kill cubans they're just killing
people that happen to have the misfortune of
being born in northern nicaragua we've done
this in angola vietnam we've done it over
20 000 times in the last 35 years the church
committee report showed us that over 100 several
hundred covert actions per year for 35 years
that's got to be 15 to 20 000 covert operations
the toll of dead now first line victims has got
to be over a million people killed you know you
give arms to the contras you send them in and
they kill people it's got to be there were eight
hundred thousand in indonesia alone from the cia's
own figures john there was an analysis last week
in in these times about the cia operations
in nicaragua and they made the interesting
point first of all this is precisely the same
thing that the cia did in 1954 in guatemala
when they supported counter-revolutionary
forces to overthrow a legitimately elected
government and it was the same thing they
attempted to do but failed at the bay of pigs
where they also armed mercenaries could you give
us some insight since you know the cia from the
inside about how the cia carries out an operation
like this to try to destabilize and overthrow a
legitimately elected government or one that has
worked from the people indeed and and my book in
search of enemies is a blueprint for what they're
doing in nicaragua working the headquarters is in
washington it's a global operation pulling
strings in every corner of the world working
from bases in the u.s for much of your training
and shipping your arms and then working from
neighboring countries in this case it's honduras
and costa rica in angola it was a year in zambia
uh to to and hiring mercenaries to go in and do
the killing for you the budget in the angolan
operation initially was 14 million uh this budget
was 19 million so sort of an inflation factor
when it started of course it's gone up they're
using the honduran army to put up additional
arms and supplies and airplanes much as we did
mobutu's army before but let me back up a minute
uh about the guatemalan operation in 54 ousting
jacob bins he was trying to take back the land buy
it back from united fruit company which owned
the country and parcel it out to the people
so they could sell the fruit to united fruit
companies so they would have a little bit of
a steak in their country and this was land which
united fruit was not using it well well basically
some of it yeah they weren't using others they
were using but he was going to pay him a dollar
2.98 cents an acre and this was exactly twice
what they had paid for it 10 years before so 100
profit the state department stepped in and said
75 dollars an acre which was outrageous and and
the country couldn't possibly come up with that
kind of money so they told the the american public
and the world that this was a communist government
threatening our national security and alan dulles
and the ci plucked our moths he's a puppet there's
no other word for it he was nobody he was not a
factor in guatemalan politics and he was not in
the country and he didn't have a following he
hadn't lost big elections by a narrow majority
anything like that they plucked him in and put
him in power they ousted our bins and put our mons
in power now and said sign this sweetheart deal
with united fruit now we find out in history read
the book bitter fruit by schlesinger henry cabot
lodge our ambassador the united nations at that
time had personal stock in united fruit company
john lodge the assistant secretary of state
for inter-american affairs had personal stock
holdings in the united fruit company john lodge's
brother was the president of united fruit company
john foster dulles was the senior adviser of the
law firm that advised the schlafly bank which not
only was the bank primary bank in philadelphia
to launder ci money it also held the papers on
the irca which is the guatemalan railroad that was
owned by the united fruit company and alan dulles
the ci director was also a member of that same law
firm have you have you read it so to defend this
nation now in addition to which our benz he was
not a communist he didn't have a single communist
in his government in his cabinet none and so
they told us it was a communist threat to our
national security interest and so the [ __
] goes on now nicaragua is a threat to our
national security interest the problem though i
think is that the american people are becoming
much more sophisticated and aware they remember
they remember the credibility gap in vietnam
and the bay of tonkin and the lies and [ __
] that were put out to justify that which
eventually collapsed i think the only thing that
troubles people now is they're just breathtaking
that the government would still have the goal to
throw at them the same lies particularly when they
see the same government go to uh communist china
and establish friendly relationships with them
and economic communications a lot of trade with
russia yeah and of course the secret is that these
countries are wanting to to at least come on an
equal basis in the multinational and transnational
uh bank and corporation relationship which of
course cannot be done within the capitalist
multinational system they won't allow that this
is what the problem is the tragedy of all this is
it's such a small interest in washington
that has control of our foreign policy
what they're doing against nicaragua does not even
help the united states economically back to the
angolan experience gulf oil and boeing were
outraged by what we were doing in our war because
it was disrupting international commerce as soon
as the war was over they were back pumping oil and
selling airplanes eight years later they're still
saying hey these angolans whatever their internal
politics are they're faithful reliable business
partners and golf is lobbying to you know i told
you before right after the war golf technicians
were in there pumping the oil with cubans guarding
them to protect them from fnlaci mercenary attack
eight years later cubans are still guarding
the gulf installations to protect them from fnla
attack and if you read what's happened recently
the past few weeks david rockefeller made a trip
to angola and with some of his cronies saying hey
this is not a bad government we want to set up
a commercial relationships with this government
and remember we reported this on alternative views
we said hey watch out pretty soon that we're going
to see some action there and sure enough about
six weeks two two months later vice president
bush made a trip to angola saying hey these are
pretty nice people there or maybe maybe if well
a year ago rockefeller did the same thing the
point is that the so-called radical governments
yeah i mean what's radical i mean the ones
that believe in people-oriented societies
that does not mean that they're our enemies
economically or otherwise unless we attack
them they're believing the angolans believe in
exactly what this country believed in when we
had our own revolution and so do the nicaraguans
we threw out george 5 and the british they threw
out samosa bloodthirsty oppressive killers
corrupt enriching themselves off the country
all this country has to do is get its ideology
straight and say hey you know a national holiday
declared because the nicaraguan people succeeded
in rising up and ousting a corrupt dictator who
was stealing money and disrupting commerce now
they're happier and we'll make more money and
everybody will be happier instead we declare war
on them we consider it a defeat but not we the
american people it's not a defeat to the values we
believe in it's a defeat for the cia because they
put they helped put samosa in power and sustain
them in power it's a defeat for the cia but not
for this country it shouldn't be john reagan's
claim is that the sandinistas are supporting the
rebels in el salvador who are our enemies is there
anything to that i take that's his justification
for no that's his cover just as we had an angola
remember and don't ever forget this we had 177
working group papers in angola each one
one paragraph of it would deal with the
story that we would tell the press for that week
through the state department spokesman or through
the ambassador at the united nations then it was
patrick moynihan now it's this lady kirkpatrick
not once did we ever discuss telling the truth now
his story is that we're only doing this to stop
the flow of arms from nicaragua to el salvador
the nicaraguans have said in every forum possible
what flow of arms there is no flow of arms and
and washington says but there is nicaragua said
show us show the united nations show somebody your
proof of this non-existent flow of arms washington
has been unable to do that but i suggest to you
again that if if the united states would ever
come to terms with its own values the stuff we
tell ourselves in the in the grizzly adams daniel
boone uh television you know the level at which we
communicate with our children incur these values
what we would do would be to start supplying the
people in el salvador with arms their government
is corrupt it's bloodthirsty commerce doesn't
work good when you have a corrupt bloodthirsty
government it works when you have a society where
the people are educated and their energies are
tapped we should you know if the nicaraguans
are sending them arms we should facilitate it
maybe give them planes to fly it in i mean i mean
let's face it what does this country believe in
do we believe in democracy president reagan is
saying that we have to attack the sandinistas
because they don't you know they don't support
democratic principles or something or other
you know the people now have the truth
enough of it over the 35-year history
that they know about washington's compulsive
lying the politics of lying the schizophrenia
president after president goes up there and
says the lies and cover stories for the ci
for example the people know of the government
after government that washington has overthrown
constitutional democracies democratically elected
presidents that we overthrew with violence and
installed dictators to replace them this is what
the american people know about increasingly today
and that's why reagan's policies in nicaragua
are running into such such gaffe he is running
policies in nicaragua to support sweetheart
deals with his cronies in the multinational
world in california in the financial world and
that is the only reason they're doing or is it
even more just political reasons that they're just
trying to show third world revolutionary movements
that there's going to be the strong arm of the
united states against them if they try to take on
their own fortunes and try to carry out their
own well that's exactly what they're doing the
point is that it's not necessary to our physical
security military security or economic security
to oppose the sandinistas the people of
nicaragua or the people of el salvador
we would have physical security military security
and and economic interests augmented if we would
get with our own traditions and support the
people well what about your observations of the
social process in nicaragua are the
people behind the government is the system
even the iaea admits the people are behind the
government there's no question about it the people
particularly the young people the only place that
they're running into any trouble at all is in the
bourgeoisie which in that country developed
under samosa was very small and the people
who owning businesses they haven't had their
businesses expropriated nothing has been stolen
nothing has been nationalized but nevertheless
the people with the moneyed interests
they wanted to get rid of samosa so they could
make more of the money samosa had been you know
devouring starting with the grand with the daddy
and then his sons had started as nothing but
the national guard commander and they had spread
where they owned 45 of the country and of course
the bourgeoisie was losing more to them than
the peasants were the peasants had always lost
now it's the most out the bourgeoisie wants a
chance to try to own it all you know i used to
when i worked for the government i used to hear
people talk about u.s imperialism and i i just you
know that was obviously a communist buzzword and
didn't have any real meaning but do you know when
the first military intervention by this country
was in nicaragua in the 19th century sometimes
1855 right william walker with backing from new
england states went down militarily and suppressed
the people's movement in the liberal party
the campesinos had an uprising in 1881
1898 1909 we put in the u.s marines to stop a
people's uprising and they stayed there for what
25 years 28 years in 1933 the congress finally
voted to get the marines out there was that famous
photograph we could dig it up and you could show
it here of the marine captain holding the head
the guy's head and his son denise's head in his
hands there was an uprising in this country i mean
a reaction and they forced the marines to come
home the congress voted and okay they created a
national guard before they left and the commander
of the national guard became a dictator when he
left the country when he was forced to flee he
took 1.6 billion dollars with him from a poor
country this compares with uh the 4.2 billion
dollars that our man the sea ice man has stolen
from zaire a poor country the national debt is
4.5 billion dollars and the 16 billion dollars
that the shah was permitted to steal from iran
there's another point i want to highlight here
a historical point and that is that sandino and
the sandinista movement were as you pointed out
not communists they were democratic nationalists
were opposed from the beginning by the communist
party in nicaragua similar to cuba where fidel was
another democratic nationalist who was criticized
constantly by the cuban communist party absolutely
and you also have the same thing happening after
both the cuban and the nicaraguan revolutions
vis-a-vis the american government that is after
the cuban revolution fidel sent some of his people
to washington well he came himself right yeah
yeah fidel came in saying look we want to be
friends we want to have good relationships etc
and the sandinistas did the same thing they
said that look we want to start working with
washington and we want to become friends with
america and both times they were rebuffed
pushed back and then the only place that would
give them any aid whatsoever is the soviet union
who gave the cubans oil and some other economic
well the soviet union has has bought cuban uh
sugar and uh but the sandinistas have not gotten
a dominant uh amount of aid from the soviet union
very little they've got it they've been bailed out
by western european countries that's a good point
but in any case the fact that america has failed
to establish satisfactory relationships with these
countries pushes them towards diplomatic relations
with other countries then we complain that they're
on the side of our enemies or their communists or
whatever and this is just moronic really you know
the the one i can explain something to you that i
doubt if anyone has ever explained to you you know
the domino theory people say it works as people
say it's [ __ ] you know and back and forth uh
and yet countries seem to be falling and the
point is that countries are falling but it's not
communism it's not like a bubonic plague that's
spreading what it is is pure and simply people
increasingly following our own example of 200
years ago are simply not willing to put up with
the oppression of greedy callous cruel dictators
it's absolutely true that el salvador has
has got revolution now the people want
to be free of this stuff read the book
el salvador face of revolution by shank and
armstrong which analyzes how far people have
to be pushed over how many decades and how
many dozens of thousands killed and raped
until every family is touched until the
people finally say we have no choice
we can't eat we have no jobs we have no education
we have no hospitals and we're going to be killed
or raped and are raped whatever we do so we might
as well die fighting now they say it will sweep up
into mexico i can guarantee it will whatever we
do it's going to go into mexico you have a vast
mass of people there who have no jobs and no money
they're starving they don't have medicine they
don't have education and then you have a little
thin oligarchy that's ripping off the hundreds of
millions of dollars that's obtained from their
oil and from the bank loans yes the people are
becoming aware of this as we did 200 years ago and
a sense of let's do something about it instead of
just dying and crying you know weeping about
our plight as we die let's do something about
it that's right in these countries king george is
their own government yeah now the exactly now the
only solution that will work it's so simple that
it's almost scary that washington can't grasp it
but the only thing that will work is for
washington to suddenly wake up and say hey
these people are what the united states is all
about the corrupt oligarchies are not what we're
all about ideologically and start supporting them
but the problem of course that you jump to there
is that our own country is no longer a democracy
capitalism you know the competitive energies of
capitalism that made this country the greatest
country in the history of the world you know
we've heard that many many times including from
reagan recently it's a game of monopoly gone stale
it's no longer competition the multinationals and
the capitalists and the david rockefellers own
such a vast share you know the hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of billions of dollars
that you know the other stuff is small potatoes
but nobody can break into that it's it's a
monopoly game going stale to the point where
it deprives people of com competitive energy
take a stewart mata or warehouse they're actually
good people i know but they inherited money that
their granddaddies had made and their fathers
attorneys had continued these people have
been deprived of the opportunity to compete
because they inherited billions of dollars
how can they compete i mean how can you compete
economically what what energies can you get from
a system where you have dumped on you at birth 100
million dollars or so and a corporate structure
that has its own rigidity it's exactly momentum
that an individual can't really creatively operate
which is intermarried with a government
and so you have one one complete whole uh
system rather than the government and the private
sector is that the bottom line gets back to the
you know these countries it gets back to the the
in search of enemies principle nicaragua grenada
angola vietnam remember ho chi minh was the united
states great friend and ally in world war ii all
of these wanted good relations with the united
states and they went a long ways courting us
and trying to be our friends and we attacked
them so why do we need enemies in the world
okay we're faced with a situation today where our
economic system is now rated something like eighth
in the world in terms of quality there are eight
nations that teach people quality of life quality
of life is down to about eight education of our
children is down to about eight health like 12 or
16. health is 12 12 and our cities are falling
apart and yet given that sad plummeting fact
we're proposing to spend projecting to spend 1.6
trillion dollars on defense in the next five years
with with them washington readily admitting that
the overruns will put it over two trillion dollars
in the next five years now you can't justify
that kind of defense spending in a peaceful world
if it's a peaceful world without threatening
enemies russia of course is a fixed enemy
but you have to have more pressing
threats you need something close by
and you have to have this antichrist of communism
waved at the people so i had this happen in a
hardware store just two days ago a nice person a
good guy and he said he said but i'll tell you one
thing we've got to stop those communists somewhere
and it may as well be nicaragua well you know he's
caught the antichrist of communism feeling he's
got that straight he knows nothing about nicaragua
the communist party doesn't support the sandinista
government but the only way you can continue
this military industrial complex and this this
trillions of dollars spending is if you have a
hostile threatening world and all spheres and so
they work it so you're suggesting that the deeper
reason for reagan's central american policy as
well as the cia operations all over the world is
to perpetuate the military-industrial complex that
people with those interests at stake are promoting
these covert operations this cold war these
hostilities everywhere and that what this is
leading to also is a militarization of our economy
and our society in which all of our economic
wealth is going into the military and the military
is becoming a tremendous social force because it
controls the dollar so it can control policies
there's also another factor that's a little bit
harder to quantify but is just as strong if
not stronger and that's the to to rationalize
violence the human beast has always been
violent and aggressive and in washington
for all of the 700 and 800 suits that the reagans
wear and the thousand dollar plates they eat off
of they're still cavemen at heart they still
have this thing for killing the ci wants to
run operations the military wants to fly planes
and shoot at something more than targets reagan
wants to be a military leader and present preside
over a war and you have to have enemies if there
aren't enemies you make enemies if you can't bring
yourself to have a showdown or it's impractical
because of atom bombs with the soviet union and
have a big war or you might lose then you have
these proxy wars through the the ci working into
and you into nicaragua and you justify this stuff
by by building up this communist antichrist and
the threats to our national security and we cannot
afford to let central america go communists before
it was southeast asia communist and then so so
it's to justify as i say this craving for violence
it's like football players that need a game
john this also brings in another aspect which i'd
like to get into that is the disinformation game
which we see over and over and over part of the
way to get the american people to accept this is
to introduce just absolute lies which they now
call disinformation but we've seen it time and
again the story of the libyan hit squads
which we talked about on a previous program
turned out to be absolute balderdash a story
fabricated by this instance the israeli press
and yet you know i saw david brinkley about uh
about four months ago on a tv program saying yeah
these libyans are the people who are sending
hit squads over to try to kill our president
and the killing of the pope the
assassination all of these things
the the nicaraguan atrocities all these
terrible killings and atrocities in nicaragua
uh covert action information bulletin and some
other people have gone into these stories and
they trace them back even sending people overseas
into the field they trace them back every occasion
they find where it starts and it's either the
cia or a cia operative overseas and then they
get it into the international wire services and
it's picked up then once it's splashed as head
as headlines it never gets retracted if uh
sufficiently like like the the sandinistas the
nicaraguan government was accused front page new
york times of an atrocity massacre of 200 mosquito
indians now the in fact the people who go up there
and see the american missionaries moravian church
journalists television crews and and hundreds
and hundreds of people are traveling and looking
they find the sandinistas it is a sensitivity
the mosquito indians who have a different ethnic
background they're working as hard as they can
to educate them help them organize and respond to
them make them feel part of the revolution there's
no question of killing 200 of them and alienating
the whole mass the new york times retracted that
headline they ran it actually for a couple of days
discussing it three weeks later they retract
it but on page nine a little thing saying
that neither the moravian church nor amnesty
international have been able to confirm that any
massacre whatsoever occurred much less who had
anything to do with it they didn't put it on the
front page saying we screwed up again we bought
another ci disinformation thing and gave you some
bad information folks in truth no massacre
occurred well they put that on the inner
page it makes good press even the new york
times has this touch of yellow journalism
if it's a good sensational story and they've got
it from some source in the government you know run
it and then you can retract it later and then you
can say well we retracted it you know we kept our
skirts going are these media people shameless i
would think they would get tired of being burned
by these cia disinformation stories for instance
we've seen a lot about the hitler diaries
where there were these fake diaries and the people
in stern magazine that published those were forced
to quit you never see anything like this over
in america when you have similar disinformation
stories is there any integrity in
american journalism or shame at least
you've got to understand that the
system of government supposedly
guarantees the right to free press you
can publish what you want to publish
it doesn't guarantee that it it will be unbiased
what you publish the people who own the new york
times who own the washington post have their own
political views and they have the right to publish
whatever they want catherine graham you recall
a year and a half ago in a press conference said
her editors would support the national security
interest well national security is a euphemism
for the cia anytime you read national security
interest you mean cia interests and she she
knows this and she confirmed that's the bias of
her paper this brinkley thing he knows better
i mean if you really sat down with him
in private and said hey what was this
but he's expressing a conservative twitch a kick
you know let's go kick ass on the communist twitch
take this thing uh the disinformation thing you
know it fascinates me because i was inside i
once had a staff that was cranking out articles
and they would come across my desk you know to
initial off on them on the angolan thing and
things relating you know southern africa and
uh the writing and how you know and then you
watch the news and see patrick moynihan giving a
speech at the united nations and stuff you signed
off on a couple of days before and so you know
ha you know he didn't run it exactly the way we
intended but he got you know the gist of it right
remember in the i forget the date but we could
dig it out in the in the mid 50s uh a russian
agent east german agent went into west germany and
killed a businessman and then later he defected
and he took the police to a canal and showed him
where he dumped the weapon the weapon was a little
gun that would fire a mist into someone's face
and provoke a heart attack instantly and there
would be no trace what an autopsy would show a
heart attack and he had a vial that he was in a
handkerchief that he would break and hold to his
own nose which was an antidote so he wouldn't have
a heart attack and he caught this businessman that
that they wanted to hit uh or coming up the stairs
to his apartment building hit him with the spray
and he died and you know he he protected himself
and he got out of the building and he went and he
disposed of the weapon by throwing it in a canal
now all of this activity to kill a guy who was not
a household name even in germany much less here i
mean it wasn't the president of germany or anybody
important that was the length to which the kgb
went in and to liquidate a lesser individual
back then an operation an agent trained for
years that kind of a weapon and somebody's
going to try to tell us and have us believe
that they would authorize an operation to kill the
pope involving uh this this idiot that uh deranged
turk working for the bulgarians with lists
in his own wallet of names and phone numbers
of the people who plotted it there's simply no
way if the kgb plotted the killing of the pope
they would they would have meetings and staffs
and teams training for weeks and weeks and weeks
to make sure that it couldn't possibly blow
what happened was this deranged turk shot
the pope that's a fact and he had contact with
some bulgarians that's apparently the fact at
least he did have you know phone numbers in his
wallet he apparently knew some of these people
and now that bulgarian intelligence or just
bulgarians well they were the the the italians
said later they were intelligence but uh then
later you know then the western intelligence
including the pope who doesn't like the
russians obviously he has an enormous bias
they seize on this is a massive thing to
sell the world in their disinformation war
we can show the bulgarian lincoln the
kg we must have known and all that
and so here you have another one uh nbc by the way
had a whole hour show on the plot to kill the pope
and was making a big deal on it night after night
on their nightly news and then about two weeks ago
i saw cbs had a report that this is nonsense
this whole story that there's no information
the italian government is going to be forced to
give up their prosecution of these bulgarians that
they'd arrested cbs yeah and that all the european
intelligence services also are very um skeptical
and the cia is skeptical the cia just about it
but that was only in a fine print somewhere in
this story i'll give you another one and i'll give
you this article so you can show it on here um
i clipped it out of the austin american states
but the other day i was flying out on one of my
lectures uh aids you know the acquired immune
deficiency syndrome uh the gay plague that's
spreading into you know society and and they don't
know what caused it so it could be the health
threat of the century did you know that it's a
cuban communist plot well i read that it said
you said that a headline in the austin american
statesman an inner page headline it's a gay plague
linked to cubans in africa and then it goes on in
this article it doesn't it doesn't cite one case
of the plague in africa or one case of the plague
in cuba or one case of a plague occurring in
around you know somewhere where a cuban exile was
here in the states i not one scientific fact but
the point that they were playing on in that one
was that we're a nation of headline readers and
people glance at and sensationalism like the aids
by the way one of my students gave me a copy of
the cuban grammar paper that addressed this they
published the american story and they pointed out
how there's not one case in cuba of this disease
it's unknown there and that even this whole thing
about it being a homosexual disease is not
necessarily clear the american homosexuals
have been doing research into this they just
raised several hundred thousand dollars in
new york to do some research into it because they
see it as a disinformation campaign against them
yeah it's clearly outside of the homosexual
world even even the the straight uh
articles about it are coming out and saying hey
it's it's well out in the society it's a headline
it's a cuban communist plot john there's been a
new book that's come out recently about the cia
can you tell us about it and evaluate it in some
ways the best book written about the ci including
my own he has some success ralph mcgee's
book deadly deceit a relatively short book
and i'll tell you why i would say his in some
ways is better than mine when i was writing
mine with all of the anguish that that i felt
inside and the anger for seeing the betrayals in
vietnam and the lies and propaganda about angola
my editors at norton conservative publisher norton
they loved the book but they kept saying tone it
down keep it straight don't moralize don't speak
anything from inside yourself keep it dry and let
the facts speak for themselves so it comes out
i mean anyone reads it can sense what's going
on inside of me but it comes out somewhat of an
indictment of ci and efficiency now mcgehee
while he was writing his book he had people
reading the the manuscript i read it for
one and uh and others who were writing in
the margin saying you got to reach inside you
got to tell us you know what is your scream
i mean you're going against your whole life
you know say it lay it out so he lays it out
and uh the case the the principal things that i
draw from this book is uh and it's a short book
it's not hard to read it's not a big tome
but in the in the simplest form i have ever
seen presented in writing he reviews and he see
he did 25 years in east asia division of the cia
he did two tours in vietnam three tours in
thailand working up country with the hmong people
and then taiwan and hong kong and somewhere else
japan i think now and this guy and he rose to he
was good he was uh an all-american football player
at notre dame and on on their unbeaten years in
47 or whatever it was and an honor student in
business and he came in determined to be the best
i mean with this this football all-american
you know he's going to be the best intelligence
officer and whatnot and he tried and what he
found was for example up country in thailand he
came up with a system of intelligence where
for for a tenth the monetary expenditure
you could find out much more accurate information
about the communist effectiveness and what degree
the people supported him or not he got an award
and they were preparing to install the system
throughout thailand and then into other countries
it was based on the way they'd done it in malaysia
the british had done it and he figured out how
americans could apply it in thailand bill colby
went to talk to him in the field and he spent a
whole day explaining the system and showing the
proof and showing and they were going to have
to reevaluate their understanding of thailand
kobe went back to bangkok flew back to the states
the next day mcgee was called down to bangkok
presuming he was going to get another award or be
told he was in charge of installing a system they
gave him his plane tickets he flew immediately
back to washington and was given a non-job
because his information was cutting the struts out
from under the rationale for the 17 000 man army
that colby was building with the hmong people
if the truth were known the army wouldn't be
justified if mcgehee had been allowed to develop
his information and report the truth the congress
could not have been persuaded to develop this
army and do this war they wanted to do so they
took him and stuck him in a non-job and so when
his career you could not produce good intelligence
now he gives an analysis for how the vietnam
war got started in terms how the cia convinced
i won't go into it now i doubt if we have the
time but incredible the way they manipulated
the disinformation and the propaganda to get the
north vietnamese catholics terrified of communists
you know the thousand pregnant women that were
ripped open and and they were catholic pregnant
women you know so the catholics fled south there
were no atrocities there were no women really
ripped open it was propaganda then the american
people could identify with the enemy's catholics
they could not identify with vietnamese
buddhists and so we get involved in sympathy
for these catholics or fleeing communism
and the war he he goes into this he also
explains the ci's operation in indonesia where
we killed the ci killed eight hundred thousand
i mean he set things in motion that killed
eight hundred thousand people and then wrote
an external report in the form of a book false
flag not you know attributed to the government
called indonesia 1965 the coup that misfired and
then an internal report which was classified top
secret which uh said that this was a model covert
action because it had not only broken an effective
national communist party it had eliminated
the entire ethnic segment of the population
that supported it the indonesian chinese had
killed them all and it put the figure at 800 000.
i've heard as high as a million and a half the new
york times said 500 000 to a million and a half
the ci figure was 800 000. bragging about it
that it claimed its operation had killed and
he also points out how the hmong people
who were being used by colby and the cia
exactly the same way the mosquitoes are being
used today now don't exist as a people anymore
they were they were decimated means one
in ten killed it's the other way around
nine and ten were killed in this thing so as
a people they don't exist john you've been
traveling around lecturing about the cia the last
year how has the audience received your critiques
of the cia and do you see a sort of consensus
growing that perhaps the cia is out of line
should be reformed perhaps eliminated or
is there still a lot of support for the cia
in the audiences that you've been taught i have
substantial crowds come and the lectures normally
start at 7 30 7 7 30 and normally there's a
large portion 80 percent of the audience still
there at midnight or 1 o'clock people are so
concerned people have read this and heard that
trying to sort through the disinformation
having in some cases they're very sophisticated
and others they have a growing feeling
that there's something profoundly wrong
in washington but they're not sure and to
have the chance to talk to a case officer a
top-ranked case officer who was in the field
but also in the national security council
they they seize upon it and they stay for like
i say and and hostile questions you can count on
one hand out of many many 150 i don't know how
many lectures uh people are deeply concerned
because they see that washington is lying they've
read about guatemala and they've read about chile
and they've read about vietnam and all the other
places where we went in and beat the drums of a
non-existent communist threat and then you know
in some cases had our own people in there being
killed and then the young people coming to these
lectures because they're sitting here with this
uncomfortable feeling that we could be so close
to putting our own troops into central america
which would mean them being used once again by the
moneyed interests and by a president and secretary
of state in their 700 dollar suits sending people
to fight a mythical monster in the jungles in this
in this case of central america and they're
just not sure they want to be used that way
and particularly they'll come to lectures to
hear a bit of the truth and uh they'll talk to
you i mean you get questions like on page 178 of
daniel jurgen's book and whatnot they're concerned
and they're reading and they're they don't want
to be used in another stupid war like vietnam
and that's alternative views for this evening
we're really glad you could join us
alternative views is a production of
the alternative information network
p.o box 7279 austin texas 78712
we'd like very much to get your comments on the
program positive negative whatever please contact
us you may write to us at the above address
and join us next time for alternative views
goodnight
and on a road light years away
spinning silent through the void
young people loudly question why
the world may slowly be destroyed
so now wait a minute cousin ed don't you believe
in the right to dissent of course i believe in the
right to descent i knock a man's teeth down his
throat that interfereth my right to descent ronnie
believes in the right to dissent what him and
me is trying to put a stop to is this criticism
the greatest satisfaction that a president of
the united states can have and one after the
other has done it or dreamed of doing it is to
send our own young people off to die and tell
them that it's noble and honorable and worthwhile
that is power sending your own people off to die
so i figured out the way we could stop war would
be if we had a ceremony and when the president
signs the act of war you would immediately take
you could construct a brick and concrete thing
in the white house lawn and and break out the
drum and bugle core and you take the president's
closest male kin and you shoot him children
strolling convoys roll on highway number one
going to school and go into war side by side
and gunned by a gun and the young ones know
that the fireworks show is a regular part
of life as the americans say as they sail
away every day is the fourth in july an evening
of political songs and comment featuring the
music of brian cuteen bill oliver tokiyamaru
and bala meal the poetry of david jewell
and especially john henry falk and john
stockwell tonight on alternative views
tonight will be a very different type of program
for alternative use because we're going to
show you some of the things that happened
during our alternative use benefit which we
had a few months ago at liberty lunch
some of austin's finest artists singers
poets were down there so we're going
to share some some of what they did
and i think you'll enjoy this too and of course
also we want to thank all the people who attended
at liberty lunch and who participated and
helped us out a bit many of you all who
came out to our benefit asked how you could get
more involved in the alternative views project
and we've developed a support group called friends
of alternative views that will work with us on
various projects and give us support of different
types if you've been watching alternative views
for several years or even our recent viewer and
want to see how you can get more involved in our
program why don't you write us a letter care the
alternative information network box 7279 austin
texas 78712 and we'll either call you or write you
immediately and give you information about how you
can join friends of alternative views i might add
that as a result of the fundraiser i guess we got
about oh nine hundred dollars which has enabled
us not only to continue to produce the program
but also has allowed us to purchase some extra
tapes which we're using to start alternative views
down in san antonio and recently in dallas and we
also have plans to go into atlanta and our dallas
connection also will see that we get into other
places in the dallas area and also fort worth
so with your help we're expanding
alternative views thank you thank you austin
this is about tv no one really admits they watch a
lot of tv people brag when they don't watch a lot
of tv and if they don't own a tv they really
rub it in i saw this woman poet once who was
supposed to be great and she kept bragging about
how she didn't watch tv and said how horrible she
thought tv was and she went to hawaii too but
didn't go swimming because she didn't like to
swim either and i thought she was stupid and left
in the middle of her show and was real glad i did
i think people who brag a lot about not
watching a tv or not owning a tv are stupid
usually they aren't all that interesting but
they act like you should think they are real
interesting just because of something they
don't do a lot of interesting people don't
watch television but they don't bother to tell
you about it or remind you of it they just don't
watch it because they don't have time to watch it
but might not mind watching it for a while when
they're going to sleep or something sometimes you
walk up to someone and tell them about something
fun you saw on tv and they say i don't watch tv
like it's a big deal and don't even listen to you
i'm not crazy about tv but it's nice now
and then and big deal is what i think
i started this song when i was
taking a little having my own little
advanced education course in southeast asia
around 1969 1970 finished it just in time for the
bicentennial thinking of the vietnamese refugees
as they celebrated the bicentennial this is mine
papa's son walking behind the buffalo trying
to bring in the rice and baby sun learning on
the gi bill mama son trying to keep them right and
they were doing all right as things there go with
almost normal lives but as things there go the
almost showed and on the fourth of july they died
children strolled convoys roll on highway number
one going to school and go into war side by side
and gun by a gun and the young ones know that
the fireworks show is a regular part of life
as the americans say as they sail
away every day as a fourth in july
sand pans loaded with people and goods i headed
for the marketplace hot rod flyboy from oklahoma
swampsome with the wash of his chopper blades and
the guys in supply of their joyrides throwing eggs
from the back of a truck it's american aided in
old man's space and a patriot down on his luck
and the handful of patriots that kept it
that way were the patriots making the box
oh
independence hall fills every day
with citizens filled with pride
this is the place where it all
began where the free world took
its biggest stride and the tour guide hides her
boredom well while the refugees hide their eyes
and the speeches fly and the peasants
die for the pride of the fourth of july
papa's son walking behind the buffalo trying to
bring in the rice baby sun learning on the gi bill
mamasan trying to keep them right and they were
doing all right things there go with almost
normal lives but as things there go the almost
short and on the fourth of july they died just
another fourth of july in july another fourth of
july and july another fourth of july and fool by
another fourth of july and me lie another fourth
of july and demand just another fourth of july
and quantry missed another fourth of july and
play cool just another fourth of july in donghae
and just another fourth of july in the delta
list another fourth of july on the line
missed another fourth of july in san salvador
just another fourth of july and grenada
are just another fourth and two lion angola
and just another fourth of july in july
yes
is
foreign
oh
that that song uh was from the afro-peruvian
folklore and it's a song that talks about
the unity of the black people and on this
fifth anniversary of alternative views
we bring our alternative music this uh some
of the songs that we sing about half of them
are what is known as the new song or the canto
nuevo and it is uh always a manifestation of
alternative service reviews which in most of our
cancers are not in fashion this is called slim
decisions like when two people are talking to you
at the same time one on your left and one on your
right you like them both and want to give equal
attention to both because you like both of them
a lot and want to let each one know that you think
he or she is very special and the one on the left
says something funny at the same time the one on
the right says something serious and you kind of
laugh and kind of look like you're lost in
thought and they both walk away kind of pissed
you know john henry faulk of texas
right over there standing at the bar at this
moment it's from a freedom-fighting family
well well he never forgot what he learned
real young some people got to fight to be
free lord lord some people got to fight
to be free in new york city in the 50s
john henry had a hit radio show
and he spoke out against the mccarthy blacklist
and mccarthy said john henry's gotta go
gotta go macarthy said john henry's gotta go
oh john henry said to mccarthy i
love this country more than you
and i never will sign your loyalty oath but i'll
take you to court and i'll sue you joe i'll take
you to court and i'll sue well the years went
by and john henry his spirit never did say die
with this folklore craft he could make you laugh
and then bring a tear to your eye to your eye
and then bring it to your eye well john henry sued
mccarthy and this case took a mighty long while
while he was waiting for his victory in the courts
it lived with his fear on trial on
trial he lived with a spear on trial
oh now john henry faulk of texas
is from a freedom-fighting family
and people who talk about john henry fog say
there goes a freedom like a man lord lord
there goes a freedom fighting man when
people talk about john henry fought
and say there goes the freedom of amen
lord lord there goes a freedom loving man
thank you and i'm delighted that all of y'all
are here gentle souls uh tonight because there's
not a more important organization in austin than
alternative views really when you stop to think
that's kind of damning it with fake praise when
you think about the daily text in austin america
being alternatives and the networks i mean the
television station it but it really is it's a
very important very important you especially in
light of the behavior of the administration in the
last few days you know ronnie do you realize
that nobody in the united states of america
has the slightest idea of what is happening right
down here in the caribbean except that which the
government wants us to know do you know what a
repudiation this is of our heritage our american
heritage that we were a people that nailed
into the basic law of this land the right of
the people to know what those birds in washington
were up to and look what they've done to us now
carried out this well they haven't done it to us
and i must say that it's a very disturbing thing
to me to think listen to these fellows around the
country talking about this is our proudest hour
america showed them where we stand by god we
went down there and we really did it when did
it become a matter of pride to any american
that the mightiest best equipped most affluent
mightiest military power in the world could go
down and stomp the daylights out of the smallest
country in the western hemisphere in the forest
when in the hell did americans start being proud
of something like that it's an abomination and a
shocking one now everybody doesn't feel that way
i realize because ned snodgrass my he's 86 years
old and he's been mad for 80 of me at six when
his mom and daddy told him the
south had lost the civil war
and he's been in the pout about that
he he has three great convictions
number one that jesse helms is the greatest
living statesman today number two that bill
bunk buckley is the greatest living writer
and number three that there's a flat surface
and i jumped him the other day on it he he he
jumped me he said johnny i know you hear what
these old students out the university doing
they're protesting that their grenada war
down there that ronnie's trying to run it's just
disgusting they get out there and they start that
protesting business and protesting business i
think they just ought to do something to them i
said now wait a minute cousin ed don't you believe
in the right to dissent of course i believe in the
right to descent i knock a man's teeth down his
throat that interferes my right to dissent ronnie
believes in the right to dissent what him and
me is trying to put a stop to is this criticism
criticized criticized criticized why can't
they leave ronald reagan alone let him fight
his wars in peace they want to criticize
somebody let him go down there and criticize
oh castro and that crowd of heathens johnny we got
there to grenader just in time oh my god you don't
understand what was going on ronnie does though
do you know that bunch of rascals down there
was planning to attack us any morning they've
got us pinned in here between the gulf of mexico
and the arctic circle and gonna come a sweeping
in here like a dose of salts through a widow woman
throwing guns down on us all of us and
making us sign our names to test papers and
and such as that that we come that will be
marxist leninist or they won't let us up again
i'll tell you ronnie has just saved america that's
what he's done from an invasion of them rascals
well i don't support him altogether in that
i'm not sure that we're that threatened by a
little country that i can it's just 21 miles
long not even that wide it's not our proudest
moment my angels and it disturbs me
very deeply that we have gone that route
but i'll tell you what disturbs me much more
deeply that the press of the united states
that's proudest boast is that it is a
free press and it we're a free people
has bent crook the pregnant hinges
of the knee before ronald reagan
instead of saying hell no we're not taking your
government handouts on what's going on down there
we have a solemn and sacred duty to the
people of the united states to let them
know what you outlaws there in washington
are doing and we're damn well gonna do it
instead of that they said well listen
tell us when we can go in will you
shameful shameful shameful this is our
country my angels this belongs to us
it don't belong to ronald reagan and don't
belong to the damn united states army either
they work for us we don't work for them well
i asked a friend of mine as a great
champion of the reagan administration
to explain ronald reagan's foreign policy to me
and he says oh i'm glad you asked me that let
me tell you something honey it's just as clear
and simple as you please it's easy to understand
john tower senator tower explained it to me the
other day johnny it's this way i can tell you to
you because i can discuss it honestly you know
ronald reagan loves the truth and i love
the truth and i love to tell it in a plain
english the language the holy bible was wrote
in the language that old mother of mine spoke
i sometimes think that almighty in his
divine wisdom when he saw fit to create
his most perfect work here on earth selected the
lone star state of texas this paradise on earth
and he came to this garden of eden on earth travis
county texas and he caught the gold from the texas
sunrise and he caught the sweetest notes from the
throat of the texas walking bird our state bird
and he caught the perfume of the texas blue bonnet
our state flower and he compounded and molded it
all together into that quintessence of sweetness
and that epitome of all virtue and goodness
my mother when that son that's what
ronald reagan's foreign program's all
about and if you don't understand it fully i'll
explain it further thank you folks very much
urban
this morning
yesterday
reality
of is
dream is
when i'm
another day only
reality voices of love
reality here
me
it's called martha treadmill
martha treadmill oozed around town with her
head in the ground she did her duties with
mindless ease filled the car while the gas man
teased her kid sneezed snot-nosed in the car
she scrubbed her yellow kitchen [ __ ] and
scraggly-haired frenzy at her curly-haired
morons who plugged their fingers in the wall
for the charge their mummy couldn't give them
she changed the pampers with a plebianaire put the
vacuum cleaner to her hair and wished she wasn't
there she was born upper middle class debutante
with a creamy ass and a cheerleader for the
hometown rodents until howard treadmill knocked
her up snot-nosed in the car she got married
in a scraggly-haired frenzy and gave birth to a
gaggle of morons then on the pavement of shoppers
plaza one vicious summer day martha treadmill
dropped her bag stole the car and ran away
talk to me in a simple tongue so
your words stay fresh in my mind
then sing for me your melody and your words will
naturally rhyme make me feel that place inside
not limited by time i will try not to
hide when my feelings flood my eyes
raise your spirits toward the heavens and hold
your glass up high won't you lay aside your
worry shackles and burst the bonds that
bind bring me a breath of refreshing air
from a land i knew before we're
all just learning how to share
no need to hurry anymore oh long ago some nights
in armor rose from a pile of dust with their
swords in hand they fought for honor then turned
away in disgust and on a road light years away
spinning silent through the void
young people loudly question why
the world may slowly be destroyed
so
falling crawling reaching calling is anybody near
honest words with warmth and
meaning are music to my ears
can you hear the ocean's mighty road
the breakers crash against the rocks
it's the sound i can't ignore
two thousand miles from the
of our docks we spend in passage with so much left
undone why criticize each other's efforts that are
reaching toward the sun come gather round while
we still can't hell how's it been at the moon
can't you feel the trembling in the
land we cannot love too much too soon
my head begins to spin
around and around and around and around again
ah
thank you all for coming out for this
benefit to support alternative views
frank morrow is going to introduce john stockwell
he was with the cia for about 15 years rose to the
rank equivalent to colonel spent time in vietnam
he also ran the angolan operation for the cia
but during this time he became quite disenchanted
with the butchery that was going on under the
auspices of the cia and the terrible things
were happening around the world he quit and
wrote a book about his experiences called in
search of enemies and john has been on network
tv 60 minutes he's been on alternative views
a lot he has visited grenada several times and
was personal friends with some of the people who
were shot by the short-lived grenadine government
thank you thank you very much i
yes this is a personal tragedy in a
slightly different way than some of
the others that i've seen but i think they're
all personal tragedies personal for all of us
the killing that goes on in the world and that
continues to go on in the world and that is
being done right now by our own government
on this latest trip i went to uh nicaragua
and toured around and saw the united states
new policy in nicaragua it's no secret it's
not really a covert action anymore the ci's
program there has shifted from trying to arm
and train the contrast to going in and establish
base camps from the north to a program of sheer
terrorism they've blown up an oil depot at
puerto corinto oil header at puerto sandino they
have dropped bombs on the airport they put a bomb
in the luggage of an airplane that was coming out
of miami to fly to managua it blew up not in
the air but after the plane landed in managua
and then from there greatly saddened by
this and greatly troubled at the prospect
that it won't work and therefore washington will
go the next step which will be to put u.s troops
into central america and to nicaragua which i
think is almost certain they will sooner or later
unless reagan by some miracle stumbles
stumbles and falters politically
but i left nicaragua to go to grenada
coincidentally when i was on the airplane i read
that bishop whom i was going to see
had been killed and i still was rather
planning to go ahead i knew bernard court
as well and so in strachan who survived
and phyllis court and the others but uh i got
to trinidad i was supposed to speak at a labor
conference there and i got uh very sick the flu
which is why i'm a little pale and picky tonight
and by the time i got on my feet a couple of days
later there was no question of going into grenada
deeply saddened but also watching the united
states troops land in grenada as john henry put
it into beautiful perspective but it led me to
think lying there with the flu and thinking and
thinking and thinking about the horrors of war
which i've seen a little bit i think i i first
began to reflect about war when i was a teenager
i began to read about war i thought it was fun
i studied caesar's conquest of gaul in the
original latin and read about alexander the great
incipio africanus and all of that and then i got
to be a marine and i thought the training was fun
and this is a theme that has interested me from
different perspectives more recently until today
is how the establishments of different countries
including this one particularly try to make and
with some success make war seem to be fun to the
young people who have to do the fighting and then
try to interest and get the support of the nation
that backs them up to make the war possible now
i found myself in 1962 standing off the mouth
of the congo as a young marine lieutenant
and we were briefed we were on the flight deck of
this aircraft carrier we had uh our weapons out
with ammunition in them to go in and it suddenly
occurred to me in the wee hours of the morning
kill africans and i remember thinking all of a
sudden it wasn't you know fantasizing killing
gooks we really would go in and kill africans to
accomplish whatever that mad little scheme was
i was greatly relieved that that mission was
cancelled i also stood off the dominican republic
off of cuba off of nicaragua while i was a marine
but always saved from having to go in and kill
but then i got out of the marine
corps into the cia and i saw
bits of wars different not world war ii big
wars but still the war in the congo uh the
vietnam war towards the end there were
certainly plenty of people being killed
uh the angolan war people being killed
and always i was struck by the young men
and trying to figure it out the young men that
were sent in to do the killing and to be killed
i began to notice that they are generally not
very enthusiastic about their role in these wars
now this is not true today my observation i think
in grenada those marines were pretty enthusiastic
but it was kind of they were told they were doing
a necessary thing and there's a lot of excitement
at that level and it wasn't buckling down and
fighting we're seeing some protests come from
the marines in lebanon now who are being asked to
sit there for a reason that i doubt if reagan or
anyone else could explain very clearly there's
no one for them to shoot back at which would
relieve their young man's uh you know reaction uh
not that that in my opinion would solve anything
but we're beginning to see their reaction to war
the soldier's reaction when he really gets into it
i saw this in vietnam 1973 to 75 when we'd
vietnamized the fighting these young vietnamese
18 year olds would be marched up to the foot
of this mountain near the tainan post where
i was and they would be ordered to charge the
communist forces up on the mountain and they
would take three steps forward and lie down and
wouldn't proceed because of course there they were
flagrantly aware of the fact that the generals and
colonels and majors and captains and lieutenants
and the president of the country and of course
many of the americans were involved in the aid
and military aid they were all corrupt they were
all making fortunes out of the war the only people
who weren't benefiting from it were the young
people who had to go and kill or be killed
now i reflected about this a lot the way you do if
you're stuck up country in a tainan and then the
scars that it'll leave later trying to figure out
war why do we have wars if the young people when
they get into them don't find them to be so much
fun i came to conclude that the greatest power the
most satisfying power there can be for power happy
people such as presidents of the united states
is not to send planes to bomb cambodia say
although that's power but that's a lesser power
the greatest satisfaction that a president of the
united states can have and one after the other has
done it or dreamed of doing it is to send our own
young people off to die and tell them that it's
noble and honorable and worthwhile that is power
sending your own people off to die this is what
reagan of course is is just since since before he
came into office dying for the opportunity to play
the role of commander sending the young people
off to die now they have a version of this of
course the height of politics i suggest to you is
when you bring the bodies back in the caskets and
you lay them out with the flags and the president
goes out arlington cemetery and you have all of
the television cameras in the world focusing on
his face while he reads this speech that he's
memorized and you catch the tear in his eye and
the drum and bugle core from the marine corps
about the noble sacrifice of this young man of
his life for his country but of course we see
we're more sophisticated than we
were a hundred years ago or before
uh we see that it isn't necessarily country
sometimes it's ego and whim of the people in power
exercising their power now i noticed that not
being a historian but reading the history of
this country we get into a war about every 10
years every one of these wars we have managed
we being our establishment our presidents and
politicians and business leaders have managed
to convince the people or at least has tried very
hard to convince them that the enemy was very evil
at one time you may or may not recall your reading
of history they sent general maxwell taylor down
here across what was the recognized border into
mexico and he paraded around until the mexicans
shot at him and then we had a provocation and
an incident and then the headlines beat the
drums until it was a noble thing to go and kill
mexicans in the mexican war as a result of that
war the united states stole new mexico and
california from from the mexican government
now in each of these wars the
indian war the spanish-american war
the philippine campaign world war one always
beating the drums convincing the people that
the enemy is totally evil now we've got a
new game we've been playing since world war
ii which is that communists are evil anything
that you can label as a communist is justified
to make war against them so we've had wars killing
communists where they don't exist by the way in
the touri forests of the congo in the wastelands
of angola in the jungles of southeast asia and now
we're invading grenada because of marxist
radicals those marxist radicals weren't killing
anybody there was a cabinet coup they killed they
assassinated the leader in his cabinet there was
no threat to anyone but it was justification
because there was some marxism involved
to invade which we've done now very briefly so
that i won't go out on a negative note altogether
the purpose of what i wanted to say to you tonight
was my reflections have not been totally in vain
i figured out how to stop wars now mind you
i thought about this a lot i thought about it
for years and i finally figured out how to stop
wars now what you have to do see the people in
power the people in the white house for example
the president even though he's sending american
people off to die he still is able to disassociate
himself from the people who go and die they're
not real human beings to him like his own family
they're people from austin texas or san antonio
or pocatello idaho or somewhere that they order to
be drafted and they or they suck into a glamorous
military program and they send them off to fight
and die now the way i figured it out in order to
stop wars we have to personalize wars so that the
man who signs the paper uh you know the order of
war so that the first person to die so it's
in his own family so it's real people who die
i thought about this a lot it's a little barbaric
but but then war is barbaric people get killed
and they die miserably and those who don't die
suffer the destabilizations and dislocations
and the loss of their own loved ones so
i figured out the way we could stop war
would be if we had a ceremony when the president
signs the act of war you would immediately take
you could construct a brick and concrete thing
in the white house lawn and and break out the
drum and bugle core and you take the president's
closest male kin and you shoot him immediately
now see obviously i mean i could visualize a
president really agonizing thinking about if
i sign this you know and but then i thought
about it by the time i developed this theory
jimmy carter was in power and his
closest male ken i believe was billy
and and my theory had some other
weaknesses in it which was that
after he's had one more to get rid of you remember
also lyndon johnson had sam houston johnson and
i mean you can see someone eager to get to
win the election to solve a personal problem
and then after they've had one more or two wars or
three wars and they run out of close mail can then
what's to stop them from having wars all over the
place after that after they paid their price so i
had to come up with a better theory and i did what
we need to do in order to stop wars permanently
is to redesign to make a law so that when the
president signs the act of war you take the
that big mall in washington below the
capitol in front of the white house all
the way down to the reflecting pool and you
put barbed wire around it and pup tents in it
and when they sign the act of war you take the
president the white house staff the congress the
state department the pentagon the cia all of them
and you run them in there and you put dungarees on
them and they sleep on the ground in pup tents
and they see rations as long as the war goes on
now i don't think that you wouldn't have to
kill a lot of them but to make it realistic just
every hour to a few mortars you know and it's just
you know just so that they realize what you know
what how much fun this really is and then just
just so that uh you won't have uh ronald reagan or
attila the hague uh thinking this sort of stuff
is fun when you when you when you run them through
this tent to take off their 700 suits and put
on the dungarees you have the doctors rub them
down with the jungle rot and you don't give
them any medicine until the war is resolved
um i swear based on my profound knowledge of men
in in action and elsewhere there would be no war
or international confrontation that couldn't
be resolved in about a day and a half time
there's still a few problems we would
have to do it in moscow and london
and tel aviv and buenos aires
my point however i hope is crystal clear i am
convinced there is not the slightest doubt in
my mind that our noble president and our noble
government in washington will manipulate us into
a war they're doing everything they possibly
can the historical cycles are crystal clear
and as john henry said a while ago indirectly
but saying the same thing the only thing that
will stop us is ourselves it's not ronald reagan's
country it's a little bit his a little bit yours a
little bit mine if we want to be part of a war if
we want to be ordered if we're young to go off and
kill and be killed if we're not quite so young to
have our loved ones sent off to kill and be killed
then we have to work we have to organize we have
to speak we have to make enough pressure felt
right now in order to stop them from the course
they've committed themselves to or we will be
at war in central america most likely in the very
near future thank you very much for hearing me out
dear washington and moscow we know you've got
the know-how to destroy this world with our
vast technology we're turning back the page now to
death valley days now but this time the narrator
isn't playing make-believe we've got better things
to do than to blow this world into there's a
better way to die than to leave nothing
behind there's a better life to live
living truths easy to give let's don't blow
this world into we've got better things to do
the western world is trembling reporting how
the kremlin used chemical warfare in afghanistan
we're quick to say they did it but we will not
admit it that agent orange and napalm did the same
in vietnam and we escalate the arms
race till everyone's in last place
and everyone's the loser to the same mentalities
we've got better things to do than to blow
this world into there's a better way to die than
to leave nothing behind as a better life to live
living truths easy to give let's don't blow
this world in two we've got better things to do
bye
people the world over in ours and other
lands gather like we have today to focus
our demands we see it and we feel
it in our minds and in our hearts
this menace we've created we must tear apart but
we've got families to raise other progress to be
made other stories to be told other
people to grow old other sunrises to see
inner secrets to set free other poetry
to write autumn leaves and summer nights
other libraries to fill higher meaning to instill
other mountains left to climb other rivers left to
ride other thoughts to be relayed other music to
be made we've got better things to do than to blow
this world into there's a better way to die then
to leave so little behind there's a better life to
live living fruits easy to give let's don't blow
this world into we've got better things to do
fred glitz was on the witness stand
he was being tried for murder his
lawyer told him to reenact the crime fred
killed the judge the jury found him guilty
foreign
food
do
is
so
in this alternative views we give you information
about nicaragua before the 1990 elections for
example i asked one of the military leaders
who was briefing me about the state of the war
and uh i asked him about what if president
reagan fabricates finds or fabricates some
excuse and puts in a large body of united
states marines to take managua and i was
a little apprehensive that i would get the macho
reaction that i'd gotten from maurice bishop when
i said the same question to him and he'd say
they won't win you donated in grenada yes uh
they uh this guy smiled and he said well they'll
they'll take an empty city it'll be deserted we're
not going to stand up and fight them head on and
and have maybe 20 or 50 000 people killed he said
uh we'll fade right back into the jungle that's
the world we know we know and are very good at
that kind of fighting and we'll send home 10 or
15 or 20 dead u.s soldiers every week and see
how president reagan likes that after a week a
month a year four years ten years and uh and i i
immediately sat back and said these people will
win that's the kind of patience the vietnamese
had the cia had its grenada desk working its
grenada task force working since carter um
the destabilization the terrorism the economic war
planning training of people in venezuela and in
this country are all was going on they had someone
a case officer amongst the medical students and he
had the radio and the frequencies to talk to the
people at ship at sea so obviously that was all
planned well ahead of time john stockwell was in
the cia for 15 years and ran the angola operation
for the agency john has made several trips in
the past couple of years to nicaragua and grenada
we'll talk extensively with john tonight
about those two countries on alternative views
wow
although the nicaraguan situation has changed
greatly since 1984 when this program is made
john's information is important john stockwell
is with us again today to talk about the cia and
some of his recent experiences in nicaragua and
cuba john is the author of a book in search of
enemies that details the cia's role in angola he
was the head of that operation resigned afterward
and since has become one of the foremost critics
of the cia in american foreign policy so john
welcome again to alternative youth over the
past few years maybe a handful or even less
that the cia has been more upfront in putting
out propaganda and in starting disinformation
efforts around the world that eventually
get back and then are believed by the
by the american people things like the all the
attempted assassination of the pope and the hit
squads that we're going to hit take out reagan
and others which are eventually always proved
to be shear balderdash but the people remember
them and the media keep uh keep them stirred up
and keep going clear sterling and also the every
so often they'll publish cia studies of certain
types to justify whatever well a lot of what
you're referring to is uh the difference between
president reagan and carter and ford and nixon in
the vietnam era in the mid 70s when the cia and
the national security complex was on the defensive
under reagan it's gone back more to the days of uh
of john foster dulles and alan dulles when the
cia was very very aggressive and very upfront
now the cia well in angola we were desperately
hiding what we were doing we were we were
literally terrified that the public would find
out and we would be exposed and investigated
under president reagan what he's doing in
nicaragua so very much parallels what we were
doing in angola but they're bragging about it they
they haven't exactly published a prospectus of the
the nicaraguan operation but they talk about
it quite openly if you if you ask as they have
president reagan in press conferences saying
uh isn't this a violation of the bullying
amendment that you're you're you say you're
in there to interdict arms and in fact the
the contras are trying to overthrow
the government and he just laughs at
the camera and says and what if we are what's
wrong with that in fact there's been several
admissions by both the state department and
reagan administration that the cia has been
active in trying to destabilize and overthrow the
sandinista government can you give some sense of
the scope of the operation of the cia operation
in nicaragua and how is an operation like this
funded where does the money come from how much you
think goes into an operation like this and is it
accountable to anyone either to congress
or the president this kind of cia operation
well the the scope of it is vast in
terms of the nicaraguan's interest
the essential funds are approved by the senate
oversight committees and the house oversight
committees they got 19 million dollars they
the cia in december of 1981 and then recently
this fall they got another 19 million dollars
this winter so the senate and the congress is
has complicity absolutely absolutely they have
approved not just the cia is a rogue elephant
that's off on its own adventure but it's
carrying out a policy formulated by the reagan
administration and supported by congress the
policy of the congress with some dissension but
the policy of the congress is that covert action
is a legitimate tool of u.s foreign policy
and there have been other administrations
other eras in which they would not make such a
statement but now they say we are not involved in
overthrowing the government of suriname although
in principle we have nothing against it however
this 38 million dollars that they've allocated so
far would not include man-hours spent by the ci
for example it would not include the office and
warehousing costs of the ci's overhead for example
so it would be many times that's just hardware
essentially and cash paid for airplanes and bombs
so it would just the ci's costs would be much
vaster then you have the entire u.s diplomatic
umbrella working against the nicaraguans in terms
of diplomacy and propaganda and trying to shut
off aid and make them look bad pulling strings
in newspapers all over central america all
over the world actually to make them look bad
then you have the build up of central
america militarily and where we're spending
literally hundreds of millions of dollars
in in honduras and el salvador in guatemala
what is the magnitude of this operation with well
all of these uh are all of these are building up
uh us military presence in central america
in order to put greater pressure on nicaragua
and the threat of invasion it's all it's all
political ultimately and then you have these
operation uh big pine one and big pine two where
the entire u.s fleet is down there with 5 000
marines so all together it's hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars a billion dollars or so
is being spent to to destabilize nicaragua
essentially and restore central america to the
the eagles talons to the control of the united
states is this even a viable option in other words
can they even spending a billion dollars overthrow
the nicaragua government or does it have popular
support of its people that would make it literally
impossible for an operation like this to succeed
my assessment and and most of the people who
are working on the subject seem to agree with me
is that the united states is not even close to
being able to dream of successfully overthrowing
sandinistas what their philosophy now is of course
looking always for the opportunity for a military
solution put in u.s troops and stomp them out of
existence but even that probably wouldn't work
their fallback position is just to try
to draw a military line across honduras
and make central america into an
armed u.s camp their their terror is
justified from their interest the the capitalist
interests as they control the people of the world
uh the the san diego the nicaraguan experiment is
so successful the principle of giving the people
a piece of the pie and an interest in what's going
on and building schools for them and feeding them
is dynamite people like that educating them health
benefits all these things democracy at the local
jobs and stopping killing them as as is being
done in salvador and guatemala and honduras now
president reagan is quite right when he says this
is you know the creeping virus yes this is the
sort of thing that people in honduras and salvador
and guatemala watch happening right across the
border in mexico and it's quite possible they
might say hey what's wrong with that and we
need a little bit of that and we're tired of being
killed and we're tired of being starved and we're
tired of being kept poor so it is very threatening
to central america as the united states would like
to keep central america and in addition to this
it's economically successful nicaraguan eyes
according to the people we've had on as the most
stable economy and also is the only one not in
default of its loans so it's working from every
aspect and internally despite the destabilization
of five percent uh economic growth last year which
was the highest in in the all of latin america
higher than you know the brazil's and argentina's
and mexico's and chile's and it is nicaragua
in the united states and this is despite despite
the destabilization in the war and the answer
yes it is incredible and the answer is very simply
what can be accomplished when you harness the
enthusiasm and energies of an entire people john
in fact you have visited nicaragua a couple times
in the last year what are some of your experiences
there and some of the things you observed
as to what they're doing in the system well i
i was there just uh just this last january and
looking around for a couple of weeks picking a
little cotton with one of the brigades talking
to as many people as i could and definitely
picking up a sense of enthusiasm now they had just
survived the the december threat in which the ci's
plan had been to cut off the little town of halapa
and set up a provisional government which would
invite in us troops so they were that close
uh to having a u.s military intervention
into nicaragua in december and the contras
simply didn't have it and the nicaraguans
definitely did have it to defend themselves
even though that little place is way up on the
border and it's kind of surrounded on three sides
they had they had survived that threat and uh
they had correspondingly a strong sense of uh
of optimism uh to the point where they were almost
checking themselves against too much over-optimism
uh i was impressed at with with the realism
and the depth of their assessment of the threat
against them and their kept their capabilities i
was also the little things that one looks for in
running an assessment beyond all of the figures
that you try to garner in briefings and whatnot
it's been four years but they're still fit
comandante gets up and goes across the office
and he may kind of spring and leap through he's
still got spring in his his legs from all of the
the years in the mountains and they jog and
they're keeping with with one exception of
all the people i've met they're keeping their
weight down they're in short they're ready to
go back to the mountains instantly if they have
to if the u.s invades they're in a war situation
and they have not gotten fat with success and
at the same time they are not the least bit
uh foolish about the threat and for example i
asked one of the military leaders who was briefing
me about the state of the war and i asked him
about what if president reagan fabricates finds
or fabricates some excuse and puts in a large
body of united states marines to take managua
and i was a little apprehensive that i would get
the macho reaction that i'd gotten from maurice
bishop when i said the same question to him and
he'd say they won't win you donated in grenada yes
they this guy smiled and he said well they'll
they'll take an empty city it'll be deserted we're
not going to stand up and fight them head on and
and have maybe 20 or 50 000 people killed he said
uh we'll fade right back into the jungle that's
the world we know we know and are very good at
that kind of fighting and we'll send home 10 or
15 or 20 dead us soldiers every week and see how
president reagan likes that after a week a month
a year four years 10 years and and i i immediately
sat back and said these people will win that's the
kind of patience the vietnamese had and realism
they know they can't go head-on against the us
military might but with that kind of determination
they cannot be beaten they also have the
experience of having fought against samosa
using similar guerrilla tactics for many
years for 130 years against a system
that would be what would happen then if there was
a us invasion do you foresee the possibility that
there might be an invasion of nicaragua under what
condition do you think reagan might be tempted
to actually send american troops to invade
nicaragua as he did with grenada well you
think they just use the foreign troops
that they've tried to whip up before
argentina's out of it and the
foreign troops can't cut it
they've tried to work up scenarios
where they could get honduras to
invade nicaragua or some such but
honduras doesn't have the energy in its
armed forces or in its military posture to
actually do something like that guatemala
these things are possible but it would be you
know this was a scenario in grenada where they
got seven other countries to to invite them
in they they asked them to invite them in
i'll put in put in honduran troops and then maybe
you know they're getting shellacked and then put
in u.s troops to back them up um there is a chance
it's just possible that nicaragua will survive
without a u.s military intervention the the
the concern on the other side getting back
to the thomas powers observation an axiom of the
intelligence business that we've mentioned before
is that to understand what a country is going to
do you look at its history its historical cycles
what is the country's personality and this country
has had all of these 200 and some odd military
interventions in other countries affairs plus a
big war every 10 years it is predictable that the
united states will get itself into a major vietnam
size war at least within the next few years
and the question is only where they
were flirting with it in the middle east
and pulled back because it was not fightable it
was not viable the u.s supply lines were too long
the situation was too complicated the israelis
syria the russian supply lines were short no no
good guys they could identify you know good guys
in quotes they could identify with and all of that
they just couldn't make it there central america
tempts them greatly because they have such control
they control the ocean and the gulf of mexico on
one side and they own honduras to the north and
they have great influence with costa rica to the
south so they could isolate it the russians could
be blockaded out of it altogether and they would
have no supply lines uh however and and and reagan
everything about his international posture since
he came into office has been flirting with war
eager to show off the macho the cowboy you know
wanting to play with his six guns the the united
states people however have not forgotten vietnam
so there's some resistance and he with the
elections coming he's actually backpedaling
somewhat he doesn't want to look quite so
militaristic the two dangers i see offhand
are that if he's trailing for example if hart
his momentum continues and he gets the democratic
nomination and his momentum is still continuing
and reagan is looking like he's in trouble right
before the elections well you have to remember
as has happened many times in our history but
1972 nixon is trailing mcgovern and he begins
to bomb hanoi again and his popularity jumps up
the instant reaction to the invasion of grenada
people not understanding what's going on and just
liking some kind of action that might be the the
string that reagan would pull if he's in trouble
in the elections has put troops into nicaragua
if not once he's elected then he has more or less
nothing to lose personally he's got four years
to get his war going somewhere and we
will have uh a serious risk of war now
the the further thing though that might save
central america from a u.s war nicaragua from
a u.s invasion is that to to put it mildly it
would not be a popular thing to do in terms of
latin america of the other countries nicaragua has
run up a large debt four point it seems to be the
vogue so have we you know 4.2 billion or something
like that it's rather large for a small country
all of the talk about a debtor's cartel if
the u.s invaded a country that was doing well
a country that was not by any stretch of
exaggeration evil it wasn't invading other
countries it wasn't abusing other peoples of
the world if the united states invaded and
began to kill and drop agent orange and all the
nice things that it did in vietnam for example
it just might provoke that debtors cartel in
which all of the countries of latin america would
suddenly gleefully say we don't think we want to
pay back any more money in which case the western
banking world would collapse and these bankers
sitting up there in new york realizing that people
are having meetings today to talk about a debtor's
cartel they have a negative power a very powerful
resource here of just refusing to pay their debts
if they could all agree and get together on it
this is threatening enough that the people in
new york might just put the phone calls through
to reagan and his advisors and say we just don't
think you should do that and that might ultimately
save central america from a war and there
another factor too i've read on several occasions
that there is very much opposite a great
deal of opposition and the joint chiefs and
staffs and some of the high military marketing
mucks against getting involved down there in
nicaragua well they don't want an unpopular
war and of course their books coming out
they're very upfront you don't have to nobody
from our side of this thing has to make up
anything these people are quite straightforward
in expressing their ambitions and desires
they're they're running studies and publishing
books on the necessity of preparing the american
people for the next war and their concern with
central america is that the american people are
not only not adequately prepared they're pretty
vigilantly uh clearly stirring in their resistance
to what is being done already much less a war in
invasion there's a lot of resistance to the to
the operation in lebanon within the military they
don't they too have not forgotten vietnam for all
of the fact that everybody in the administration
they're all saying you know central america is not
vietnam they don't want to get into another
unpopular war that would have uh all of the
demonstrations and all of the rotc's closed down
a situation burned down and and a situation where
no one from the pentagon or the state department
or the cia would dare set foot on any campus in
the nation uh these are things and they remember
and these are things they would like to avoid so
the next war and they're they're quite eager for
one they feel that the american people would buy
such a war would accept it if it were clean and
neat like grenada let's talk about grenada john
grenados is on the flip side of nicaragua they
didn't say what actually happened there was no
um admission of overt activities that were going
there and yet uh recently it's it's coming out
particularly if you happen to read the covert
action information bulletin that there was a very
elaborate complex plot against grenada which had
been going on for well ever since the maurice
bishop took over and it looked to me that there
were oh you might say five aspects of this overall
situation one was a propaganda putting things in
the paper about how it was dangerous down there
don't go down there and and visit grenada
because grenada depends a lot on tourism
there was a terrorism blowing up uh setting off
bombs and public meetings and some setting fires
and some other aspects of sure sheer terrorism
economic destabilization the us not cooperating
with multilateral financial organizations to
help out grenada when grenada needed loans
and then of course there was the military in the
political aspects too you've been following this
and you also read that covert action information
bolton are things kind of beginning to fall into
place as to in terms of our knowledge of what
happened yes yes indeed the the destabilization we
were already tracking that uh and you recall our
show here on alternative views last march in which
we predicted uh that grenada would be invaded and
as a matter of fact i was in grenada in september
talking to maurice bishop at some length and uh
and i warned him that that he would be invaded
the the indicators were all there and then
we've got lots of details coming out now
details like the one of the medical students
was a cia case officer complete with radio
and frequencies to talk to the people out on
the ships details like conversations that this
infamous major austin had with us officials before
he and bernard court moved to kill bishop and
and create the crisis which reagan used as an
excuse to move in well that's a new one i haven't
heard never read about that you say that uh austin
and cord were actually in communication with the
u.s well this is cia or the state department just
hudson austin not cord uh court i don't believe
was in contact with u.s officials but he and cord
moved against bishop austin was in at least its
confirmed diplomatic contact with u.s officials
and uh there's there's an indication that he was
also in contact with the cia now we probably will
not know because the cia's records won't be made
public no one will be permitted because of the
new laws to write a book like mine about what
what happened in grenada like i wrote about what
happened in angola but exactly what the cia was
telling austin we won't know what did did they
tell him to get rid of bishop and and offer him uh
inducements and encourage him to take over
power did they have it planned to the point of
of specifying the date or was that a coincidence
and if they did that they've sold him out because
he's now in prison now they may have dangled him
they may have dangled him with encouragement and
he had the feeling well if i just take over the us
is you know would be very appreciative in fact as
soon as austin took over after bishop was killed
he declared that grenada should develop more
private enterprise have closer relations to the
united states which is more of a right-wing agenda
oh yeah and a left-wing agenda austin was the
kind of guy that the united states traditionally
loves up on in the third world countries a
military-heavy right-wing military-heavy uh free
enterprise relations with the united states for
sure and killing off your enemies that's that's
you know the shah mobutu marco samosa all the cia
all of the ci did you ever meet him now you met
and talked with a lot of high officials in grenada
yeah i knew a number of the 16 that were killed
we talked about jacqueline kreff the minister of
education who was one of the ones that was shot
and bishop in court i knew quite well in phyllis
cord i did not meet austin i hesitate a little
bit because i was there speaking three or four
years ago and he may have been at one of the
speeches and but i i never sat down with him and
talked i i don't i don't remember visiting with
him what about the chords now they were portrayed
in the press and on tv as being hardcore leftists
particularly mrs card they both were uh i
i talked to them at length and they were
they were pretty determined people
bernard told me that he became a committed
marxist uh when he was nine years old
he figured this when he got his first
he figured this all out and the exploitation
of the people and he decided that it was not
possible to work for the benefit of the people
through uh the capitalist system and that a
revolution would be necessary when he was nine
he told me and he proceeded to arm himself with
education and get his phd in finance so that he
would be better qualified uh well now he sounds
like somebody who would be more close to bishop
and be more compatible as far as the ideas and
goals are concerned but not with austin so how
did that hooked up well this is something i've
hedged in all of the analysis i haven't seen
anything that positively proved that cord and
austin were together in the killing of bishop cord
was moving against bishop and this is documented
trying he was concerned that bishop was not moving
the country in the direction of nationalization of
property of of of socialism and bishop was also
flirting with the united states and cord was
moving against bishop demanding that he turn over
the economic portfolio from bishop turn it over to
cord and the party so the cord could complete the
revolution and then uh he kept challenging bishop
the pressure mounted in september and october now
then bishop was put under house arrest then the
people mobbed up the hill and released him and
then he led them up the hill to confront austin
and austin killed bishop and everybody in the
government all of the members of the cabinet
except cord now was cord on the telephone with
austin right before the killing saying well we
better kill him you know it's we can't we
can't cope or was cord hiding for his life
now he wouldn't march up the hill with bishop
because he had led a move against bishop at first
not saying the bishop should should resign but
that he should just relinquish more power to court
it may very well be that cord was when when the
guns were going off and bishop was dying that cord
and phyllis were down in town uh deeply concerned
about their own safety and that austin was going
to come after them next and then he was acting
alone possibly with the c.i.a behind him austin
was acting alone yes uh or with some you know
his military and with the cia encouraging him
it's also possible that some kind of a deal was
cut and that austin was uh talking to court on the
phone and cord was saying well you better waste
them however the statements that austin was making
after he took power i was in trinidad at the
time i'd been on my way to grenada and then
this all erupted and i couldn't get back
in so i was following it on the radio and
newspapers as closely as i could and talking
to people who were telephoning into grenada
court didn't make any statements in those
days those four days or five days after
bishop's death before the invasion he
didn't make a single public statement
and the statements that austin was making did
not sound the least little bit like cord they
sounded right-wing and cord was was an absolutely
committed left winger so i still think it's quite
possible that cord was not in cahoots with austin
and that in that takeover so it was a right-wing
coup d'etat in grenada that alienated the
government from the people which made it so easy
for the americans to invade because there wasn't
popular support any longer for the system because
the people were behind bishop who was killed
in his movement and not austin and the generals
let's go back if we can kind of unravel
this plot it looks like from now
you've read that covert action information
bulletin story and i think you have two done
one of the problems that the media always face
in the united states is simplicity they operate
on a simplistic basis they don't take time to to
try to tell a story that is complex and so as a
result we get uh you know very sugar-coated
and simplistic picture and when something
like this which is very complex taste takes
place the media don't have any stomach for it
but this seems to me an extremely complex
operation you have first of all economic uh
operation not even where we talked
about the economic while to go but
you have the political aspects which uh started
apparently back during the carter administration
and which involved the woman what's
her name who was the ambassador to the
had met uh bishop on grenada and also had
left a representative there who had had some
perhaps relationships with the cia and the state
department but they started along with the people
who started and headed up the medical school they
started nurturing relationships with austin and
cord and they were apparently part of the wedge
to get in between them and as well as bishop and
then promising apparently support if they would
overthrow bishop well in the meantime then there
was this military planning and operation going
on uh particularly we saw it starting with the
reagan administration where the u.s navy started
practicing uh invasions mock invasions of grenada
and where they had paratroopers practicing on
the airstrips in the united states in just such
a situation as would come up in grenada well then
the strange thing that we saw on television then
when the grenada invasion took place was that
sally shelton and the people from the who had
the medical school were on television saying hey
why don't you give austin and cord some time we
think they're good guys they've told us that
they want relationships with the united states
as doug said they want private enterprise and
let the u.s corporations back in they promised
they wouldn't hurt the medical good schools with
this given time don't go in there and do this
and then after they were called back uh sally
shelton and the people the medical school were
called back for briefings at the cia and the
state department suddenly they came out and
said oh well we agree with everything everything
is okay to start out with now do you think that
this was all one big elaborate plot a masterminded
perhaps by the cia or do you think that there were
do you think there were two separate plots going
on and if plot b didn't work then plot a if plot a
didn't work then plot b would be uh implemented
the military means or do you think that plot a
with sally shelton and all was just a ploy to set
up cord and he would be the patsy and give give
the reagan and the people the excuse to come in
and take over i do you recall the the footnote in
my book in search of enemies where i point out
that there is no m as in james bond no mastermind
running these things who plans
things and sets them in motion and
and six months later the whip cracks
exactly the place you want it to crack
ambassador shirley temple black's analogy that
the united states is not chess playing it's it's
poker play you take the the hens that are dealt
and you play your cards and then you take up the
next 10 and play it i think we have a series of
hens that are being played here and improvising
i think there was a continuity of ci
effort against grenada that's documented
there was a plan and rehearsal for an
invasion they had an invasion ready
uh the ambarine islands exercises 18 months before
as in the grenadine islands i mean it was it was
exactly uh what was eventually done to rescue to
rescue americans exactly uh president reagan's two
statements on public television that that grenada
was a threat to our national security well now
come on you know this tiny little place out of all
the four billion people in the world why it would
be named unless they were preparing the people
of the united states for an invasion okay these
things come together and you have the invasion at
that weekend whatever the date was in october now
i do not necessarily conclude that the ci
planned the whole thing for exactly that date
i rather have the feeling that they
stir up the pot enough and things happen
uh they stir up the pot enough and bernard bernard
cord moves against bishop so you have a crisis
you have them fighting amongst themselves then as
happens time after time throughout the third world
the the civilian leaders begin to
squabble and the military steps in
and this is why i still suspect or wonder if
cord and austin perhaps had nothing to do with
each other no plan whatsoever to work together
that that court is moving against bishop and the
government is falling apart and austin steps in
with a very heavy hand and also he disarmed the
people's militia and disarmed the militia now the
united states picked exactly that time to invade
why they there is no if there were any
honesty in what washington does and says they
you know they couldn't possibly invade they were
lying as is usual in dealing with cover stories
president reagan lied extensively on television
about it so did schultz and the others they
invaded i mean the coincidence is absolutely
overpowering that was the week that the bodies
were coming home from beirut the 241 marines
that was the time of the crisis that was when
the united states was focusing on the bankruptcy
of his policies president reagan's policies
in the middle east and we had these young marines
as evidence and they were being brought back and
all of the television cameras in the world were
going to be interviewing people about the horror
of us lives being lost in the middle east and
suddenly wham a big dramatic invasion of grenada
and and people are talking about that a lot more
than they are about the marines instead of people
being horrified young americans are flocking down
to join the marines because it looked like so much
fun what was done in grenada and they were not
focusing so much on what happened in lebanon
this to me is the explanation of the timing
reagan said it was to protect the medical
students it wasn't they weren't in danger
the government there had a curfew on as
is traditional anywhere in the world that there is
a change in government and upheaval new government
comes in and puts in a curfew to calm things
down until they can sort it out and get people
going back to work normally and then relax it
gradually if anything the curfew was to protect
the tourists and medical students there not as a
threat to anyone and they had said they were going
to protect them they had said that publicly and
they had said it to the head of the medical school
the the reagan administration said that there were
cuban brigades there were not there were engineers
who were working on that on that airport for a
project which margaret thatcher had helped finance
none of their rationales and explanations were
true and honest so you look for the reason why
they were not overthrowing a marxist dictatorship
because bishop had been killed austin was in power
and he was a a military man the kind that they're
they're so comfortable with normally so the
reason was to serve the timing of their their own
political problems and interests back here in this
country and it was a brilliant operation for that
it was it was so neat because grenada is so small
that that they could smother it militarily
even then you notice that they got in trouble
because the cuban engineers pulled
out their aks and fought back
and so you recall that the the white house
and the pentagon were saying that there was a
half a cuban brigade there they were fighting
so so hard and it turned out in the end they
were exactly the number of cubans that fidel had
said there were there were some all engineers and
they were all engineers except for a few security
guards and uh just exactly as the cubans had said
there wasn't that general in the kernel
and all that and the brigade and all of
that nor did the cubans attack the u.s forces
by the way and this is a very significant point
we landed our helicopters and the parachutist
landed the cubans could have killed hundreds
of them in the air and shot down helicopters as
they were coming in and parachutists as they're
coming down they didn't they didn't fire a
shot until the u.s troops were on the ground
regrouped and assaulted the cubans and then the
cubans fired back and put up one hell of a fight
uh what was the total number of dead aside from
bishop and his cabinet being killed there were a
couple of hundred people killed in the in the
invasion so president reagan wasted a couple
hundred people's lives because he was embarrassed
with a couple hundred people being killed in in
beirut but also this was the opportunity they had
been looking for obviously this had been planned
and was part of an overall destabilization plan
that had been in effect for years and they said
that the aircraft carrier had been diverted from
lebanon down to as if hey fellas once you take
a side trip down there to grenada we got a little
bit of work for you but something like that takes
a lot of planning a lot of specialized training
and those specialized people have to be on board
and ready to go it isn't something you can just
snap their fingers but remember the principle that
reagan and his type of leadership they're hawks
they want military solutions he wants to show
off the fleet show off u.s might he wants to go in
the history books as having invaded here and put
the marines in there he likes this image the point
is that the destabilization apparently was working
bishop had been overthrown major austin was in
power and he was talking to former u.s ambassadors
and every indication was they could have
gotten everything they wanted politically
without any military invasion they'd
won the destabilization had succeeded
they now had the marxist dictatorship overthrown
and and had a a capitalist uh the grounds of a
capitalist democracy or whatever you call it as
in guatemala and el salvador in the makings and
all they had to do to avoid adverse publicity is
just to sit quietly and establish relations with
austin and his new government and and uh and work
from there they wanted a military show and they
wanted it for two reasons again president reagan
the hawk doing his thing with his six guns and and
and the other one of course was to distract
the people from the middle east well what about
the cia during all this why do you suppose they
were what was their involvement in this this is
something that occurred over two administrations
so there was some continuity involved
oh yes the cia had its grenada desk working its
grenada task force working since carter and um
the destabilization the terrorism the economic
war planning training of people in venezuela
and in this country are always going on
they had someone a case officer amongst
the medical students and he had the radio and
the frequencies to talk to the people that ship
at sea so obviously that was
all planned well ahead of time
they have been faulted to a certain extent for
not having adequate intelligence about the island
uh a soldier mental institution bombed a hospital
yeah bombed a hospital uh because they didn't know
allegedly didn't know that it was a hospital and
uh the soldiers driving around the island with
tourist maps trying to find their way here and
there as they as they did their raids and because
they hadn't printed up enough us government
maps and whatnot i i intelligence services
like in certain situations to be caught out uh
they get their budget jacked up every time they
have a failure you know they say well you know
you were you were leaning on us in the mid 70s and
here we have a coup that might never have happened
if we'd had enough men power and then we have a
destabilization you know our program is successful
they say that quietly or they don't say that but
but then publicly you know they say we didn't have
adequate intelligence coverage because our budget
has been cut and our people have been demoralized
and this is a classic example yeah talking with
people who are intimately familiar and lived and
worked in grenada they said there was absolutely
no security it was the most laid-back place in
the world you can just walk into any government
building and you can have a bomb and go up
and knock on maurice bishop's door say hi
that's pretty pretty much true except for for
his own house his own quarters up on the mountain
uh which did have some guards but the rest
of the island was yeah there was it was not
a military state there were no sub-bases there
were no missile bases there was no terrorist
training camps they loved tourists and tourists
were all over the island and it was you know it
was another shabby chapter in u.s history it
was another case in which the u.s president is
willing to waste the lives of young americans
for his own political ploys to show his macho
and once again i'm reminded of my my own feelings
which developed when i was fairly young of of
admiration and preference for the greek uh
leadership when they declared war they led the
troops and uh you know they also had a public vote
as to whether they wanted warning athens at least
in thucydides history of the peloponnesian wars
they're always having debates should we go to war
or not public debates yes and then they led you
know they they picked up their spear and shield
and and led the way into into combat and uh these
guys in the you know the luxury and comfort of the
white house with their seven hundred dollar suits
eating on thousand dollar plates it's awfully fun
to wave your hand and send the fleet in and and
only 200 people died you know so it was a great
brilliant operation the cynicism of this kind of
leadership and then having the gall to stand up
after you know that plus nicaragua and the
other places where they're killing people
i've i've been as i say recently to nicaragua and
put my hand on the nubs of the missing limbs of
maimed children and talked to with an interpreter
because i don't have spanish to women who had been
gang-raped by by contras who were trained in
florida by the cia and uh you know we don't we
don't have our faces rubbed in it the media
doesn't cover it very much so we have this
plausible denial to our own consciences but you go
and look at that and then you consider president
reagan having the gall to go on television and
call the soviet union and evil society i don't
know how else you could define evil other than
what president reagan is doing in nicaragua today
i have to point out and i'm sure everyone in
this country in the world has observed this
and is aware of it president reagan is doing
this thing destabilizing nicaragua because
of the communist threat the creeping
virus of communism and communism is so
evil and yet he's making a big watch the coverage
he's going to give to his trip to communist china
next month and he's approved the sale of 10
billion dollars of grain to communist russia plus
all of the billions of dollars of of strategic oil
field drilling equipment and whatnot to communist
russia and uh the hypocrisy the principle is that
you know big communists are more or less okay
you can talk to them but you don't do anything
against them because they can hit back
or you need them but little non-communists who are
doing humanitarian things in nicaragua or cuba are
evil there was an article on the catholic reporter
recently which it said after looking at the u.s
media coverage and also the manipulation of it by
the white house and the state department that the
way is handled is that the grenadines disappeared
it was cuba it was russia that we were fighting
there weren't any grenadines down there and
so when you do that you can do that anywhere
it can be nicaragua it can be any place in
africa and you're still fighting the same
people so that's an even fight if you're fighting
the nasty communists from russia and cuba but you
can just it's it's a crypto thing you can just
label it anything you want and go in anywhere
yeah yeah but what about this claim in fact
that in grenada there were all these cuban
armed supplies there the grenade was going to be
used as a base to export revolution throughout the
caribbean that there was some sort of secret
treaties between grenada and the soviet union
how would you address these claims at the reagan
administration well of course there were secret
treaties between grenada and the soviet union
every country in the world has secret treaties
with other countries and the soviet union
is one of the major powers in the world
they were economic treaties and there was there
was agreements to provide to obtain from the
soviet union a certain amount of arms bishop
had an announced policy to create a militia of
twenty thousand and they found in the warehouse
they the us marines found in the warehouses
ten thousand arms many of which were obsolete some
of them dating back to world war one much less
world war ii so he had about half the amount of
arms that he had projected to create his militia
as i say in september i asked him if he had in
fact created his militia and delivered the arms to
him because you recall at the time of the bay of
pigs this was the great gesture when fidel opened
the warehouses and gave the cuban people weapons
and then nicaragua they've armed the people
and i asked bishop if he had done this or not
and in fact he hadn't because when the invasion
happened the arms were still in the warehouse and
only half of what he needed and there were not
there simply wasn't the weaponry there to suggest
any remote possibility of aggressive action and
it's a propaganda war these people in washington
are playing they're not interested in the truth
so they fly the weapons back up to washington
and george bush parades around inspecting them
and you get some headlines out of it and he makes
a statement saying you know this is proof that
what we did was right it's proof of exactly the
opposite to any analyst of the thing well john do
you think the world is considerably more dangerous
and frightening place than it was three and a half
four years ago every day every day the clock ticks
to the closer to the hour of midnight every day
they're building more bombs every day they're
selling more weapons to everybody in the world
every day they are taking actions that are making
more and more people angry at each other and angry
at us and uh that without any we are sitting on
a powder keg of these these 52 000 atom bombs
and president reagan plans to build 60 and deploy
16 000 more bombs they will not permit anything
to be said or signed in geneva that will in fact
stop that because there's so much money involved
if we build 16 000 more the russians will build
uh 19 000 more and by the time mr reagan is out
of office when he's re-elected there will be
90 000 bombs in the world instead of 52 000 now
at that time they're not going to shut down the
industry because there's too much money involved
shutting down the nuclear industry and i don't
mean for for electricity the bomb producing the
bomb making industry would be like closing down
detroit you don't make cars and then stop making
cars you keep on making them by by by five
years from now we will be so saturated with
atomic weapons that there won't be anywhere to
put any more missiles and so they're not going
to shut down the industry though they're going
up into space instead of a 450 billion dollar
program then they'll have a three trillion
dollar program to have laser platforms and
nuclear platforms writing in space that's exactly
what reagan announced in his state of the union
oh yes oh yes i'm i'm not making up anything
nor is anyone else this is what they are
publicly projecting now at the same time you
recall after the day after was shown schultz
looked right at the camera and lied as they always
do he said we're cutting back we're reducing
they're not cutting back anything they're pulling
back a thousand tactical useless weapons in europe
pulling them back but they're replacing them with
other strategic weapons they're adding 55 000 more
more than 50 more than 50 more of what they have
in strategic weapons and they're building a total
of sixteen thousand seventeen thousand i think
the figure published in washington is well as
people have told us from various countries around
the world not only us here but also read about it
the only people who can stop world war iii
and all these interventions around the world
or the united states people in fact john how
do you think that this trend can be reversed
that's so frightening towards his arms build up
and trend towards war i've thought about this
endlessly and i lecture about it often and
and discuss it everywhere i go i had a long
conversation with maurice bishop on this subject
for example and he commented that it was almost
a shame that we hadn't had the nuclear war in the
50s when there were only 400 smaller bombs because
now and he said how do you think it makes
us feel down here that we will be wasted and
everyone else in the world because of the madness
of people in in washington and moscow and london
i personally would say that there
is about one chance in a million
that us sitting here in this room will not
see uh nuclear weapons going off in our lives
the human beast is just as aggressive the dumb
one of the strongest social uh instincts of
the human animal uh is is the hatfields and
mccoys it's the polarization and paranoia and
hostility and this led to the clans having this
integrity and protecting themselves that led to
this species growing when it was physically weaker
and dominating the others that and technological
things and whatnot this hasn't changed a bit it
still dominates all other emotions uh national
security nationalism patriotism the paranoia the
good guys against the bad guys and we're building
weapons constantly and everyone knows how if
you produce three television cameras two of them
are don't work or one of them doesn't work or they
all have glitches in them if you wind up with 90
000 nuclear weapons deployed in this world what
are your statistical chances of getting through a
year without something going wrong and in fact you
know it leaks out there are hundreds and hundreds
of little uh mistakes little problems with these
things they're not they're not the least bit
infallible as well as major computer malfunctions
that almost automatically have triggered off war
space lab in its last firing two 75 million dollar
satellites don't work and that's the technology
that's putting these thousands and thousands of
bombs if there is any hope for the human race
we have to have a complete rethink of
this emotion instinct of nationalism
and the whole paranoia the rules of interaction
of people and governments and countries have to be
changed we have to start dismantling weapons now
we have whatever it is all together 20 000 or so
and we could cut it back to as few as 500 and
still have 1 000 atom bombs is enough to eliminate
all life on the face of the earth we could
cut back to about 500 weapons and still have a
retaliatory capability against the
soviet union that could could end mankind
we need to start whacking away weapons in
such numbers that they would be put in an
untenable position in terms of of dealing with
the subject and dealing with the rest of the
world to the point where instead of working
on the concept of paranoia and patriotism
we are obviously working on the concept of
stopping the madness and otherwise there
will be no end to the madness well there will
be an end to the madness but not a happy one
and that's alternative views for this evening
glad you could join us again alternative
views is a production of the alternative
information network po box 7279 austin texas 78713
please write to us at that address good night
you have men hands to pull the triggers from the
salvadorian army itself our arms are going to
the rebels just as they did in vietnam the the
the people in power there trying to make money
out of our presence or turning the stuff over and
selling it they have flat taken over the contras
they tell them what to say the u.s mines harbors
and tells the contras to have a press conference
and take credit for it the u.s pilots bomb
targets inside nicaragua and tell the contrast
to have a press conference and say they did it
i don't believe anybody in this nation uh denies
that we are heading for war there the wheels are
turning the machinery is being oiled and greased
the military is scrimmaging they're building
bases and airfields uh militarizing the whole
place and and the preparation of the american
people just as we saw in the libyan thing
this major recent major development was to say
that the cubans are planning a major offensive
uh in el salvador for the fall where he told
the israeli minister about well i was to show
his sympathy for israel when i was in auschwitz
at the end of the war i took pictures and i have
those pictures until today and the minister went
back and had a press conference and said i don't
understand president reagan never left the united
states during world war ii he was not in germany
he was never at auschwitz he was in a movie about
it he just he just his his mind out of fantasy uh
he addressed a veterans group in new york and told
them a tale from world war ii about this pilot who
wouldn't leave the ship and crashed with his crew
because somebody couldn't get out and they and the
veterans researched the files no such incident was
reported to have happened in world war ii it was a
movie in which president reagan the ironic thing
there wouldn't have been any survivors to tell
this story everybody would have crashed and with
former cia official john stockwell we talk about
many things tonight the assassination attempts
on qaddafi the preparation for war in central
america and the u.s support for right-wing death
squads in el salvador tonight on alternative views
hey
we're pleased to have with us today former
cia agent john stockwell to do an update
on the role of the cia in the world today
and their involvement in some current events
that you see on your tv screens but don't hear
the cia's role in that in recent days there's
been quite a bit on the news about the libyan
terrorist activity so-called in england where
a group of libyans supposedly marched on
the libyan embassy in britain and a libyan shot
from the embassy killing a british policeman
a week or two thereafter colonel gaddafi of
libya was the victim of assassination attempt
and none of this has really been discussed in the
news about what is behind this and what possible
cia role is involved likewise there's been a lot
in the news recently about central america the
elections in el salvador the possibility of a u.s
invasion of nicaragua as reagan's christmas time
present to the nicaraguans after the election and
again the cia is involved in these activities in
certain ways but it hasn't really been highlighted
in the media so john's going to discuss about the
cia's role in all of this today so john shall we
begin with libya i think most americans don't even
know much about libya and the u.s relationship
over the years with colonel gaddafi in libya
for sure but what i really want to talk about is
orchestration the orchestration of covert actions
we've done before a discussion about
the orchestration of the invasion of
grenada which i see of course is a dress
rehearsal for the eventual invasion of nicaragua
as mondale said day before yesterday i believe it
was the president reagan's december his december
pres present to the united states uh orchestration
of these things we have another example
it happens to be about libya it could be about
you know colonel whomever in whichever country
that was a target of of cie destabilization and
a presidential hostile focus the point is that
gaddafi went on television last
week after this attempt on his life
and said that the united states and england
were behind it of course washington scoffed but
let's jump back we don't have at least i haven't
had time to go through and pull out all of the
significant events that built up to what happened
there last week but let's go back to 1981 and just
run through a series of events the orchestration
preparation of the public for an event
the spring and summer of 1981 there were numerous
rumors in the u.s media of u.s plots against
gaddafi now president reagan was just in
office the ci was just beginning to feel
his presence and his encouragement casey you
remember the director and hugh gell the ddo
reagan buddies that's the the operation the deputy
operation yeah the deputy director of operations
huguel was fired during this period of time at the
the insistence of the congress because of his over
eagerness his adventuresomeness but april april
6 us news and world reports reported that the u.s
with egyptian logistical supports was funneling
arms to anti-qadhafi forces in chad and the sudan
so you have the rumors going around remember
the bay of pigs and the rumors that were
going around before it for example or today the
rumors and speculation that's going on about a
u.s invasion of nicaragua in fact in the cuban
example you had attempts to assassinate castro
and you had the training of anti-castro forces by
the c.i.a as we now know before as preludes to the
bay of pigs and it was being bandied
about in the media and discussed and
the you know administrations denying and whatnot
ironically a lot of the training was being done
in nicaragua as a matter of fact okay may 1981 the
u.s expelled all libyan diplomats from the united
states july the assistant secretary of state for
african affairs chester crocker testified before
the congress that the united states would help any
country that was opposing libya qaddafi's libya
july 26 details were leaked to the public from
congressional sources of the ci's plans to
destabilize libya in august we had the provocation
of president reagan putting in the fleet uh in the
bay of sidra and then the it worked those sparks
were struck and the u.s shot down two of their
planes august 25 jack anderson reported that the
ci plotters still have gaddafi in their sight
now the point is that the u.s government
was plotting against gaddafi at this time
and and the press was uh was smelling it happening
and getting leaks and getting quotes uh proving it
but uh this was troubling people it the the nation
hadn't been turned against gaddafi sufficiently
okay it heats up or the ci plugs that gap if
you will october 28 jack anderson who has who
has by the way become a traditional uh frequent
mouthpiece for the ci and then he goes back and
admits it every time he gets burned he'll write
something saying by the way i was had again but
he goes to the cia to get these stories he calls
it his intelligence sources october 28 jack
anderson reported that colonel gaddafi has placed
president reagan at the top of a hit list and is
plotting his death well see that's sensational
somebody's plotting the death of our president so
so now the public opinion you know it begins to
surge november and december you'll remember uh
during that period of time the the talk
throughout the country of of gaddafi plotting
against our president and then the hit team the
hit teams in the united states you remember that
november nbc newsweek late november reported uh
the unusual security precautions uh to protect
president reagan from the libyan hit squad so you
had the hit squad that's what in all the media it
was the top story of every network so they came up
with a thing that would really sensationalize the
the evil of qaddafi and his threat to our national
security november 28 the washington post reported
the names of six members of this hit team and
shortly after that jack anderson released pictures
rough drawings of the members of the hit team oh
that's incredible okay well the washington post
now has had a long history of close association
with the cia also have been bradley and the crew
for sure the old boy thing it's close they have
lunch together they have breakfast together and
stories okay they overplayed the thing or it
was so successful that a reaction began to
set in because clearly there was no hit team
because events didn't emerge you didn't have
in fact the police and and and fbi and ci stan you
know on every street corner in the nation they the
way they would have been if there had been a hit
team stalking our president and they couldn't find
anybody nobody was here right and the p you know
it was overplayed and skepticism began to set in
december 7 you had a washington post article
by michael getler which said that the reports
were quote a source of puzzlement and then
on the 8th the next day you had a full page
washington post commentary by haines johnson
entitled the believe it or not show quote
they are setting new standards of incredibility it
is almost as if public opinion were being prepared
for dramatic action say a strike against libya
or gaddafi himself it is reminiscent of the talk
about castro in the days when the united states
was planning the bay of pigs investigate invasion
and in fact commissioning assassination schemes
against castro himself okay it's incredible if
they would run that which was completely counter
to everything else or do you think they'd finally
realize that they've been had or well they no they
clearly been had the ci had overplayed its hand
there was no hit team and the media was realizing
and as well as the the astute people across the
nation were beginning to say what hit team so the
washington post was backpedaling over there yeah
the story was breaking that there was no hip team
there's also rivalries between the fbi and the cia
here the cia was orchestrating the story and was
putting the fbi in charge of investigation so it's
the fbi that looks bad and this is they can't
find the libyan hit team that doesn't exist and
some fbi people resent this and i think some fbi
agents leaked to the press as i recall a skeptical
account that they hadn't come up with any hit team
so again you get these rivalries between these
intelligence agencies that sometimes and the
friction between the ci and the congress and of
course the cia running operations on the fbi and
vice versa and against the congress and that's how
stories come out right on december 10 though still
playing the hand president reagan invalidated u.s
passports for all travel to libya and ordered all
americans to leave now that's what you're going to
do to get your people out before an invasion and
on december 19 there was an attempt on qaddafi's
life how did this occur now it was uh it was an
ambush of the car's car he and his cavalcade were
in and he was wounded wounded in the cheek and
possibly worse he went into two weeks seclusion
they caught the killer he was the the assassin the
prima primary assassin was killed and of course
gaddafi launched a roll up much as we would of
everybody who was who would ever talk to him
so there you have it the orchestration right up
to an assassination attempt on the man's life
and then significantly uh in late december
the u.s media began to report comments from
the administration saying that the threat had
receded that the hit team had apparently left
and then in january jack anderson wrote a series
of articles and he by the way was more responsible
than anyone for the hysteria in this thing
with his sketches and his article in drawing
but he wrote a series of articles saying flatly
explaining how the media had been duped by the ci
by the intelligence sources so there you have it
as neat and orchestration preparation of the media
as we have ever seen building up to an
assassination attempt on gaddafi himself there's
one other factor here that messed up this plan
and that is the americans who were living in libya
refused to leave most of them were oil corporate
executives who had big business and big interests
in libya and good connections with the libyan
government and oil ministries and they just
simply didn't leave reagan tried to get them all
to scare them to get them to leave so obviously
the plan was to assassinate gaddafi and then to
invade libya and take over the oil but they just
weren't able to do it because one they couldn't
assassinate gaddafi and two they couldn't get
the americans there to leave or even yeah the
invasion it may be the americans presence there
uh discouraged chill the invasion itself or it
could be that they were just feared they being
reagan his administration feared a reaction to the
killing of gaddafi that if if he is killed by the
right elements you might have a government come
into power i presume they had a plan to try to
see to it that a quote moderate element came into
power but there could be a bloodbath i mean who
knows how many people might take to the streets
and how many americans might be chopped down
and the administration clearly knew that
an assassination was about to be attempted
and so they were telling the american people to
get out they couldn't tell them the truth and say
by the way we're going to try to kill the man next
week and then invade the country and there'll be
thousands of people killed by bombs and yeah well
there's one thing about gaddafi that we really
don't know what libya is like what the qaddafi
government really is like and what how the people
relate to gaddafi we had a syrian filmmaker nabil
male on the program a couple of years ago in which
he gave a quite different uh description
of gaddafi than the rest of the world gets
he was saying actually that qaddafi is taking
a lot of the oil riches and trying to build up
the people a lot of the amenities for the
people for uh the country rather than just
exploit them like occurs in most countries a
lot of public services a lot of modernization
are you suggesting that this
man may not be totally evil
i don't know you don't get any other i'm sure if
the cia's against him he can't be all bad but i
don't know that much about libya to know what
all he has done we never get that aspect of it
obviously the multinational corporations who are
down there aren't complaining too much about him
as far as i can tell in california during this
period of time i was lecturing and there was a
dinner afterwards uh with some some intellectuals
of some expertise in international abe loewenthal
wrote the book about the kurds in iran jerry
bender the angola and the various others and
we got to talking about gaddafi just what you're
saying is this man as evil as we're being told
so we decided to play a game and we did of a kind
of an improvised charade we we chose up two sides
and we had one side was trying to we got over
in scribble notes to remember every outrageous
thing qaddafi allegedly had ever said that we
could remember and the other side was everything
outrageous that uh president reagan had ever said
that we could remember about qaddafi or no just
just oh just and then as well as about gaddafi
and then uh we you know we read these things
out and then the rest of the people the panel
judged who was the matter of the two and there
was no question president reagan if i mean these
stark statements that gaddafi makes that shock us
so much president reagan was far crazier i mean
it's a question of degree but qaddafi had said
that if an invasion happened of libya that he
would blow up the the peaceful thermonuclear
electric generators in france and president
reagan had said that we could survive nuclear
war and we would have test demonstration bombs in
germany to show everybody our intentions now both
statements are kind of mad but one is quite a bit
matter because you're talking about the holocaust
as viable as and survivable and qaddafi's talking
about blowing up one peaceful nuke well there's
been no question that since 1981 these events
there has been a generally negative picture
of gaddafi in the u.s media and how do we move
now to the more recent events where in britain
there were this demonstration in front of the
libyan embassy supposedly by libyans who are
against gaddafi then there was a murder by of a
british policewoman i think supposedly by some of
the libyan embassy people and then of course libya
and britain broke off relations and then within a
week or two after that there was this attempt on
gaddafi's life how do you connect all of these
events in terms of the connection is obvious uh
the thing that i would observe in a broader sense
is that kadasi and the people that relate to him
are very very useful to the united states to the
cia and its principle of searching for enemies
of keeping the hostile presence in the world
keeping the world hostile it's much harder
for them to attack san danistas in nicaragua
in nicaragua all they can do is just make up
flagrantly full stories of death squads which
do not exist in nicaragua in salvador you have the
bodies turning up constantly and the proof of the
of the death squad's activities and statements and
who's on the payroll and the whole it's obviously
true uh in nicaragua the sandinistas are so sane
and rational they don't give the ci ammunition
for its its enemy surge for its politics of
paranoia gaddafi gives him a lot of of ammunition
in addition to which he inspires uh people who
you know for thousands of years have been feisty
they have it in their religion that it's an honor
to die in the cause and this makes them capable of
doing things that uh that the sandinista would
never do i don't believe any nicaraguan from a
nicaraguan embassy or san diego would shoot out
the window at a washington policeman or a british
policeman they just wouldn't do that they're
much you know they're restrained and careful
even if they felt they were being about to be
overrun well do you think this business of the
in the british embassy was something which just
occurred and the cia and all the governments
took advantage of or do you think it perhaps was
covertly planned i mean there are anti-qaddafi
forces but we don't know who's behind them
how they're funded who's orchestrating
well there was the the story at one time that
maybe the the shot that killed the policewoman
did not come from the libyan embassy it might
have come from somewhere else and a total set up
just like we don't know in
grenada who actually killed bishop
and his government the british police when they
took the embassy eventually claimed to have found
uh weapons and and spent rounds but of
course they could have planted those
but you get into a level of murk and intrigue
where you simply can't tell for sure and even
if the shot was fired from inside the embassy
it might have been someone who was planted there
to to to trigger a series of events that would
work against gaddafi gaddafi has been a thorn
in their side for many years he's been a
target for many years and the ci's first
task force for the destabilization of libya
under gaddafi was put together in 1972 and it
didn't get anywhere but their activities against
him date back that far but see you were still in
the cia then oh indeed that was before i ever
went to vietnam that was years before i got out
now how many times how many attempts have there
been on gaddafi's life then there was an attempt
in 73 or 74 i believe and then in 1981 and then
this one for sure is there been a couple of other
times where there were uh speculation of attempts
he disappeared from sight and there were rumors
of the attempts but they weren't documented and
what's the most recent one then the most recent
one was last week a couple weeks ago yeah and
what uh what what details do we have on that now
well just what we get from the press that a a
planned obviously well-planned trained uh hit
was an attack on his quarters commando attack
with a whole group of where between 10 and 15
people whose bodies were shown on libyan
television after their they were all killed
the people who tried to kill gaddafi and i didn't
see any pictures on american television although
i saw a couple in the press know that there is a
large movement of libyans who are against gaddafi
so the question is how does the cia relate
to oppositional movements like this do they
infiltrate them do they direct them etc just
whatever they can get and then if you have a
reagan's administration encouraging them to covert
action they're looking for more than just an
agent an information agent they're looking for
someone they can influence pay direct to plan
to actually uh make make an attempt of
some kind to direct their activities
to jump back to central america which is much more
important since that is most likely where the next
war will be involving u.s troops they have flat
taken over the contras they tell them what to say
the u.s mines harbors and tells the contrast to
have a press conference and take credit for it
the u.s pilots bomb uh targets inside nicaragua
and tell the contras to have a press conference
and say they did it concerning the mass media
and the business and the gaddafi hit squads
is that continuously even now you in in spite of
the fact that the whole business of the libyan
hit squad has been completely disavowed and just
exposed as being absolute baloney still people
in the media will repeat the story even uh some
of the so-called star reporters and commentators
will say yeah but oh he had those hit squads out
against reagan so he's obviously bad man there's
two other examples to take us to the caribbean
and central america of the constant repeating
in the media of lies one was the grenada story
about the air airport runway that was being built
by the cuban supposedly as a base for cuban and
soviet troops which of course the grenadine said
look we need this for our tourism and day after
day in the media month after month this airport
was seen as evidence of the danger the military
threat that grenade opposed to the united states
the example in el salvador and nicaragua that
parallels this is the supposed supporting of the
el salvadorian troops by the nicaraguans over and
over again the cia says the reagan administration
says that the nicaraguans are supplying arms
to the el salvadorian rebel troops and are
forming revolution in central america there
isn't the faintest shred of evidence of this
in fact there's been some sharp critiques
of this but again it's reported in the media
without question day after day month after month
well the south korean rebels are getting all the
arms they need more arms than they have men hands
to pull the triggers from the salvadorian army
itself our arms are going to the rebels just
as they did in vietnam the the the people
in power there trying to make money out of our
presence or turning the stuff over and selling it
however the in the sense of the orchestration
of what is eventually to happen there the most
significant thing the the el salvadorian hit squad
or the thing comparable to it president reagan
used in his big speech asking for more aid is that
cuba is planning a major offensive in el salvador
cuba is planning he said this and then
the press picked it up and commentators
have picked it up and said cuba is planning
a major offensive in el salvador now that
of course will stir people up here cuba
is invading el salvador and you have even
uh the editors of the austin american statesman
saying that if our friends are in danger most
americans would agree we have to go and help them
even if it involves remember the austin american
statesman last week even if it involves putting
in u.s troops so there you have our own newspapers
saying this and of course the absolute foolishness
of it is there's no way the cuban troops can even
get there no it's not a cuban problem the cubans
are not putting arms in the rebels are getting the
arms from the united states the cubans aren't
directing that thing these people have been
fighting their own revolution for years moreover
they have the most sophisticated intelligence
operations and equipment around el salvador that
has ever been probably anywhere in the world
that is they have all of these a wax and other
intelligence airplanes they have ships with radar
they have submarines patrolling the waters
they've got the contra forces they've got
satellites satellites they've got about 3 000
american troops in honduras and so obviously they
with all this apparatus they could detect any arms
going from nicaragua or cuba to el salvador they
haven't released the slightest shred of evidence
although recently some right-wing congressmen say
that they have been begging the cia to release
information proving to the cubans and nicaraguans
of taking arms there because everyone's getting
skeptical and so the right-wing congressmen
say that they've seen this but no one else
is saying but you know you don't need facts
president reagan by going on television himself
and saying a cuban planned uh offensive it's so
effective that not just the uneducated throughout
the country will take up on it but the editor of
the austin american statesman writes that if our
friends are attacked we'll have to bail them out
even if we have to send in our own truth so it
works even with newspaper editors who are not
exactly pro reagan well let's take a look at an
enormous story that isn't getting a play in the
in the press even though it is uh this and
this is one but in the progressive magazine
of may 1984. if you want to be shocked well maybe
not so shocked if you watched our program enough
or seen john stockwell enough but if you want
to find out what the us has really been doing
down there this will open your eyes because
this exhaustive study indicates that the us
has been behind the death squads down there
in el salvador all these years for decades
they have financed them they have equipped them
they have trained them they've set up their
intelligence service supplemented by continuing
information from the cia and the state department
itself themselves giving additional information
they've had people on the high people on the cia
payroll and even adobe zone it's an incredible
story and except for i guess you were saying
one tiny little mention on the cbs evening
news it's not being picked up at all the cbs
evening news once had brought walder cronkite out
of retirement to interview a former el salvadorian
treasury policeman who had been involved
with the death squads who said that a general
carranza had been involved in the forming
the training the executing of operations
with the death squads and that he was a cia
agent and that another fellow named medrano
who was one of the formers of ordon which was
the right-wing terrorist paramilitary operation
in the countryside was also a cia agent in other
words the cia had organized ordon and trained the
death squad members originally and also they
were behind the founding of dabason's arena
party so that was the only mention that i've seen
on network news was the cronkite interview but
this progressive story gives it's a long long
story and it goes into great detail on how all
this actually worked and including the old bit of
the cia training these people in torture methods
and then sending the material equipment and
all down to el salvador so that they could
be used as well as the old business of having
seminars down in el salvador and making sure that
people learned how to to torture correctly the
irony is that this was all an indirect part of
the alliance for progress putting together the
absolutely death squads was part of the alliance
for progress under under gen under kennedy
that wonderful liberal who was saying that
the point was to bring the standard of living
of all the people up so they could identify
so they could join the modern world but this was a
very comprehensive it wasn't just the c i a that's
involved with it although they were the main actor
it was the us army it was the state department
although it says here during carter the state
department kind of backed away from this a bit
and the cia was the main agency doing it but well
even aid was involved but so they just didn't set
the thing up either and get it going and then step
back they continue to provide support of all kinds
including most insidiously giving information
dossiers pictures to the salvadorian security
service so they in turn could go and pick up these
people and torture them and kill them and as they
said here uh you're going to kill a person there's
one page devoted to a fellow who told about how
all the torture worked and all the things they did
to them and they said that he was the guy walder
cronkite interviewed was this the guy yeah well
he was telling about how you wire up people and
uh torture them and they said you're going to
kill them anyway but you just torture them anyway
just because well i guess it's kind of a fun
thing to do for some people but particularly
they take the bodies then after they're mutilated
and toss them out in the street with a little note
that the mono blanco the white hand has done
this to people is a warning to other people
the frightened opposition yeah and it says however
a key thing i thought he said that uh if there is
a lot of pressure like from amnesty international
or from some foreign countries they won't kill
the person they'll just torture him and then
turn him loose but if they're just will never
be known anything about them well they'll just
kill them and that's it so that's what over 80
000 people this has happened to that tiny it
must be up with over 100 000 80 000 thousand
in guatemala alone forty two thousand in el
salvador since president reagan came into office
just since then how many people began to add
up all the countries for 20 30 years brazil
uruguay nicaragua under samosa for example not
to mention the other places panama and elsewhere
uh you're into the hunt you're in hundreds of
thousands there's been a lot of people killed and
disappeared under with you know these techniques
these policies the hypocrisy of the reagan
administration is recently they've been trying
to distance themselves from these death squads
arguing that the death squads are a product of
the extreme right and they want to support duarte
in the christian democratic center whereas in fact
the cia and the united states government is behind
these right-wing death squads as we've indicated
founding them training them and participating
with their agents in these executions so it's
really hypocrisy of the reagan administration
washington it's politics uh washington has had the
leaks and admissions of the 2.1 million dollars
the cia spent to make sure that dwarty won the
elections and obison did not what we won't know
perhaps never or unless someone comes out with the
information is how much money did the cia spend
to pacify and buy off they'll be zaun and the
death squad leaders so they won't kill duarte and
launch a terror campaign on our own diplomats and
and others this is what this is what dolby song
has said before in the tv tv broadcast that duarte
and the other people are communists and if he gets
into power he knows what he's going to do with
communism even out of power he you know the death
squad people are not very responsive to authority
like elected by the cia well when duarte was in
power before there was no different dwarf they
had no power and the death squads were operating
normally all the time so no things aren't going
to change let's let's focus on this on this uh did
you have another point well i was just going to
make a ask you to make a parallel with vietnam now
you were there were you there and when the phoenix
program was going on when the cia that was the cia
operation that supposedly was assassinating the
uh quote viet cong infrastructure two thousand to
forty four thousand depending whether you took the
ci's figures or the vietnamese figures bill colby
eventually the cia director was in charge of that
i was not there then i got there in 73 the us had
pulled out our involvement in the phoenix program
was terminated but the cadre that we had created
of vietnamese was still functioning and they
would come up to my post and tune in regularly
out on a hit to go in and clean up some nest
of of of communists somewhere who they thought
were communists oh well these were just families
women children oh yeah the first time they came
up my staff the americans who were working with
me who had been there for one for several years
i was rushing in with some excitement saying we
can clean this place up now because these guys
are really good they'll really go out there and
get them and there won't be any of this trial and
chew hoy and coming over stuff so at that time i
wasn't you know my mind hadn't progressed very far
beyond the cia and so i was trying to think of
well what places do we know where there are real
communist cells that we would want to go in
and try to to neutralize them or kidnap them
or whatever and so i was sitting there working
through the files and trying to talk to my staff
and my staff was just saying no no you know this
is the eraser we can just clean up things and it
finally began to dawn on me that these people
weren't talking about a place where you knew
a communist battalion commander was living or
working or some communist terrorist squad we
didn't know of any such things it was just an
eraser we'd go into a village and do do what
you wanted to do and i i didn't i didn't work with
them we weren't required to work with we weren't
part of their activity they would come up and if
they got a support or presence or help from us or
they might be drinking beer together sort of thing
or otherwise they just go on about their business
so the point is that this type of activity of
the cia and the us government is something that's
been policy standard policy for decades yes which
brings me to the next point that i wanted to get
into which was the recent election in el salvador
you mentioned briefly just a minute or two ago
about how the cia funneled something like two
million dollars into assure that duarte would
be elected because they didn't want dobasan to
be elected because then congress wouldn't give
any more money possibly for reagan's policies
down there they also gave another moderate
right wing candidate something like half a million
dollars isn't this also a standard cia operation
of funneling literally millions of dollars in
political elections to candidates that the cia for
whatever reason wants to win the election yeah one
of the biggest frauds of uh of white house talk
of presidential speak whether it's it's reagan
or carter or nixon is our support of democracy
and freedom around the world the united states has
no interest in democracy when it involves getting
people into power if it upsets the oligarchy the
norm chomsky's books pointing out 18 he counts uh
constitutional democracies that were over
overthrown the overthrow engineered by the
cia this is a case in point the what you know
what is democratic about a tiny little country
like el salvador as unstable as it is right now
with the united states going in and spending 2.1
million dollars putting in a team of professionals
to manipulate the thing and to to you know jesse
helms was getting into this because he was angry
because he likes dobby's on the killer and he was
frustrated that reagan had gone with duarte the
the moderate and and helms was the one that broke
it broke it open the new york times reports today
that he's been censored by barry goldwater and
patrick moynihan for breaching the faith for going
public with sensitive information but he reported
that a cia officer that he was grilling told him
quote we did everything but stuff the ballot box
and that says that of the techniques that
we know they did specifically one was to fly
uh 18 journalists from europe and latin america
they're not the cia saying you know here our
agents go and report this going indirectly and
inviting these journalists to come and then
having them briefed feeding them information
that was patently false about what we saw
so that they would go and write bad things
about him and create sympathy for duarte
yeah john in what way do you see all
of this as orchestrating a possible
either invasion of nicaragua or bringing american
troops into el salvador this has been sort of
the theme of our discussion the way that cia
sort of orchestrates these major interventions
through media manipulation and i i def i don't
believe any any by starting to say any rational
person in this nation but i don't want to poison
the well i don't believe anybody in this nation
uh denies that we are heading for a war there
the wheels are turning the machinery is being
oiled and greased the military is scrimmaging
they're building bases and airfields militarizing
the whole place and and the preparation of the
american people just as we saw on the libyan thing
this major recent major development was to say
that the cubans are planning a major offensive
in el salvador for the fall and then president
reagan's comments to de la madrid in washington
yesterday the same thing saying you know you
have you can't ignore the communist threat well
madrid uh challenged him on it but mildly
you got the feeling he was a little bit uh
uh not in his own element not speaking
from mexico itself but he did challenge
and disagree with the president but he knows
it's not a communist threat washington knows it's
not a communist threat president reagan knows
that the cubans are not planning an offensive
we don't know that for sure i mean it's not
clear that reagan doesn't actually believe
some of these lies that he says that people
just feed him and that's why he comes off
sincere and convincing yeah you could tell
when carter was lying but reagan doesn't
know that well you may have a pretty good
point because this man has lived in a world
of make-believe of make movies of make-believe
he did and this is very very important to him
war is a glamorous thing uh he did movies about
it it was exciting to play the bomber you know
and you your planes you know the engines are
smoking and you make it back and all of this stuff
war to him is a very exciting thing and the cowboy
thing where you go and and you kill the bad guys
and and the good guys always win now i'm not just
being cynical we have evidence that he can't keep
it straight in his own mind uh between the move
you know the two two events one was where he told
the israeli minister about well i was to show
his sympathy for israel when i was in auschwitz
at the end of the war i took pictures and i have
those pictures until today and the minister went
back and had a press conference and said i don't
understand president reagan never left the united
states during world war ii he was not in germany
he was never at auschwitz he was in a movie about
it he just he just his his mind out of fantasy uh
he addressed a veterans group in new york and told
them a tale from world war ii about this pilot who
wouldn't leave the ship and crashed with his crew
because somebody couldn't get out and everything
he held the wounded bombardier's hand because he
couldn't get out so he went down the plane with
him and they and the veterans researched the files
no such incident was recorded to have happened
in world war ii it was a movie in which president
reagan the ironic thing there wouldn't have been
any survivors to tell this story everybody would
have cried and reagan couldn't he didn't have this
straight in his mind between the movie script and
the real life so he sees the prospects of war
in central america and putting in the troops as
the cowboy going in to clean out the nest of
bandits and it's all noble and heroic and and
the blood is ketchup and nobody really gets hurt
but notice that we're on on in the mass media
and in congress there's been a slow change now
it's complete whereas before they might call the
guerrillas as left-wing guerrillas or or may
perhaps marxist gorillas and the sandinistas as
a left-wing or maybe maybe a marxist government
down there now it's all communists they're all
communists in nicaragua and all the rebels are all
communists despite the fact that some very many
moderate people of the junta which preceded duarte
who quit the hunt and joined the the democratic
front and resistance down there they could hardly
be called uh marxists and as far as the communists
is concerned in nicaragua the communist party
is as historically and still is in opposition
to the san anista government as a matter of
fact the government had to jail some of the
communist leaders because they were being uh quite
disruptive and secondly the communist party and
the el salvador in the rebel democratic front or
i forget what if whatever it is there's so many of
them but uh they're a very minor part of it and as
a matter of fact they went to the soviet union to
try to get support the soviet union just rebuffed
them so the communists who are the communists
the issues are not coming let the media repeat
this and repeat this and repeat this and so now
everybody says oh we got to stop communism
down there because they'll be coming across
the rio grande see this is the other danger of
reagan's hollywood mindset he sees the world
through the lenses of hollywood movies there's the
good guys and the bad guys and we're the good guys
and somewhere he got this sense of the communists
or the bad guys so wherever there is any smell or
any stain or whatever of communism he thinks
that there's an evil that has to be eradicated
and the way you do it on the hollywood formula is
violence you blow them away you blow them away and
that seems to be reagan's mindset if you can it
doesn't make a good movie if you go and everybody
lays down their swords and shields and drinks
a beer together that doesn't make a good ending
to a movie you got to have a shootout but you
know you must never forget that behind reagan
in lockstep with him or all the people are making
the trillions of dollars out of building arms
and and and selling arms to everyone in the world
and this paranoia this the threat of communism
in central america and elsewhere is
what keeps this arm industry going
to me what's even more frightening than that
well on the escalation basis the ultimate fright
is the holocaust but is that the reagan
administration has announced this policy of
unrestricted preemptive strikes against quote
terrorists around the world anywhere at any time
including the united states and who are the
terrorists in the united states they're going
to leave that up to the state department and
the department of state and a lot of those
people have said basically anybody who disagrees
with reagan any of the people who demonstrated
nuclear power plants people in the peace
movement people who are supportive of the plo
uh just about anybody in opposition they've
declared specifically for example that c-space
is associated with terrorists anybody who against
reagan's foreign policy and central america
anybody who helps the salvadorian or guatemalan
refugees they're automatically terrorists so they
can go in with their right wing death squads or
any kind of death squads they've already using
the klan and the nazis in greensboro effectively
and elsewhere yes and they can do it at now and
it's all legal it's all legal the president at
any time can declare an imagine an emergency
put all dissidents in concentration camps take
over the banks take over the communications
system take over transportation now the right
wing has been screaming about this for a long time
what is the status of this though john i
know that reagan made that policy statement
on terrorism and wanted to do presidential
directives so that any time there was a supposed
terrorist enemy he could do a preemptive strike
but this congress has to approve of this is this
now the law or is this just something that
reagan wants to get but may not be able to like
some of the other more outrageous i was asking
that question of some friends or lobbyists in
in washington just just a few days ago and uh
it has been it has been announced as a reagan
uh reagan policy it has been proposed
it has been suggested to congress
uh that you know in terms of formulating
a budget and a policy that would be a law
but their feeling was one he has not gotten a law
from congress the debate uh was a little chilling
because it happened to come about the time of the
mining of the harbors and whatnot kind of got lost
in the rhetoric on other things but that in fact
he may set it up right now it may be that on the
presidential order that they're proceeding to to
do and prepare for these things and perhaps do
if if the the incident in libya against
gaddafi as an example perhaps to start to do it
but of course it's a shade it's really the
only thing that's a great deal difference is
is announcing it publicly preemptive strikes
and then saying yes and we would also do it
in the united states but they have been doing
this throughout the world for many many years
and they have also killed and assassinated people
in the united states for decades literally so it's
a question of of escalating of going public
of saying this is the kind of people we are
as opposed to doing it and denying it and hoping
the truth doesn't come out and what is there just
something that's surfaced in a right-wing populist
newspaper the spotlight and it talks about a mass
mass detention facilities concentration
camps in other words that are being set
up by a number in a number of major u.s military
installations on secret orders of president reagan
you never know this came from right-wing source
if you didn't see it but there were ten prison
camps in key places across the country and they're
being set in motion for an unprecedented roundup
of aliens and security suspects now ostensibly
is just to take care of of aliens illegal
aliens but the secret part another secret part of
this thing called rex 84 is to jail any resistors
or outspoken critics whom the administration
considers dangerous the concentration camps
are fort chaffee arkansas ford indian camp
pennsylvania camp ap hill in virginia now they
already have the about eight concentration camps
which were set up by the mccarran act and these
have been kept in a caretaker status all these
years supposedly they haven't been used but you
don't know these are addition to that and there
are also some supplementary ones in georgia and
vandenberg air force base in california etc
and this says that the major network of fbia
and u.s marshals immigration naturalization
service customs coast guards they're all going to
be getting in with this to join with state police
and massive roundups and put the people in these
uh so we may not be having a program here in in
a few years the fact that even think about this
shows the really dangerous elements in the reagan
it's not just just in case they're doing this
as part of a coordinated program after the vietnam
war you had reagan and rusk and mcnamara and many
others going public saying the next war cannot be
fought in the eye of the television camry it can't
be debated in the campuses in the united states
they have been putting together law after law uh
mostly ci laws and secrecy laws they to be able to
muzzle uh the press and keep the american people
from knowing the horrible truth as we get into
the next war and they have many of these laws
on the books this is just another uh step not
a contingency plan but preparatory step getting
ready for the next war if there's no war and then
an anti-war movement they'll arrest the anti-war
they've got concentration camps for them they
have for example you know cy hersh exposing milai
they now have a uh the the philadelp passport
law in which the secretary of state can take
away anybody's passport without a prior hearing
pluck and you don't travel anymore so there won't
be people going to vietnam and covering stories
are going to to honduras nicaragua salvador and
covering stories and writing things if they do
they'll lose their passport the threat of this
will means that they'll be careful in what they
write then as far as the activities on campuses
and throughout the united states the sds and
whatnot you've got preparations like this
draft resistors also they mentioned nerf the
national emergency reaction plan the national
guard streamline and dust it off so it can react
instantly this is not just haphazard this is all
very specific planning getting ready for the
war that they have talked about that will be
fought differently from vietnam john i know you're
traveling around the united states have you seen
building up of a concern about the reagan
administration and his foreign policy and the
dangers of war and political repression and do you
think this is going to impact on the election and
resistance absolutely reaganism when my first book
came out in search of enemies people were flocking
to my lectures to hear the truth about the cia
and the truth about angola now that book is years
old and people are not coming at all because of
that book they're coming because of their concern
about central america and the winds of war
that are blowing and reagan's policies and
the lies they know that they're being told the
interesting thing is they're coming in larger
numbers and they're showing just as much and
even more or in some cases far more enthusiasm
stanford notoriously conservative the ci chose it
a couple of months ago to stage a big recruitment
scenario and had division chiefs fly out there
to give speeches and whatnot and then they had
articles written about how popular the cia was on
campuses i was there two weeks ago they had a hole
that had a thousand seats in it they had people
sitting in the aisles and standing around the back
and they stayed three and a half
hours until the building was closed
and there wasn't any hostile reaction when i quit
the speech and moved into the question and answer
people stood and applauded so long that i couldn't
get them to quiet down to get into the question
and answer thing and this is what i'm running into
throughout the nation people everywhere deeply
concerned at the militarization of this country at
the at the way the president is building using the
law changing the law to profit the very rich and
the fact that we are obviously building towards a
major war which is going to be in central america
and the young people are going to be killed and
then beyond that that all of this is leading to
a destabilization of the world that's going to
put us on the brink of the holocaust we're on
the brink already that's going to nudge us over
and to top all of this is an article written
by michael claire in inquiry magazine
he's been on our program several times he was
the first one two years ago who talked about the
uh change of organized policy which in which
these uh worldwide uh anti-terrorist squads of the
united states would be two years before ever hit
the regular media he's talking about here about
the reagan doctrine which is incredibly important
because he says it is a a significant change from
any military doctrine which you've had in the past
and when military doctrine basic military doctrine
and attitudes change then the business of war
also changes he says the frightening thing is that
reagan and weinberger and all the whole all
the administration up there are changing to
considering not considering the planning
not just an all-out protracted nuclear war
with the soviet union in which they think they
can win but then afterwards the soviet union and
the united states but when the soviet union is
the people are trying to put back some type of
society and crawling out from under the rubble the
u.s will have saved enough nukes to wipe them out
that is really a sick mind we're all deeply
concerned the entire nation is concerned about
the world about these bombs and the the prospects
of the holocaust and this this absent-minded
cowboy playing games with the fate of the earth
and the harsh people on the other sides of the
river playing similar games uh the whole world is
concerned about this at the same time they even
very intelligent people are capable of getting
sucked into the superficial line and hollywood
smile i'll give you an example i was interviewed
in gunnison colorado by several television
stations in a kind of a press conference one of
these uh guys at the outset very pleasantly said
you know don't expect much sympathy here this is
one of the most conservative places in the nation
and i said that doesn't bother me i'm an ex-marine
let's talk 15 minutes later this man as you know
the the press conference was essentially over this
man was asking me if i would stay over the next
day and give him an hour talk on his morning show
because he said this stuff has got to be discussed
he said i want you to come on my show and he was
asking i couldn't i had a lecture i had to fly out
i offered to get up at seven in the morning
and do it and tape it and he said he would do
it but he had somewhere else that he promised
to be with his cameras at seven in the morning
now this man knew the truth about the bombs and
he knew the truth about the wars i didn't say
anything he hadn't heard before but he'd managed
to let this stuff filter down to the the bottom
of his consciousness and to seize on this you
got to stop the communists in el salvador line
and put in the troops and build bombs and show
the russians he knew better and there's so many
people throughout the nation that know better but
they will still drift along the president gives
a speech and he gets his mx missiles he gives a
speech and he gets his arms for salvador i might
just note in conclusion there's an article here
about a lecture that john had given in minnesota
on the cia and some of these things we've been
talking about today and the next day there was
a cia recruiting team on campus and groups of
students who'd heard john the night before blocked
their recruiting efforts and were demonstrating
against them and in the same article in the
guardian there's stories about a whole series of
protests against henry kissinger and weinberger
and some of these other spokesmen for the war
policies who are going around the campus and
are now getting attacked by students who
just are horrified by their attempting to
legitimate war be it in el salvador or nuclear
well these students don't realize their proper
role in history the young man has always been
a cannon fodder and they just don't want to
play you know it's their turn and they just don't
want to play the game of being cannon fodder for
cynical administration's policies their fathers
did and grandfathers did and others did i don't
know what's wrong with them they don't want to go
out and be cannon fodder from president reagan's
cowboy games in central america i think that's
why we're all being subject to this increased
propaganda yeah well we've countered it in
a tiny wee way tonight on alternative use
and that's alternative views for this
evening please join us next week alternative
views this production of the alternative
information network po box 7279 austin texas
78713 if you'd like to contact us there's
our address we'd like to hear from you good
night you